THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
EDUCATION WILL COME TO ORDER, SO
. GOOD MORNING. AND FIRST OFF,
WELCOME TO JULIE FROM MISSOURI,
IN CASE YOU'RE WONDERING WHO
THAT IS, THAT'S AMANDA RICHIE'S
MOM. SHE TUNES IN FROM HER HOME
STATE TO WATCH HER DAUGHTER DO
HER WORK. A HAPPY BIRTHDAY AS
WELL TO APRIL JOHNSON, WHO IS
LUCKY ENOUGH TO BE MARRIED TO
IAN. IAN ASKED FOR THE DAY OFF
TODAY BECAUSE IT WAS HIS WIFE'S
BIRTHDAY. I DIDN'T FALL FOR
THAT, THERE ARE 30 BILLS ON
TODAY'S AGENDA, THAT'S THE BAD
NEWS. THE GOOD NEWS IS 11 BILLS
ARE ON CONSENT. THEY ARE AS
FOLLOWS. ITEM NUMBER SIX, AB
1984. ITEM NUMBER EIGHT, AB
2048. ITEM NUMBER TEN AB 20
2768. ITEM NUMBER 11 AB 2074.
ITEM NUMBER 12 AB 2112. ITEM
NUMBER 13 AB 2165. ITEM NUMBER
15 AB 2181. ITEM NUMBER 20 AB
2492. ITEM NUMBER 24 AB 3131.
ITEM NUMBER 27 AB 2953. ITEM
NUMBER 30 AB 3010, WE ACTUALLY
DO TODAY. HAVE ANOTHER COMMITTEE
HEARING SCHEDULED FOR THIS ROOM
IMMEDIATELY FOLLOWING THIS
HEARING, SO WE'RE GOING TO
ENDEAVOR TO MOVE ALONG AS WE GO,
TODAY, WITNESSES ARE ASKED TO
LIMIT THEIR TESTIMONY TO THREE
MINUTES EACH TO ENSURE THE
COMMITTEE IS ABLE TO COMPLETE
TODAY'S AGENDA IN A TIMELY
FASHION, SEEING NO QUORUM QUITE
YET, LET'S BEGIN AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE, WITH THE FIRST
AUTHOR. AND I SEE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TAZ HERE IS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TING. HERE HE IS. NOT
YET, YOU'RE UP. PLEASE WELCOME.
AND PLEASE PROCEED WHEN READY.
GOOD MORNING, CHAIR AND MEMBER
OF THE COMMITTEE. FIRST, I'D
LIKE TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR THEIR WORK ON THIS
BILL. AB 1793 WILL ENSURE THAT
DEPENDENTS OF ACTIVE DUTY
MILITARY MEMBERS STATIONED
OUTSIDE CALIFORNIA. BUT
MAINTAINING CALIFORNIA RESIDENCY
WILL BE ELIGIBLE FOR CURRENT AND
MIDDLE CLASS SCHOLARSHIP
PROGRAM. MILITARY SERVICE
MEMBERS WHO ARE CALIFORNIA
RESIDENT MAY SOMETIMES RECEIVE
GOVERNMENT ORDER REQUIRING THEM
TO RELOCATE OUTSIDE OF THE STATE
FOR EXTEND PERIOD, AND THEIR
FAMILY OFTEN ACCOMPANY THEM
SINCE THEIR PARENTS ARE STILL
OFFICIALLY RESIDENT OF
CALIFORNIA, THE STUDENT QUALIFY
FOR IN-STATE TUITION RATE AT OUR
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES.
HOWEVER UNDER CURRENT LAW,
STUDENTS ARE INELIGIBLE FOR
CURRENT OR THE MIDDLE CLASS
SCHOLARSHIP PROGRAM IF THEY
TEMPORARILY RESIDE OUT OF STATE.
AB 1793 WOULD ONLY APPLY TO A
VERY SPECIFIC GROUP OF ACTIVE
DUTY SERVICE MEMBERS. THIS. THIS
BILL DOES NOT APPROPRIATE ANY
ADDITIONAL FUNDS FOR THE CURRENT
PROGRAM. IT SIMPLY ALLOWED
DEPENDENTS OF ACTIVE DUTY
CALIFORNIA MILITARY MEMBERS TO
ACCESS THE RENT. I'D LIKE TO
INTRODUCE ZEITSCHRIFT WITH REEB
GOVERNMENT RELATIONS TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF AB 1793. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE
ON AB 1793. THANK YOU SIR. MR.
REEB, WELCOME. GOOD MORNING.
PLEASE PROCEED. GOOD MORNING,
HONORABLE CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS.
MY NAME IS SETH REEB WITH REEB
GOVERNMENT RELATIONS
REPRESENTING AMVETS. DEPARTMENT
OF CALIFORNIA, CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTY VETERANS
SERVICE OFFICERS, CALIFORNIA
STATE COMMANDERS, VETERANS
COUNCIL, MILITARY OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION OF AMERICA,
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL OF CHAPTERS
I'M HERE TO EXPRESS OUR STRONG
SUPPORT FOR AB 1793, WHICH AIMS
TO EXTEND CAL GRANT AND MIDDLE
CLASS SCHOLARSHIP ELIGIBILITY TO
DEPENDENTS OF CALIFORNIA
MILITARY MEMBERS STATIONED
OUTSIDE THE STATE. THE NATURE OF
MILITARY LIFE MEANS FREQUENT
RELOCATIONS, OFTEN IMPACTING THE
EDUCATIONAL OPPORTUNITIES FOR
SERVICE MEMBERS. CHILDREN EVEN
DESPITE MAINTAINING CALIFORNIA
RESIDENCY, THESE STUDENTS FACE
BARRIERS TO ACCESSING STATE
SPONSORED EDUCATIONAL GRANTS DUE
TO THEIR TEMPORARY OUT OF STATE
LIVING SITUATIONS. AB 1793
REFLECTS THAT RECTIFIES THIS BY
ENSURING THAT MILITARY
DEPENDENTS ARE NOT UNFAIRLY
PENALIZED FOR THEIR PARENTS
SERVICE. THIS LEGISLATION NOT
ONLY SUPPORTS THE EDUCATIONAL
ASPIRATIONS OF MILITARY
FAMILIES, BUT ALSO UPHOLDS OUR
VALUES OF FAIRNESS AND EQUITY. I
URGE YOU TO PASS AB 1793
STANDING FIRM AND OUR COMMITMENT
TO THOSE WHO SERVE AND SACRIFICE
FOR OUR NATION. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. ARE THERE OTHERS IN THE
HEARING WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THE
MEASURE? SO PLEASE COME FORWARD,
DO WE HAVE OPPOSITION PRESENT
TODAY? IS THERE ANY YOU'D LIKE
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO THE
MEASURE? SEEING NONE, COME BACK
TO SENATOR WILK. YEAH. GREAT.
BILL, THANK YOU FOR DOING IT.
AND I WILL MOVE IT, WHEN
APPROPRIATE. I REALLY APPRECIATE
THAT, FOR MY PART, GLAD TO
SUPPORT IT AS WELL, I THINK
YOU'LL HAVE NO TROUBLE, SECURING
OUR VOTES TO PASS IT, SO THANK
YOU, WE'LL LEAVE IT ON HOLD
UNTIL WE ESTABLISH A QUORUM.
WE'LL LET IT CLOSE. I THINK I'LL
LET THEM CLOSE. PLEASE CLOSE.
THANKS, CHAIR. YEAH THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR SUPPORT. I, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR ELBOW.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU. SORRY NOT
TO DO THAT. BETTER ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT UP.
THANK YOU, SENATOR WILK. KEEPING
ME ON TRACK, WHO IS OUR NEXT,
ASSEMBLY MEMBER? REYES, PLEASE.
I'LL MAKE SURE I GIVE YOU AN
OPPORTUNITY TO CLOSE. SO
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY. THANK
YOU, MR. CHAIR. AND MEMBERS, I
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT TO YOU AB 2724. VOTER
REGISTRATION IS THE LAW. IT IS
AN EXCELLENT TOOL TO MAKE IT
POSSIBLE FOR 16 AND 17 YEAR OLDS
TO PRE-REGISTER TO VOTE SO THAT
UPON THEIR 18TH BIRTHDAY, THEY
ARE AUTOMATICALLY REGISTERED
VOTERS. THIS BILL WOULD PROVIDE
HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS IN
CALIFORNIA THE OPPORTUNITY AND
RESOURCES NEEDED TO PRE-REGISTER
TO VOTE BY THE END OF THE 11TH
GRADE. EVERY ELECTION CYCLE, WE
DISCUSS THE LOW VOTER TURNOUT
FROM ALL ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
UNFORTUNATELY, MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS PASS UP ON THE
OPPORTUNITY TO EXERCISE THEIR
DEMOCRATIC RIGHT TO VOTE AT
EVERY ELECTION. ONE CRITICAL
STRATEGY WE CAN EMPLOY TO
ADDRESS THIS IS BY ENSURING THAT
YOUNG CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE
ELIGIBLE TO VOTE ARE REGISTERED
TO DO SO. CURRENTLY, ONLY 11% OF
16 AND 17 YEAR OLDS IN
CALIFORNIA VÀ ARE ACTUALLY
PRE-REGISTERED TO VOTE BY
FOCUSING ON OUR YOUTH AND
BRINGING THE RESOURCES TO THEM
AT THEIR HIGH SCHOOLS, WE CAN
ENSURE MORE CALIFORNIANS,
ESPECIALLY YOUNG CALIFORNIANS,
ARE VOTING AND DEVELOPING THE
HABIT OF DOING SO AT AN EARLIER
AGE. CIVIC ENGAGEMENT IS
INVALUABLE, WHICH IS WHY WE NEED
AB 2724, THE HIGH SCHOOL VOTER
REGISTRATION ACT, SO MORE VOICES
CAN BE HEARD AT THE POLLS ON
ELECTION DAY. HERE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT IS ANNA VIKTORIA CHÁVEZ,
A STUDENT ORGANIZER WITH INLAND
CONGREGATIONS UNITED FOR CHANGE.
WELCOME MISS CHÁVEZ. PLEASE
PROCEED. THANK YOU. CHAIR, VICE
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS ANNA
VICTORIA CHÁVEZ. I AM A SENIOR
AT SAN BERNARDINO HIGH SCHOOL IN
THE CITY OF SAN BERNARDINO AND A
LEADER WITH INLAND CONGREGATIONS
UNITED FOR CHANGE. ICAC, I'M
HERE TODAY. I'M HERE TODAY TO
EXPRESS MY STRONG SUPPORT FOR AB
272. FOR THIS SCHOOL YEAR, I
TOOK ON THE ROLE OF PROMOTING
VOTER REGISTRATION AT MY SCHOOL.
WHEN I APPROACHED STUDENTS
DURING LUNCH, MANY APPEARED
DISINTERESTED, AS IF VOTING
WASN'T A SERIOUS OR IMPORTANT
MATTER TO THEM. THIS MADE ME
REFLECT DEEPLY BECAUSE I HAVE A
DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVE ON VOTING.
GROWING UP, I WAS DEEPLY
INVOLVED IN FAMILY DISCUSSIONS
ON WHO MY PARENTS PLANNED TO
VOTE FOR AND WHAT THEY BELIEVED
WOULD BENEFIT OUR COUNTRY IN THE
LONG RUN. THESE CONVERSATIONS
TAUGHT ME THE IMPORTANCE OF
VOTING AND EDUCATING OURSELVES
ON THE MATTERS OF OUR COUNTRY IN
ORDER TO MAKE THE BEST DECISION
WHEN VOTING, THEY MADE ME FEEL
ENTHUSIASTIC AND EAGER ABOUT
TURNING 18 AND VOTING. SEEING IT
AS A CRUCIAL RESPONSIBILITY AS A
CITIZEN. THEREFORE HEARING THAT
SOME OF MY PEERS SEEMED
UNINTERESTED IN VOTING SHOCKED
ME. I'VE BEEN REFLECTING ON HOW
FORTUNATE I AM TO HAVE PARENTS
THAT TOOK THE TIME TO DISCUSS
VOTING AND ITS IMPORTANCE TO ME,
ESPECIALLY CONSIDERING I LIVE IN
A LOW INCOME AREA WITH A LARGE
HISPANIC POPULATION. MANY OF MY
FRIENDS ARE FIRST GENERATION
AMERICAN AND HAVE NOT HAD THE
PRIVILEGE OF HAVING FAMILY
MEMBERS WHO ENCOURAGE THEM TO
VOTE. THIS IS WHY AB 2724 IS
IMPORTANT BECAUSE IT AIMS TO
EMPOWER YOUTH LIKE MYSELF, TO
BECOME INFORMED AND ENGAGED
PARTICIPANTS IN OUR DEMOCRACY BY
TEACHING STUDENTS THAT OUR
VOICES MATTER AND ENCOURAGING US
TO PARTICIPATE IN ELECTIONS. AB
2724 CAN CREATE A MORE ENGAGED
ELECTORATE BY BRINGING THESE
CONVERSATIONS TO OUR SCHOOLS. IT
WILL HELP US STUDENTS FEEL
INVOLVED AND CARE FOR THE FUTURE
OF OUR COUNTRY. THIS BILL IN
FRONT OF YOU TODAY HAS BEEN
GARNERING TREMENDOUS SUPPORT
BOTH AT THE STATE AND LOCAL
LEVEL, AS IT HAS MADE ITS WAY
HERE. JUST YESTERDAY, BOARD
MEMBERS FROM THE SAN BERNARDINO
CITY UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
UNANIMOUSLY PASSED A RESOLUTION
IN SUPPORT OF AB 2724. HELP US
CONTINUE MOVING THIS FORWARD AND
SUPPORT US IN GIVING EVERY
STUDENT IN CALIFORNIA THE
EDUCATION IN ORDER TO HAVE A
VOICE. THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU. AND I WELL PRESENTED
AND I COMMEND YOU FOR YOUR
ADVOCACY. ARE THERE ANY OTHERS
HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF THE MEASURE? SO
PLEASE COME FORWARD AND. YES I
AM. PLEASE COME TO THE
MICROPHONE AND Þ. SHE WAS ONE OF
OUR. OH, YOU'RE A LEAD WITNESS.
YES. COME ON UP. YEAH. TAKE YOUR
SEAT. SORRY. THERE'S A FIELD
FELLOW WITH POWER. CALIFORNIA.
VERY GOOD. WELCOME. HAVE A SEAT.
SORRY, EVERYBODY. QUITE ALL
RIGHT, I DIDN'T ANTICIPATE ALL
THAT TRAFFIC IN THE CAPITAL, I
APOLOGIZE, YOU HAVE THREE
MINUTES. PLEASE PROCEED. SURE.
THANK YOU. MY NAME IS MARIA
TELLEZ. I LIVE IN PITTSBURG,
CALIFORNIA. I AM REPRESENTED
ACTUALLY, BY SENATOR GLAZIER,
WHO I DON'T SEE, BUT, FOR THE
PAST TWO MONTHS, I HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK ON A VOTER
REGISTRATION PROGRAM, AND I HAD
THE PRIVILEGE TO GO BACK TO MY
HIGH SCHOOL, MY ALMA MATER IN
PITTSBURG HIGH SCHOOL, TO
FACILITATE PRESENTATIONS ON THE
IMPORTANCE OF VOTING AND GETTING
STUDENTS TO REGISTER AND
PREREGISTER TO VOTE. MY TEAM AND
I WERE ABLE TO REGISTER AND
PRE-REGISTER OVER 400 STUDENTS.
I WAS BLOWN AWAY BY THE
ATTENTION AND SERIOUSNESS IN
WHICH THESE STUDENTS TOOK THE
PRESENTATION AND DECIDED THAT
THEY WOULD REGISTER AND
PRE-REGISTER TO VOTE. THEY
SHOWED THAT YOUNG PEOPLE ARE
READY TO LISTEN AND READY TO
EXERCISE THEIR VOICE. ALL THEY
NEED IS THE INFORMATION TO BE
ABLE TO COMMIT. HOWEVER, THERE
WAS A HIGH SCHOOL IN THE
DISTRICT THAT DID NOT ALLOW,
THAT DID NOT ALLOW ME TO DO THE
PRESENTATIONS. SORRY. AB 2747
ENSURES THAT ALL HIGH SCHOOLERS
GET THE INFORMATION THEY NEED TO
STRENGTHEN THEIR PRESENTATION IN
OUR GOVERNMENT AND THAT VOTER,
PRE-REGISTRATION HAPPENS AT ALL
HIGH SCHOOLS IN CALIFORNIA.
FURTHERMORE, IN HIGH SCHOOL,
YOUNG VOTERS ARE ALREADY
LEARNING ABOUT CIVICS AND
GOVERNMENT, WHICH MAKES IT A
PERFECT OPPORTUNITY FOR THEM TO
EXERCISE REAL WORLD CIVIC
PARTICIPATION. EVIDENCE SHOWS
THAT WHEN YOUNG PEOPLE VOTE IN
THEIR FIRST FEW CONSECUTIVE
ELECTIONS, THEY BECOME LIFETIME
VOTERS FROM THE LAST ELECTION
CYCLES, WE'VE SEEN MORE AND MORE
YOUNG PEOPLE TURN OUT TO THE
POLLS TO VOTE ON ISSUES THAT
MATTER TO THEM AND THEIR
COMMUNITIES. BEING A DACA
RECIPIENT, I CANNOT VOTE. SO I
DO ALL THAT I CAN TO ENCOURAGE
OTHERS TO VOTE, ESPECIALLY YOUNG
PEOPLE. I URGE YOU TO SUPPORT AB
2740 24 AND GIVE YOUNG FOLKS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SURPRISE YOU.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ONCE AGAIN.
ANY OTHERS WHO'D LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT YOUR NAME, YOUR
ORGANIZATION, YOUR POSITION.
WELCOME GOOD MORNING, LUCY
SALCIDO CARTER, ON BEHALF OF THE
ALAMEDA COUNTY BOARD OF
EDUCATION IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
ANYBODY ELSE, SEEING NONE. DO WE
HAVE ANYBODY WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
MEASURE? UNSURPRISINGLY, SEEING
NONE, LET'S COME BACK TO THE
DAIS. COMMENTS, QUESTIONS? NO
COMMENTS. QUESTIONS. SO I WILL
SAY GLAD TO SUPPORT THE MEASURE,
APPRECIATE THE WORK YOU'RE
DOING. APPRECIATE BOTH THE
WITNESSES. I WOULD ARGUE THERE'S
A THERE'S AN ADDITIONAL NEED,
WHICH IS TO BETTER TEACH CIVICS
IN SCHOOL. THAT'S A CONVERSATION
FOR ANOTHER DAY. ANOTHER BILL,
BUT WITH THAT, WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE? I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR. I VOTED APPROPRIATE TIME.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU. WE'LL TAKE
A MOTION AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME, AND WE'LL TAKE A VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH TO THE
WITNESSES. HERE, ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ADAMS IS HERE, WELCOME. AND THE
BILL NUMBER IS. WELL, THANK YOU,
HONORABLE CHAIR. MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE STAFF, MY STAFF, OUR
WITNESSES THAT ARE HERE TODAY. A
LOT OF EFFORT HAS GONE INTO
BRINGING THIS BEFORE YOU, AND IT
TAKES A TEAM. AND SO I WANT TO
SAY THANK YOU TO THAT TEAM. I'M
HERE TODAY TO ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON AB 1971, THE STUDENT
PRIVACY PROTECTION ACT AS PUBLIC
EDUCATION. AND THE INTERNET
CONTINUE TO BECOME MORE AND MORE
INTERTWINED, IT IS IMPERATIVE
THAT CALIFORNIA TAKES THE
APPROPRIATE STEPS TO ENSURE THE
SAFETY OF OUR STUDENTS. AN OFTEN
OVERLOOKED ASPECT OF STUDENT
SAFETY IS AROUND A STUDENT'S
PERSONAL DATA, WHICH IS
INCREASINGLY AT RISK OF MISUSE
AS THE INTERNET AND I BECOME
INTEGRATED WITH DIFFERENT
ASPECTS OF PUBLIC EDUCATION THE
STUDENT PRIVACY ONLINE, PERSONAL
INFORMATION PROTECTION ACT, OR
SOPA, WAS CREATED IN 2014 WITH
THE INTENT OF PROVIDING
SUBSTANTIAL PROTECTIONS TO
PERSONAL STUDENT DATA IN K-12
EDUCATION. HOWEVER, SOPA HAS A
CRITICAL WEAKNESS THAT WE CAN
FIX THE LANGUAGE DEFINING K-12
PURPOSES IS AMBIGUOUS WHEN IT
COMES TO THE INCLUSION OF
STANDARDIZED TESTING ENTITIES.
THEREFORE, THIS BILL DOES ONE
VERY NARROW THING, BUT VERY
IMPORTANT THING, WHICH IS SIMPLY
TO CLARIFY THAT STUDENT DATA
GATHERED VIA STANDARDIZED
TESTING PLATFORMS IS COVERED BY
THE PRIVACY PROTECTIONS OF SOPA
STANDARD STANDARDIZED TESTS, AND
THE ORGANIZATIONS RESPONSIBLE
FOR THEM GATHER AND USE STUDENT
DATA, AND THEREFORE STUDENT
DATA. PRIVACY PROTECTION SHOULD
BE IN PLACE. STANDARDIZED TESTS
CAPTURE NUMEROUS TYPES OF
SENSITIVE DATA FROM STUDENTS,
INCLUDING GENDER, GENDER
IDENTITY, ETHNICITY, IMMIGRATION
STATUS, NATIONALITY, RELIGIOUS
AFFILIATION, AND MORE, WHICH
HIGHLIGHTS THE NEED FOR
STRINGENT DATA PROTECTIONS BY
ADDING STANDARDIZED TESTS
EXPLICITLY INTO THE DEFINITION
OF K-12 SCHOOL PURPOSES,
STUDENTS WILL BE ABLE TO TRUST
THAT THEIR DATA STAYS OUT OF THE
HANDS OF THIRD PARTY VENDORS
THAT TRULY HAVE NO BUSINESS IN
PUBLIC EDUCATION. SO WITH ME
TODAY AS WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
ARE ANNIE CHAU, LEGISLATIVE
ADVOCATE FOR THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION, AND THEN
HAYDEN MEYER, A GRANITE BAY HIGH
SCHOOL RISING SENIOR WHO JUST
COMPLETED AN AP US HISTORY AS
PART OF HIS COURSE OF STUDY. SO
I'LL TURN IT OVER TO ANNIE,
WHO'S FIRST. I'LL GO FIRST. ALL
RIGHT, MR. CHAIR, WELCOME. GOOD
MORNING. THANK YOU, THANK YOU,
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. AND
MEMBERS, I'M ANNIE CHOW WITH THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION,
PROUD SUPPORTERS OF AB 1971.
THIS BILL SEEKS TO BETTER ALIGN
SOPA WITH EXISTING STATE AND
FEDERAL LAWS THAT PROTECT
CONSUMER PRIVACY AND STUDENT
PRIVACY. STUDENTS ARE REQUIRED
TO TAKE VARIOUS STANDARDIZED
TESTS TO GRADUATE FROM HIGH
SCHOOL WITH A GED OR BE
CONSIDERED FOR COLLEGE
ADMISSIONS AND FOR FINANCIAL AID
FOR THOSE INSTITUTIONS. WHILE
STUDENT STUDENTS ACADEMIC
INFORMATION IS PROTECTED UNDER
FERPA, UNFORTUNATELY, THEY ARE
NOT ALWAYS PROTECTED WHEN THEY
TAKE THEIR GED OR MAKE A
DECISION TO TAKE TESTS IN ORDER
TO GO TO COLLEGE. VENDORS OF
STANDARDIZED TESTS HAVE THE
ABILITY TO COLLECT AND RETAIN A
GREAT DEAL OF INFORMATION ABOUT
STUDENTS THAT USE THEIR
PRODUCTS, AND WE MUST CLOSE GAPS
TO ENSURE THAT INFORMATION IS
APPROPRIATELY PROTECTED. AS
STUDENTS TAKE THE LEAP TOWARDS
ADULTHOOD. AB 1971 PROTECTS
STUDENT PRIVACY RIGHTS WHILE
ALLOWING THEM TO FURTHER THEIR
GOALS POST HIGH SCHOOL. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME. URGE YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY, MR. MAYER. WELCOME
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE SENATE
EDUCATION COMMITTEE, THANK YOU
FOR ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT OF AB 1971.
IF YOU CAN PUT THE MIC JUST A
LITTLE CLOSER. OKAY, MY NAME IS
HAYDEN MAYER, AND I'M A SENIOR
AT GRANITE BAY HIGH SCHOOL.
THROUGHOUT MY HIGH SCHOOL
CAREER, I HAD MULTIPLE
INTERACTIONS WITH STANDARDIZED
TESTING ORGANIZATIONS FROM THE
PSAT AS A SOPHOMORE TO THE SAT
AND ACT AS A JUNIOR AT MY HIGH
SCHOOL, ALL STUDENTS WERE
ENCOURAGED TO TAKE THESE TESTS
AS THEY WERE SEEN AS MANDATORY
STEPS TOWARDS HIGHER EDUCATION.
EVEN THOUGH SOME UNIVERSITIES
REMOVE THE REQUIREMENT TO
SUPPORT SAT SCORES. I KNOW FROM
PERSONAL EXPERIENCE THAT MANY
STUDENTS SEE THESE TESTS AS AN
ESSENTIAL PIECE OF THEIR COLLEGE
APPLICATIONS, WITH OVER 1.9
MILLION STUDENTS TAKING THE SAT
EVERY YEAR. I KNOW THAT THIS
BELIEF IS NOT CONFINED TO MY
HIGH SCHOOL, APART FROM
STANDARDIZED TESTS. ANOTHER
CONSTANT, TODAY'S K THROUGH 12
EDUCATION SYSTEMS TECHNOLOGY
FROM WHEN I STARTED KINDERGARTEN
TO MY GRADUATION FROM HIGH
SCHOOL LAST MAY. THE AMOUNT OF
TECHNOLOGY STUDENTS INTERACT
WITH ON A DAILY BASIS HAS
INCREASED EXPONENTIALLY, WITH
TECHNOLOGY AND THE INTERNET
BECOMING INCREASINGLY INTEGRATED
WITH WITHIN THE CLASSROOM, IT IS
MORE IMPORTANT THAN EVER THAT
STUDENTS HAVE ADEQUATE, ADEQUATE
PROTECTIONS FOR THEIR DATA.
STUDENTS NEED TO BE ABLE TO
TRUST THEIR SCHOOLS AND THE
VENDORS THEIR SCHOOLS CONTRACT
WITH TO TREAT THEIR SENSITIVE
PERSONAL DATA WITH THE NECESSARY
PROTECTIONS. AB 1971 WILL ENSURE
THAT STUDENTS CAN MAINTAIN THAT
TRUST IN THEIR SCHOOLS, CLOSING
A LOOPHOLE THAT ALLOWS
STANDARDIZED TESTING.
ORGANIZATIONS TO SHARE STUDENT
DATA WITHOUT STUDENTS EXPRESSED
CONSENT. AS A RECENT GRADUATE OF
ONE OF CALIFORNIA'S HIGH
SCHOOLS, I URGE YOU TO VOTE AYE
AYE ON AB 1971. THANK YOU, THANK
YOU. WELL DONE, DO WE HAVE OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF THE
MEASURE? PLEASE COME FORWARD.
REBECCA KRAMER, MATTER ON BEHALF
OF ACLU CALIFORNIA ACTION IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. ANYBODY ELSE
IN SUPPORT OF THE MEASURE?
OPPOSITION. IF YOU ARE, WE DO WE
HAVE LEAD WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION? IF SO, PLEASE COME
TO THE TABLE. WELCOME. I SEE WE
HAVE TWO, THREE MINUTES EACH,
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY. WELCOME.
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS
JENNIFER SMITH. I SERVE AS
ASSOCIATE GENERAL COUNSEL FOR
PRIVACY FOR COLLEGE BOARD. I
HAVE BEEN IN HIGHER EDUCATION
FOR NEARLY MY ENTIRE 20 YEAR
LEGAL CAREER, MOST RECENTLY
JOINING COLLEGE BOARD. COLLEGE
BOARD OPPOSES ÁP 1971. AS IT
APPEARS BEFORE YOU TODAY. THIS
IS AN UNFORTUNATE SITUATION OF
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES WHICH
WILL HARM CALIFORNIA STUDENTS
AND FAMILIES. THIS BILL ATTEMPTS
TO AMEND SOPA AS WAS APTLY
DESCRIBED BY OTHERS, WHICH DOES
GOVERN EDTECH IN THE CLASSROOM.
THE RESTRICTIONS ON USE AND
DISCLOSURE OF STUDENT DATA BY
EDTECH VENDORS IN THE CLASSROOM
MAKE GREAT SENSE WITH WHICH WE
COMPLY, INCLUDING FOR THE
ASSESSMENT SPOKEN ABOUT THE
WITNESSES YOU'VE HEARD FROM
ALREADY TODAY. BUT BY DESIGN,
THE BILL BEFORE YOU WILL REACH
OUTSIDE THE CLASSROOM AND GOVERN
WHAT STUDENTS AND FAMILIES DO AT
HOME. THE LATEST SET OF
AMENDMENTS SHATTERS THE
FRAMEWORK OF SOPA BY ADDING TO
ITS SCOPE THE ADMINISTRATION OF
STANDARDIZED TESTS TAKEN ON A
WEEKEND CHOSEN BY A STUDENT,
PAID FOR BY THEIR PARENT
COMPLETELY AT THEIR OWN
DISCRETION, BY APPLYING SOPA TO
A CONSUMER CONTEXT, IT WILL
RESULT IN EXTRAORDINARY
CIRCUMSTANCE CONSEQUENCES,
INCLUDING DENYING COLLEGES
DIVERSE RECRUITMENT AND HITTING
UNREPRESENTED STUDENTS THE
HARDEST. LET ME EXPLAIN. WHEN
YOU REGISTER FOR THE SAT WEEKEND
, YOU DO SO THROUGH THE COLLEGE
BOARD WEBSITE AND YOU CREATE A
PERSONAL ACCOUNT TO WHICH HIGH
SCHOOLS DO NOT AND SHOULD NOT
HAVE ACCESS. YOU THEN, AS A
STUDENT, CAN USE THAT SAT DATA
TO CREATE A PROFILE TO ACCESS
OTHER COLLEGE AND CAREER
READINESS PROGRAMS, TO SHARE
DATA WITH SCHOLARSHIP PROGRAMS
AND HEAR FROM POST-SECONDARY
OPPORTUNITIES. ALL OF THIS IS
NOW BEING QUESTIONED UNDER THIS
BILL, BECAUSE THOSE ACTIVITIES
ARE EXACTLY THE TYPE RESTRICTED
UNDER SOPA. WHEN IN A CLASSROOM.
VERY IMPORTANTLY, STUDENTS MAY
NOT BE ABLE TO PARTICIPATE IN
STUDENT SEARCH SERVICE. STUDENTS
WHO PARTICIPATE IN SEARCH ARE
CONTACTED BY COLLEGES AND
RECEIVE, ON AVERAGE, 29% MORE
OFFERS FOR ADMISSION. THERE ARE
CURRENTLY 828,000 CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS PARTICIPATING IN SEARCH
. 85 CALIFORNIA COLLEGES WHO
RELY ON SEARCH TO HAVE A
DIVERSITY PIPELINE FOR THEIR
COLLEGE ADMISSION AND FILL THEIR
CLASSES. HISPANIC STUDENTS FOUND
TO PARTICIPATE IN SEARCH ENROLL
IN A FOUR YEAR COLLEGE AT A RATE
8.3 POINTS HIGHER PERCENT HIGHER
THAN SIMILARLY SITUATED HISPANIC
STUDENTS. BLACK AND HISPANIC
STUDENTS WHO RECEIVE SEARCH
ENABLED COLLEGE OUTREACH. THE
MAIL YOU PROBABLY ALL GOT WHEN
YOU WERE YOUNG, OR HAVE FAMILY
MEMBERS OR OTHERS IN YOUR LIFE
WHO GET MAIL ABOUT COLLEGE AND
UNIVERSITY OPPORTUNITIES.
HISPANIC AND BLACK STUDENTS, 46
AND 66, RESPECTIVELY, ARE MORE
LIKELY TO APPLY FOR COLLEGE THAN
THOSE SIMILARLY, AND IDENTICALLY
SITUATED BLACK AND HISPANIC
STUDENTS WHO DO NOT RECEIVE
THOSE MAILINGS THROUGH SEARCH.
AND THIS MIGHT JUST BE THE
BEGINNING. NOT ONLY WOULD THIS
DIVERSITY PIPELINE FOR COLLEGES
AND ACROSS THE COUNTRY BE
POTENTIALLY BLOCKED, THE REACH
INTO SAT WEAKENED BY THIS BILL
COULD DENY STUDENTS THE CHANCE
TO LEARN ABOUT AND APPLY FOR
SCHOLARSHIPS, APPLY FOR
FINANCIAL AID, LOSE CONTROL OVER
THEIR PERSONAL DATA THROUGH
THEIR PERSONAL ACCOUNT, WHERE
THEY LEVERAGE THEIR OWN COLLEGE
AND CAREER JOURNEY. WORKING
DIRECTLY WITH COLLEGE BOARD.
EVEN THE BASIC SENDING OF THEIR
AP EXAM SCORE COULD BE
JEOPARDIZED, AS THIS BILL IS
WRITTEN. TO BE CLEAR, COLLEGE
BOARD HAS GREAT RESPECT FOR
STUDENT PRIVACY. WE WOULD BE
PLEASED TO SUPPORT ONGOING
PROTECTIONS FOR STUDENTS AND
THEIR FAMILIES AS WE DO TODAY,
THROUGH COMPREHENSIVE PRIVACY
POLICIES. ONLY COMPLIANT WITH
SOPA FOR ALL IN SCHOOL
ASSESSMENTS AND PROVIDE CHOICE
FOR STUDENTS TAKING AWAY THE
CHOICE FOR STUDENTS UNDER THE
GUISE OF PRIVACY IS UNTENABLE,
AND THUS THIS BILL MUST BE
REJECTED. I'D BE HAPPY TO
ADDRESS QUESTIONS. THANK YOU,
NEXT WITNESS, PLEASE. GOOD
MORNING. CAN YOU HEAR ME? YES.
OKAY MY NAME IS MARY LAFAYE AND
I WORK FOR ACT. I WORK FOR A
COMPANY THAT HAS FOR THE PAST 65
YEARS, MADE IT OUR MISSION TO
SERVE INDIVIDUALS OF ANY AGE TO
ACHIEVE EDUCATION AND WORKPLACE
SUCCESS. THAT IS OUR MISSION. I
SIT HERE AS SOMEONE WHO, FOR 15
YEARS, WITH THAT SAME
ORGANIZATION, HAS BEEN A
RESEARCHER AND A POLICY ANALYST,
AND ONLY FOR THE PAST THREE
YEARS IN GOVERNMENT RELATIONS
TRIED TO POSITIVELY IMPACT
EDUCATION AND WORKFORCE POLICY.
VOTING YES ON AB 1971 COULD
REDUCE THE NUMBER OF LOW INCOME
AND MINORITY STUDENTS IN
CALIFORNIA THAT ARE RECRUITED BY
COLLEGES. SINCE THE HARVARD UNC
SUPREME COURT DECISION LAST
YEAR. LEGALLY, COLLEGES CANNOT
USE RACE IN ADMISSIONS DECISIONS
, AND INSTEAD THEY RELY UPON
SERVICES LIKE THE ONE CHEN
DESCRIBED AND THOSE SIMILAR
SERVICES THAT ACT PROVIDES IN
ORDER TO RECRUIT A MORE DIVERSE
INCOMING CLASS. HELPING STUDENTS
TO CONNECT WITH COLLEGES THAT
WANT TO ADMIT MORE DIVERSE
STUDENTS, HELPING MORE
MINORITIES THAT HAVE STRUGGLED
AND ADMITTING STUDENTS WHO HAVE
OVERCOME CHALLENGES COULD BE A
PROHIBITED ACTIVITY UNDER AB
1971. I'M NOT A LAWYER, BUT I DO
KNOW GOOD POLICY. I URGE EACH
COMMITTEE MEMBER TODAY TO ASK
THE QUESTION, HOW WILL THIS BILL
IMPACT UNDERSERVED STUDENTS IN
CALIFORNIA, AND TO RESPECTFULLY
CONSIDER OUR OPPOSITION TO AB
1971? THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ARE
THERE OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC HERE WHO'D LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO THE
MEASURE? SO PLEASE COME FORWARD.
I'M SEEING NONE, COME BACK TO
THE DAIS. COLLEAGUES, QUESTIONS,
CONCERNS ABOUT THE BILL, LET ME
START, SO PRIVACY PROTECTION
DATA, OBVIOUSLY AN IMPORTANT
THING FOR THE STATE, ON BEHALF
OF STUDENTS AND OTHERS, WE'VE
HAD TWO BILLS OVER THE LAST
DECADE THAT ARE EXPRESSLY GEARED
TOWARD ENSURING BETTER HANDLING
OF DATA AND THE PROTECTION OF
PRIVATE INFORMATION. MY
UNDERSTANDING, THOUGH, IS THAT
ACT AND COLLEGE BOARD HAVE MADE
A PRACTICE OF SELLING USER
INFORMATION. IS THAT CORRECT?
SURE. OKAY. HERE WE GO. SO WE DO
NOT SELL STUDENT DATA. WE
LICENSE IT FOR LIMITED TIME AND
A LIMITED PURPOSE TO
UNIVERSITIES TO ONLY USE FOR
RECRUITMENT. BUT IT'S STILL ON
A, ON A, ON A PAID BASIS. YOU
STILL THERE IS A SERVICE THAT IS
A SERVICE WE DO NOT PROVIDE FOR
FREE. IT IS SOMETHING THAT A
STUDENT CAN OPT INTO AND FOR US
TO PROVIDE THE SERVICE TO THE
COLLEGES, TO CONNECT WITH
STUDENTS. WE DO CHARGE A
LICENSING FEE. AND THE PROVISION
OF THOSE THOSE RECORDS, IS IT
LIMITED TO THOSE RECORDS,
ASSOCIATED WITH STUDENTS WHO
HAVE OPTED IN EXPRESSLY? YES
EXPRESS OPT IN. OKAY. AND WE ARE
FULLY COMPLIANT WITH CCPA, WE
KNOW THAT THERE WAS A PERCEIVED
LOOPHOLE WITH CCPA FOR
NONPROFITS AS YOU MAY OR MAY NOT
HAVE HEARD, ACT UNDERWENT A
TRANSITION WITHIN THE LAST
COUPLE OF MONTHS. WE ARE NOW A
FOR PROFIT PUBLIC BENEFIT
EDUCATION CORPORATION, AND ARE
FULLY UNDER THE JURISDICTION OF
CCPA AND ARE ALREADY FULLY
COMPLIANT WITH THAT LAW. OKAY,
AND MISS SMITH, THE COLLEGE
BOARD IS STILL A NONPROFIT, BUT
STILL, OPERATES THE SAME
SERVICE, SAME PRACTICE. RIGHT.
LICENSES DATA ON A PER RECORD
PAYMENT. IT IS NOT ON A PER
RECORD PAYMENT. SO EXCELLENT
QUESTION. SO THE STUDENT SEARCH
SERVICE ONE IS FREE TO STUDENTS
AND TWO, THE COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES AND NONPROFIT
SCHOLARSHIP ORGANIZATIONS THAT
SUBSCRIBE TO OUR ENROLLMENT
SOLUTIONS PAY A SUBSCRIPTION
FEE. IT'S A FLAT FEE. THERE IS
NO PER NAME FEE. THAT WAS AN
HISTORICAL PRACTICE OF COLLEGE
BOARD THAT HAS SINCE EXPIRED.
AND IT'S A LUMP SUM SUBSCRIPTION
FEE REGARDLESS OF THE VOLUME OF
RECORDS. AND MOST IMPORTANTLY,
THAT PROGRAM IS NOT NOT PART OF
OUR IN SCHOOL TESTING
EXPERIENCE. SO PIPPA ALREADY
PROHIBITS THE SALE OF STUDENT
DATA. IT ALREADY PROHIBITS US AS
AN EDTECH VENDOR WHEN WE ARE
OFFERING IN-SCHOOL ASSESSMENTS
INCLUSIVE OF THE PSAT AND OTHER
ASSESSMENTS SPOKEN TO BY OTHERS.
WE DO NOT PRESENT THAT SEARCH,
OPT IN TO STUDENTS IN THEIR IN
SCHOOL EXPERIENCE. WE DO NOT USE
THE DATA AT ALL COLLECTED
THROUGH THAT IN SCHOOL
EXPERIENCE FOR SEARCH THAT IS
ENTIRELY DONE. IF A STUDENT ON
THEIR OWN WERE TO CHOOSE TO COME
TO COLLEGE BOARD AND ENGAGE WITH
US FOR THEIR OWN PROGRAMS AND
SERVICES, SUCH AS WANTING TO
REGISTER FOR THE SAT WEEKEND, OR
TO CREATE A COLLEGE BOARD
ACCOUNT TO CREATE WHAT'S CALLED
A BIG FUTURE EXPERIENCE, WHERE
YOU CAN TAKE COLLEGE AND CAREER
QUIZZES. THROUGH THAT
EXPERIENCE, WE PRESENT TO
STUDENTS THE SEARCH PROGRAM, BUT
IT'S A ROBUST NOTICE WITH AN
AFFIRMATIVE OPEN CHECKBOX
CONSENT, WITH AN OPT OUT
MECHANISM AVAILABLE AT ANY TIME.
AND IT'S VERY CLEAR. AND EVEN WE
TELL STUDENTS IN THAT NOTICE
THAT WE CHARGE A FEE TO THE
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES TO
WHOM THEIR DATA IS DISCLOSED TO
SUPPORT OUR NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION, TO TRULY JUST FEED
RIGHT BACK INTO OUR MISSION. SO
WHILE WE CHARGE VÆ, IT'S NOT TO
THE STUDENTS. SO TO SO TO YOUR
POINT THAT, YOU KNOW, THERE'S
MAKING A DISTINCTION IN SCHOOL,
NOT IN SCHOOL. I THINK MR. MEYER
MADE A VERY GOOD POINT, WHICH IS
TO A STUDENT, IT'S ACTUALLY LESS
CLEAR THESE ARE THINGS THAT
COULD SAFELY OR FAIRLY BE
REGARDED AS NECESSARY STEPS
TAKING THE SATS. RIGHT.
TECHNICALLY, YOU'RE NOT DOING
THAT IN SCHOOL, BUT AS A MATTER
OF COURSE, IF YOU WANT TO
PROCEED, TO HIGHER EDUCATION,
YOU'RE GOING TO DO THAT. RIGHT?
SO I DON'T THINK A STUDENT MAKES
THE SAME DISTINCTION, BUT TO
EITHER THE AUTHOR, MR. MEYER,
LIKE WHAT? WHAT WHAT'S THE
ISSUE? AS YOU SEE IT, WITH A
STUDENT WHO HAS AFFIRMATIVELY
OPTED IN, CHECKBOX CLEAR
LANGUAGE TO RECEIVING THOSE
KINDS OF OFFERS OR OTHER
INFORMATION. IT'S CLEARLY TO THE
GOOD IF THEY'VE BEEN PROPERLY
APPRIZED. NO, I APPRECIATE THE
QUESTION. AND I WOULD SAY ALSO
21 YEAR EDUCATOR STANDING HERE,
TESTIFYING MYSELF, A MOM OF A
HIGH SCHOOL SENIOR AS WELL AS
SOMEONE WHO JUST GRADUATED HIGH
SCHOOL, SO HAVE THE EDUCATOR
BACKGROUND AS WELL AS THE PARENT
BACKGROUND AS WELL AS THE
LEGISLATIVE BACKGROUND ON THIS.
WE AGREE WE WOULD LIKE THIS DATA
TO BE ACCESSIBLE FOR STUDENTS TO
CONNECT WITH UNIVERSITIES. WE
THINK THAT'S AN IMPORTANT PIECE
OF THIS. AND SO WE HAVE PROPOSED
ADDING AN EXPLICIT EXEMPTION TO
ALLOW THE SALE OR THE LICENSING,
WHAT HAVE YOU OF STUDENT DATA TO
COLLEGES FOR THE PURPOSE OF
ADMISSION OR ACCESS TO FINANCIAL
AID. AND THAT'S AN AUTHOR
AMENDMENT THAT WE ARE HAPPY TO
TAKE BETWEEN THIS COMMITTEE AND
THE NEXT, DUE TO THE TIMELINE,
ON NEGOTIATED OPTIONS, WE
WEREN'T ABLE TO GET IT DONE
BEFORE THIS. ADDITIONALLY, WE
HAVE PROPOSED ANOTHER EXPLICIT
EXEMPTION WHICH WOULD EXEMPT
ACTIVITIES FROM SOPA'S
REQUIREMENTS IF THOSE ACTIVITIES
DO NOT MEET THE DEFINITION OF
K-12 SCHOOL PURPOSES. SO THIS
WOULD ENSURE THAT SERVICES
PROVIDED BY THE OPPOSITION THAT
SHOULDN'T BE UNDER SOPA WOULD
NOT BE UNDER SOPA. SO WE ARE IN
NO WAY TRYING TO STOP ACCESS OF
LOW INCOME PEOPLE OR PEOPLE OF
COLOR OR ANY GROUP FROM
ACCESSING COLLEGES, BECAUSE
THAT'S WHY THEY'RE TAKING THESE
TESTS. YOU ENROLL IN AP CLASSES,
YOU ENROLL IN AP TESTS, YOU
ENROLL IN THE ACT, YOU ENROLL IN
THE SAT EXPLICITLY BECAUSE YOU
WANT TO GO TO COLLEGE. AND SO
THAT'S NOT WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
LIMIT, WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
LIMIT IS THE AND LET ME JUST SAY
WE HAVE SHARED THESE AMENDMENTS
WITH OPPOSITION. THEY HAVE NOT
SAID YES TO THEM. I THINK WE'RE
IN ONGOING CONVERSATIONS, AND
I'M ABSOLUTELY PERSONALLY
OPTIMISTIC. I DON'T THINK YOU
HEARD THAT. BUT PERSONALLY, I
THINK WE CAN GET THERE. SO WHAT
WE WANT TO LIMIT JUST TO BE A
LITTLE MORE SUCCINCT, IS THIS
DATA GOING TO OTHER PARTIES THAT
REALLY SHOULDN'T HAVE THIS DATA.
AND IT IS THERE IS A HISTORY OF
THAT HAPPENING. OKAY. SO
NOTWITHSTANDING THAT HISTORY, TO
THE EXTENT THAT PUBLIC BENEFIT
CORPORATION, NONPROFIT IN THE
SERVICE OF YOUR BROADER MISSION,
I ASSUME YOU'RE OPEN TO THOSE
CONVERSATIONS? VERY MUCH SO. WE
HAVE BEEN WE HAVE BEEN ACTIVELY
ENGAGED. AND THE COMPLEXITY HERE
ABOUT TRYING TO INTRODUCE THE
SAT WEEKEND IN THOSE OTHER
WEBSITE ACTIVITIES, WHEN A
STUDENT COMES TO COLLEGE BOARD
TO ENGAGE PERSONALLY AND TRYING
TO PULL APART, ONLY PROTECTING
THAT SAT WEEKEND DATA IS THAT
IT'S ALL INTEGRATED. SO WHEN YOU
COME TO THE COLLEGE BOARD
WEBSITE, YOU CREATE A PERSONAL
ACCOUNT AND YOU PROVIDE
INFORMATION ABOUT YOURSELF, ALL
OPTIONAL. AND COLLEGE BOARD THEN
CREATES A PROFILE THAT'S
EXPLICITLY PROHIBITED BY SOPA,
CREATING OF A PROFILE. BUT I'M
SORRY TO INTERRUPT, BUT TO YOUR
THE AUTHOR IS WILLING TO FIND A
BASIS FOR MAKING THE APPROPRIATE
EXEMPTION THERE. CORRECT?
ABSOLUTELY ONLY IF THIS IS
CONNECTED TO UNIVERSITY AND
SCHOLARSHIP ADMISSION,
REGARDLESS OF WHEN THE TEST,
WHETHER IT'S ON THE WEEKEND OR
DURING SCHOOL HOURS. UNDERSTOOD
BUT THAT'S THE POINT, IS THAT
THERE IS NO SEGMENTATION. SO
WHEN A STUDENT CREATES A COLLEGE
BOARD ACCOUNT AND USES THAT TO
CREATE FOR SAT WEEKEND, THAT
COLLEGE BOARD ACCOUNT INCLUDES
THAT PERSONALLY IDENTIFIABLE
INFORMATION THAT THEY CAN THEN
USE ONE TO REGISTER FOR THE SAT
WEEKEND. AND OR EXPERIENCE ALL
THOSE OTHER SUITES OF BIG FUTURE
AND COLLEGE AND CAREER READINESS
TOOLS LIKE COLLEGE CAREER
QUIZZES AND WHATNOT. AND SO THIS
PROPOSED AMENDMENT TO TRY TO SAY
ONLY THE PART OR PORTION OF YOUR
WEBSITE, THAT'S FOR SAT WEEKEND
IS COVERED AND ALL THE OTHERS IS
NOT IS A FACTUAL FICTION BECAUSE
YOU CAN'T SEGMENT A ONE PERSONAL
ACCOUNT WHERE A STUDENT PROVIDES
THEIR PERSONAL INFORMATION TO
ACCESS ALL OF COLLEGE BOARD'S
CONSUMER PROGRAMS AND SERVICES,
AND ONLY SEGMENT THE SAT WEEKEND
PART VERSUS COLLEGE AND CAREER
READINESS QUIZZES VERSUS
APPLYING FOR FINANCIAL AID
VERSUS THE WHOLE SUITE OF
SERVICES. IT'S ONE COLLEGE BOARD
ACCOUNT. IT'S NOT WALLED OFF ON
ONE LITTLE PART OF THE WEBSITE.
AND SO THE AMENDMENT IS
NONSENSICAL. IT'S IMPOSSIBLE TO
DEPLOY BECAUSE A PROFILE IS
CREATED. IT'S USED TO SERVE
COLLEGE AND CAREER READINESS,
USING THAT STUDENT DATA FOR ALL
OF THOSE NONPROFIT EDUCATION
MISSION PURPOSES. AGAIN, YOU
CAN'T JUST PULL OFF WHAT'S DONE
FOR SAT WEEKEND REGISTRATION
BECAUSE YOU FIRST CREATE A
COLLEGE BOARD ACCOUNT TO THEN
REGISTER FOR SAT WEEKEND. SO WE
ALREADY HAVE THE DATA FOR THE
ACCOUNT. THAT'S USED FOR
MULTIPLE PURPOSES, AND WE CAN'T
ALLOW THE COLLEGE BOARD ACCOUNT
TO BE SUBJECT TO SOPA. AND
THAT'S WHERE IT BECOMES ROUND
HOLE, SQUARE PEG TO TRY TO TAKE
ALL THE PROVISIONS OF SOPA THAT
WERE WRITTEN ABOUT EDTECH IN THE
CLASSROOM ROOM AND PUT IT ON A
CONSUMER CONTEXT, JUST DOES NOT
FIT. BUT IT DOES SEEM WORTH
TRYING. IF THE ALTERNATIVE IS
SOMETHING THAT'S FAIRLY RESTRICT
FROM YOUR POINT OF VIEW. AND IT
SEEMS TO ME THERE'S TWO ISSUES
HOW DATA IS HANDLED AND HOW AN
OPT IN IS CONSTRUCTED. I WOULD
THINK THAT'S THAT WOULD BE A
SOLVABLE PROBLEM FOR SOME
COMBINATION OF YOUR LAWYERS AND
YOUR YOUR WEB FOLKS. BUT IF YOU
SAY NO, THEN I GUESS THE CHOICE
FOR US IS ACTUALLY FAIRLY BINARY
HERE, SO, I MEAN, I HOPE YOU'D
BE WILLING TO DO THAT, AND I
GUESS I'D BE LOOKING FOR A
COMMITMENT TO DO THAT. BUT YOU
KNOW, ABSENT THAT COMMITMENT, WE
HAVE A CHOICE HERE. EITHER TO
PROTECT STUDENTS ALL IN OR TO
EXCEED HERE. AND I THINK IN WAYS
THAT MOST OF US WOULD AGREE WITH
AT THE AT THE PROSPECTIVE OF, TO
THE DETRIMENT OF STUDENT
PRIVACY, ESPECIALLY GIVEN
EXISTING LAW. SO I GUESS THE
QUESTION REALLY IS FOR YOU
FOLKS, IS THAT SOMETHING YOU'RE
WILLING TO CONTINUE WORKING ON?
BECAUSE I'M UNDERSTANDING FROM
THE AUTHOR THAT YOU ARE. WE
ABSOLUTELY ARE, ARE HAPPY AND
AGREE THIS. I MEAN, I DON'T COME
TO THE TABLE DRAGGING MY FEET. I
ABSOLUTELY UNDERSTAND THE
IMPORTANCE OF SHARING THIS DATA
WITH UNIVERSITIES AND WITH
SCHOLARSHIPS. WE WANT KIDS AND
WE WANT FAMILIES TO KNOW THAT
WHEN THEY GO TO TAKE THE SAT,
WHEN THEY GO TO TAKE THE AP
TEST, THERE'S A PURPOSE FOR
THAT. THE EXPRESS PURPOSE IS TO
GET INTO COLLEGE AND TO GET
HIGHER GRADES. UNDERSTOOD?
UNDERSTOOD YOU KNOW, THE REAL
QUESTION HERE IS FOR I'M SURE
YOUR YOUR, YOUR SORT OF
PROCESSES ARE SLIGHTLY
DIFFERENT, BUT BUT YOUR CONCERNS
ARE THE SAME. YOU KNOW HOW TO
CONSTRUCT A PRIVACY POLICY, BUT
ALSO HOW TO HANDLE DATA SUCH
THAT THE OPT IN INCLUDES THE
ABILITY TO CIRCUMSCRIBE OR
OTHERWISE SUBSET DATA, WHICH
SAYS, YOU KNOW, I'D LIKE ONLY MY
INFORMATION BE SHARED WITH
COLLEGES VERSUS SOMETHING ELSE.
I DON'T KNOW, I'M NOT A I'M NOT
A WEB GUY. I USED TO BE, BUT I
THINK THAT'S A SOLVABLE PROBLEM
IF YOU'RE IF YOU'RE OPEN TO IT,
BUT PARTICULARLY IF IT'S
NECESSARY. SO I GUESS MY
QUESTION TO THE OPPOSITION HERE
IS THAT'S SOMETHING YOU'RE
WILLING TO WORK ON, SPEAKING FOR
MY ORGANIZATION, IT IS SOMETHING
THAT WE ARE ALWAYS WILLING TO
CONTINUE A CONVERSATION TO TRY
TO IMPROVE THE LANGUAGE. IT IS
DIFFICULT FOR ME TO COMMIT TO A
HYPOTHETICAL SET OF, OF, OF
WORDS IN A NARRATIVE THAT MY
LAWYER HASN'T LOOKED AT, BECAUSE
THIS IS THIS IS ABOUT. BUT YES,
THE COMMITMENT TO CONTINUE NØ
RESPECTFULLY, CHAIR, YES TO YOU,
BECAUSE THAT'S REALLY WHAT'S AT
STAKE HERE. WE'RE GOING TO MAKE,
BY DEFINITION, A BINARY VOTE.
IT'S EITHER YES OR NO. THAT YES
COULD INCREASE THE COMMITMENT ON
THE SHARED SORT OF AGREEMENT
BETWEEN THE PARTIES THAT YOU'RE
GOING TO CONTINUE TO WORK ON
THIS. AND IF YOU'RE OPEN TO
THAT, I'M WILLING TO SUPPORT
THAT. BUT ALSO I'M ALSO WILLING
TO BRING IT BACK IF WE DON'T
MAKE ENOUGH PROGRESS. IF I MAY.
CHAIR. YES, I DO BELIEVE
OPPOSITION HAS SEEN THESE
AMENDMENTS. NOT REALLY. THAT'S
NOT REALLY MY CONCERN RIGHT NOW.
IS THIS A WORKABLE SCENARIO?
EXACTLY AND SO AND YOU KNOW, ALL
I'M ASKING FOR IS A GOOD FAITH
EFFORT HERE TO TRY AND DO THAT
BEFORE THE NEXT LEGISLATIVE STEP
. ABSOLUTELY. WE HAVE WE HAVE
PROPOSED SEVERAL ALTERNATIVE
AMENDMENTS TO TRY TO ACHIEVE THE
SAME GOAL AND HAVE EXPENDED
EXTRAORDINARY AMOUNT OF HOURS
WITH THE STAFF AND
REPRESENTATIVES TO GET TO A
REASONABLE SOLUTION. I JUST WANT
TO BE CLEAR THAT IT IS NOT JUST
ABOUT THE OPT IN OPPORTUNITY TO
SHARE THIS DATA WITH COLLEGES
AND UNIVERSITIES. IT'S ABOUT HOW
YOU'VE CONSTRUCTED THESE
PROGRAMS AND HOW THEY HOW THEY
INTERSECT. I UNDERSTAND, BUT I
YOU KNOW, AGAIN, I'D ARGUE THERE
MAY BE BENEFIT, IN FACT,
NECESSARY TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO
HOW TO DECOUPLE THOSE THINGS IN
A WAY THAT WORKS TO PROTECT, TO
MEET THE GOALS OF THE
LEGISLATION. AND SO, YOU KNOW,
WE HAVE A SHARED UNDERSTANDING
HERE, RIGHT? SOME EMIRATIS
YOU'RE WILLING TO CONTINUE. I
UNDERSTAND IT'S NOT A SIMPLE
THING WE HAVE. I MEAN, AGAIN, WE
HAVE THE TWO PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS. WELL, YOUR
AMENDMENTS MIGHT BE A STARTING
POINT. NOT EXACTLY RIGHT. BUT AS
LONG AS YOU'RE WILLING, WE'RE
WILLING TO CONTINUE THE
CONVERSATION. LET'S SAY THAT,
OKAY, WE'RE WILLING TO CONTINUE
THE CONVERSATION. LET US QUICKLY
BEFORE WE LOSE ANOTHER MEMBERS.
LET'S ESTABLISH A QUORUM. I SEE
YOU'VE GOT YOUR TRACK SHOES ON.
SO, MADAM, THERE'S NO NO EXCUSES
NEEDED HERE. GO AHEAD. PLEASE
ESTABLISH A QUORUM. MADAM NEWMAN
HERE. NEWMAN HERE. OKOBOJI.
OKOBOJI. PRESENT. COURTNEY
GLASER. GLASER. PRESENT.
GONZALEZ. SMALLWOOD CUEVAS. WILK
HERE. WILK. HERE. ALL RIGHT. A
QUORUM IS NOW PRESENT, OKAY. SO
QUESTION FOR THE FOR THE AUTHOR.
YOU'RE WILLING TO CONTINUE
CONVERSATIONS, YOU KNOW, NOTING
THAT THIS IS THIS COULD BE
TECHNICALLY FAIRLY CHALLENGING
TO THE OPPOSITION. YOU'RE
WILLING TO CONTINUE. OKAY YOU
KNOW, I'M TRYING TO BE HELPFUL
HERE, BUT I BUT I WILL SAY VERY
CLEARLY, YOU KNOW, I'M GLAD TO
LEARN MORE, PARTICULARLY MISS
SMITH, ABOUT, YOU KNOW, THE SORT
OF THE CHALLENGE, THE INHERENT
CHALLENGES THAT YOU DESCRIBED.
IF IT TURNS OUT THAT THEY'RE NOT
SOLVABLE, I'LL LET YOU KNOW.
I'LL RESPECT THAT. BUT IT SOUNDS
TO ME LIKE IT SHOULD BE,
ESPECIALLY GIVEN SORT OF THE
NATURE OF THE EFFORT HERE, WHICH
IS TO PROTECT PRIVACY OF
STUDENTS, BUT ALSO TO MAINTAIN
THE ABILITY FOR YOUR SERVICES TO
SHARE THAT DATA IN WAYS THAT
SUPPORT THOSE SAME STUDENTS. SO
LAST THOUGHTS ON THAT? NOPE.
HAPPY TO CONTINUE TO WORK ON IT.
VERY GOOD, QUESTION. SENATOR
GLASER, CHAIR NEWMAN I JUST WANT
TO SAY I SUPPORT YOUR DIRECTION
THAT YOU'VE INDICATED THIS BILL
WAS INTRODUCED ON JANUARY 30TH.
I KNOW THE OPPOSITION CAME IN
LATE LAST WEEK, WHICH I THINK
WAS OUT OF THE COURTESY OF THE
CHAIR. A HEARING WAS DEFERRED ON
THE BILL TO PROVIDE A LITTLE
MORE TIME, IT SEEMS LIKE THERE
IS A NEED FOR SOME MORE TIME. IT
SOUNDS LIKE YOU WOULD PREFER TO
MOVE THE BILL ALONG TODAY WITH
THE UNDERSTANDING THAT THEY'LL
CONTINUE TO WORK ON IT VERSUS
DEFER THIS TO THE NEXT HEARING.
GIVE THEM THE NEXT WEEK. IS THAT
IS THAT RIGHT? YEAH. I MEAN, YOU
KNOW, WE DON'T HAVE A TON OF
TIME LEFT IN THE LEGISLATIVE
CYCLE FOR THAT. BUT BUT I WILL
SAY THIS, WE SHOULD SOLVE THIS
PROBLEM TO THE SATISFACTION OF
BOTH PARTIES BEFORE THE NEXT
LEGISLATIVE STEP. AND THAT'S
THAT'S MY STIPULATION HERE FOR
PROVIDING MY VOTE. SO ANYTHING
ELSE I'D BE HAPPY TO MOVE THE
BILL. ALL RIGHT. WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE? WELL, I JUST WANT TO
SAY THANK YOU SO MUCH TO THE
CHAIR FOR WORKING ON THIS. THANK
YOU TO THE OPPOSITION FOR THEIR
COMMITMENT TO WORK TOGETHER FOR
THE GOOD OF CALIFORNIA STUDENTS.
AND WITH THAT, I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU. WE
HAVE A MOTION FROM SENATOR
GLASER, MADAM CONSULTANT, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL FOR ITEM FIVE. AB
1971 ADDIS MOTION IS DUE. PASSED
THE SENATE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
NEWMAN A NEWMAN. AYE OCHOA BOG.
CORTEZ. GLASER. GLASER. AYE
GONZALEZ. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
WILK Ã. WILK. AYE THE MEASURE
NOW HAS THREE VOTES. WE'LL LEAVE
IT OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU.
AND OGLALA.
WELCOME, SIR.
YOU WILL BE PRESENTING AB 1780.
THANK YOU. YOU MAY PROCEED.
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. FIRST LET
ME THANK YOU. THE COMMITTEE
CONSULTANTS. I KNOW WE'VE HAD A
NUMBER OF ROBUST CONVERSATIONS
ON THIS BILL. SO VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE YOUR ATTENTION AND
YOUR GUIDANCE. WE ARE ACCEPTING
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS, AB
1780 WOULD PROHIBIT HIGHER
EDUCATION INSTITUTIONS THAT
RECEIVE PUBLIC FUNDING FOR
FINANCIAL AID PURPOSES, TO
PROHIBIT LEGACY AND DONOR
ADMISSIONS, OR TO PROHIBIT
PREFERENTIAL TREATMENT FOR
LEGACY CHILDREN OF LEGACIES, AS
WELL AS DONORS AND LEGACIES ARE
DEFINED AS FORMER ALUMNI, LEGACY
ADMISSIONS IS AGAIN THE PRACTICE
OF OFFERING THE CHILDREN OF
ALUMNI A PREFERENTIAL TREATMENT,
GOING BACK HISTORICALLY, ONE OF
THE MAJOR CONCERNS IS THAT NOT
EVERYBODY HAD TRADITIONAL ACCESS
TO THESE INSTITUTIONS. IF YOU GO
BACK TO HEARING PEOPLE WHO ARE
THIRD GENERATION OR FOURTH
GENERATION LEGACIES, THE, THE
INSTITUTIONS THAT THEIR GRANDPA
WENT TO LOOKS VERY, VERY
DIFFERENT THAN THE INSTITUTIONS
THAT, EXIST TODAY, THERE ALSO
BEEN BARRIERS, RACIAL BARRIERS.
THERE HAVE BEEN RELIGIOUS
BARRIERS TO SOME OF THESE
INSTITUTIONS. AND SO, AGAIN, WE
BELIEVE THAT THIS IS A VERY
GOOD, GOOD STEP FOR THE STATE.
AND RIGHT IN LINE WITH OUR
CONSTITUTIONAL GUIDELINES AROUND
EQUAL OPPORTUNITY AND FAIR
ACCESS. AND JUST TO PROVIDE A
CERTAIN LEVEL OF CONTEXT, WE
HAVE THREE INSTITUTIONS,
PRIMARILY THAT OFFER LEGACY
ADMISSIONS, IN, ACCORDING TO
THEIR OWN DATA, AS OF 2022,
BETWEEN 13 TO 14% THAT STANFORD,
USC AND THE UNIVERSITY, THE
SANTA CLARA UNIVERSITY. AND TO
GIVE YOU CONTEXT THAT
SIGNIFICANTLY ALMOST DOUBLE THE
NUMBER OF AFRICAN AMERICANS THEY
ADMIT AND ALMOST AS MANY AS
LATINOS THAT THEY ADMIT INTO
THEIR CLASS. SO THIS IS A VERY
SIGNIFICANT PORTION OF THOSE
THREE INSTITUTIONS IN THEIR
INCOMING CLASSES, WE ALSO LOOKED
AT A REPORT BY OPPORTUNITY
INSIGHTS THAT WAS CITED LAST
YEAR THAT CAME OUT ON THE HEELS
OF THE SUPREME COURT DECISION TO
BAN THE USE OF ANY KIND OF
RACIAL PREFERENCES IN THE
ADMISSIONS PROCESS, AND WHAT
THEY FOUND WAS ACTUALLY FAIRLY,
ALARMING, WHICH WAS THAT LOOKING
AT IVY LEAGUE PLUS SCHOOLS AND
THAT'S CONSIDERED IVY LEAGUE
INSTITUTIONS, PLUS LIKE MINDED
SCHOOLS LIKE UNIVERSITY OF
CHICAGO, STANFORD, DUKE THAT,
CHILDREN OF FAMILIES AT THE TOP
1. AND THAT'S ROUGHLY PEOPLE WHO
FAMILIES THAT MAKE OVER $600,000
WHEN ALL THINGS WERE BEING EQUAL
, THAT THEY HAD TWICE AS LIKELY
A CHANCE TO GET ADMITTED INTO
THOSE INSTITUTIONS AS EVERYBODY
ELSE. AND SO THE FACT THAT WE
WOULD THINK THAT SOMEBODY WHO,
YOU KNOW, HAD A SUMMER JOB,
SOMEONE WHOSE FAMILIES HAD TO
OVERCOME OPPORTUNITIES, THAT
THAT WOULD BE A COMPELLING
ADMISSIONS CASE, ACTUALLY, THE
MOST COMPELLING ADMISSIONS CASE,
UNFORTUNATELY, AT TIMES WAS,
POTENTIALLY SOME FAMILY'S
ABILITY TO DONATE TO THE
INSTITUTION. AND SO, AGAIN, WE
BELIEVE THAT IT IS TIME TO
ELIMINATE THIS PREFERENCE, FOR
THE WEALTHIEST, FOLKS IN OUR, IN
OUR COUNTRY, THAT THERE REALLY
ISN'T ANY REASON TO HAVE A
PREFERENCE NOW TO STATE THIS,
THIS DOES NOT BAN THE ADMISSION
OF LEGACY STUDENTS OR DONOR
STUDENTS. YOU CAN YOU CAN
CONTINUE TO ADMIT STUDENTS FROM
THOSE FAMILIES. ABSOLUTELY YOU
JUST CANNOT OFFER THEM
PREFERENCE. SO THAT'S JUST THE
BIG DISTINCTION, SO WITH THAT I
WOULD ASK, FOR YOUR SUPPORT ON
AB 1780, WE HAVE TWO WITNESSES.
WE HAVE, SARAH ARCE WITH THE
CAMPAIGN FOR COLLEGE OPPORTUNITY
AND RYAN LEWIS. CECE LUKOWSKI.
EXCUSE ME, LEAD ORGANIZER FOR
CLASS ACTION. SO THANK YOU.
WELCOME TO BOTH OF THE WITNESSES
, THANK YOU, MR. ROSSI. PLEASE
PROCEED. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING, CHAIR NEWMAN AND
MEMBERS. SARAH RC, ON BEHALF OF
THE CAMPAIGN FOR COLLEGE
OPPORTUNITY, WE ARE AN
ORGANIZATION THAT'S DEDICATED TO
ENSURING ALL STUDENTS,
REGARDLESS OF RACE, ETHNICITY,
INCOME, DOCUMENTATION, STATUS,
OR THE ZIP CODE THAT THEY WERE
BORN INTO. CAN ACCESS A COLLEGE
EDUCATION WITH THE SUPREME
COURT'S DECISION LAST SUMMER TO
BAN RACE CONSCIOUS ADMISSIONS,
IT IS CRUCIAL NOW MORE THAN EVER
TO ENSURE THAT THOSE WHO HAVE
BEEN HISTORICALLY EXCLUDED AND
UNDERSERVED BY OUR COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES HAVE A REAL
OPPORTUNITY TO GO TO COLLEGE AND
SUCCEED. WE CAN DO THIS BY
PROMOTING EVIDENCE BASED
SOLUTIONS AND EQUITY, ADVANCING
STRATEGIES IN COLLEGE
PREPARATION, ACCESS AND
COMPLETION. ONE OF THESE
STRATEGIES IS TO PROHIBIT
PREFERENTIAL TREATMENT IN
ADMISSIONS BASED ON LEGACY AND
DONOR STATUS. LEGACY AND DONOR
ADMISSIONS PERPETUATE A CYCLE OF
PRIVILEGE THAT FORTIFIES
INEQUITY IN HIGHER EDUCATION,
WHERE STUDENTS FROM WEALTHY
BACKGROUNDS ARE GRANTED UNDUE
ADVANTAGES IN THE ADMISSIONS
PROCESS. ONE STUDY FOUND THAT
LEGACY APPLICANTS WHO ARE
TYPICALLY WHITE AND WEALTHY, ARE
45% MORE LIKELY TO GAIN
ADMISSION TO SELECTIVE COLLEGES
AND UNIVERSITIES COMPARED TO
EQUALLY QUALIFIED NON LEGACY
CANDIDATES, FURTHER WIDENING THE
GAP IN EDUCATIONAL OPPORTUNITY
IS THE VAST MAJORITY OF
CALIFORNIA COLLEGE AGED
POPULATION ARE FIRST GENERATION
BLACK, LATINX, ASIAN AMERICAN,
NATIVE HAWAIIAN PACIFIC ISLANDER
STUDENTS WHO DO NOT BENEFIT FROM
LEGACY ADMISSIONS BUT HAVE THE
MOST TO GAIN FROM A COLLEGE
EDUCATION. THE PRACTICE OF
LEGACY AND DONOR PREFERENCE AND
ADMISSIONS IS A BARRIER TO
SOCIAL MOBILITY FOR THESE
STUDENTS, AND A BARRIER TO THE
ECONOMIC COMPETITIVENESS OF THE
STATE. SOME PRIVATE COLLEGES IN
CALIFORNIA, LIKE OCCIDENTAL
COLLEGE IN LOS ANGELES, HAVE
CHOSEN TO DO AWAY WITH LEGACY
ADMISSIONS ON THEIR OWN ACCORD
IN THE WAKE OF THE SUPREME COURT
DECISION, AND WE APPLAUD THIS
DECISION AND COMMEND THE COLLEGE
FOR THEIR EFFORTS TO MOVE TOWARD
MORE EQUITABLE ADMISSIONS. AB
1780 PROVIDES A SIMPLE SOLUTION
IN ALIGNMENT WITH THE EFFORTS OF
FIVE OTHER STATES PURSUING
SIMILAR POLICIES, PROHIBIT
PREFERENTIAL TREATMENT AND
ADMISSIONS BASED ON LEGACY OR
DONOR STATUS. WE URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT AB 1780 AND SEND A
STRONG MESSAGE THAT IN
CALIFORNIA, WE BELIEVE THAT
POWER, INFLUENCE AND MONEY
SHOULD NOT DICTATE WHO GETS A
SEAT AT OUR ESTEEMED COLLEGES
AND UNIVERSITIES. WE BELIEVE ALL
STUDENTS DESERVE A FAIR SHOT AT
A COLLEGE EDUCATION, REGARDLESS
OF FAMILY BACKGROUND, INCOME
LEVEL OR COLOR OF THEIR SKIN.
AND WE BELIEVE A COLLEGE
EDUCATION CAN INTERRUPT RACIAL
AND SOCIOECONOMIC INEQUITY.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU, MR.
CIESZKOWSKI. DID I GET THAT
RIGHT? WELL DONE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. PLEASE
PROCEED. CHAIR NEWMAN, MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE. GOOD MORNING.
MY NAME IS RYAN SISKOWSKI. I AM
A CALIFORNIAN AND A RECENT
GRADUATE OF STANFORD UNIVERSITY.
I'M HERE TODAY AS THE LEAD
ORGANIZER FOR CLASS ACTION,
WHICH IS A NONPROFIT OF STUDENTS
AND ALUMNI WORKING TO ENSURE
THAT SO-CALLED ELITE COLLEGES
PRIORITIZE THE INTERESTS OF ALL
AMERICANS AND NOT JUST THE
PRIVILEGED FEW. FOR MOST PEOPLE,
LEGACY ADMISSIONS ISN'T A
CONTROVERSIAL ISSUE. 75% OF THE
AMERICAN PUBLIC, 89% OF COLLEGE
ADMISSIONS DIRECTORS, AND THE
VAST MAJORITY OF COLLEGE
STUDENTS THINK THAT IT'S UNFAIR.
AMONG THOSE STUDENTS ARE THE
UNDERGRADUATE AND GRADUATE
SENATORS AT STANFORD UNIVERSITY,
WHO VOTED OVERWHELMINGLY TO PASS
A RESOLUTION ENDORSING THIS
BILL. IN A POWERFUL TESTAMENT TO
THE STUDENTS DISCONTENT WITH
LEGACY ADMISSIONS, THESE ELECTED
LEADERS VOTED IN FAVOR OF ENDING
A POLICY WHICH COULD BENEFIT
THEIR FUTURE CHILDREN. TODAY,
I'D LIKE TO GET ACROSS WHY
STUDENTS AT STANFORD AND AROUND
THE COUNTRY ARE DETERMINED TO
END LEGACY. I'LL MAKE FOR BRIEF
POINTS ONE. THEY WANT AN END TO
LEGACY ADMISSIONS BECAUSE THEIR
SCHOOLS ACCEPT MORE STUDENTS
FROM THE TOP 1% OF THE INCOME
DISTRIBUTION THAN THE ENTIRE
BOTTOM 50. AND A RECENT STUDY
SHOWS THAT LEGACY ADMISSIONS IS
ONE OF THE LEADING REASONS WHY.
TWO ON THIS JUNETEENTH, IT'S
IMPORTANT TO REMEMBER THAT
LEGACY ADMISSIONS WAS DESIGNED
IN THE 1920S TO SAVE SPOTS AT
ELITE COLLEGES FOR PROTESTANT
WHITES, AND TO THIS DAY, IT
DISPROPORTIONATELY ADVANTAGES
WEALTHY WHITE APPLICANTS, A
REALITY WHICH IS ALL THE MORE
CONCERNING AFTER THE FALL OF
RACE CONSCIOUS ADMISSIONS. THREE
STUDENTS WHO ATTEND ELITE
INSTITUTIONS KNOW THAT THEIR
SCHOOLS ARE FAST TRACKS TO THE
HALLS OF POWER, AND THAT AS A
NATION, WE SHOULDN'T BE
SELECTING THE NEXT GENERATION OF
LEADERS BASED ON FAMILIAL
BLOODLINE. THIS COUNTRY SHOULD
NOT BE AN ARISTOCRACY. FOURTH,
AND FINALLY, STUDENTS WANT
LEGACY GONE BECAUSE THEY DON'T
WANT TO BE ASSOCIATED WITH A
SYSTEM THAT RUNS ON NEPOTISM,
ESPECIALLY AS TRUST IN HIGHER
EDUCATION IS AT AN ALL TIME LOW.
STUDENTS WANT THEIR SCHOOLS TO
BE AVENUES OF ACCESS AND NOT
COUNTRY CLUBS, WHERE MEMBERSHIP
IS RESERVED FOR THOSE WITH
CONNECTIONS. SENATORS AB 1780 IS
ON THE SIDE OF STUDENTS, AND I
RESPECTFULLY URGE YOU TO BE AS
WELL. THANK YOU. THANK YOU. LET
US NOW HEAR FROM OTHERS IN THE
AUDIENCE WHO'D LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF THE MEASURE.
PLEASE COME FORWARD WITH YOUR
NAME, YOUR ORGANIZATION, AND
YOUR POSITION. GOOD MORNING.
SABRINA MEANS, ON BEHALF OF THE
INSTITUTE FOR COLLEGE ACCESS AND
SUCCESS IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU,
MR. CHAIR. MEMBERS. AMY BROWN,
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CHARTER SCHOOLS ASSOCIATION, IN
SUPPORT. HI. GOOD MORNING, CAROL
GONZALEZ, ON BEHALF OF THE
EDUCATION TRUST WEST IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU, GOOD
MORNING, KATE ROGERS, ON BEHALF
OF GENERATION UP. PROUD TO
CO-SPONSOR ALSO IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING, FAITH
LEE. WITH ASIAN AMERICANS
ADVANCING JUSTICE, SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA WE'RE PROUD
CO-SPONSOR I'M ALSO HERE TO
PROVIDE A ME TOO. FOR FOLKS WHO
CAN'T BE HERE. THERE ARE KIDS
CITY HOPE SPACE SOCAL CAN LATINO
LATINA ROUNDTABLE AND NAACP,
POMONA VALLEY BRANCH COUNCIL OF
MEXICAN FEDERATIONS IN NORTH
AMERICA, SF RISING AND THE
INSTITUTE FOR COLLEGE ACCESS AND
SUCCESS. THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
HI, ANYA HOOPER, A STANFORD
GRADUATE OF THREE DAYS AND
FORMER LEGACY STUDENT, ALSO A
CLASS ACTION ORGANIZER I
SUPPORT. THANK YOU AND
CONGRATULATIONS. THANK YOU.
NEXT, PLEASE. NATALIE STEINER,
STANFORD GRADUATE. I'M A CLASS
ACTION ORGANIZER AND A
CALIFORNIA RESIDENT IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING, SOPHIE
CALCOTT, CALIFORNIA NATIVE,
ANOTHER STANFORD GRADUATE OF
THREE DAYS AND A LEGACY STUDENT.
AND I'M A CLASS ACTION
ORGANIZER. AND HERE IN SUPPORT
YOU SHOULD BE IN CABO OR
SOMEWHERE NEXT WE HAVE BEACHES
HERE IN SACRAMENTO. COME ON ETC.
HI, KATIE. FEE, ALSO RECENT
STANFORD GRADUATE, LEGACY
STUDENT AND ORGANIZER WITH
STUDENTS FOR EQUITABLE EDUCATION
AT STANFORD IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. NEXT PLEASE. HI. JAMES
REED, STANFORD GRADUATE,
CALIFORNIA ON CLASS ACTION
ORGANIZER AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. NEXT, PLEASE. GOOD MORNING,
DAVID RAMIREZ, ON BEHALF OF THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA STUDENT
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. NEXT, PLEASE. GOOD MORNING.
MARIA MORALES. ON BEHALF OF
HISPANAS, ORGANIZED FOR
POLITICAL EQUALITY. HOPE A PROUD
CO-SPONSOR AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. NEXT, PLEASE. THANK YOU,
MR. CHAIR. AND MEMBERS, TRISTAN
BROWN OF CFT, UNION OF EDUCATORS
AND CLASSIFIED PROFESSIONALS,
AND A LEGACY STUDENT NOT OF
STANFORD HERE IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. NEXT, PLEASE. WOULD YOU
ASPIRE IN SUPPORT? THANK YOU,
LET'S NOW GO TO OPPOSITION LEAD
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. PLEASE
COME FORWARD. MR. GRAVES, GOOD
MORNING.
IT'S YOUR HONOR. WHEN IT'S
READY, I MAKE SENSE. THERE YOU
GO, GOOD MORNING, CHAIR AND
MEMBERS, ALEX GRAVES, THE
ASSOCIATION OF INDEPENDENT
CALIFORNIA COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES HERE IN RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL IN PRINT,
THOUGH, WOULD NOTE THAT THE,
AMENDMENTS, IN THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS TAKEN TODAY DO ADDRESS
A SERIOUS CONCERN THAT WE HAD
HAD AT THIS POINT COMING TO THE
SENATE, WE HAVE HISTORICALLY
MAINTAINED STRONG RESERVATIONS
AS A SECTOR ABOUT THE STATE
DICTATING ADMISSIONS OR ACADEMIC
PRACTICES AT PRIVATE COLLEGES.
ADMITTEDLY BUT WE ALSO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE IMPORTANCE OF
THE TOPIC FOLLOWING LAST YEAR'S
SUPREME COURT RULING BANNING
AFFIRMATIVE ACTION, WE
APPRECIATE AND WELCOME THE
DISCUSSION ON HOW WE CAN ENSURE
STUDENTS, FAMILIES AND THE
PUBLIC FEEL THAT ALL APPLICANTS
RECEIVE A FAIR SHOT. AND I DO
WANT TO BE SURE TO THANK THE
MEMBER, HIS STAFF, AND THE
SPONSORS FOR TAKING TIME TO HAVE
SEVERAL MEETINGS WITH US OVER
THE COURSE OF THIS PROCESS TO
DISCUSS OUR CONCERNS. THOSE
DISCUSSIONS HAVE HELPED US GET
AGREEMENT ON SEVERAL AMENDMENTS,
INCLUDING LANGUAGE THAT ALIGNS
THE IMPLEMENTATION AND REPORTING
WITH THE BEGINNING OF THE 20
2526 ACADEMIC YEAR AND ALSO
CLARIFYING THAT COLLEGES CAN
CONTINUE TO GET THIS INFORMATION
PROVIDED IT IS FOR PURPOSES THAT
ARE NOT CONSIDERED IN THE REVIEW
OF THEIR APPLICATION FOR
ADMISSION. AS I NOTED, OUR
BIGGEST CONCERN HAD BEEN
REGARDING THE CIVIL PENALTY, BUT
AGAIN, WE APPRECIATE THAT THAT
ISSUE HAS BEEN ADDRESSED HERE, I
WOULD JUST EMPHASIZE THAT OUR
PERSPECTIVE AND APPROACH IN
THESE DISCUSSIONS HAS BEEN ON
THE, THE GOAL OF ACHIEVING WHAT
WE WOULD FIND TO BE A BALANCED
PROPOSAL. WE HAVE URGED BALANCE
BECAUSE OUR SCHOOLS ARE
COMPLIANCE DRIVEN INSTITUTIONS
WHO MEET THE REQUIREMENTS
CONTAINED IN NUMEROUS STATE LAWS
PASSED EACH YEAR. INCLUDING THAT
THEY HAVE MET THE OBLIGATIONS
OUTLINED IN AB 697 TO REPORT
INFORMATION ON THESE PRACTICES.
THE LAST 4 OR 5 YEARS. WE ALSO
URGE BALANCE, RECOGNIZING THAT
THE DATA CONTAINED IN THOSE
REPORTS SHOWS THAT IN FOUR
YEARS, ACROSS THE 7 OR 8
INSTITUTIONS WHO HAVE
SELF-REPORTED THAT NEARLY ALL
STUDENTS IDENTIFIED AS LEGACY
WHO WERE ADMITTED MET THE SAME
ACADEMIC QUALIFICATIONS THAT
APPLY TO ALL APPLICANTS. AND IN
THOSE FOUR YEARS OF REPORTING,
THERE'S ONLY BEEN ABOUT 7 TO 10
APPLICANTS WHO, BY THE
INSTITUTION'S OWN ADMISSION,
WERE OFFERED ADMISSION, WHO
WOULD OTHERWISE NOT BE,
ACADEMICALLY QUALIFIED OR MEET
THE SAME QUALIFICATIONS, JUST
FOR CONTEXT, LAST YEAR IN OUR
LAST REPORT, WE HAD SEVEN
INSTITUTIONS WHO SELF-IDENTIFIED
THAT THEY HAD OFFERED ADMISSION
TO APPROXIMATELY 3300 APPLICANTS
ACROSS THOSE INSTITUTIONS WHO
WOULD BE CONSIDERED LEGACY. OF
THOSE, ABOUT 1700 ENROLLED, BUT
ONLY ONE APPLICANT WHO WAS
OFFERED ADMISSION WAS DEEMED TO
HAVE BEEN ADMITTED UNDER
ACADEMIC QUALIFICATIONS. IT
WOULDN'T WOULDN'T BE THE SAME
ACADEMIC QUALIFICATIONS APPLIED
TO OTHER APPLICANTS. SO AND
LASTLY, WE BELIEVE THIS BALANCE
IS WARRANTED BECAUSE THE
UNDERGRADUATE DEMOGRAPHICS OF
OUR INSTITUTIONS SHOW THAT
APPROXIMATELY TWO THIRDS OF OUR
STUDENTS IDENTIFY AS NONWHITE.
AND EVEN WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE 7
OR 8 INSTITUTIONS WHO HAVE
SELF-REPORTED LEGACY PRACTICES,
YOU FIND THAT THEIR
UNDERGRADUATE DEMOGRAPHICS ARE
STRIKINGLY SIMILAR TO WHAT YOU
WOULD SEE AT UC BERKELEY OR UCLA
, REGARDING DONOR ADMISSIONS, I
KNOW WE'VE TALKED MOSTLY ABOUT
LEGACY. I WOULD JUST NOTE THAT
STANFORD UNIVERSITY TÊ IN THEIR,
ADVANCEMENT OFFICE WEBSITE DOES
HAVE A VERY EXPLICIT POLICY
STATING THAT THEY DO NOT THEY
MAKE IT VERY CLEAR TO DONORS,
POTENTIAL DONORS, THAT THAT
CANNOT INFLUENCE AN ADMISSIONS
DECISION. IT MAKES VERY CLEAR
THAT ADMISSIONS OFFICES ARE
SEPARATE FROM ADVANCEMENT
OFFICES, AND THAT POLICY IS
PUBLICLY AVAILABLE ON THEIR
WEBSITE IF ANYONE WANTS TO GO
READ IT. SO AGAIN, WE DO STILL
HAVE SOME REMAINING CONCERNS
AROUND SOME OF THE REPORTING
LANGUAGE AND DATA POINTS THAT
ARE REQUESTED IN THAT. BUT
AGAIN, WANT TO REITERATE THAT WE
THINK THE DISCUSSIONS HAVE BEEN
PRODUCTIVE AND THAT WE'RE, MUCH
CLOSER TO ADDRESSING THOSE
CONCERNS. THANK YOU. ANY OTHERS
HERE IN OPPOSITION TO THE
MEASURE, IF YOU'D LIKE TO COME
FORWARD, SEEING NONE, LET'S COME
BACK TO THE DAIS. COLLEAGUES
QUESTIONS? NO, FOR MY PART,
THANK YOU, MR. TING, FOR WORKING
WITH COMMITTEE STAFF AND WITH ME
. I BELIEVE WE FOUND A
REASONABLY GOOD BALANCE. I DO
BELIEVE STRONGLY, YOU KNOW, TO
THE EXTENT THE STATE HAS TAKEN A
POSITION AS IT RELATES TO ALL OF
OUR PUBLIC INSTITUTIONS, WE
SHOULD BE ABLE TO APPLY THAT
SAME STANDARD TO PRIVATE
INSTITUTIONS THAT RECEIVE STATE
FUNDS. AND I THINK THAT'S WHAT
WE'VE ENDEAVORED TO DO. I THINK
WE'VE DONE THAT SUCCESSFULLY
WITH THE AMENDMENTS, THE
AMENDMENTS TO WHICH YOU REFERRED
TO THREE BASIC THINGS REMOVE THE
CIVIL PENALTIES, ADOPT LANGUAGE
THAT PROVIDE THAT INDEPENDENT
COLLEGES WHO FOREGO CALIFORNIA
GRANT FUNDS CAN CONTINUE TO
APPLY THE PREFERENCES AS WE'VE
DISCUSSED, I'D ARGUE THERE'S A
THERE'S A COST BENEFIT
CONSIDERATION THERE. THE
REPUTATIONAL BENEFIT OF,
COLLEGES LIKE OCCIDENTAL. MR.
GRAVES IS A PROUD GRADUATE OF
OCCIDENTAL WHO'VE DONE THAT, I
THINK TO THEIR BENEFIT VERSUS
THE REPUTATIONAL DAMAGE FOR A
SCHOOL THAT WOULD HAVE THEN OPT
OUT AND I BELIEVE THAT
REPUTATIONAL DAMAGE WOULD BE
SUFFICIENT TO, YOU KNOW, INHIBIT
THAT CHOICE. LASTLY GLAD TO
RESTORE SOME OF THE REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS SO THAT OVER TIME,
WE'VE GOT A GOOD BASE, BASIS FOR
SEEING YOU KNOW, WHAT THIS
MEASURE ACTUALLY DOES. AND I
THINK THAT'S IMPORTANT. AND I
THINK IT'S EQUALLY IMPORTANT
THAT OVER TIME THAT WE'RE
WILLING TO REVISIT THIS, IF, IN
FACT, WE DON'T SEE THE KINDS OF
CHANGES THAT THAT WE'VE
ENDEAVORED TO PRESCRIBE HERE, SO
I APPRECIATE AGAIN YOUR
WILLINGNESS TO DO THAT. I DO
THINK WE FOUND A GOOD BALANCE.
I'M GLAD TO SUPPORT THE BILL IN
ITS AMENDED FORM. WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE? THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR.
AND AGAIN, THANK YOU FOR THE
DIALOG AND THE DISCUSSION AND
FOR WORKING WITH US. VERY PROUD
TO PUT FORWARD AB SEVEN 1780,
WHICH WILL, PROHIBIT,
PREFERENTIAL TREATMENT FOR
LEGACIES AND CHILDREN OF DONORS
FOR PRIVATE INSTITUTIONS THAT
ACCEPT STATE FUNDS. I THINK IT'S
A HUGE FIRST STEP AND ALSO A
MAJOR, MAJOR WIN TO EVEN THE
PLAYING FIELD FOR MANY OF THESE
MAJOR INSTITUTIONS. AND AGAIN,
OUR COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES
AREN'T JUST ORGANIZATIONS WHICH
TAKE STATE FUNDS. THEY HAVE MUCH
MORE IMPACT AND MUCH MORE
INFLUENCE THAN THAT. THEY THEY
REALLY ARE SEEN BY MANY PEOPLE
IN THEIR COUNTRY AS A WAY TO
MAKE YOUR LIFE BETTER, TO GET
GREATER OPPORTUNITY TO MOVE
CLASSES, WHETHER YOU'RE WORKING
CLASS, MOVING INTO THE MIDDLE
CLASS, THAT HAS BEEN THE LONG
TRADITION THAT WE'VE HAD, AND I
BELIEVE THAT OUR HIGHER
EDUCATION INSTITUTIONS ARE
PROBABLY THE MAIN REASON WE HAVE
THE ECONOMY THAT WE DO IN
CALIFORNIA. SO WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT PEOPLE OF, EVERY,
EVERY WALK OF LIFE ARE ABLE TO
ACCESS THOSE INSTITUTIONS AND
THAT THEIR ADMISSIONS ARE FAIR
AND EQUITABLE. WITH THAT,
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE ON
AB 1780. THANK YOU. DO I HAVE A
MOTION? DO YOU KNOW YOU KNOW, WE
CAN CARRY IT OVER YOU DON'T HAVE
TO. YOU COURTESY MOTION. THE
MOTION. WE HAVE A MOTION FOR
SENATOR GLAZER. MADAM
CONSULTANT, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
FOR ITEM ONE. AB 1780 TING.
MOTION IS DUE. PASS IS AMENDED
TO SENATE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
NEWMAN Ã NEWMAN, I OTOBO
CORTEZ. GLAZER. GONZALES
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. WILK. THAT
MEASURE CURRENTLY HAS ONE VOTE.
WE WILL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS. APPRECIATE IT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. OKAY. NEXT, I
SEE ASSEMBLY MEMBER JACKSON.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE.
YOU'LL BE PRESENTING AB 1818.
THANK YOU TO THE WITNESSES. YOU
MAY PROCEED WHEN READY. SIR DO
YOU HAVE WITNESSES IN SUPPORT? I
DO NOT, OKAY. PLEASE PROCEED,
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, MR. CHAIR.
AND MEMBERS, FIRST, I WANT TO
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR, AND YOUR,
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR WORKING WITH
ME ON THIS, BILL. AND GLADLY
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE'S
AMENDMENTS TO CLARIFY AND
FURTHER MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
CLEAR ON THE RESTRICTIONS OF
THIS PILOT PROGRAM, MEMBERS AB
1818 IS A BILL THAT REQUIRES THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE AND THE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY'S, CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE TO ESTABLISH A PILOT
PROGRAM TO CREATE BEST PRACTICES
TO ESTABLISH ON HOW WE CAN MAKE
SURE THAT WE ARE STABILIZING OUR
HOMELESS STUDENTS BY ALLOWING
THEM TO PARK OVERNIGHT INSTEAD
OF IN DANGEROUS PARTS OF
WHEREVER THEY MAY TRY TO FIND
ANOTHER PLACE TO PARK, TO SLEEP
IN THEIR CARS, WHILE AT THE SAME
TIME, PROVIDING THEM WITH
SERVICES TO ENSURE THAT THEY ARE
ABLE TO GET OUT OF THOSE
VEHICLES AND INTO STABLE HOUSING
. THIS DOES NOT ALLOW FOR RVS.
THESE ARE JUST STANDARD VEHICLES
, ALSO, THIS PILOT PROGRAM
ENSURES THAT WE FOLLOW SOME VERY
SIMPLE SOCIAL WORK PRINCIPLES,
AND THAT IS YOU IDENTIFY SOMEONE
IN NEED, YOU HELP TO STABILIZE
THEM AND GIVE THEM A SENSE OF
SAFETY AND CONSISTENCY AND
PREDICTABILITY. AND THEN YOU
OFFER THEM SERVICES AND GET THEM
CONNECTED. IN THIS CASE WOULD BE
THEIR COUNTY'S CONTINUUM OF
CARE. AND OTHER HOUSING
VOUCHERS. IF THERE'S NO
EMERGENCY HOUSING AVAILABLE ON
THOSE SELECTED CAMPUSES, AND
THEN MOST IMPORTANTLY, ALLOW FOR
BEST PRACTICES TO BE DEVELOPED
THAT CAN THEN BE SHARED SYSTEM
WIDE SO THAT WE CAN MAKE SURE
THAT WE ARE DEALING WITH WHAT
CONTINUES TO BE A TOP PRIORITY
FOR THE STATE. AND THIS IS
SIMPLY SAYING THAT HOMELESSNESS
CONTINUES TO BE A STATE
PRIORITY. THEREFORE, WE NEED ALL
OF OUR STATE INSTITUTIONS INS,
WHEREVER THEY ARE, WHATEVER THEY
DO TO GET IN THE GAME, TO HELP,
TO FIND WAYS TO MAKING SURE THAT
WE DEAL WITH OUR HOMELESSNESS
ISSUE THROUGHOUT THE STATE, AND
SO WITH THAT, FOR ME, THIS IS
JUST A MORAL QUESTION. ARE WE
DOING EVERYTHING THAT WE CAN TO
HELP OUR HOMELESS STUDENTS? AND
FOR ME, THIS IS MAKING SURE THAT
THIS SYSTEM, WHO IN MANY CASES
ARE ONE OF THE ONLY ONES TO BE
ABLE TO IDENTIFY WHO THESE FOLKS
ARE AND WHAT THEIR NEEDS ARE TO
IDENTIFY THEM, STABILIZE THEM,
GET THEM ON THE COURSE SO THAT
THEY CAN BE ABLE TO THRIVE AND
FOCUS ON THEIR HIGHER EDUCATION.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I
VOTE. THANK YOU, MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC HERE IN SUPPORT OF THE
MEASURE. PLEASE COME FORWARD
WITH YOUR NAME, YOUR
ORGANIZATION, YOUR POSITION.
GOOD MORNING. KIM LEWIS,
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
COALITION FOR YOUTH AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. NEXT, PLEASE,
PRISCILLA, KUDOS HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA FACULTY
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU, STEPHANIE GOLDMAN, ON
BEHALF OF THE STUDENT SENATE FOR
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU, DAVID
RAMIREZ, ON BEHALF OF THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA STUDENT
ASSOCIATION, IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU, TRISTAN BROWN, WITH CFT AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. ANY OTHERS?
SEEING NONE. OPPOSITION THÀNH,
WELCOME TO THE OPPOSITION.
PLEASE COME FORWARD. WELCOME TO
BOTH OF YOU, THANK YOU SO MUCH.
GOOD MORNING, CHAIR NEWMAN,
SENATORS, AIDES AND THOSE
ASSEMBLED, I AM ELLIOT STERN. I
AM PRESIDENT OF SADDLEBACK
COLLEGE IN MISSION VIEJO. I AM
HERE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO
AB 1818, WHICH IS A DIFFICULT
TASK. WE ALL WANT TO DO
SOMETHING ABOUT THE HOMELESSNESS
SITUATION, THÀNH. AND WE
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE THAT THERE
IS WITHIN THAT BILL A NOD TO AND
THE EXPRESSION OF EMPATHY FOR
HOMELESS STUDENTS. I APPRECIATE
THAT EMPATHY THERE IS EXPRESSED
IN THIS BILL FRUSTRATION WITH
OUR HOMELESSNESS SITUATION AND
OUR INABILITY TO GET ON TOP OF
IT. I SHARE THAT FRUSTRATION.
BUT THE PROPONENTS OFTEN
DESCRIBE THIS BILL AS DOING
SOMETHING AND SOMETHING IS
BETTER THAN NOTHING. I WOULD
POSIT TO YOU THAT WE ARE NOT
DOING NOTHING, AND IT IS
OFFENSIVE TO SUGGEST WE ARE MANY
OF THE THINGS THAT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER JACKSON HAS SPOKEN TO ARE
ALREADY DOING, ALREADY HAPPENING
AT COLLEGES ACROSS THE STATE. AT
MOST, IF NOT ALL, COLLEGES
ACROSS THE STATE. AND WHAT AB
1818 WOULD DO WOULD BE TO
SUPPLANT THOSE BY VIRTUE OF ITS
MANDATE AND BY VIRTUE OF PULLING
FUNDS FROM THINGS THAT WE ARE
ALREADY DOING TOWARD THE NEEDED
POLICING. THAT WOULD HAPPEN
UNDER AB 1818 FOR LESS EFFECTIVE
PRACTICES, SPECIFICALLY, WE
FOLLOW HIGH IMPACT PRACTICES
THAT ARE SUGGESTED BY EXPERTS IN
HOMELESSNESS ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
THESE FORCE US TO FOCUS ON DOING
SOMETHING IMMEDIATELY FOR
STUDENTS RAPID RESPONSE, GETTING
THEM REHOUSED AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE, TRYING TO PREVENT LACK
OF HOUSING IN THE FIRST PLACE.
IF WE CAN HELP SOMEBODY WHO'S
BEHIND IN THEIR RENT, IF WE CAN
GIVE SOMEBODY A SECURITY DEPOSIT
TO GET A NEW PLACE, THOSE ARE
THE MEASURES THAT HAPPEN.
PREVENTION, RAPID RESPONSE AND A
HOLISTIC APPROACH TO TREATING
OUR STUDENTS, NOT ALLOWING THEM
TO SLEEP IN THEIR CARS, BUT
RATHER GETTING OUT OF THEIR CARS
INTO OUR BASIC NEEDS CENTER. SO
WE CAN LOOK AT ALL OF THE NEEDS
THAT THEY HAVE. THESE INCLUDE
FOOD, TRANSPORTATION, WELLNESS,
TECHNOLOGY, ALL THE THINGS THAT
STUDENTS NEED NEED TO BE
ADDRESSED HOLISTICALLY. AND IF
THEY STUCK IN THEIR CAR IN A
PARKING LOT, THEY'RE NOT COMING
IN FOR THOSE SERVICES. AND THE
LONGER THEY DELAY IN COMING IN
FOR THOSE SERVICES, THE WORSE
THE PROGNOSIS FOR PREVENTING OR
GETTING THEM OUT OF HOMELESSNESS
IN THE FIRST PLACE. SO THIS CAN
ACTUALLY HARM WHAT WE'RE TRYING
TO DO. IN MANY WAYS. WE OFFER
THESE BASIC NEEDS CENTERS THAT
ADDRESS THESE NEEDS THAT I'VE
SPOKEN OF VERY HOLISTICALLY WITH
STUDENTS AND SPECIFICALLY FOR
UNHOUSED STUDENTS. WE RESPOND IN
THREE WAYS. FIRST, WE OFFER
STUDENTS VOUCHERS. SO THE
VOUCHERS CAN BE FOR A HOTEL, A
YOUTH HOSTEL OR OFTEN WE OFFER
AIRBNB VOUCHERS TO ALLOW
STUDENTS TO GET A REAL ROOF OVER
THEIR HEAD, NOT THE ROOF OF
THEIR CAR. WE ALSO OFFER
STUDENTS REFERRALS TO COMMUNITY
AGENCIES TO HELP THEM WITH
LONGER TERM HOUSING NEEDS. AND
FINALLY, AND MOST IMPORTANTLY,
WE OFFER EMERGENCY GRANTS. AS I
SAID EARLIER, TO PREVENT THEM
FROM BECOMING HOMELESS IN THE
FIRST PLACE OR TO GET THEM IN
NEW HOUSING AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE. AT SADDLEBACK COLLEGE,
IN ADDITION TO OUR BASIC NEEDS
CENTER, WHICH ARE THROUGHOUT THE
STATE AT EVERY COLLEGE, I CAN
ASSURE YOU AT THIS POINT WE ALSO
OFFER WE ALSO DO A SURVEY. A
STUDENT NEEDS SURVEY AT THE
START OF THE TERM TO ACTUALLY
FIND OUT WHAT OUR STUDENTS NEED.
AND AMONG THOSE QUESTIONS ARE
ARE YOU COUCH SURFING? ARE HAVE
YOU BEEN WITHOUT A HOME FOR 1 OR
2 DAYS THIS YEAR? AND WE GO TO
THEM. WE ARE PROACTIVE IN GOING
TO THEM AND MAKING SURE THAT
THOSE NEEDS ARE ADDRESSED
ACUTELY AND QUICKLY, AND NOT
GIVING THEM TIME TO BECOME
CHRONICALLY HOMELESS. AB 1818
WOULD RAISE COSTS FOR ME
CONSIDERABLY. HERE'S WHY IT'S
EASY FOR WALMART, OR FOR THE
TRAIN STATION, OR FOR A STRIP
MALL TO OPEN THEIR PARKING LOT.
THEY'RE NOT UNDER TITLE NINE,
THEY'RE NOT UNDER CLERY ACT. I
HAVE A HIGHER MANDATE FOR HIGHER
LEVEL OF SECURITY. THIS MEANS
THAT I WOULD HAVE TO HAVE 24
HOUR POLICING AND PROVIDE A SAFE
SPACE FOR STUDENTS. THE COST OF
THAT HAS BEEN ESTIMATED FOR MY
COLLEGE, SOMEWHERE AROUND
$400,000. OTHER COLLEGES MAKE
THAT ESTIMATE MUCH HIGHER. IN
ANY CASE, THAT $400,000 HAS TO
COME FROM SOMEPLACE. I MENTIONED
TO YOU THAT WE'RE DOING
EMERGENCY GRANTS. I HAVE TO ASK
YOU TO WRAP THOSE EMERGENCY
GRANTS COST US 500,000. THE
400,000 WOULD NEED TO COME FROM
THE 500,000. SO WE WOULD BE
SUPPLANTING AN EFFECTIVE MEASURE
AGAINST HOMELESSNESS WITH A LESS
EFFECTIVE MEASURE. THIS IS A
STEP BACKWARDS FOR THE STATE AND
A STEP BACKWARDS FOR THE GOOD
WORK THAT THE COLLEGES ARE
ALREADY DOING. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THANK YOU. WELCOME. GOOD
MORNING, CHAIR MEMBERS. SO MY
NAME IS RAY MURRAY. I'M THE
INTERIM ASSISTANT VICE
CHANCELLOR FOR STUDENT AFFAIRS,
EQUITY AND BELONGING WITH THE
CSU OFFICE OF THE CHANCELLOR AND
I'M HERE TO SPEAK IN RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION TO AB 1818, WHICH
WOULD REQUIRE THE CSU TO CREATE
A PILOT PROGRAM TO ALLOW
STUDENTS TO SLEEP IN THEIR
PERSONAL VEHICLES. THE CSU
RECOGNIZES SEVERITY OF THE
STUDENTS EXPERIENCING HOUSING
AND SECURITY AND SHARES THE
AUTHORS AND THE LEGISLATORS
GOALS IN SUPPORTING HOUSING
INSECURE STUDENTS. WITH THE
LEGISLATURE'S ONGOING SUPPORT TO
ADDRESS BASIC NEEDS, EVERY CSU
UNIVERSITY HAS AN EMERGENCY
HOUSING PROGRAM. THESE PROGRAMS
RANGE FROM ON CAMPUS, SHORT TERM
ACCOMMODATIONS TO HOTEL VOUCHERS
TO LONG TERM SOLUTIONS. ONE SUCH
PROGRAM IS THE RAPID REHOUSING
PROGRAM. IN 2019, THE
LEGISLATURE CREATED AND FUNDED A
RAPID REHOUSING PROGRAM AT THE
CSU AT THE CSU TO SUPPORT
STUDENTS EXPERIENCING HOUSING
INSECURITY. EIGHT CSU CAMPUSES
CURRENTLY HAVE A RAPID REHOUSING
PROGRAM THAT WORKS IN
COLLABORATION WITH COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS TO PROVIDE
HOUSING OPTIONS FOR STUDENTS, A
NOTEWORTHY POINT FOR 2425 IS THE
CSU WILL BE INCREASING THE
NUMBER OF CAMPUSES THAT
PARTICIPATE IN THE RAPID
REHOUSING PROGRAM. WHEN A
STUDENT UTILIZES A UNIVERSITY'S
HOUSING EMERGENCY HOUSING
PROGRAM, THEY ALSO RECEIVE
WRAPAROUND SERVICES THROUGH
BASIC NEEDS CASE MANAGER,
INCLUDING MENTAL HEALTH AND MEAL
SUPPORT. THESE STATE FUNDED
PROGRAMS HAVE DESIGNED HAVE BEEN
DESIGNED TO ADDRESS THE
STUDENT'S BASIC NEEDS WITH
DIGNITY. IN 2223, THE CSU
SUPPORTED 14,000 STUDENTS
THROUGH VARIOUS HOUSING
ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS AND
ADDITIONAL 7600 STUDENTS
RECEIVED EMERGENCY FUNDING, WITH
EXISTING PROGRAMS IN PLACE TO
ADDRESS STUDENT HOUSING
INSECURITY. THE CSU BELIEVES IT
WOULD BE A STEP BACKWARDS TO
FUND A PROGRAM THAT WOULD ALLOW
STUDENTS TO SLEEP IN THEIR
VEHICLES. CAMPUSES HAVE BEDS
AVAILABLE FOR STUDENTS
EXPERIENCING HOUSING INSECURITY.
IT WOULD BE A DISSERVICE FOR OUR
STUDENTS TO LOWER THEIR STANDARD
OF SUPPORT AND HAVE THE STUDENTS
SLEEP IN THEIR VEHICLES. WHILE
THE BILL IS DESIGNED TO CREATE A
PATHWAY FOR EXISTING HOUSING FOR
EXISTING EMERGENCY HOUSING
PROGRAMS, THE CSU FEELS IT IS
IMPERATIVE TO HAVE THE STUDENTS
ACCESS EXISTING PROGRAMS THAT
WOULD PROVIDE A SAFE BED AND NOT
HAVE THEM SLEEPING IN A PARKING
LOT. THE CSU ESTIMATES THAT THE
THAT AB 1818 WOULD CREATE A COST
TO THE SYSTEM. ABOUT $3.5
MILLION TO ADMINISTER PER YEAR.
FINANCIALLY, WE WOULD LIKELY
HAVE TO DIVERT FUNDS FROM THE
OTHER BASIC NEEDS AND HOUSING
PROGRAMS TO OPERATE THIS PILOT.
THE CSU AND THE LEGISLATURE HAVE
INVESTED IN EMERGENCY HOUSING
PROGRAMS THAT ARE DESIGNED TO
ALLOW STUDENTS TO FIND LONG TERM
HOUSING SOLUTIONS WHILE
SUPPORTING TO BE, WELL,
SUPPORTING THEM TO BE SUCCESSFUL
IN THE CLASSROOM, PERMITTING
STUDENTS TO LIVE IN THEIR CARS
AS A HOMELESSNESS STRATEGY WOULD
BE A SUBSTANTIAL CHANGE THAT
MOVES THE UNIVERSITY'S AWAY FROM
THE SUCCESSFUL PROGRAMS THAT CSU
AND OUR UNIVERSITIES OPERATE. TO
ENSURE A SAFE ENVIRONMENT THAT
FOSTERS STUDENT SUCCESS AND
WELL-BEING. ON BEHALF OF THE CSU
AND THE 23 UNIVERSITIES, I
RESPECTFULLY URGE YOU TO OPPOSE
THIS BILL. RECOGNIZING THE
IMPORTANCE OF STUDENTS AND
EXISTING EMERGENCY HOUSING
PROGRAMS. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME AND CONSIDERATION, AND
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY.
ARE THERE OTHERS WHO LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION? WELCOME
GOOD MORNING, CHAIR AND MEMBERS,
ASHLEY WALKER WITH NOSSAMAN ON
BEHALF OF NORTH ORANGE COUNTY
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT.
CITRUS COLLEGE AND MOUNT SAN
ANTONIO COLLEGE, IN RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. NEXT
THANK YOU. CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
MARK MCDONALD, ON BEHALF OF THE
ANTELOPE VALLEY KERN FOOTHILL-DE
ANZA PERALTA, PALO VERDE, SAN
BERNARDINO, SAN DIEGO, AND
CONTRA COSTA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICTS, ALL IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU. NEXT THANK
YOU, MR. CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
DAVID NEVIN, ON BEHALF OF
CERRITOS, CUESTA AND ALLAN
HANCOCK COLLEGE, IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING. ON
BEHALF OF THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA AND THE
CALIFORNIA, EXCUSE ME AND THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE ADMINISTRATORS
. THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ANY
OTHERS IN OPPOSITION? ANY
TWEENERS NOT SEEING ANY TWEENERS
COME BACK TO THE DAIS.
COLLEAGUES, QUESTIONS, COMMENTS
FOR THE AUTHOR. SENATOR GLASER,
GO AHEAD. WELL, I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE SENTIMENT BEHIND
THIS BILL, I SHARE THE AUTHOR'S
CONCERN FOR THE PROBLEM EASILY
IDENTIFIED BY, YOU KNOW, I'VE
HAD THE OPPORTUNITY AS THE CHAIR
OF THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
STUDENT SUCCESS TO TRAVEL AROUND
TO STATE UNIVERSITIES TO HEAR
ABOUT BASIC NEED PROBLEMS.
CERTAINLY, THE PROBLEM THAT
YOU'VE IDENTIFIED OF STUDENTS
NOT HAVING STABLE HOUSING, IT'S
A SERIOUS ISSUE, WE ALSO KNOW
IT'S A SERIOUS ISSUE COMMUNITY
WIDE. IT'S NOT JUST JUST FOR OUR
UNIVERSITIES AS WELL, AND I
THINK THAT PART OF THE
RESPONSIBILITY THERE, IS ON US
AS A LEGISLATURE TO PROVIDE
ADEQUATE STUDENT HOUSING AT SOME
OF OUR UNIVERSITIES. AND
CERTAINLY THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES
HAVE ALMOST NONE ON THAT. IF WE
COULD BE DOING THAT BETTER, I
THINK IT WOULD HELP ALLEVIATE
THE PROBLEM THAT YOU'VE
IDENTIFIED IN YOUR BILL. BUT
IT'S, IT'S DIFFICULT TO DO. AND
FOR OBVIOUS REASONS, IT'S
EXPENSIVE, WITH LIMITED FUNDS
THAT WE DO HAVE, IT TAKES AWAY
FROM OTHER THINGS, NEVERTHELESS,
YES. I MEAN, THE QUITE FRANKLY,
THE THING THAT HAS ALWAYS
BOTHERED ME WHEN I ENGAGE WITH
CAMPUS LEADERS ABOUT THIS
PROBLEM IS THAT TO TALK ABOUT
THE RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN THE
COUNTY SOCIAL SERVICE SIDE OF
THINGS AND WHAT HAPPENS ON THE
CAMPUS, AND THE FACT THAT IN
MANY COMMUNITIES, THE CAMPUSES
ARE ALMOST SEEM LIKE ISLANDS,
THAT IT'S THEIR PROBLEM AND Ã
COUNTY, WHO HAS THE SOCIAL
SERVICE ASSISTANCE, THAT CAN BE
VERY VALUABLE SOMEHOW. IT'S JUST
NOT THEIR PROBLEM. AND THEY
DON'T CONNECT TO THE STUDENT
COMMUNITY THE WAY THEY SHOULD.
AND IT'S A POINT OF FRUSTRATION
GOES WAYS BEYOND YOUR BILL. BUT
IT'S A PART OF THE INQUIRY THAT
I KNOW THAT I HAVE MADE, I
GUESS, AND I APPRECIATE ALSO THE
FACT THAT YOU ARE WANTING TO DO
THIS AS A PILOT, SHOWING THAT WE
WANT TO TAKE SOME BABY STEPS
HERE IN THIS SPACE. AND THAT'S,
I THINK, THOUGHTFUL IN WHAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO ACCOMPLISH. THE
THING THAT MAKES ME PAUSE, TODAY
, DESPITE THE REALLY GOOD
INTENTIONS THAT YOU HAVE, IS
THAT, WE HAVE, AT LEAST ON THE
STATE UNIVERSITY LEVEL, WE'VE
WE'VE APPOINTED PEOPLE TO BE IN
CHARGE AND IN THE SENATE, WE GET
A CHANCE TO INTERVIEW THEM AND
CONFIRM THEM IF THEY'RE IF
THEY'RE QUALIFIED TO, TO RUN THE
STATE UNIVERSITY SYSTEM, THE
BOARD OF TRUSTEES AND I HAVE
HEARD AND YOU CAN CONFIRM THIS,
THAT YOU HAVE NOT HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY YET TO GO TO THE
BOARD OF TRUSTEES AND ASK THEM
SPECIFICALLY TO ENGAGE IN THIS.
WHAT IS AN OBVIOUS ISSUE OF
CONCERN THAT YOU APPROPRIATELY
HAVE RAISED? HAVE YOU HAD THE
CHANCE TO HAVE IT BE AGENDIZED?
ENGAGE THE TRUSTEES ON THIS TO
SEE IF THEY COULD, IN THEIR OWN
WAY, COME UP WITH A POLICY THAT
HELPS ADVANCE THE GOALS THAT YOU
HAVE PROPERLY IDENTIFIED. I HAVE
NOT, AND I'M NOT SURE YOU KNOW
THE APPROPRIATE WAY TO GO ABOUT
THAT. I MEAN, I USED TO SIT ON
THE BOARD OF TRUSTEES FOR THIS
ISSUE, AND THE, THAT TYPE OF
ENGAGEMENT IS NOT USUALLY
SOMETHING THAT ACTUALLY HAPPENS.
I MEAN, OF COURSE, AS A MEMBER
OF THE SENATE, YOU HAVE MORE
ENGAGEMENT BECAUSE OF YOUR
APPOINTMENT POWERS, BUT BUT
CERTAINLY I HAVE NOT. IT'S JUST
BEEN THE ENGAGEMENT WITH THEIR
OFFICES, THEIR SACRAMENTO
REPRESENTATIVE. SO IF THE BILL
IF THE BILL DOESN'T MOVE
FORWARD, I'D BE HAPPY TO HELP
YOU WITH THAT. THAT IT'S NOT
DIFFICULT TO GET AN ITEM
AGENDIZED ON THE AGENDA OF, OF
THE TRUSTEES AND TO HAVE YOU
COME AND PRESENT AND SHARE THAT
CONCERN APPROPRIATELY. SO TO SEE
WHETHER THAT BOARD CAN MAKE SOME
DECISIONS OR GIVE SOME GUIDANCE
TO THE 23 CAMPUSES ABOUT HOW
THEY'D LIKE TO SEE IT HANDLED,
MAY BE EVEN BETTER THAN WHAT
YOU'RE SUGGESTING, OR AT LEAST
CERTAINLY TO GET UPDATED TO
UNDERSTAND HOW RESPONSIVE THEY
ARE THEY ARE TO THESE PROBLEMS
THAT YOU HAVE CORRECTLY
IDENTIFIED MORE THAN JUST
HOUSING BASIC NEEDS IS A BROAD.
OH, ABSOLUTELY. YEAH. BUT I AND
I YOU KNOW, THE BILL MAY VERY
WELL MOVE FORWARD TODAY, BUT I'D
BE HAPPY TO WORK WITH YOU TO
HELP MAKE SURE THAT IF YOU WANT
TO GO ON THAT COURSE THAT I CAN
PARTNER WITH YOU TO ENCOURAGE
THEM TO ENGAGE DIRECTLY. I THINK
THAT'S A HEALTHY THING. AND BY
THE WAY, THIS GOES BEYOND YOUR
BILL. THIS IS A GENERAL
PHILOSOPHICAL VIEW. I HAVE ABOUT
A LOT OF EFFORTS TO COME TO THE
LEGISLATURE AND TRY TO ESTABLISH
STATEWIDE POLICY IN A PLACE
WHERE WE DO HAVE APPOINTING
AUTHORITY, AND WE DO HAVE THERE
IS RESPONSIBILITY THAT WE HOLD
GOVERNING BOARDS ACCOUNTABLE
FOR. SO THIS IS JUST BEYOND YOUR
BILL? NO. ABSOLUTELY TIME TO
KIND OF ENGAGE ON IT. YEAH.
THAT'S WHERE I HAVE RELUCTANCE
TODAY ON SUCH A GOOD AND CARING
PROPOSAL. NO I APPRECIATE THAT.
I WOULD JUST SAY A FEW THINGS.
THAT NUMBER ONE, WHAT OPPOSITION
HAS STATED THIS IS NOT TO STATE
THAT THE PREFERENCE IS FOR THEM
TO SLEEP IN PARKING LOTS IF THEY
HAVE PROGRAMS ALREADY, AND
ROBUST ENOUGH TO PREVENT THAT
FROM HAPPENING IN THE FIRST
PLACE. BY ALL MEANS DO IT. BUT
IF YOU DON'T, AND A STUDENT
FINDS THEMSELVES, HAVING TO FIND
SOME STREET, SOME ALLEY
SOMEWHERE THAT IS LESS SAFE,
THEN WE SHOULD PROVIDE THEM WITH
THAT STABILITY. AND IT MAY BE A
SITUATION WHERE IS THIS ALSO
REQUIRES THE STUDENT TO APPLY
FOR THIS SPECIAL PERMIT, WHICH
MEANS NOW WE KNOW WHO THEY ARE.
AND THAT WOULD BE A PERFECT
OPPORTUNITY FOR THEM TO SAY
THAT. OH, DID YOU KNOW WE HAVE
THESE OTHER SERVICES AVAILABLE?
THE IDEA IS HOW DO WE GET THEM
INTO THAT PIPELINE? AND
CERTAINLY WITH THE DATA SAYS IS,
IS THAT WE'RE NOT DOING
EVERYTHING THAT WE CAN. AND THIS
ALLOWS US TO ACTUALLY CREATE A
BEST PRACTICES BY, FOR ANY
REASON. THIS ENDS UP HAVING TO
BE A LAST RESORT, NOT THE
PREFERENCE. RIGHT. BUT THE LAST,
RESORT VOIGTS RESORT. AND SO YOU
KNOW, IN MANY CASES, I'VE THE
THOSE WHO HAVE DECIDED TO MEET
WITH ME, I HAVE LITERALLY Kò,
ENGAGED VERY THOUGHTFULLY AND
MADE AMENDMENTS TO ADDRESS
THOSE, THERE'S MANY THINGS THAT
WERE SAID TODAY THAT, NUMBER
ONE, I'VE NEVER HAD THE CHANCE
TO ACTUALLY MEET WITH THEM, BUT
NEVER HAD THOSE OTHER ISSUES
BROUGHT UP TO ME. AND SO I'M
TRYING TO BE VERY THOUGHTFUL FOR
THIS, BUT ALSO UNDERSTANDING
THAT SOMETIMES RAIMES
INSTITUTIONS HAVE TO CONTINUE TO
ADAPT TO FIND OUT, TO SEE WHAT'S
GOING ON ON THE GROUND, AND
THEIR UNWILLINGNESS TO, I THINK
IS JUST AN ISSUE. NOW, I DON'T
REPRESENT INSTITUTIONS. I
REPRESENT THE STUDENTS WHO ARE
HOMELESS AND I THINK THAT'S JUST
A DIFFERENCE FROM WHAT I BELIEVE
IS MY REPRESENTATION. RIGHT, AND
SO, YOU KNOW, RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE. BUT AT THE END OF
THE DAY, YOU KNOW, I JUST TRYING
TO CONTINUE TO MOVE THE NEEDLE
AND STILL OPEN TO HAVING THOSE
DISCUSSIONS AND ALL THOSE TYPE
OF THINGS, TOO, BUT I JUST THINK
THAT, YOU KNOW, MANY CASES,
THESE ARE SOME THINGS YOU HAVE
TO DO CONTINUE TO PUSH THOSE
ISSUES FORWARD. SO HOPEFULLY
THAT THEY WILL CONTINUE TO ADAPT
TO THE CHANGING ENVIRONMENT.
WE'RE FINDING OURSELVES IN HERE.
COULD I ASK THE CSU REP TO COME
BACK TO THE TABLE FOR A
QUESTION? CERTAINLY. HE'S RIGHT
HERE. COME COME BACK TO THE
TABLE, MR. MURILLO. ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU, I'D JUST LIKE TO ASK,
YOU KNOW, THERE HASN'T BEEN AN
AGENDA ITEM THAT I'M AWARE OF,
AND YOU CAN FAMILIAR ON THIS
ISSUE IN RECENT YEARS IS THAT
CORRECT? CORRECT. YEAH. WE
REGULARLY REPORT ON BASIC NEEDS
TO THE BOARD OF TRUSTEES, WHICH
INCLUDES STUDENTS EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS. I THINK I'D LIKE
TO ASK YOU TO TAKE BACK AT LEAST
THIS BILL. COULD VERY WELL MOVE
FORWARD TODAY. WE'LL SEE HOW IT
GOES THROUGH THE PROCESS. BUT
I'D LIKE TO REQUEST THAT THEY
AGENDIZE THIS AS A FORMAL ITEM.
SO THE ASSEMBLYMAN COULD COME
AND APPEAR AND SPEAK TO THE
CONCERNS THAT HE SEES AND GIVE
THEM THE TRUSTEES, THE
OPPORTUNITY TO RESPOND. SO
THAT'D BE MY REQUEST TO YOU.
SURE. IT'S CERTAINLY OPEN TO THE
CHANCELLOR. WE WERE ALREADY
SCHEDULED OR PLANNING TO
SCHEDULE A PRESENTATION FOR THIS
FALL FOR THE BOARD OF TRUSTEES
ON BASIC NEEDS. SO IT'S IN
ALIGNMENT WITH WHAT WE'RE
PLANNING TO DO. ALL RIGHT. THANK
YOU, SENATOR OCHOA. THANK YOU,
MR. CHAIR. GOOD MORNING, DOCTOR
JACKSON. MEMBER JACKSON, I SO
FIRST OF ALL, I JUST WANT TO
NOTE THAT IN THE 2324, THE STATE
INVESTED $33.1 MILLION INTO
BASIC NEEDS AND RAPID REHOUSING
PROGRAMS AS A TOTAL, INTERSTATE,
WHICH, AS WE KNOW, IN THE PAST
TWO YEARS, THREE YEARS TO THREE
YEARS, WE'VE WE'VE FUNDED
UNPRECEDENTED OR HEARD
UNPRECEDENTED AMOUNTS OF FUNDING
TOWARDS OUR SCHOOLS. I'VE ALSO
IN BUDGET ONE BEEN A PROPONENT
OF ACTUALLY BUILDING HOUSING ON
OUR CAMPUSES BECAUSE OF THE
BURDEN THAT IT POSES ON THE
COMMUNITIES SURROUNDING THESE
COLLEGES AND HOW THAT IMPACTS
THE COST OF LIVING. I DID NOT
KNOW, AND I'M JUST SHARING WHAT
I'VE LEARNED SINCE BEING ON, ON
THESE COMMITTEES IS THAT, YOU
KNOW, WE ARE AS A STATE, WE
REQUIRE OUR UNIVERSITIES,
COLLEGES TO INCREASE ENROLLMENT
AND IN THAT WE DON'T ALWAYS
FACILITATE THE HOUSING TO
ACCOMMODATE THOSE STUDENTS. AND
THAT HAS AN IMPACT ON OUR, OUR
OUR COMMUNITIES AND THE COST OF
HOUSING, I KNOW THAT THERE WAS A
LOT OF PROPOSALS WITH REGARDS TO
VOUCHERS AND GIVE THEM VOUCHERS
TO ACCOMMODATE, HOUSING WITHIN
THE LOCAL COMMUNITIES. AND I AND
I SAID, YOU KNOW, THAT STILL HAS
AN IMPACT ON THE HOUSING
INVENTORY FOR OUR LOCAL
COMMUNITY MEMBERS, STILL
IMPACTING THE COST OF HOUSING.
SO IT JUST GOES RIGHT UP, RIGHT?
WE DON'T HAVE ENOUGH HOUSING,
AND IT STILL GOES UP REGARDLESS
OF HOW MANY VOUCHERS WE GIVE.
THAT STILL DOES NOT ADDRESS THE
ROOT PROBLEM, WHICH IS ACTUALLY
HOUSING IN ITSELF. SO I'VE BEEN
A PROPONENT OF ACTUALLY SOLVING
THE ISSUE AT THE ROOT OF THE
PROBLEM, WHICH IS MAKING SURE
THAT WE HAVE HOUSING AVAILABLE,
PERIOD BUILDING, BUILDING IT ON
OUR CAMPUSES. IF WE'RE GOING TO
REQUIRE THAT. HAVING SAID THAT,
I KNOW FROM DISCUSSIONS IN MY
DISTRICT, AND I'M NOT SURE HOW
THAT HAS BEEN MODELED OR BEEN,
PRACTICED IN OTHER AREAS, BUT I
KNOW WITHIN MY WITHIN MY
DISTRICT, THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF
COLLABORATION BETWEEN K-12 AND
JUNIOR COLLEGES AND COLLEGES.
WHO AND COUNTIES ACTUALLY TO
COME TOGETHER TO THE TABLE AND
CREATE SYSTEMS IN WHICH ONCE WE
KNOW OUR STUDENTS IN K-12 ARE
QUALIFIED FOR FREE LUNCH, THEY
ARE AUTOMATICALLY TAGGED AND BE
ABLE TO SHARE THAT INFORMATION,
AS THEY MOVE TO, TO COLLEGE, TO
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES OR THE
LOCAL COLLEGES AND THE COUNTY IN
ORDER TO CARRY THAT INFORMATION
ON THOSE DEMOGRAPHICS, TO GET
THEM THE SERVICES THAT THEY NEED
, SO THAT IS SOMETHING THAT IF
WE'RE NOT DOING STATEWIDE,
SOMETHING THAT, YOU KNOW, OTHER
DISTRICTS COULD LOOK, TO SEE HOW
THEY COULD IMPLEMENT THAT
COLLABORATION OF DATA SO THAT
THEY DON'T THE STUDENTS, WHEN
THEY GRADUATE FROM COLLEGE OR
HIGH SCHOOL, DON'T HAVE TO APPLY
FOR ALL THOSE SERVICES, GO
THROUGH IT. SO COMING TO
IDENTIFYING THOSE STUDENTS CAN
CONTINUE MOVING FORWARD. SO IT'S
ONE WAY WHERE WE DON'T LOSE THEM
TO A SYSTEM WHERE THEY BECOME
HOMELESS AND WITHOUT SERVICES
AND WITHOUT RESOURCES AROUND
THEM. SO WHEN THERE IS AN
AWARENESS AND THEN THERE'S A
WILL, WE CAN CREATE THOSE
SYSTEMS OF COMMUNICATING AND
FOLLOWING THOSE STUDENTS
THROUGH. RIGHT? NO, ABSOLUTELY.
SO THERE'S CLEARLY WAYS AND
MEANS TO BE ABLE TO DO THAT, THE
OTHER QUESTION, THE CONCERN THAT
I HAD WAS, AS WE IMPLEMENT THE
LIABILITY THAT HAPPENS WHEN WE
ALLOW OUR STUDENTS TO SLEEP IN
THEIR CARS FOR THE UNIVERSITIES,
THAT IS ONE CONCERN. THE COST OF
DIVERTING THE FUNDING FROM OTHER
PROGRAMS ARE EFFECTIVE INTO
TRYING TO PROVIDE TO ACCOMMODATE
THIS LAST RESORT AND HOW THE
IMPACT, I DO HAVE A QUESTION
THAT WAS A CONCERN, A QUESTION
THAT I HAD WAS, DO WE HAVE A
NUMBER OF STUDENTS WHO ARE
SLEEPING IN THEIR CARS RIGHT NOW
THAT ARE NOT BEING, MET THROUGH
THE COLLEGES AND THE UNIVERSITY
CITIES, WITH THE PROPER
RESOURCES TO ACCOMMODATE THEM,
TO WHERE WE WOULD NEED TO
FACILITATE THIS PARTICULAR
PROGRAM, AND I'M CURIOUS ABOUT
THAT BECAUSE I KNOW IT HAPPENS,
BUT DO WE HAVE THE DATA AS TO
HOW MANY KIDS WE'RE MISSING,
BECAUSE IF WE HAVE THAT DATA,
THEN AS A COLLEGE IN THE
UNIVERSITY, WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE ARE MEETING THOSE. I'M
JUST WORRIED THAT WE'RE GOING TO
TAKE AWAY FROM ROUTING THOSE
STUDENTS TO TOWARDS THE
RESOURCES OF HAVING PROPER
SHELTER, WHICH I GET I GET THAT
THAT'S NOT THE COURSE. THIS IS
LAST RESORT. BUT IN ORDER TO
IMPLEMENT THIS, WE WILL BE
FACILITATING OR TRYING TO OR
REMOVE FUNDING FROM THOSE
PROGRAMS THAT ARE ACTUALLY
ACCESSING THOSE STUDENTS. SO A
LOT I KNOW I'VE SAID IT QUITE A
BIT. I'M ALL OVER THE PLACE, BUT
THERE'S JUST SO MUCH ALREADY
AVAILABLE TO ME TO THE STUDENTS.
BASED ON MY EXPERIENCE THESE
PAST THREE YEARS AND WHAT WE'VE
BEEN TRYING TO ACCOMMODATE THAT,
I'M I'M THINKING OF WHY DO WE
STILL NEED TO CONSIDER SUCH A
BILL AT THIS TIME? AND SO I'M,
I'M RELUCTANT TO, TO SUPPORT IT
BECAUSE AS I THINK IN LIEU OF
THIS, WE HAVE TO MAYBE GO BACK
AND REASSESS WHAT WE ALREADY ARE
SUPPOSED TO BE DOING AND THE
FUNDING THAT WE'RE ALREADY
ALLOCATED TO THESE PROGRAMS, AND
TRY TO SEE WHERE WE NEED TO
ADDRESS THE ISSUE AT THE ROOT OF
THE PROBLEM, RATHER THAN
EXPANDING SOMETHING THAT IS NOT
IDEAL OR SAFE AND MORE COSTLY
AND DIVERTING FUNDING FROM OTHER
CURRENT PROGRAMS. YEAH DOES THAT
MAKE SENSE? NO NO NO NO,
ABSOLUTELY. NUMBER ONE, A
NUMBER, THE IN TERMS OF
STATEWIDE DATA, PARTICULARLY TO
HOMELESS STUDENTS, EACH CAMPUS
HAS THEIR OWN DATA, RIGHT? THE
DATA THAT'S PROVIDED STATEWIDE,
YOU KNOW, IS LAGGING, MEANING
IT'S NOT AS CURRENT FOR ME TO
SAY THESE ARE THE EXACT NUMBERS
THIS YEAR. RIGHT. BUT THERE'S NO
DOUBT EVEN IN I HAVE TWO
COMMUNITY COLLEGES IN MY
DISTRICT, AND THEY ALL THEY HAVE
BASIC THEY HAVE THE BASIC NEEDS
PROGRAM. RIGHT BUT THERE ARE
STILL NOT ENOUGH PLACES OR THEY
DON'T HAVE THE ADDITIONAL,
RESOURCES TO TAKE THEM OUT OF
THEIR VEHICLES. SO THEY'RE STILL
RIGHT NOW, HUNDREDS OF STUDENTS
THROUGHOUT THIS STATE WHO WILL
BE WHO WILL BE GETTING THEIR
BASIC NEEDS IN TERMS OF FOOD,
FOOD PANTRIES FROM THEIR
COLLEGES. BUT THEY WILL BE
TAKING THEM HOME, TAKING THEM TO
THEIR VEHICLES AND DRIVING
AROUND TRYING TO FIND A PLACE, A
SAFE PLACE TO SLEEP. THIS IS NOT
INTENDED TO DIVERT RESOURCES,
AND I'M MORE THAN WILLING TO DO
SOME UPON APPROPRIATION LANGUAGE
AND THOSE TYPE OF THINGS TO
ADDRESS THAT ISSUE. NOT A
PROBLEM. RIGHT, BUT THE IDEA IS
WHAT WE'RE DOING IS NOT ENOUGH,
AND WE'VE GOT TO STILL FIND
DIFFERENT WAYS TO DO IT. THERE
IS A SAFE WAY TO ALLOW PEOPLE TO
PARK IN THEIR VEHICLES. I KNOW
THIS FROM MY OWN SOCIAL WORKER
BACKGROUND. THERE ARE MODELS
BEING USED THROUGHOUT THIS STATE
RIGHT NOW THAT DOES THAT IN A
SAFE WAY. NOT THE IDEAL, RIGHT,
BUT THERE'S A WAY TO DO IT. IN
TERMS OF YOUR LIABILITY
QUESTION, WE ADDRESSED IT IN THE
IN THE BILL IN TERMS OF
LIABILITY. AND THEN WE ASKED
THEM FOR ADDITIONAL LANGUAGE FOR
THEIR OWN LEGAL PEOPLE TO GIVE
US. AND THEY DID NOT. THEY
DECIDED NOT TO GIVE ME
ADDITIONAL LANGUAGE IN TERMS OF
LIABILITY. K¾T. AND SO WE HAVE
ADDRESSED ALL OF THOSE ISSUES
HERE, AND I'M EVEN WILLING TO
ADDRESS THE IDEA OF TRYING TO
TAKE AWAY RESOURCES FROM ONE
THING TO DO ANOTHER. THAT'S
THAT'S JUST THAT DOESN'T MAKE
SENSE TO ME. AND IF THAT'S NOT
CLEAR HERE, I'M MORE THAN
WILLING TO ADDRESS THAT. SO LET
ME DO THIS. AND, SENATOR
SODERBERG, SO I'M ACTUALLY GOING
TO HAVE TO LEAVE AND COME BACK.
I HAVE TO GO PRESENT TO
APPROPRIATIONS. AND I DON'T MEAN
TO SHORT CHANGE THIS
CONVERSATION, BUT I WANT TO MAKE
A COUPLE OF POINTS BEFORE I
LEAVE. SO, ASSEMBLYMEMBER
JACKSON, YOU AND I SPOKE, I
THINK, LAST WEEK, AND IF YOU
RECALL, MY REACTION TO THIS BILL
WAS, YOU KNOW, OPPOSITIONAL TO
START, I MEAN, TO PRESIDENT
STERN'S POINT, I WAS CONCERNED
ONE AT THE PROSPECTIVE COST, TWO
AT THE SORT OF WHAT I THOUGHT
PERHAPS WAS THE DUPLICATIVE
FEATURE HERE. AND THEN THIRD,
YOU KNOW, THIS QUESTION ABOUT
IMPACT ON BOTH SCHOOLS AND
COMMUNITIES IS RELATED TO PUBLIC
SAFETY. AND YOU'VE ADDRESSED ONE
OF THOSE, AND I APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMITMENT FOR, YOU KNOW, FOR
LANGUAGE THAT MAKES IT CLEAR
THAT THIS WOULD BE UPON
APPROPRIATION. SO THERE'S NO
ADVERSE IMPACT OR, YOU KNOW,
SQUEEZING OUT OF ON, ON THE PART
OF THE COLLEGES. AND YOU WERE
ALSO, I THINK, GOOD ENOUGH TO
ACCEPT MY SUGGESTION AMENDMENT
OF NO RVS. RIGHT. BECAUSE WHAT
WE'RE NOT TRYING TO DO HERE,
WE'RE NOT TRYING TO HAVE NO
TAILGATE PARTIES AROUND HERE.
WELL, OKAY. BUT BUT I THINK WHAT
WHAT GETS LOST HERE AND YOU MADE
THE POINT VERY WELL TO ME WAS
THAT, YOU KNOW, THIS IS A
COMPLEMENT TO NOT A REPLACEMENT
FOR OTHER PROGRAMS. AND I DO
APPRECIATE THE LOGIC HERE THAT,
YOU KNOW, FOR THOSE STUDENTS
THAT FIND THEMSELVES IN THAT
PRECARIOUS POSITION, THAT THAT
THE, THE OPPORTUNITY K¾T FOR,
YOU KNOW, A VERY LIMITED PERIOD,
YOU KNOW, A RESPITE, AS IT WERE,
WOULD COME WITH THE REQUIREMENT
TO ACTUALLY APPLY TO GET A
PERMIT ON A LIMITED DURATION
BASIS. AND WITH THAT, TO USE
THAT AS, AS AN INTEGRATION AND
SCREENING BASIS FOR, FOR CAUSING
THEM, YOU KNOW, PROACTIVELY TO
ACCESS EXISTING SERVICES. AND SO
I THINK THAT'S, YOU KNOW,
THERE'S PROMISE IN THAT CONCEPT
AS LONG AS IT'S DONE IN SUCH A
WAY. THE PRESIDENT'S TURNS POINT
THAT IT'S NOT AT THE EXPENSE OF
OTHER PROGRAMS, THAT IT'S NOT
BEING DONE IN LIEU OF OTHER
PROGRAMS. AND SO YOU MADE THAT
CLEAR TO ME THAT THAT'S THAT'S
THE INTENT. AND SO I WOULD ASK
YOU ALSO TO CONSIDER A LIMITED
LIMITATION ON THE DURATION,
RIGHT? SO, YOU KNOW, IF
SOMEBODY'S GOT A PERMIT, I GUESS
TWO LIMITATIONS, ONE, THERE'D BE
A LIMITED TIME PERIOD, COULDN'T
GO GO ON OPEN ENDEDLY. CORRECT.
AND TWO, THAT THAT, YOU KNOW,
IT'S NOT ALL DAY. RIGHT. SO I
ASSUME THIS WOULD BE AS A MATTER
OF COURSE, THAT THERE WOULD BE
HOURS. SO YOU DON'T NEED TO THE
PRESIDENT'S POINT 24 HOUR
SECURITY AROUND THE PROGRAM, BUT
WE'VE ALSO YOU'VE ALSO ACCEPTED
THE AMENDMENTS. I THINK I DID
THAT WE'RE GOING TO CIRCUMSCRIBE
THIS TO FIVE CSU'S MAXIMUM AND
THE 20 MAKE IT PROPORTIONAL
ACROSS THE SYSTEM'S 20 COMMUNITY
COLLEGES WITH A SUNSET. IS THAT
CORRECT? THAT'S CORRECT. OKAY,
AND, YOU KNOW, SO WITH THAT, YOU
STILL THERE STILL IS THE LARGER
QUESTION ABOUT FISCAL IMPACT.
THIS WILL GO FROM HERE TO
JUDICIARY. THERE MAY BE SOME
LEGAL ISSUES YOU CAN DISCUSS,
BUT AT THE END OF THE DAY, YOU
KNOW, IT'S ABOUT THE COST. AND
YOU KNOW, THIS, AS YOU KNOW, IS
CHALLENGING FISCAL ENVIRONMENT.
SO YOU'LL HAVE TO GET THROUGH
THAT GATE. AND I THINK YOU'LL
ALSO HAVE TO GIVE THE ASSURANCE
THAT THIS WON'T CANNIBALIZE
OTHER PROGRAMS THAT ARE EQUALLY
NEEDED AT THIS TIME. AND SO WITH
THAT, I, YOU KNOW, I'M GOING TO
LEAVE BECAUSE I HAVE TO GO
IRONICALLY, GO TO
APPROPRIATIONS, MAKE A BID FOR
ONE OF MY OWN BILLS. BUT I'M
GOING TO GIVE YOU I'LL BE THERE
NEXT WITH THIS. I GET TO BEAT
YOU THERE. I KNOW I'LL BEAT YOU
THERE. OH, YOU'RE ON THE
COMMITTEE? NO. OKAY, THEN I'LL
BE. I'LL BE BEGGING. NICE. YOU.
THAT'S GREAT. SO YOU KNOW, I'M
GOING TO GIVE YOU A, YOU KNOW, A
SORT OF A, YOU KNOW, A
CONDITIONAL. YES. VOTE HERE. BUT
I DO THINK IT'S IMPORTANT. AND I
APPRECIATE ALL OF THE SCHOOL'S
CONCERNS AS, AS WELL ARTICULATED
BY PRESIDENT STERN, THAT WE HAVE
TO MAKE SURE THAT THIS IS A
COMPLEMENT TO AND PROPERLY
INTEGRATED WITH ALL OF THE OTHER
PROGRAMS, BECAUSE THERE IS AN
ACKNOWLEDGED THAT AND I THINK AN
ONGOING EFFORT BOTH AT THE CSU
AND THE CS TO MAKE, YOU KNOW, TO
ADDRESS THIS REALLY PRESSING
NEED OF AND VERY COMPLICATED
HOUSING. YEAH. AND CHALLENGES,
VERY COMPLICATED. YEAH. ALL
RIGHT. WITH THAT, I'M GOING TO
PASS THE GAVEL BACK TO SEN.
COULD I ASK A CLARIFICATION
BEFORE YOU LEAVE? I KNOW YOU'RE
RUSHING OUT TO GET FIRST IN
LINE, BUT I'M LIKE LAST IN LINE.
I'M ABOUT TO LOSE MY PLACE.
OKAY. GO AHEAD. YOU SAID SUBJECT
TO AN APPROPRIATION SO THAT THAT
I WANT TO JUST BE CLEAR ON THAT,
THAT THE AUTHORS AGREE ON MORE
THAN THAT'S HIS THAT'S HIS
OFFER. AND GLAD TO TAKE YOU UP
ON THAT. ALL RIGHT. YES. OKAY.
YEP. YEAH. OKAY. AND THEN FOR
ME, I'M JUST GOING TO, THANK
YOU, I'M JUST GOING TO I'M GOING
TO ABSTAIN ON THE, THE BILL
TODAY, I WOULD LIKE, WOULD I
THINK WOULD BE PROBABLY BEST,
MOVING FORWARD IN MY PERSONAL
HUMBLE OPINION, IS THAT PERHAPS
DOING A STUDY OF WHAT WE
CURRENTLY HAVE, ACROSS THE STATE
WHEN ADDRESSING OUR STUDENTS IN
NEEDS AND SEEING WHAT IS
WORKING, WHAT'S NOT WORKING, AND
WHAT THE LOOPHOLES WOULD BE IN
ORDER TO ADDRESS IT. BECAUSE WE
ARE WE ARE ALLOCATING A LOT OF
FUNDING, AND WE HAVE SO MANY
PROGRAMS AVAILABLE THROUGHOUT
THE STATE, ON SO MANY LEVELS,
WHETHER IT'S COUNTY, WHETHER
IT'S AT THE COLLEGE LEVEL, THAT
IF WE'RE STILL MISSING SOME,
SOME, SOME STUDENTS IN THIS
PROCESS THAT WE SHOULD PROBABLY
LOOK INTO WHERE WE'RE FAILING
AND MOVE FORWARD ON THAT, IN
THAT, IN THAT PERSPECTIVE. SO I,
I THINK IF THERE'S STILL A NEED,
I PERSONALLY, I THINK A STUDY
WOULD PROBABLY BE BEST, TO
ENSURE THAT WE DO HAVE THE
PROGRAMS OR AN AUDIT TO SEE, YOU
KNOW, HOW WE'RE SPENDING THOSE
THOSE FUNDINGS AND THOSE
PROGRAMS OR THE FUNDING FOR
PROGRAMS IN OUR STATE ADDRESSING
OUR STUDENTS IN NEED, SO WITH
THAT, I'M GOING TO LAY OFF
BECAUSE I DON'T STILL DON'T
THINK THAT THIS ISSUE, THIS THIS
BILL IS ADDRESSING THE ROOT
CAUSE OF THE PROBLEM, AND SO I,
YOU KNOW, WITH THE UTMOST
RESPECT, I WILL BE LAYING OFF ON
THE BILL TODAY, WITH THAT. OH
YES. YOU KNOW, I'M GOING TO MOVE
THE BILL UNDER THE CONDITIONS
THAT HAVE BEEN SET BY THE CHAIR
TO YOU HAVE MY WORD ON THAT. AND
THAT YOUR HEART IS TOTALLY IN
THE RIGHT PLACE DOING THE RIGHT
THING. AND I WOULD GO BACK TO
THE CSU AND SAY, I KNOW YOU'RE
HAVING AN AGENDA ON BASIC NEEDS,
BUT I WANT THIS SPECIFIC
PROPOSAL. IF IT DOESN'T MOVE
THROUGH THIS YEAR, I WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT IT'S CLEAR THAT
THE SPECIFIC PROPOSAL BY THE
ASSEMBLYMAN IS ONE I HOPE WILL
BE PART OF THAT AGENDA, SO THEY
CAN ADDRESS SPECIFICALLY ABOUT
PARKING ON CAMPUS. OKAY. THAT
I'M HAPPY TO I APPRECIATE IT.
OKAY THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
MEMBER JACKSON, WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE, I APPRECIATE THE
DISCUSSION. VERY COMPLICATED
ISSUES, BUT THERE'S NOTHING BUT
COMPLICATED ISSUES LEFT. SO HERE
WE ARE I APPRECIATE IT.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. MEMBER JACKSON.
MADAM SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL FOR ITEM THREE AB 1818
JACKSON MOTION IS DUE. PASS AS
AMENDED TO SENATE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE. NEWMAN OTOBOKE CORTEZ
. GLASER. GLASER. AYE. GONZALEZ.
SMALL CUEVAS. WILK THANK YOU.
WE'LL WE HAVE ONE VOTE,
REGISTERED FOR THE, FOR A AB
1818, AND WE WILL PUT THAT ON
HOLD FOR OUR ABSENT MEMBERS.
OKAY. WE HAVE, MEMBER WARD,
PRESENT ITEM NUMBER, FILE NUMBER
FOUR, AB 1858. NEXT WELCOME.
THANK YOU. WELL, SENATORS, LET
ME START BY. I WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR THEIR WORK. AND
I'M VERY HAPPY TO ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEE'S AMENDMENTS ON THEIR
CLARIFYING IN NATURE, BUT ALSO
ALIGN WITH THE INTENT OF WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO ACHIEVE THROUGH
THIS BILL IN CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS,
THERE ARE CLEAR POLICIES AND
PROCEDURES FOR EARTHQUAKE AND
FIRE DRILLS. UNFORTUNATELY, THIS
IS NOT THE CASE FOR ACTIVE
SHOOTER DRILLS. SCHOOL SHOOTER
DRILLS TAKE MANY FORMS, FROM
BEING AS BASIC AS MODIFIED
LOCKDOWNS TO EXTREME ACTIVE
SHOOTER SIMULATIONS WITH
GUNFIRE, FAKE BLOOD, ACTORS ON
CAMPUS, STUDENTS AND STAFF NOT
BEING MADE AWARE THAT A DRILL IS
TAKING PLACE AND CAUSING
SIGNIFICANT TRAUMA TO ALL WHO
ARE INVOLVED. NOWHERE ELSE IN
OUR SCHOOL SYSTEM IS THERE
SOMETHING SO ABRASIVE AND
UNREGULAR. WHEN WE'RE DOING A
FIRE DRILL, YOU WOULDN'T FILL
THE HALLS FULL OF FAKE FLAMES
AND TURN UP THE TEMPERATURE. AND
WHEN YOU HAVE AN EARTHQUAKE
DRILL, YOU WOULDN'T START
SHAKING THE ROOM. AB 1858 SEEKS
TO STANDARDIZE SCHOOL SHOOTER
DRILLS BY GIVING CLEAR GUIDANCE
TO THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION. SO THEY CAN UPDATE
THEIR CURRENT REQUIREMENTS FOR
SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO USE WHEN
CONDUCTING THESE DRILLS. THIS
GUIDANCE WILL FOCUS ON AGE
APPROPRIATE DRILL PROCEDURES,
BANNED SIMULATED SHOOTING AND
VIOLENCE, PROVIDE LOCAL
RESOURCES FOR STUDENTS TO REACH
OUT TO ADDRESS TRAUMA. REQUIRE
STUDENTS AND STAFF BE TOLD WHEN
A DRILL IS BEGINNING AND
NOTIFICATION OF THE DRILL THE
WEEK OF AND FOLLOWING THE DRILL
THAT SAME DAY. SO WE UNDERSTAND
THAT THERE'S A DRILL COMING AND
IT IS NOT THE REAL THING I.
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF AB
1858, CASSANDRA WHETSTONE FROM
MOMS DEMAND ACTION AND TRISTAN
BROWN FROM THE CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS. AND WHEN
THE TIME IS APPROPRIATE, I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. MEMBER BOARD.
WELCOME. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING, VICE CHAIR AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS
CASSANDRA WHETSTONE. I'M A
PARENT. I'M AN EDUCATOR, AND I'M
A VOLUNTEER WITH MOMS DEMAND
ACTION. I'M HERE TODAY ASKING
YOU TO SUPPORT AB 1858. THIS
BILL WILL GUIDE SCHOOLS
CONDUCTING ACTIVE SHOOTER DRILLS
TO UTILIZE A TRAUMA INFORMED
APPROACH, INCLUDING ADVANCED
NOTIFICATION OF DRILLS TO STAFF
AND PARENTS, LIMITATIONS ON
DRILLS WITH SIMULATIONS, AND
AVAILABILITY OF MENTAL HEALTH
RESOURCES, ACTIVE SHOOTER DRILLS
COME FROM A PLACE OF GOOD
INTENTIONS. STUDENT SAFETY. AS
AN EDUCATOR, I KNOW THAT
STUDENTS LEARN BEST WHEN THEY
FEEL SAFE, CONFIDENT, AND
COMFORTABLE. BUT THESE DRILLS
HAVE MEASURABLE NEGATIVE IMPACTS
ON THE STRESS AND ANXIETY LEVELS
OF STUDENTS. RESEARCH HAS FOUND
THAT DRILLS INVOLVING CHILDREN
HAVE NOT PROVEN TO BE EFFECTIVE
IN PREVENTING SCHOOL GUN
VIOLENCE, WHILE SIMULTANEOUSLY
FINDING THAT THESE DRILLS
SIGNIFICANTLY NEGATIVELY IMPACT
STUDENTS MENTAL HEALTH. AB 1858
WILL HELP TO MITIGATE THESE
STRESSORS BY INCLUDING GUIDANCE
FOR AGE APPROPRIATE DRILLS AND
MAKING SURE THESE DRILLS ARE
TRAUMA INFORMED WITH THE
WELL-BEING OF STUDENTS TAKING
PRIORITY. THIS BILL IS BACKED
AND GUIDED BY RESEARCH. A REPORT
PUBLISHED BY EVERYTOWN FOR GUN
SAFETY, THE AMERICAN FEDERATION
OF TEACHERS, AND THE NATIONAL
EDUCATION ASSOCIATION THÀNH.
WHILE WE DON'T RECOMMEND ACTIVE
SHOOTER DRILLS FOR CHILDREN IF
THEY ARE HAPPENING, WE BELIEVE
THAT THEY NEED TO BE CONDUCTED
IN WAYS THAT WILL MINIMIZE THE
HARMFUL IMPACTS ON OUR SCHOOL
COMMUNITIES. ON BEHALF OF
EVERYTOWN FOR GUN SAFETY, MOMS
DEMAND ACTION AND STUDENTS
DEMAND ACTION, I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON AB
1858. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK
YOU, MADAM CHAIR, AND MEMBERS,
TRISTAN BROWN OF CFT. WE
REPRESENT OVER 120,000 EDUCATORS
IN THIS STATE. ALL OF WHICH ARE
LIVING IN A CONSTANT FEAR THAT
SOMEDAY MIGHT BE THEIR DAY TO,
UNFORTUNATELY, BE A PART OF A
TRAGEDY AT SCHOOL. SO WE DO TAKE
THIS POLICY AREA EXTREMELY
SERIOUSLY. WE KNOW THAT OUR
MEMBERS HAVE HAD TO SERVE AS
SHIELDS FOR CHILDREN IN THE PAST
, AND SEEN UNSPEAKABLE TRAGEDIES
IN OUR CAMPUSES. UNFORTUNATELY,
AS THESE CONTINUE TO GROW IN OUR
COMMUNITIES YEAR IN AND YEAR
OUT, WE NEED TO BE PREPARED. BUT
PREPARATION DOES NOT REQUIRE
TRAUMA TO ALSO ACCOMPANY IT. WE
WERE EXCITED TO SEE THAT THE
AUTHOR OF THIS BILL PUT THIS
POLICY FORWARD TO PREVENT
UNNEEDED TRAUMA TO BOTH
EDUCATORS, CLASSIFIED STAFF AND
STUDENTS TO HAVE TO LIVE THROUGH
A VERY SERIOUS AND TRAUMATIC
EXPERIENCE. ANECDOTALLY, WE KNOW
THAT SOME CAMPUSES HAVE TRIED TO
MAKE A VERY AUTHENTIC TRAINING
HAPPEN WHERE NOTICE WAS NOT
PROVIDED TO STUDENTS OR STAFF IN
A WAY TO MAKE IT AS MOST
REALISTIC AS POSSIBLE. THIS DOES
KEEP PEOPLE UP. THIS DOES CREATE
TRAUMA THAT THEY HAVE TO LIVE
WITH, AND WE DON'T NEED TO HAVE
TO SEE THE GORE. WE DON'T HAVE
TO LIVE THROUGH THE SHOTS TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT TO DO IN CASE OF
AN EMERGENCY TO VACATE, TO HIDE,
TO FIGHT IN SOME CIRCUMSTANCES.
AND WHATEVER THE BEST TRAINING
METHODS ARE, WE HOPE AND SEND
ALL POSITIVE ENERGY THAT WE
NEVER HAVE TO LIVE THROUGH A DAY
LIKE THIS AGAIN. BUT IN THAT
EVENT, WE'RE HOPEFUL THAT WE CAN
DO SO. BEING PROPERLY TRAINED
WITHOUT THE TRAUMA ASSOCIATED
WITH LIVE FIRE, WITH FAKE FIRE,
WITH GORE, WITH ANY OF THOSE
ELEMENTS THAT WILL KEEP, STAFF
AND PUPILS AWAKE AT NIGHT
RELIVING THESE TRAUMATIC MOMENTS
AND WONDERING WHEN THEIR DAY IS
COMING. WE'D MUCH RATHER HAVE
FOLKS KNOW TO HIDE AND TO SEEK
OUT LAW ENFORCEMENT AND TO SEEK
OUT SAFETY, WHATEVER THE BEST
PRACTICES ARE, BUT NOT NEED
NEEDLESSLY SEND FOLKS THROUGH A
VERY TRAUMATIC EXPERIENCE. SO
THE FEDERATION OF TEACHERS, BOTH
REPRESENTING CLASSIFIED AND
CERTIFICATED STAFF IN OUR STATE,
ARE HAPPY TO SUPPORT THIS BILL.
AND WE URGE YOUR AYE VOTE THIS
MORNING. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THEN WE'LL CONTINUE WITH ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF AB 1858.
THE ORIGINAL VOLUNTEER WITH MOMS
DEMAND ACTION IN SUPPORT.
KIMBERLY MANFREDI, A VOLUNTEER
WITH MOMS DEMAND ACTION IN
SUPPORT. CLARA WHETSTONE, A
VOLUNTEER WITH MOMS DEMAND
ACTION IN SUPPORT. JULIE
CHAPMAN, A VOLUNTEER WITH MOMS
DEMAND ACTION IN SUPPORT.
JILLIAN KING, VOLUNTEER MOMS
DEMAND ACTION AND RETIRED K-12
ADMINISTRATOR. CHRIS MYERS WITH
THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION IN STRONG SUPPORT.
REBECCA MARCUS WITH THE BRADY
CAMPAIGN AND SUPPORT. GOOD
MORNING, MADAM VICE CHAIR AND
SENATORS PAMELA GIBBS,
REPRESENTING THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION AND
SUPPORT. SIERRA COOK WITH THE
SAN DIEGO UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT AND SUPPORT PRISCILLA
KUDOS HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF CHILD AND
ADOLESCENT PSYCHIATRY AND THE
SAN FRANCISCO BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT. LUCY
SALCIDO CARTER WITH THE ALAMEDA
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION IN
SUPPORT. WITH TWIN RIVERS
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT IN
STRONG SUPPORT. WENDY BRAMBLE,
JUST A NORMAL CITIZEN IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
SEEING NO OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT, WE'LL NOW MOVE TO ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO AB
1858. SEEING NONE WILL BRING IT
BACK TO THE DAIS. SENATOR WILK.
WELL, YOU GOT YOU GOT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE ME. WHY WAS THIS NOT
ON CONSENT, I WAS NOT PRIVY TO
THOSE DISCUSSIONS. WELL, I'D
ADMONISH THE CHAIR IF HE'S HERE.
IN FACT, I WILL ADMONISH TO THE
CHAIR BECAUSE HE'S NOT HERE.
YEAH, THIS SHOULD HAVE BEEN ON
CONSENT. SO BACK IN THOSE OF YOU
WHO HEARD THE STORY BEFORE, I'M
SORRY. SO BACK IN 2019, WHEN I
WAS OUT HIKING EARLY IN THE
MORNING, I COME BACK TO THE
HOUSE, THE TV IS ON AND IT'S AN
AERIAL VIEW OF A NEIGHBORHOOD. I
GO THAT LOOKS LIKE MY
NEIGHBORHOOD. AND IT WAS BECAUSE
20 MINUTES EARLIER THERE WAS A
SHOOTING AT THE AT THE HIGH
SCHOOL THAT MY KIDS HAD GONE TO.
ANYBODY THAT YOU KNOW OF WHO
KNOWS THAT AREA WOULD SAY THAT
WOULD BE THE LAST SCHOOL IN
AMERICA WHERE THAT WOULD HAPPEN.
SO IT CAN HAPPEN ANYWHERE. AND
THE THING THAT WAS INTERESTING
ABOUT IT, OBVIOUSLY IT WENT DOWN
THE RIGHT OF WAY. FIRST
RESPONDERS WERE SO IMPRESSED BY
THE WAY THE STUDENTS EXECUTED
THE, THE, THE GAME PLAN THAT
THEY HAD LEARNED AND THEY
LEARNED IT WITHOUT ALL THE
TRAUMA AND ALL THAT. SO YOU CAN
DO IT WITHOUT THAT. THAT'S ONE.
AND NUMBER TWO, TWO STUDENTS.
WELL, ACTUALLY, THREE STUDENTS
DIED. THE SHOOTER, TWO OTHERS,
AND THEN TWO WERE WOUNDED, ONE
OF THE WOUNDED STUDENTS WHO
ACTUALLY WAS THE TARGET, SHE DID
NOT DID NOT HAVE THE SAME
FEELINGS FOR THE SHOOTER AS HE
HAD FOR HER, A FRIEND OF OURS,
SO HER SHE THAT SHOT IN HER WENT
THROUGH CLEANLY, SO THAT WAS
GOOD. SO WE WENT TO GO VISIT
HER. AND AFTER SHE GOT OUT OF
THE HOSPITAL IS THIS SUNDAY THE
PATRIOTS GAME IS ON YOU KNOW, WE
BRING A GIFT. WE GO THERE LIKE
20 MINUTES AND HAVE A GREAT TIME
. ANOTHER FAMILY COMES SO WE
LEAVE. AND THEN IT'S INTERESTING
. MY WIFE AND I GET IN THE CAR
AND WE BOTH START CRYING AND WE
AND WE'RE JUST WE'RE WE'RE JUST
TRIGGERED FROM THAT. SO I COULD
SEE WHERE YOU COULD GET
TRIGGERED, FROM SOME OF THESE
EXTREME EXAMPLES THAT I'VE, YOU
KNOW, SEEN ABOUT OR HEARD ABOUT.
SO I THINK THIS IS JUST A COMMON
SENSE THAT AND AGAIN, I CAN'T
BELIEVE IT'S NOT ON CONSENT. BUT
ANYWAY, HE'S ALREADY MOVED THE
BILL. SO, BUT I'LL VOTE FOR IT.
THANK YOU, SENATOR. SENATOR
GLAZIER. WELL JUST JUST FOR THE
RECORD, TO PROTECT THE CHAIR IN
HIS ABSENCE. A BILL ON CONSENT
TYPICALLY GETS THERE BECAUSE
THERE'S AGREEMENT BETWEEN THE
CHAIR AND THE VICE CHAIR. THAT'S
HOW THINGS APPEAR ON CONSENT,
JUST AS I UNDERSTAND IT. AND BY
THE WAY, IT'S OKAY TO BE
SENSITIVE. SENATORS ARE
SENSITIVE. AND THAT'S ALL RIGHT.
I'M HAPPY TO MOVE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING IT TO US.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU, MR.
SENATOR GLAZIER, SO NOW, WELL,
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE? THANK
YOU, MADAM CHAIR, NO, I
APPRECIATE YOUR CONSIDERATION OF
THIS. I THINK IT SETS IMPORTANT
GUARDRAILS IN PLACE. WHERE, OF
COURSE, WE WANT OUR SCHOOLS TO
BE SAFE SPACES. WE NEED TO GO
THROUGH EXERCISES THAT ARE GOING
TO BE ABLE TO THINK ABOUT WHAT
TO DO IN THE TRAGIC EVENTUALITY
OF A REALLY DIFFICULT SITUATION
WHEN WE INTRODUCED THIS BILL, IT
MIGHT NOT SURPRISE YOU THAT WE
RECEIVED A LOT OF COMMUNICATION
STATEWIDE, FROM STUDENTS OR
FORMER STUDENTS THAT HAD LIVED
THROUGH A DRILL THAT HAD INDUCED
TRAUMA. SOME OF THEM WERE STILL
LIVING FOR THAT YEARS AFTER THE
FACT, FROM I REMEMBER CALLS FROM
THE PENINSULA, FROM THE CENTRAL
VALLEY, THAT THEY JUST HAD AN
EXPERIENCE WHERE THEY THOUGHT IT
WAS THE REAL THING, AND THAT,
YOU KNOW, I THINK JUST REALLY
AND, YOU KNOW, THEY THEY HEARD
SOUNDS OR THEY HEARD ACTIVITIES
THAT JUST REALLY INDUCED AND
TRIGGERED A REAL FEAR FOR THEM.
SO LET'S, AND I'LL SAY FOR THE
RECORD, TOO, THAT, YOU KNOW, A
LOT OF OUR SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE
USING DRILLS, BUT THEY'RE DOING
SO RESPONSIBLY. AND THE FACT
THAT WE JUST HAVEN'T HAD
STATEWIDE GUIDANCE THAT IS
ACTUALLY CREATING SOME
CONFORMITY AND SOME GUARDRAILS
ABOUT BEST PRACTICES AND WHAT TO
DO OR NOT DO, IS HELPFUL TO MAKE
SURE THAT WELL-INTENTIONED OR
OTHER DISTRICTS THAT MAY BE
THINKING ABOUT SOMETHING DESIGN
THAT IS JUST GOING TOO FAR. BUT
FOR ALL THE GOOD INTENTIONS,
WE'RE PREVENTING THAT. AND SO
I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO THIS
GUIDANCE, BEING ABLE TO SUPPORT,
SCHOOLS SO THAT THEY CAN
CONTINUE TO BE, AS WE HEARD, THE
SAFE AND THRIVING ENVIRONMENTS
THAT WE WANT AND WOULD
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. MEMBER WARD,
MADAM SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL, FILE ITEM FOUR AB 1858
WARD MOTION IS TO PASS, AS
AMENDED, TO SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
NEWMAN, OCHOA, BOGH I OKOBOJI I
CORTEZ. GLASER. GLASER I.
GONZALEZ SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
WILK. HI. WILK I. THANK YOU.
THREE VOTES. WE WILL PUT THAT ON
CALL FOR ABSENT MEMBERS. DO WE
HAVE NEXT. OH SO. LU█T. OKAY, SO
WE HAVE, THE WONDERFUL PRESENCE
OF MEMBER COLORA. YOU'LL BE
PRESENTING ITEM 18 AND 19, WOULD
YOU LIKE, DO YOU HAVE A
PREFERENCE OF WHICH ONE YOU'D
LIKE TO? WE'LL GO IN ORDER. I
THINK 23 AND 98 IS THE FIRST
ONE. SO NUMBER ITEM FILE ITEM
NUMBER 18 AB 2398. THANK YOU,
MADAM CHAIR. AB 2398 WOULD
REQUIRE THE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY SYSTEM TO CONDUCT AN
EXTERNAL AUDIT OF EACH OF ITS
CAMPUSES BY JANUARY 1ST, 2028.
IT WOULD ALSO REQUIRE ALL AUDITS
OF THE CSU SYSTEM OR ITS
CAMPUSES TO BE MADE AVAILABLE TO
THE PUBLIC. CURRENTLY, THE CSU
SYSTEM CONDUCTS AN EXTERNAL
SYSTEM WIDE AUDIT EACH YEAR. IT
ALSO CONDUCTS SMALLER, IRREGULAR
AUDITS OF VARIOUS PROGRAMS
OPERATED BY INDIVIDUAL CAMPUSES.
HOWEVER IT IS NOT CURRENTLY
CONDUCTING STANDALONE EXTERNAL
AUDITS OF EACH OF ITS 23
CAMPUSES. WHILE EXISTING AUDITS
CONTAIN SOME INFORMATION
REGARDING EACH CAMPUSES
FINANCIAL STATUS AND ACTIVITIES,
THEY DO NOT CONSTITUTE THE FULL
INSPECTION THAT WOULD BE OFFERED
BY A COMPLETE CAMPUS LEVEL
AUDIT. FOR EXAMPLE, WHILE THESE
GENERAL OVERVIEWS REFERENCED
INSTRUCTIONAL EXPENSES AND
PAYMENTS TO EMPLOYEES, THEY DO
NOT INCLUDE ANY DETAILED
INFORMATION ABOUT FACULTY
SALARIES, JUST LAST YEAR, THE
IMPACT OF THIS DATA DEFICIT WAS
ILLUSTRATED BY A TURBULENT
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING PROCESS
BETWEEN THE CSU SYSTEM AND THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION.
WHILE CFA ASKED FOR A 12% RAISE,
THE CSU SYSTEM SAID THAT IT
COULD ONLY AFFORD A 5% RAISE.
HOWEVER, AN ANALYSIS BY
INDEPENDENT, ACCOUNTING
PROFESSOR DOCTOR HOWARD BUNCE'S
CONCLUDED THAT IN 2022, THE CSU
SYSTEM HAD AROUND 13.8 $13.8
BILLION NET ASSETS AND 8.1
BILLION IN MOSTLY UNRESTRICTED
RESERVES. UNFORTUNATELY THIS
DIFFERENCE IN FINANCIAL
ASSESSMENT WAS NOT IMMEDIATELY
RESOLVED, LEADING TO A SERIES OF
HISTORIC SYSTEM WIDE STRIKES
ACROSS ALL 23 CSU CAMPUSES.
EVENTUALLY, CFA AND THE CSU
SYSTEM CAME TO AN AGREEMENT THAT
INCLUDED APPROXIMATELY 10% PAY
INCREASE AB 2398, WHICH WILL
SHED MUCH NEEDED LIGHT ON THE
GENERAL FINANCIAL HEALTH OF ONE
OF OUR STATE'S MOST CRUCIAL
EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTIONS. BY
REQUIRING A COMPLETE AUDIT OF
EACH OF THE 23 CSU CAMPUSES,
THIS BILL WILL HELP US MAKE
BETTER FINANCIAL DECISIONS THAT
WILL POSITIVELY IMPACT FACULTY,
STUDENTS AND THE CSU SYSTEM
ALIKE. WITH ME TO PROVIDE
SUPPORTING TESTIMONY IS
PRISCILLA QUIROZ ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA FACULTY
ASSOCIATION, WELCOME, MISS
QUIROZ, YOU HAVE THREE MINUTES.
THANK YOU, PRISCILLA. GOOD
MORNING. CHAIR MEMBERS,
PRISCILLA QUIROZ, ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA FACULTY
ASSOCIATION, PROUD SPONSORS OF
AB 2398. JUST WANT TO THANK THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND HIS STAFF
FOR ALL THE WORK ON THIS
MEASURE. AB, AB 2398 IS A
CRUCIAL STEP TOWARDS ENHANCING
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
WITHIN THE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY SYSTEM BY REQUIRING
EXTERNAL FINANCIAL AUDITS FOR
EACH CSU CAMPUS BY JANUARY 1ST,
2028. AS THE SELLING MEMBER
STATED EARLIER THIS YEAR, THE
CSU SYSTEM FACED AN
UNPRECEDENTED STRIKE, THE FIRST
OF ITS KIND IN THE NATION, WITH
ALL 23 CAMPUSES GOING ON STRIKE.
THE DISCREPANCY IN BARGAINING
NUMBERS UNDERSCORE THE NEED FOR
ACCURATE, ACCURATE FINANCIAL
INFORMATION ON AB 2398 WILL
COMPLEMENT THE SYSTEM WIDE
ANNUAL ANNUAL AUDIT BY AUDITING
INDIVIDUAL CAMPUSES. THIS IS
ESSENTIAL FOR UNDERSTANDING HOW
PUBLIC FUNDS ARE UTILIZED
EFFECTIVELY AND APPROPRIATELY.
FOR THESE REASONS, WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE TODAY. THANK YOU, THANK
YOU. ARE THERE ANY OTHERS HERE
WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF THE MEASURE? SO
PLEASE COME FORWARD. SEEING NONE
, DO WE HAVE OPPOSITION TO THE
MEASURES? ANYONE HERE IN
OPPOSITION TO THE MEASURE? AGAIN
SEEING NONE, COME BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE, SENATOR GLAZER, I
WILL ASK A QUESTION ON THIS, YOU
KNOW, THE BARGAINING THAT TAKES
PLACE IS NOT A CAMPUS BY CAMPUS
AGREEMENT ON ON SALARIES AND
BENEFITS, IT'S A SYSTEM WIDE
AGREEMENT. SO I'M, I'M TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND WHY THIS IS REALLY
GOING TO AFFECT THE BARGAINING
ASPECTS THAT YOU RAISED IN YOUR
IN YOUR OPENING. THANK YOU.
SENATOR, YOU KNOW, THE POSITIVE
BENEFITS OF A CAMPUS LIKE CAMPUS
AUDIT IS NOT SIMPLY RELATED TO
BARGAINING OR, WILL NOT ONLY
HAVE BENEFITS RELATED TO
BARGAINING, HOWEVER, IT COULD
SHED LIGHT AND CREATE MORE
TRANSPARENCY AS TO, THE FUNDS
THAT ARE AVAILABLE SYSTEM WIDE
IF YOU'RE DOING A CAMPUS BY
CAMPUS AUDIT BECAUSE SINCE THEY
DON'T DO CAMPUS BY CAMPUS
AUDITS, OFTENTIMES FUNDS ARE
IT'S NOT EASILY DELINEATED WHERE
THE FUNDS ARE. AND SO BY DOING A
BY DOING A CAMPUS BY CAMPUS
AUDIT, OFTENTIMES OR IN IN MANY
CASES THERE ARE IT COULD BE
THROUGH THE BARGAINING PROCESS,
SPECIFIC ASSETS OF SPECIFIC
CAMPUSES OR FOR EXAMPLE, RIGHT
NOW I'VE WORKED WITH SAN JOSE
STATE UNIVERSITY, BOTH IN TERMS
OF HOUSING ISSUES, AS WELL AS IN
TERMS OF FACILITIES UPGRADES. IT
WILL BE VERY HELPFUL TO KNOW HOW
THEY'RE DEALING WITH THEIR MONEY
BEFORE THEY COME AND ASK FOR
MONEY FROM US THROUGH OUR BUDGET
PROCESS, AS WELL. SO IT'S NOT
SPECIFIC. THE BENEFITS AREN'T
SPECIFIC JUST TO BARGAINING,
HOWEVER, I THINK THAT IF THE
NUMBERS WERE MORE CLEAR AND THE
CAMPUS BY CAMPUS AUDITS WOULD
HAVE MADE THE NUMBERS MORE CLEAR
, IT COULD HAVE POTENTIALLY
PREVENTED A STRIKE BECAUSE THE
SOME OF THE FUNDS THAT WEREN'T
AS CLEARLY IDENTIFIED WOULD HAVE
BEEN MORE CLEAR ON THE CAMPUS BY
CAMPUS LEVEL, OFTENTIMES MONEY
THAT YOU'RE LOOKING AT AT A CSU
LEVEL IS ACTUALLY BEING KEPT AT
A CAMPUS BY CAMPUS LEVEL. AND SO
I THINK THERE'S OPPORTUNITIES
FOR, YOU KNOW, NOT JUST FOR
BENEFITS TO BARGAINING, BUT A
MUCH BROADER BASE, BECAUSE THE
LOT WHAT THE CSU DOES TODAY IS
THEY PROVIDE EXPENDITURES OF
50,000 OR MORE ARE POSTED.
RIGHT. SO THOSE KINDS OF AND AN
AUDIT IS DETERMINING WHETHER THE
BALANCE SHEET IS ACCURATE, SO I
AM TRYING TO WRESTLE I KNOW THAT
LOOK AT TRANSPARENCY IS GOOD,
BUT I AM WRESTLING WITH WHETHER
THIS IS GOING TO CREATE AN
EXPENSE. THIS IS NOW I MEAN,
AUDITS ARE VERY EXPENSIVE.
THEY'RE VERY EXPENSIVE. I
CHAIRED THE AUDIT COMMITTEE AT
THE CSU, SO I KNOW, AND, THIS IS
GOING TO REQUIRE 23 NEW AUDITS,
NEW HIRING OF NEW ACCOUNTING
FIRMS TO DETERMINE WHETHER THE
BALANCES ARE REPORTED, BEEN
REPORTED CORRECTLY, DESPITE THE
FACT THAT THEY'RE ALREADY
PROVIDING THIS DETAIL AT GREAT,
A SIGNIFICANT LEVEL. IN FACT, WE
HAD A BILL, A FEW WEEKS AGO THAT
BROUGHT IT DOWN TO BRING DOWN TO
$10,000, WHICH IS I DIDN'T
SUPPORT IT. IT'S LIKE THAT'S
EXCESSIVE TO ME. ONE FINAL
THING. AND AGAIN, I KNOW THE
INTENTIONS ARE GOOD HERE, BUT A
LOT OF THE CRITICISMS DURING
THAT STRIKE, AS I UNDERSTAND IT,
WAS ABOUT THE RESERVE POLICY OF
THE SYSTEM AND OF THE CAMPUSES,
AND I FOUND THAT TO BE
CHALLENGING TO UNDERSTAND
BECAUSE WHEN YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT SALARIES THAT YOU HAVE AN
OBLIGATION TO PAY EVERY YEAR,
YOU DON'T PAY IT OUT OF ONE TIME
MONEY, AND THE RESERVES ARE SET
ASIDE FOR ONE TIME. I UNDERSTAND
WHY THERE COULD BE CRITICISM OF
IT, OF HOW MUCH YOU HAVE, BUT
THE IDEA THAT THAT A RESERVE
LEVEL COULD SOMEHOW COMPENSATE
FOR AN ONGOING SALARY OBLIGATION
WAS REALLY DIFFICULT TO FOLLOW.
BUT I KNOW THE INTENTIONS ARE TO
TRY TO CREATE, A, A KUMBAYA
MOMENT BETWEEN THE FACULTY UNION
AND THE SYSTEM. I KNOW THAT'S A
POSITIVE THING TO, ACCOMPLISH.
I'M JUST NOT SO SURE THAT THESE
ADDITIONAL EXPENSES THAT THIS
BILL WOULD, WOULD, WOULD FORCE
THE SYSTEM TO INCUR. THAT MEANS
THAT THAT AFFECTS TUITION, THAT
AFFECTS THE MONEY AVAILABLE FOR
SALARIES AND BENEFITS. I MEAN,
THERE IS A COST HERE, BUT THIS
ISN'T THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. SO WE DON'T HAVE TO
DEAL WITH THAT. AND, SENATOR,
YOU'RE 100% CORRECT. THE
INTENTION CERTAINLY IS NOT TO
INCREASE TUITION. WHAT HAVE YOU.
TO YOUR POINT, A LOT OF THE
DETAILS ARE ALREADY KEPT. A LOT
OF THE THEY HAVE THE INFORMATION
THERE THAT WOULD BE MADE
AVAILABLE RELATIVELY EASILY FOR
AN EXTERNAL AUDIT TO OCCUR, THIS
WOULD REQUIRE AUDITS OF THE
CAMPUSES EVERY THREE YEARS,
WHICH MEANS THEY WOULDN'T HAVE
TO DO ALL 23, EVERY YEAR. IT
WOULD BE 7 OR 8 AUDITS A YEAR.
AGAIN, THAT'S AND WE DELAYED IT
TO 2028. ALSO TO CONSIDER THE
COST, ESPECIALLY THE RAMP UP, IN
ORDER TO REDUCE THAT RAMP UP
COST. AND SO THOSE, THESE ARE
ISSUES THAT HAVE BEEN BROUGHT UP
OVER THE COURSE OF THIS BILL
MOVING FORWARD. AND WE'RE TAKING
THEM AS SERIOUSLY AS WE CAN. WE
DEFINITELY DON'T WANT TO SEE ANY
IMPACT ON STUDENTS. BUT I THINK
THAT GIVEN THE FACT THAT A LOT
OF THE DETAILS THAT WOULD BE
REQUIRED FOR AUDIT ARE ALREADY
KEPT, I THINK IT WOULD BE A
MATTER TO JUST MAKE THEM
AVAILABLE TO EXTERNAL TO
EXTERNAL AUDITING FIRM, WHICH
DOES HAVE COST TO IT, OBVIOUSLY.
BUT SOME OF THE INFORMATION
THAT'S GLEANED FROM THE SYSTEM
WIDE AUDIT CAN ALSO BE USED, AS
WELL. AND SO I THINK THAT WE
HAVE TO BALANCE IT, THERE'S NO
DOUBT ABOUT IT IN TERMS OF WHAT
THE COSTS ARE, WHAT SAVINGS CAN
BE GLEANED FROM THE COST OF AN
AUDIT, AND IN TERMS OF RESERVES
AS WELL, I MEAN, I THINK THERE'S
A LOT OF ASKS FOR FUNDING FOR
INFRASTRUCTURE IMPROVEMENTS ON
CAMPUSES AND THERE'S LARGE
RESERVES. YOU KNOW, I THINK THAT
SHOULD BE CONSIDERED WHEN, WHEN
WE'RE ASKED FOR STATE MONEY TO
GO TO SOME OF THOSE COSTS, IF
THEY'RE RESERVES AS TO WHY THEY
AREN'T USING SOME OF THOSE
RESERVES FOR SOME OF THOSE
INFRASTRUCTURE COSTS AS WELL,
WHICH THEY MAY HAVE A GOOD
ANSWER TO. BUT I THINK THOSE
QUESTIONS NEED TO BE ASKED. LET
ME ASK KIND OF A FOLLOW ON
QUESTION, THEN, WITH RESPECT TO
THE CURRENT AUDIT PROCESS, IS
YOUR CONCEPT WILL THE INDIVIDUAL
CAMPUS ARTISTS BE SEPARATE AND
DISTINCT FROM THAT, OR CAN THEY
BE INCORPORATED INTO THE KPMG
ANNUAL AUDITS THAT ARE DONE?
THERE'S NO REASON WHY THEY
COULDN'T ALSO CONTRACT WITH THAT
SAME FIRM AGAIN TO REDUCE COST.
IT'S I THINK IT'S EASIER TO HAVE
A MULTI AUDIT CONTRACT WITH THE
FIRM THAT YOU'RE ALREADY USING.
SO I THINK THERE ARE COST
SAVINGS THAT COULD BE MADE,
PARTICULARLY BECAUSE THAT FIRM
IS GOING TO HAVE AN
UNDERSTANDING OF THE FISCAL
OPERATIONS OF THE, OF THE LARGER
ENTITY. AND SO THERE'S
ABSOLUTELY OPPORTUNITIES FOR IT.
FOR EFFICIENCIES TO BE OCCURRED,
NO DOUBT ABOUT IT. SO THEN WHAT
WE'RE REALLY, YOU KNOW, OVER A
THREE YEAR SPAN, YOU'RE LOOKING
FOR SORT OF AN AUDIT PLUS, AS IT
WERE, WHICH IS ON AN ONGOING
BASIS, SEVEN, EITHER 7 OR 8
CAMPUSES FOR EACH OF THREE YEARS
TO BEING, YOU KNOW,
PROSPECTIVELY TO BE INCLUDED IN
THE KPMG AUDIT. AND THAT
SHOULDN'T BE TOO ONEROUS, IT
SHOULDN'T BE TOO ONEROUS. BUT AS
SENATOR GLASER'S POINT, THERE'S
OBVIOUSLY GOING TO BE A COST.
IT'S NOT GOING TO BE
UNSUBSTANTIAL. BUT I THINK IT'S
ABSORBABLE, WITHIN THE CSU COSTS
OF THEIR, YOU KNOW, IN THEIR
AUDITING PROCESSES, ALSO IN
BEING MADE AVAILABLE TO THE
PUBLIC, THEY ALREADY HAVE A
WEBSITE THAT POSTS THEIR AUDIT
PUBLICLY. SO I DON'T THINK IT
WILL BE TOO ONEROUS TO INCLUDE,
YOU KNOW, LINKS TO EACH OF THE
CAMPUS AUDITS ONCE THEY'RE
AVAILABLE, AS WELL. SO THE
INFRASTRUCTURE IS IN PLACE. AND
I THINK OFTENTIMES THAT'S THE
MOST EXPENSIVE PROCESS IS
CREATING KIND OF KIND OF GETTING
OUT OF FIRST GEAR, CREATING THAT
INFRASTRUCTURE, THAT
INFRASTRUCTURE IS ALREADY IN
PLACE. SO I DO THINK TO YOUR
POINT, MR. CHAIR, THAT THE COST
WON'T BE AS MUCH AS IF AS IF
FROM THE GROUND UP AUDIT
PROCESS. RIGHT. BUT COST IS
ALWAYS A FACTOR, SENATOR. SO SO
WOULD YOU BE REQUIRING THE
AUDITS FOR THE UNIVERSITIES TO
BE HELD EVERY SINGLE YEAR, FOR
EVERY CAMPUS, EVERY THREE YEARS?
EVERY THREE YEARS, ALL CAMPUSES
EVERY THREE YEARS. SO THAT MEANS
EACH ABOUT 7 OR 8 CAMPUSES A
YEAR. AND SO FOR EACH INDIVIDUAL
CAMPUS, IT'LL BE EVERY THREE
YEARS, EVERY THREE YEARS, AND
THIS WOULD ONLY ADD TO WHAT IS
CURRENTLY ALREADY IN PLACE AS
FAR AS THE, CURRENT AUDIT, HOW
DOES THIS ALL PLAY IN, WITH
REGARDS TO THE BILL THAT WE SAW
LAST WEEK, THAT THAT WOULD LOWER
THE THRESHOLD OF THE AUDIT,
COMPONENTS TO BE LOWERED TO
10,000 VERSUS 50,000. HOW DOES
THAT ALL COMBINE INTO. AND I
THINK THAT HELPS IN TERMS OF
SETTING UP THIS BILL FOR
SUCCESS, BECAUSE NOW IF YOU'RE
ACTUALLY LOWERING THE THRESHOLD,
THAT MEANS THERE'S GOING TO BE
EVEN MORE DATA. THAT'S GOING TO
BE MORE BE READILY AVAILABLE TO
AN AUDITING TEAM. AND SO I
FRANKLY THINK IT MAKES IT THAT
MUCH MORE COST EFFECTIVE IF
YOU'RE LOWERING THAT THRESHOLD.
TO SENATOR GLASER'S POINT, I
DON'T THAT'S PRETTY ONEROUS TO
ROLL IT ALL THE WAY DOWN 10,000.
BUT IF THAT'S HAPPENING FOR THE
PURPOSES OF THIS BILL, I THINK
IT ACTUALLY ADDS TO THE
EFFICIENCIES. OKAY AND THEN I
THINK THE LAST COMMENT THAT I
HAVE IS WHAT'S INTERESTING IS,
IS THE BILL THAT WE SAW LAST
WEEK HAD OPPOSITION, BUT ON THIS
ONE, IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING THAT
THERE IS ABSOLUTELY NO
REGISTERED OPPOSITION WITH
REGARDS TO THIS BILL. I FIND
THAT VERY INTERESTING ACTUALLY.
THANK YOU. WELL, IT SPEAKS TO
YOUR POINT. I MEAN, ON THE ONE
HAND, IT'S HARD TO ARGUE AGAINST
TRANSPARENCY, AND THE OTHER,
THAT'S PROBABLY AN EFFICIENT WAY
TO DO THIS, ANY OTHER QUESTIONS?
COMMENTS LOOKING FOR A MOTION
GIVE YOU A CHANCE TO CLOSE AS A
COURTESY? I'D BE HAPPY TO MAKE
THE MOTION. I APPRECIATE THAT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH,
SENATOR GLASER. THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR. AND MEMBERS,
RESPECTFULLY. I MEAN, GOOD
CONVERSATION. RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU,
MADAM CONSULTANT, PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL FILE ITEM 18 AB 2398.
CALL MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
NEWMAN NEWMAN I OKOBOJI I
OKOBOJI I CORTESE. GLASER
GONZALEZ. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS
WILK. THAT MEASURE HERE HAS TWO
VOTES, AND WE WILL LEAVE IT
OPEN. AND WE ARE NOW MOVING ON
TO YOUR SECOND MEASURE, AB 2640,
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU
, MR. CHAIR. I'D LIKE TO THANK
THE COMMITTEE FOR THEIR WORK ON
THIS BILL AND BE ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS. AB 2640 IS
THE COMPASSIONATE LEARNING
ADVANCEMENT FOR SCIENCE STUDENTS
ACT, ALSO KNOWN AS THE CLASS
ACT. THIS BILL WILL REQUIRE
TEACHERS AND SCHOOLS TO PROVIDE
STUDENTS WITH A WRITTEN NOTICE
INFORMING THEM ABOUT THEIR RIGHT
TO OPT OUT OF ANIMAL DISSECTION
ASSIGNMENTS. IN ADDITION,
STUDENTS WILL BE ABLE TO RECEIVE
INFORMATION ABOUT WHERE THE
ANIMAL WAS SOURCED FROM AND THE
CHEMICALS THEY'LL BE EXPOSED TO.
UNDER CURRENT LAW, STUDENTS
ALREADY HAVE THE RIGHT TO OPT
OUT. HOWEVER, MANY STUDENTS MAY
NOT BE AWARE OF THIS RIGHT AND
FEEL OBLIGATED TO PARTICIPATE IN
THE ANIMAL DISSECTION
ASSIGNMENT, FEARING IT WILL
IMPACT THEIR GRADES. THE CLASS
ACT IS A STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION TO STRENGTHEN STUDENTS
ABILITY TO OPT OUT, WHILE
ENCOURAGING ALTERNATIVE METHODS
TO HELP INCREASE STUDENT
ENGAGEMENT AND SUPPORT THEIR
INTERESTS, AND LEARNING ABOUT
ANATOMY, ANATOMY AND DISSECTION
ARE ESSENTIAL SCIENTIFIC
PEDAGOGY. HOWEVER, WITH THE
ADVANCEMENTS IN EDUCATIONAL
TECHNOLOGY, ALTERNATIVE METHODS
HAVE BECOME MORE WIDELY
ACCESSIBLE AND COST EFFECTIVE.
THIS HAS REALLY SHOWN DURING THE
PANDEMIC, WHEN THOSE
ALTERNATIVES HAD TO BE USED FOR
EVERY STUDENT AND EVERY TEACHER,
THESE ALTERNATIVE METHODS, SUCH
AS SYNTHETIC SYNTHETIC FROG
MODEL OR FROGGIPEDIA, AN
APPLICATION FOR MOBILE PHONES OR
TABLETS, OFFER A PRACTICAL
ALTERNATIVE METHOD THAT ALLOWS
STUDENTS TO STILL PARTICIPATE IN
THE MATERIAL. IN ADDITION,
PURCHASING THE ANIMAL SPECIMENS
CAN BE COSTLY AND MAY ONLY SERVE
AS A ONE TIME USE USE. WHEREAS
ALTERNATIVE METHODS CAN BE
REUSED YEAR AFTER YEAR,
RESULTING IN COST SAVINGS OVER
TIME FOR OUR SCHOOLS. BY
PROVIDING STUDENTS WITH THE
WRITTEN NOTICE, AB 2640 EMPOWERS
THEM TO BE INFORMED, GIVEN THE
CHOICE TO OPT OUT OF ANIMAL
DISSECTION AND INSTEAD RECEIVE
AN ALTERNATIVE COMPARABLE
ASSIGNMENT. THE BILL HAS
RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN
THE ASSEMBLY, AND I'M HAPPY TO
HAVE WITH US TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT. CATHERINE HAMPTON, A
STUDENT AT CHAPMAN UNIVERSITY,
AND SAMANTHA CROW, PROGRAM
MANAGER FOR TEACHING SCIENCE AND
A FORMER PROFESSOR OF BIOLOGY,
WELCOME, BOTH OF YOU. PLEASE
PROCEED. WHOEVER WOULD LIKE TO
GO FIRST WOULD LIKE TO GO FIRST.
OKAY. I HAVE TO PRESS THIS, HI.
MY NAME IS CATHERINE HAMPTON,
AND I'M A STUDENT AT CHAPMAN
UNIVERSITY IN ORANGE. I WAS BORN
AND RAISED IN THE BAY AREA, AND
MY FAMILY MOVED TO EL DORADO
HILLS WHEN I WAS ENTERING MIDDLE
SCHOOL. THROUGHOUT MY TIME IN
MIDDLE AND HIGH SCHOOL, I HAD
GROWING CONCERNS REGARDING
LESSONS THAT REGULARLY TOOK
PLACE IN MY SCIENCE CLASSES.
BECAUSE OF THIS, I STRONGLY,
STRONGLY SUPPORT AB 2640 YEAR
AFTER YEAR IN GRADE SCHOOL. I
FOUND MYSELF FORCED TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE DISSECTION OF
VARIOUS ANIMALS FROM WORMS TO
CATS. DURING THESE LESSONS, I
WAS Ó. DURING THESE LESSONS, I
WAS PRESENTED WITH A PREVIOUSLY
LIVING INDIVIDUAL TO CUT OPEN
AND OBSERVE THEIR ANATOMY WHILE
BEING GIVEN INFORMATION ABOUT
BODILY FUNCTIONS. I WAS EXPOSED
TO THE PUNGENT SMELLS OF
FORMALDEHYDE THAT OVERWHELMED MY
NOSE AND MADE MY EYES WATER. AS
A STUDENT WHO WAS BORN WITH A
SEVERE ASTHMATIC CONDITION, I
TOOK IT UPON MYSELF TO MONITOR
MY HEALTH EXTRA CAREFULLY ON
DISSECTION DAYS. MOREOVER, AS A
STUDENT WHO PREFERS NON-ANIMAL
METHODS, I BECAME BECAME
PANICKED AND ANXIOUS WHEN I WAS
TOLD I NEEDED TO DISSECT A CAT
FOR A GRADE. WHEN I ASKED FOR AN
ALTERNATIVE, I WAS TOLD TO
QUOTE, JUST DO IT. AND EVEN
AFTER REPEATING MY CONCERNS TO
MY TEACHER, I WAS NOT OFFERED AN
ALTERNATIVE. SEVERAL OF MY
CLASSMATES WHO WERE ALSO
DISTURBED TO BE DISSECTING CATS,
HAD TO LEAVE THE ROOM BECAUSE
THEY WERE SO UPSET, AND THEY
TOLD ME THEY WOULD HAVE OPTED
OUT IF THEY KNEW THAT THAT THEY
COULD. LEARNING ABOUT ANATOMY
AND BIOLOGY IS ESSENTIAL.
HOWEVER, STUDENTS LIKE ME ARE
PRESSURED TO DISSECT ANIMAL
CADAVERS, MAKING IT IMPOSSIBLE
TO EFFECTIVELY ABSORB THE
INFORMATION THAT WE'RE SUPPOSED
TO LEARN. AN ALTERNATIVE
ASSIGNMENT WILL ENABLE STUDENTS
TO PARTICIPATE MEANINGFULLY IN
ANATOMY LESSONS, RATHER THAN
EXITING THE CLASSROOM AND
MISSING OUT ON VALUABLE LEARNING
OPPORTUNITIES DUE TO EXPOSURE TO
HARSH CHEMICALS OR ETHICAL
CONCERNS. OR, LET'S FACE IT, BY
SIMPLY BEING GROSSED OUT. THE
LAW IN CALIFORNIA IS NOT
CURRENTLY PROTECTING STUDENTS AS
IT WAS INTENDED, AND IT MUST BE
CHANGED. THAT'S WHY AB AB 2640
IS SO IMPORTANT. STUDENTS SHOULD
BE PROVIDED WITH ACCURATE
INFORMATION AND EMPOWERED TO
MAKE INFORMED DECISIONS
REGARDING ANIMAL DISSECTION. I
ENCOURAGE YOU TO REFLECT
CAREFULLY ON THE POTENTIAL
BENEFITS THAT ENACTING AB 2640
COULD BRING TO STUDENTS
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA. AS A
STUDENT IN THE STATE, I
APPRECIATE YOUR WILLINGNESS TO
CONSIDER MY PERSPECTIVE ON
ANIMAL DISSECTION IN THE
CLASSROOM. THANK YOU, MISS
HAMPTON, AND WELCOME. HONORABLE
CHAIRMAN AND SENATORS, THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME, I'M SAMANTHA
CROW, PROGRAM MANAGER FOR PETA'S
HUMANE SCIENCE EDUCATION
DIVISION. AND A FORMER PROFESSOR
OF BIOLOGY. AB 2640 IS ALL ABOUT
EMPOWERING STUDENTS. THE CLASS
ACT IS A SIMPLE BILL THAT
STRENGTHENS CURRENT LAW BY
ENSURING THAT STUDENTS ARE AWARE
OF THEIR RIGHT TO OPT OUT AND
EMPOWER THEM TO MAKE AN INFORMED
DECISION. STUDENTS WILL NOT BE
TOLD TO DROP A CLASS OR ACCEPT A
FAILING GRADE IF THEY REFUSE TO
VIOLATE THEIR ETHICAL
CONVICTIONS. ANIMAL DISSECTION
IS NOT A MAGICAL WAY TO GET
STUDENTS EXCITED ABOUT SCIENCE.
IN FACT, IT DISENFRANCHIZES
COMPASSIONATE STUDENTS AND CAN
OFTEN TURN THEM AWAY FROM THE
SCIENCES. ANIMAL DISSECTION IS
AN ANTIQUATED INSTRUCTIONAL
STRATEGY THAT IS NOT CHANGED IN
A CENTURY. ANIMAL DISSECTION IS
NOT REQUIRED OR EVEN MENTIONED
IN THE NGSS, CTE, IB OR COLLEGE
BOARD AP CLASSES, AND NO MEDICAL
SCHOOLS USE ANIMAL DISSECTION
AND EXPERIENCE WITH IT IS NOT
EXPECTED OR REQUIRED OF INCOMING
STUDENTS. IN FACT, THE UPDATED
AAVMC, WHICH IS THE AMERICAN
ASSOCIATION OF VETERINARY
COLLEGES, IN THEIR NEW HANDBOOK
FOR 2024, THE USE OF ANIMALS IN
VET ED HIGHLIGHTS THE NEED TO
MAKE PROGRESS IN INCORPORATING
HUMANE, NON-ANIMAL METHODS INTO
VETERINARY SCHOOLS. ANIMAL
DISSECTION IS LESS EFFECTIVE
THAN NON-ANIMAL METHODS OF
TEACHING ANATOMY. ACCORDING TO A
2022 SYSTEMATIC REVIEW PUBLISHED
IN THE AMERICAN BIOLOGY TEACHER
JOURNAL, COMPARING STUDENT
LEARNING OUTCOMES SHOWS THAT
STUDENTS AT ALL EDUCATIONAL
LEVELS, WHEN COMPARING
NON-ANIMAL METHODS TO ANIMAL
DISSECTION, PERFORMED AS WELL AS
OR BETTER IN 95% OF THE STUDIES.
THIS IS A SYSTEMATIC REVIEW OF
THE LITERATURE, AND THIS
HAPPENED WHEN THEY WERE LEARNING
ANATOMY USING NON-ANIMAL METHODS
. NON-ANIMAL METHODS PREPARE
STUDENTS BETTER FOR HIGHER ED
THAN ANIMAL DISSECTION, WITH
IN-DEPTH LAYERING OF ANATOMICAL
PARTS, CORRECT COLORIZATION,
SIMULATIONS OF BODY SYSTEMS
WITHIN A LIVING ORGANISM. NONE
OF THESE THINGS CAN BE
ACCOMPLISHED BY USING AN ANIMAL
CADAVER. WHILE TEACH KIND
SCIENCE RECOGNIZES EDUCATORS
PROFESSIONAL JUDGMENT IN
SELECTING INSTRUCTIONAL
MATERIALS AS WELL AS THEIR
RESPONSIBILITY TO ENSURE THOSE
MATERIALS ARE SAFE AND SAFE.
PARDON ME? HUMANE AND COST
EFFECTIVE, INCLUSIVE AND ALIGNED
WITH THE PRINCIPLES OF SOCIAL
AND EMOTIONAL LEARNING AND
TRAUMA SENSITIVE INSTRUCTION.
PLEASE HELP STUDENTS BECOME
BETTER SCIENTISTS AND HELP
EDUCATORS HONOR STUDENTS RIGHT
BY VOTING AYE ON AB 2640. THANK
YOU AND THANK YOU. ARE THERE
OTHERS WHO WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THE MEASURE? WELCOME.
HELLO. MY NAME IS NICK SACKETT,
ON BEHALF OF CO-SPONSORS, SOCIAL
COMPASSION IN LEGISLATION,
COURTESY FOR PHYSICIANS,
COMMITTEE FOR RESPONSIBLE
MEDICINE AND ANIMAL LEGAL
DEFENSE FUND IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. MASON MILITO, RECENT
COLLEGE GRADUATE AND RESIDENT OF
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. HI, PRISCILLA. KUDOS
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE HUMANE
SOCIETY OF THE UNITED STATES AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. WENDY
BRAMBLE SUPPORTING THIS BILL,
FOR PETA AND ALSO AS A RECENT
MASTER OF PUBLIC HEALTH GRADUATE
FROM LOMA LINDA UNIVERSITY.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. HELLO,
SENATORS, I'M APRIL JOYCE, I
LIVE IN SACRAMENTO, CALIFORNIA.
I AM A LIFESTYLE AND PERFORMANCE
MEDICINE COACH. WE ARE THE
NEWEST BRANCH OF THE AMERICAN
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION. WE TREAT,
PREVENT AND REVERSE DISEASE
THROUGH LIFESTYLE. I'M ALSO A
MEMBER OF THE PHYSICIANS
COMMITTEE ON RESPONSIBLE
MEDICINE. I'M AN ACE CERTIFIED
PERSONAL TRAINER, JUST LIKE THE
BILL WE HEARD BEFORE US ABOUT
SCHOOL SHOOTINGS, YOUR POSITION
PLEASE. I VOTE STRONGLY FOR THIS
BECAUSE I VOTE STRONGLY FOR
COMPASSION AND EMPATHY. THANK
YOU, SENATOR. THANK YOU. NEXT
PLEASE. DOMINICA WITH DOMINICA.
CHERIAN WITH TWIN RIVERS UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT. AND AS A PARENT
AND THE SEVENTH GRADER IN ME WHO
HAD TO TAKE AN F FOR REFUSING TO
DISSECT A FROG WHO, ALMOST
FAILED THAT CLASS BECAUSE OF
THAT SITUATION, BUT IN COLLEGE,
SUCCEED DID THE SOFTWARE
APPLICATION WITH THE SAME
PROJECT AND RECEIVED A B. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF ÁP. APPRECIATE THAT. NEXT
PLEASE. HI, I'M HALEY HOLSTEIN,
I'M A FORMER TEACHER AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. MY NAME IS LINDA
MIDDLESWORTH. I'M IN SUPPORT OF
THIS COMPASSIONATE ACTION AND I
WORK FOR PHYSICIANS COMMITTEE
FOR RESPONSIBLE MEDICINE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. OPPOSITION. DO WE
HAVE WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION?
MR. WENGER, WELCOME. YOU HAVE
THREE MINUTES. PLEASE PROCEED
WHEN READY. MR. CHAIR MEMBERS,
JOHN WENGER HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE HANDS ON SCIENCE
PARTNERSHIP, WE'RE A CONSORTIUM
OF BUSINESSES, EDUCATORS AND
OTHER STAKEHOLDERS INVESTED IN
IMPROVING STUDENT ACHIEVEMENT IN
SCIENCE THROUGH HANDS ON
LEARNING. FIRST I'D LIKE TO
THANK THE AUTHOR, THE STAFF AND
THE SPONSORS FOR ROBUST DIALOG.
WE'VE HAD GOOD CONVERSATIONS
WITH THEM. ALSO WOULD LIKE TO
THANK THE CHAIR AND THE
COMMITTEE FOR ALL THEIR HARD
WORK ON THE AMENDMENTS,
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE THE
DIRECTION THAT THIS BILL IS
GOING. I THINK, FIRST AND
FOREMOST, HANDS ON SCIENCE
PARTNERSHIP DOES SUPPORT A
STUDENT'S RIGHT TO OPT OUT OF
ANIMAL DISSECTION, AND WE
SUPPORT ENSURING THOSE RIGHTS
AND ENSURING THAT THOSE RIGHTS
ARE COMMUNICATED TO THE STUDENT.
I THINK OUR OVERARCHING CONCERNS
WITH THE BILL WERE SORT OF
TWOFOLD. ONE WAS THE STRUCTURE
OF THE NOTICE, WHICH WE THOUGHT
FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE WAS
ACTIVELY DISCOURAGING STUDENTS
FROM PARTICIPATING IN HANDS ON
LEARNING. AND THEN THE SECOND
COMPONENT OF THE BILL THAT WAS
ENCOURAGING SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO
EXPLORE ALTERNATIVES BY 2028. I
THINK THE AMENDMENTS DO ADDRESS
SOME OF OUR CONCERNS AROUND THE
NOTICE PROVISIONS. WE STILL
BELIEVE A WRITTEN NOTICE IS A
LITTLE BIT OVERLY BURDENSOME TO
TEACHERS, AND COULD TAKE UP
VALUABLE CLASS TIME, BUT THE
CHANGES TO THE NOTICE DO SEEM TO
BE MORE NEUTRAL. SO WE DO
APPRECIATE THAT, WE DO
APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEE
REMOVING THE WORD STRONGLY FROM
SECTION 32255.4 B. BUT WE DO
CONTINUE TO OBJECT TO THAT
PROVISION, WHICH ENCOURAGES
SCHOOLS TO EXPLORE ALTERNATIVES
TO ANIMAL DISSECTION. WE
CONTINUE TO BELIEVE THAT THAT
DECISION SHOULD REMAIN AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL WITH THE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND WITH THE TEACHERS,
AND THAT THE, THE STATE
LEGISLATURE SHOULDN'T REALLY BE
WEIGHING INTO THAT DECISION FROM
A STATE POLICY PERSPECTIVE.
OVERALL, WE DO BELIEVE HANDS ON
DISSECTION DOES SERVE AN
IMPORTANT PURPOSE, WE BELIEVE
THAT IT ENHANCES STUDENTS
UNDERSTANDING OF ANATOMY AND
PHYSIOLOGY, PHYSIOLOGICAL
CONCEPTS, AND THAT HANDS ON
DISSECTION PROVIDES ADDITIONAL
SENSORY INFORMATION AND
ANATOMICAL VARIATION THAT MANY
OF THE ALTERNATIVE MODELS CANNOT
PROVIDE. SO WE DO HAVE A POSED
POSITION ON THE BILL. CURRENTLY
BUT WE DO APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR'S COMMITMENT TO, AT LEAST
HAVING A DIALOG WITH US. AND WE
APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEE'S WORK
ON THIS, BUT ARE OPPOSED TODAY.
APPRECIATE THAT. OTHER WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION, IF ANY, SEEING
NONE. YOU ARE AN ARMY OF ONE.
MR. WIENER LET'S COME BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE. QUESTIONS
COMMENTS FROM MEMBERS, I
ACTUALLY HAVE A QUICK QUESTION.
IT MIGHT BE FOR YOU, BUT IT'S
STARTING WITH MISS HAMPTON. SO
YOU WERE HOW OLD WHEN YOU WERE
ASKED TO DISSECT A CAT? I WAS A
SENIOR IN HIGH SCHOOL, SO I WAS
17, 18. AND I DON'T KNOW IF YOU
KNOW MR. WINKLER LIKE HOW I'M
MORE USED TO KIND OF FROGS, ETC.
HOW COMMON IS IT FOR SCHOOLS TO
BE USING HOUSE PETS FOR A
DISSECTION? I WOULD NEED TO
CHECK WITH MY CLIENT AND ASK
THEM THAT I'M NOT ENTIRELY SURE.
I THINK I BELIEVE THOSE TYPES OF
DISSECTIONS TYPICALLY HAPPEN IN
THE MORE ADVANCED ANATOMY AND
BIOLOGY CLASSES, BUT I COULD
DEFINITELY FOLLOW UP ON THAT.
JUST SEEM SORT OF OUT OF STEP
WITH CURRENT SENSIBILITIES, I
TOO HAD CONCERNS ABOUT THE
NOTICE. AND, YOU KNOW, SO WE'VE
TRIED TO MAKE THAT A LITTLE LESS
ONEROUS BECAUSE I THINK, YOU
KNOW, WE'VE HAD THIS
CONVERSATION IN DIFFERENT
MEETINGS. YOU KNOW, I HAVE A
LITTLE KID IN SCHOOL AND WE GET
WAY TOO MANY NOTICES, ABOUT
EVERYTHING, AND I'LL ADMIT, I
DON'T READ MOST OF THEM. SO YOU
KNOW WHAT THE CONCERN IS? I'M A
BAD DAD. I'LL ADMIT IT. IT'S ON
THE RECORD. MY KID WOULD TELL
YOU IF SHE WAS HERE, SHE'D TELL
YOU FATHER'S DAY. I DO MY BEST.
SO SO, YOU KNOW, SO THAT IS A
CONCERN ABOUT ABOUT
COMMUNICATION AND MAKING SURE
THAT THAT, YOU KNOW, A NOTICE IS
PROPERLY DISTRIBUTED, BUT IN
WAYS THAT AREN'T ADVERSE, YOU
KNOW, TO THE BROADER GOALS. I'M
ALSO SORT OF CONCERNED,
INTRIGUED ABOUT ENFORCEMENT.
RIGHT. AND SO TO, TO YOUR TO THE
WITNESSES POINT, YOU HAVE EVERY
RIGHT UNDER CALIFORNIA EXISTING
STATUTE TO OPT OUT OF A LIVE
DISSECTION. BUT YOU WERE TOLD
THAT AND I THINK ONE OF THE
WITNESSES, ACTUALLY SAID THAT
THEIR CHILD WAS TOLD THAT THEY
WOULD TAKE A FAILING GRADE. SO
THAT'S IMPROPER. AND I HAVE REAL
CONCERNS ABOUT THAT. AND IT
EXTENDS WELL BEYOND THIS, THIS
AREA. BUT HOW HOW SHOULD WE
THINK ABOUT THAT? ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WELL, MR. CHAIR, I THINK
THAT THE FACT THAT WE'RE NOW
ASKING THAT A WRITTEN, THAT
BASED THEIR RIGHT TO OPT OUT IS
GIVEN TO THEM IN A WRITTEN FORM,
IN A STANDARDIZED WRITTEN FORM,
WILL NOW GIVE THE STUDENT THE
INFORMATION THAT THEY DO HAVE
THE RIGHT TO OPT OUT, REGARDLESS
OF WHAT THE TEACHER SAYS. THEY
NOW HAVE TO PROVIDE THIS FORM
THAT EXPRESSLY INFORMS THEM THAT
THEY CAN OPT OUT RIGHT. AND SO,
YOU KNOW, THE CONCERN THERE IS
IF IT'S APPARENT, LIKE ME, THAT
IT DOESN'T COME BACK. THAT'S AN
EFFECTIVE THAT'S A DEFAULT OPT
OUT. AND UNLESS YOU KNOW, SO IS
THERE A TIME LIMIT THERE? I
MEAN, HOW HOW DO WE MAKE SURE
THAT, YOU KNOW, IT'S NOT
INFERRED AS AN OPT OUT WHEN IN
FACT IT'S JUST NOT NOTICED. SO I
DON'T KNOW, MR. WENGER. YEAH.
WE'RE STILL HAVING, I THINK,
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE SPONSORS ON
HOW THE MECHANICS OF THE PARENT
AND YOU'RE, YOU'RE OPEN, YOU'RE
GOING TO CONTINUE THAT. WELL
YEAH. I THINK THE AMENDMENTS
THAT THE COMMITTEE PUT FORTH
WERE PART OF THE CAME THROUGH
THE CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
OPPOSITION. BUT I WOULD JUST
SAY, LOOK, YOU KNOW, WE YES,
THERE ARE A LOT OF NOTICES AND
WHAT HAVE YOU FOR OUR STUDENTS,
BUT THAT'S ON ISSUES THAT ARE
REALLY IMPORTANT. THESE ANIMAL
DISSECTION KITS ALREADY HAVE
NOTICE ON IT. THEY'RE CALLED
PROP 65 WARNINGS. SO YOU KNOW WE
HAVE TO RECOGNIZE THAT WE ARE
GIVING THESE CHEMICALLY LADEN NÓ
I APPRECIATE IT. BUT, YOU KNOW,
IT'S ALREADY AN OBLIGATION FOR
THE TEACHER TO GIVE SOME SORT OF
YEAH, WE'VE WE'VE HEARD
NOTIFICATION. WE'VE JUST HEARD
ANECDOTALLY THROUGH THE NATIONAL
SCIENCE TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
THAT A LOT OF TEACHERS ARE
ACTUALLY NOT, AWARE EITHER OF
CALIFORNIA CURRENT LAW. SO I
THINK THERE'S, DEFINITELY SOME
CONVERSATION TO BE HAD AT THE
DISTRICT LEVEL ON ENSURING THAT
THE THAT THE TEACHERS ARE AWARE
AND ARE GIVING THE STUDENTS
THOSE RIGHTS. WE DEFINITELY
SUPPORT THAT. OKAY, ANYTHING
ELSE FROM COLLEAGUES? ALL RIGHT.
YOU KNOW, AND SO YOU MADE CLEAR
YOU'RE ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS.
YES. OKAY. AND WITH THAT, YOU
KNOW, GLAD TO SUPPORT GLAD TO
SUPPORT THE BILL. GOT A MOTION
FROM SENATOR GLAZER. WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
YEAH. THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. AND
I APPRECIATE THE DIALOG ON THIS.
THIS IS REALLY JUST ABOUT
INFORMING STUDENTS OF A RIGHT
THAT THEY ALREADY HAVE, THAT
THEY MAY NOT BE AWARE OF, AND
THE TEACHERS MAY NOT BE AWARE
OF. SO I APPRECIATE THE WORK BY
THE COMMITTEE AND RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. MADAM
KANSEN, WE HAVE A MOTION FROM
SENATOR GLAZER. PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL CALL. ITEM 19 AB 2640. CALL
THE MOTION IS Dð PASS AS AMENDED
TO SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. NEWMAN Ã NEWMAN I
OKOBOJI. OKOBOJI. CORTESE.
CORTESE, AYE. GLAZER GLAZER.
AYE. GONZALEZ. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. SMALLWOOD CUEVAS. AYE.
WILK. WILK. AYE VERY GOOD. THAT
THAT IT HAS SIX VOTES AND WE
WILL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR THE ONE
MISSING MEMBER. BUT THANK YOU.
AND THANK YOU TO THE WITNESSES,
AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER FONG,
WELCOME BACK. I FEEL LIKE I'VE
SEEN YOUR TWIN BROTHER OVER
APPROPRIATIONS. YES HE'S LOOKING
GOOD TODAY. YOU MAY PROCEED WHEN
READY. GOOD MORNING, MR. CHAIR
AND MEMBERS. THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR, FOR BEING A PARTNER IN
OUR WORK ON ASSEMBLY BILL 2047.
ASSEMBLY BILL 2047 WOULD
ESTABLISH A SYSTEM WIDE OFFICE
OF CIVIL RIGHTS AT THE CSU
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE AND THE UC
OFFICE OF THE PRESIDENT. THE
BILL WOULD ALSO REQUIRE EACH
CAMPUS TO THE CSU AND UC TO
DESIGNATE A TITLE NINE
COORDINATOR AND A TITLE NINE
OFFICE TO PROCESS SEXUAL
HARASSMENT COMPLAINTS ON CAMPUS.
THE SYSTEM WIDE OFFICE WILL BE
TASKED WITH MONITORING EACH
CAMPUS TO ENSURE EFFECTIVE
ACTIONS ARE TAKEN TO ADEQUATELY
PREVENT AND ADDRESS SEXUAL
HARASSMENT ON CAMPUS, WITH THE
ULTIMATE GOAL OF PREVENTING A
RECURRENCE. THE TITLE NINE
OFFICES WILL NOW HAVE CODIFIED
RESPONSIBILITIES TO ADDRESS AND
PREVENT THE OCCURRENCES OF
SEXUAL HARASSMENT. CALIFORNIA IS
A PIONEER FOR CHANGE IN OUR
COUNTRY AND ITS MEASURE, AND THE
CALL TO ACTION BUILDS UPON THE
FEDERAL TITLE NINE REGULATIONS
AND ARE BASED ON BEST PRACTICES
ESTABLISHED BY THE US DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE AND THE US DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION, OFFICE OF CIVIL
RIGHTS. ASSEMBLY BILL 2047 WILL
PROVIDE THE NECESSARY STRUCTURE
FOR CSU AND UC CAMPUSES TO
ADDRESS SEXUAL HARASSMENT IN A
MANNER THAT WILL RESTORE
EDUCATIONAL EQUITY AND HAVE
POSITIVE IMPACTS ON THE HEALTH
AND WELL-BEING OF OUR CAMPUSES.
WITH ME TODAY TO SPEAK ON THE
MERITS OF THE MEASURE IS KATE
ROGERS OF GENERATION UP. THANK
YOU, MISS ROGERS. WELCOME AGAIN.
PLEASE PROCEED, GOOD MORNING,
CHAIRMAN NEWMAN. MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS KATE
ROGERS. I'M THE C  CHIEF OF
POLICY FOR GENERATION UP. I'M
ALSO A CURRENT UCLA JUNIOR,
WE'RE PROUD TO CO-SPONSOR A CHEN
UP TEN OUT OF 12 OF THE CALL TO
ACTION BILLS, INCLUDING AB 2047.
SO REPRESENTING THOUSANDS OF
STUDENTS ACROSS THE STATE, IT'S
CHEN RESPONSIBILITY TO ADVOCATE
FOR LEGISLATION THAT WILL CREATE
SAFER CAMPUSES. SO I WANT TO
THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER FONG FOR
SUPPORTING THE CALL TO ACTION
PACKAGE AND FOR INTRODUCING AB
2047, 1 IN 4 UNDERGRADUATE WOMEN
WILL EXPERIENCE SEXUAL VIOLENCE
WHILE IN COLLEGE. 1 IN 4. THAT
NUMBER IS ASTRONOMICAL. AND I'LL
ADMIT THAT I DIDN'T FULLY GRASP
THE MAGNITUDE OF THAT STATISTIC
UNTIL I MYSELF BECAME A PART OF
IT, IN MY NEARLY THREE YEARS AT
UCLA, I'VE HEARD MANY, MANY
STORIES SIMILAR TO MY OWN
STORIES, WHERE STUDENTS WERE
REACHED OUT TO TITLE NINE AND
WERE MET WITH INDIFFERENCE, LIKE
ME, STORIES WHERE STUDENTS FELT
TOO HOPELESS TO EVEN REACH OUT
AT ALL. AND I WILL SAY THAT I
HAVE YET TO MEET A STUDENT
SURVIVOR THAT ACTUALLY HAS
RECEIVED JUSTICE BY GOING
THROUGH THE TITLE NINE PROCESS,
BUT I'VE MET PROBABLY DOZENS
THAT HAVE EITHER NOT REACHED OUT
OR NOT RECEIVED THE HELP THEY
NEEDED, SO LIKE I SAID, WHEN I
WAS FACED WITH MY OWN DECISION
TO CONTACT TITLE NINE, I CHOSE
NOT TO, AND SEXUAL VIOLENCE
FEEDS OFF OF OUR SILENCE. I,
LIKE MANY OF MY CLASSMATES, HAD
COMPLETELY LOST FAITH IN MY
SCHOOL'S ABILITY AND WILLINGNESS
TO PROTECT ME. SO AS LONG AS OUR
TITLE NINE OFFICES FAIL TO
PROTECT STUDENTS, WE'LL KNOW IT
AND WE'LL CHOOSE NOT TO COME
FORWARD. AND THEN THERE'LL BE NO
PROGRESS MADE ON THIS ISSUE. SO
AB 2047 AND THE CALL TO ACTION
PACKAGE AS A WHOLE, REALLY HAS
GIVEN ME HOPE FOR THE FIRST TIME
IN A LONG TIME, THAT THINGS
MIGHT ACTUALLY CHANGE, SO BY
ESTABLISHING A CONSISTENT TITLE
NINE FRAMEWORK, THIS BILL WILL
ENSURE THAT UC AND CSU SYSTEMS
HAVE, MUCH MORE RELIABLE ACCESS
TO LIKE, SERVICES FOR THEIR
STUDENTS, SO THROUGH THIS BILL,
FOR THE FIRST TIME, I THINK
EVERY SINGLE STUDENT WILL HAVE
THEIR RIGHTS RESPECTED AND
ACCESS TO THE RESOURCES THAT WE
REALLY DO NEED. SO, ON BEHALF OF
GENERATION UP, I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE TODAY.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ANY OTHER
WITNESSES HERE OR INDIVIDUALS
HERE LIKE TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT
OF THE MEASURE? PLEASE COME
FORWARD. GOOD MORNING, MAGGIE
WHITE WITH THE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY OFFICE OF THE
CHANCELLOR HERE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU.
NEXT, PLEASE. HELLO, WENDY BRILL
WYNKOOP, PRESIDENT OF THE
FACULTY ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING. GENESIS GONZALES, ON
BEHALF OF LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR
ELENI KOUNALAKIS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. MARIO
GUERRERO, ON BEHALF OF THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA. WE
DON'T HAVE A POSITION ON THIS
BILL, BUT WE REALLY WANTED TO
THANK THE AUTHOR. YOUR STAFF HAS
BEEN AMAZING. I THINK WE
ADDRESSED A LOT OF THE ISSUES WE
HAD, AND WE'RE HAPPY TO CONSIDER
THE BILL AS IT MOVES FORWARD.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH, ANY OTHER TWEENERS?
NO OTHER WITNESSES. LET'S COME
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE. COMMITTEE
MEMBERS, ANY QUESTIONS OR
CONCERNS FOR THE AUTHOR? I'VE
GOT A MOTION FROM SENATOR GLAZER
, YOU KNOW, JUST TO NOTE VERY
CLEARLY, THIS BILL ADDRESSES,
ONE OF THE REPORT'S
RECOMMENDATIONS FROM THE RECENT
HEARINGS AND THE REPORT THAT
FOLLOWED. SO I APPRECIATE YOU
BRINGING THIS MEASURE FORWARD.
I'M GLAD TO SUPPORT IT. I'VE GOT
A MOTION FROM SENATOR GLAZER.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE? THANK
YOU SO MUCH, I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR A NO VOTE. THANK YOU. WITH
THAT, MADAM KANSEN, PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. FILE ITEM SEVEN AB
2047, MIKE FONG, MOTION IS Dð
PASSED. SENATE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE. NEWMAN Ã NEWMAN I
OKOBO OKOBO I CORTEZ. CORTEZ I.
GLASER. GLASER I. GONZALEZ
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS I. WILK WILK I. VERY,
VERY GOOD. THAT MEASURE HAS SIX
VOTES. WE'LL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR
THE TIME BEING, BUT IT WILL
PASS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. AND THANK YOU, MISS
ROGERS. WELCOME, MR. MCCARTY. I
SEE YOU HAVE TWO BILLS,
WHICHEVER ORDER YOU CHOOSE.
WE'LL GO WITH THE ORDER IN THE
FILE. SO AB 2565. PLEASE PROCEED
WHEN READY. YEAH. SO THIS IS A
BILL THAT I WISH WE DIDN'T HAVE
TO PRESENT IN THIS DAY AND AGE.
IT'S ABOUT THE IMPACTS OF
HORRIFIC SCHOOL SHOOTINGS
THROUGHOUT OUR COUNTRY AND
TRYING TO PROTECT OUR STUDENTS
AND STAFF BY MAKING SURE OUR
SCHOOLS ARE SAFER. A SIMPLE
CONCEPT IS WHEN SCHOOLS REMODEL,
ON THEIR ON THEIR SCHOOL SITES.
THIS WOULD FOCUS ON A
REQUIREMENT THAT THEY INSTALL
INTERIOR LOCKS WHILE THEY
UNDERGO CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS.
AND AFTER THE TRAGIC SANDY HOOK
SHOOTING NEARLY A DECADE AGO,
YOU KNOW, THIS WAS A TOP
RECOMMENDATION AND CLEARLY FOUND
THAT NOT A SINGLE LOCKED DOOR
HAS EVER BEEN BREACHED DURING A
SCHOOL SHOOTING. AND ONE QUARTER
OF SCHOOLS DON'T HAVE INTERIOR
LOCKS. THIS IS A COMMON SENSE,
BIPARTISAN APPROACH, AND WE DO
HAVE FUNDING SOURCE. SO WE
IDENTIFIED IN THE ASSEMBLY SIDE
FOR THE BILL THAT PASSED LAST
YEAR. AND SO WITH THAT,
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU, MR.
BROWN. WELCOME. PLEASE PROCEED.
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. AND
MEMBERS. TRISTAN BROWN OF CFT.
THIS HAS BEEN A LONG TIME
COMING. THIS HAS BEEN A HIGH
PRIORITY OF OUR MEMBERSHIP FOR
MANY, MANY YEARS. WE HAVE MADE
INCREMENTAL PROGRESS TOWARDS
OBTAINING INTERIOR DOOR LOCKS
THROUGHOUT OUR SCHOOL SYSTEM. I
THINK HOPEFULLY THIS BILL PUTS
US ACROSS THE FINISH LINE TO
MAKE SURE THAT THIS IMPORTANT
SAFETY MEASURE IS AVAILABLE TO
EVERY STUDENT AND STAFF MEMBER
ON CAMPUS, MANY OF YOU JUST
HEARD ME TESTIFY ON ANOTHER BILL
ABOUT HOW OUR MEMBERS ARE
CONSTANTLY WORRIED THAT THEIR
DAY IS COMING TO HAVE A SCHOOL
SHOOTING IN THEIR CAMPS, CAMPUS,
AND PREPARED TO BE SHIELDS FOR
THEIR STUDENTS. IT IS NOT A
WORLD THAT WE WANT TO LIVE IN,
BUT UNFORTUNATELY, HERE WE ARE.
SO WE HOPE THAT WE CAN FINALLY
MAKE SURE EVERY CLASSROOM IS
EQUIPPED TO HAVE AN INTERNAL
DOOR LOCK SO THAT IF THE WORST
DOES HAPPEN, OUR MEMBERS CAN
KEEP OUR STUDENTS SAFE, UNTIL
SUCH TIME THAT HELP ARRIVES AND
THE INCIDENT IS PASSED. SO WITH
THAT, WE DO URGE YOUR AYE VOTE
THIS MORNING. THANK YOU, ANY
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT?
SEEING NONE. ANY OPPOSITION TO
THE MEASURE, PLEASE COME
FORWARD. SEEING NONE, BACK TO
THE DAIS. GOT A MOTION FOR
SENATOR GLAZER VERY BRIEFLY. IF
YOU COULD, YOU MENTIONED YOU'VE
IDENTIFIED A FUNDING SOURCE. IF
YOU COULD JUST EXPAND BRIEFLY.
YEAH. THERE WAS A BILL THAT
PASSED THIS HOUSE LAST YEAR.
IT'S A, SURCHARGE OR FEE ON ON
GUN AND AMMUNITION, WHOLESALE
PURCHASES THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
A PART OF THAT IS FOR SCHOOL
SAFETY IN THE MEASURE THAT WE
PASSED WAS SIGNED INTO LAW. AND
THIS ADJUSTS THE DEFINITION OF
SCHOOL SAFETY, FOCUSING ON
ONTARIO LOCKS. VERY GOOD. ALL
RIGHT. WE HAVE A MOTION FROM
SENATOR GLAZER HAPPY TO SUPPORT
THE BILL. MADAM CONSULTANT,
PLEASE CALL THE Þ. WELL, I'M
SORRY IF YOU'D LIKE TO CLOSE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. UNLESS THAT WAS
YOUR. AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. MADAM CONSULTANT, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL CALL. ITEM 22 AB
2565 MCCARTY. MOTION IS DUE
PASSED A SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. NEWMAN A NEWMAN I
OKOBOJI. OKOBOJI. CORTEZ CORTEZ
I. GLASER. GLASER, I GONZALEZ.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS I. WILK WILK I. VERY
GOOD. THAT MEASURE HAS SIX
VOTES, WE'LL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR
THE TIME BEING. AND YOUR NEXT
MEASURE IS AB 2927. YES. THANK
YOU. THIS NEXT MEASURE IS, I
THINK, A REALLY EXCITING
OPPORTUNITY FOR CALIFORNIA TO
PUSH FORWARD THE ISSUE WITH
FINANCIAL LITERACY AND OUR HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENTS. I KNOW WITH TWO
TEENAGERS AT HOME, THEY'RE ALL
ABOUT MONEY. AND WHEN WE HAD
THEM GO TO A COURSE LAST YEAR TO
LEARN ABOUT PERSONAL FINANCE,
THEY WERE INTRIGUED. THEY DIDN'T
KNOW THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN A
CREDIT CARD AND A DEBIT CARD.
AND SO MANY PEOPLE GO TO COLLEGE
NOW AND THEY GET A FINANCIAL AID
PACKAGE. AND YOU ASK THEM, WHAT
DOES THAT MEAN? IS IT A GRANT OR
A LOAN? I DON'T KNOW, I GOT
FINANCIAL AID AND SO THOSE ARE
TWO BIG DIFFERENCES. AND YOU
KNOW, WHEN YOU GO TO COLLEGE ON
THOSE FIRST DAYS, YOU SEE MORE
CREDIT CARD TABLES THAN YOU DO
THE LIBRARY OR WHERE YOUR
CLASSROOMS ARE. SO THIS WOULD
PUT CALIFORNIA FORWARD AND GET
US IN PAR WITH 17 OTHER STATES
THAT HAVE A FINANCIAL LITERACY,
REQUIREMENT FOR HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS FOR GRADUATION. THÀNH,
75% OF STUDENTS SURVEYED SAID
THAT THEY WOULD GREATLY BENEFIT
FROM THIS, AND THEY LEARNED SO
MUCH, THEIR INFORMATION,
UNFORTUNATELY, FROM SOCIAL
MEDIA, YOU KNOW, I ASKED MY KIDS
RECENTLY, I SAID, HOW MUCH DO
AIR JORDANS COST? AND THEY'RE
LIKE, WELL, IT DEPENDS, YOU
KNOW, WHO CARES? LET'S SAY,
YEAH, LET'S SAY $200. THEY SAID.
AND I SAID, WHAT IF YOU BOUGHT
THOSE AIR JORDANS ON BUY NOW,
PAY LATER? A FIRM WHICH WHEN YOU
GO ON YOUR PHONE, YOU USE YOUR
APPLE PAY YOUR CREDIT CARD OR
FERM. I SAID, WHAT IF YOU MISS
ONE PAYMENT AND YOU GO FROM THE
TEASER RATE AND HAVE YOUR
INTEREST RATE TRIPLED AND YOU
PAY A MINIMUM PAYMENTS FOR THE
LIFETIME OF THOSE AIR JORDANS,
YOU'D BE PAYING $500 FOR THOSE
SAME PAIR OF AIR JORDANS. AND
LIKE, THAT'S NOT FAIR. AND SO I
THINK YOUNG PEOPLE DON'T
UNDERSTAND THAT. AND SO WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO DO IS FOCUS ON
THIS FROM OUR HIGH SCHOOL
GRADUATION REQUIREMENTS. IN THE
HIGH SCHOOL EDUCATION, AS YOU
KNOW, THERE IS A BALLOT MEASURE
THAT'S QUALIFIED. AND I THINK
IT'S FAIR TO HAVE THE
LEGISLATURE FOCUS ON OUR OWN
SOLUTION. WE CAN CRAFT IT AND
IRON OUT SOME OF THESE ISSUES.
WE THINK WE HAVE DONE. SO
WORKING WITH PARTIES AND
REMOVING THE MAJORITY OF THE
OPPOSITION, THIS IS NOW AN
OPTION FOR STUDENTS TO TAKE THIS
IN LIEU OF ECONOMICS AND WE
THINK THAT'S A CHOICE THAT THEY
CAN MAKE AND HAVE, YOU KNOW,
SIMILAR TYPE, INPUT THAT THEY
WOULD GET AS FAR AS, YOU KNOW,
DOLLARS AND CENTS AND MONETARY
POLICY AND PERSONAL FINANCE,
THIS HAS A MULTI YEAR
IMPLEMENTATION. SO IT WOULDN'T
START TILL THE 2031 CLASS. WE
THINK THAT WE'VE CHECKED THE
BOXES TO PUSH FORWARD THIS ISSUE
TO HELP OUR YOUNG PEOPLE SUCCEED
IN IN CALIFORNIA, BUT ALSO
WORKING WITH OUR EDUCATORS AND
OUR SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND OUR AND
OUR, YOU KNOW, PEOPLE IN THE
EDUCATION FIELD TO MAKE SURE WE
FOCUS ON WHAT'S NEEDED TO PUT
THIS ISSUE FORWARD. SO THANK
YOU. RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I
VOTE AND ASK FOR MY WITNESSES TO
PRESENT NOW AS WELL. THANK YOU.
WELCOME TO THE WITNESSES. PLEASE
INTRODUCE YOURSELF. YOUR THREE
MINUTES EACH. SO I'LL GO FIRST,
I WANT TO THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR
TIME, SO MY NAME IS KOBE BELL
AND I AM A FATHER OF THREE, AND
I'M ALSO AN OWNER OF A FINANCIAL
PRACTICE, WHEN I WAS FIRST MADE
AWARE OF AB 2927 BY A SIMILAR
ASSEMBLY MEMBER, KEVIN MCCARTY,
I WAS IMMEDIATELY INTERESTED AND
WANTED TO BE A PART OF THE
PROCESS OF DOING WHATEVER IT
TAKES TO HELP MOVE THIS BILL
FORWARD. I WOULD ALSO LOVE TO
SHARE MY FINANCIAL KNOWLEDGE AND
RESOURCES TO HELP SUPPORT THE
CURRICULUM THAT WILL BE NEEDED
TO ENSURE THAT OUR YOUTH ARE
MOVED BY THE PERSONAL FINANCE
COURSES THAT WILL BE IMPLEMENTED
. ONE OF THE MAIN COMPONENTS OF
MY PROFESSION IS SITTING DOWN
WITH FAMILIES AND INDIVIDUALS IN
OUR COMMUNITY AND HAVING
CONVERSATIONS REGARDING THEIR
PERSONAL FINANCES. ONE OF THE
PAIN POINTS THAT I HEAR
REGULARLY FROM MY CLIENTS IS
THAT THEY WISH THEY WOULD HAVE
BEEN TAUGHT THESE KEY COMPONENTS
LIKE SAVING, BUDGETING, AND
INVESTING IN THEIR FUTURES AT A
YOUNGER AGE. I BELIEVE THAT THIS
BILL HELPS START THAT JOURNEY.
IF THIS BILL IS APPROVED AND THE
RIGHT PEOPLE ARE INVOLVED IN
HELPING MOVE THIS BILL FORWARD
AND ROLLING IT OUT TO OUR
SCHOOLS, I TRULY BELIEVE THAT
THIS WILL BE A HUGE INTRODUCTORY
SUPPLEMENT TO OUR COMMUNITIES
FINANCIAL INDEPENDENCE, ECONOMIC
PROSPERITY, AND RETIREMENT
PLANNING FOR OUR FUTURE
GENERATIONS. FOR ALL THESE
REASONS, I STAND BEHIND AB 2927
AND THE IMPACT IT CAN HAVE ON
OUR STATE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
MISTER MONACO, WELCOME. ALL
RIGHT. SO THANK YOU, CHAIR, AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE FOR
INVITING ME TO SHARE MY
PERSPECTIVE ON THIS BILL. AS A
CURRENT HIGH SCHOOL STUDENT, MY
NAME IS KAVON BENINCA, AND I'M A
RISING JUNIOR AT MODESTO HIGH
SCHOOL. SO I'M GOING TO TAKE A
WILD GUESS AND ASSUME THAT MOST
OF YOU PROBABLY HAVE NEVER
VISITED MODESTO HIGH SCHOOL, OR
MAYBE EVEN MODESTO AS A WHOLE. I
DON'T BLAME YOU. IT'S NOT
EXACTLY THE BAHAMAS, SO I'LL
PAINT A QUICK PICTURE FOR YOU.
AGRICULTURE PLAYS A HUGE ROLE IN
OUR LOCAL ECONOMY. IN FACT, OUR
BASEBALL MASCOTS ARE LITERALLY
ALL THE ALMOND AND WALLY THE
WALNUT, AND MY SCHOOL IS LOCATED
IN THE HEART OF DOWNTOWN. MANY
OF MY PEERS HAVE BACKGROUNDS IN
FARMING AND AGRICULTURE AND WORK
LONG HOURS PART TIME TO SUPPORT
THEIR FAMILY ON TOP OF THEIR
ACADEMIC RESPONSIBILITIES. IN
FACT, AROUND 80% OF STUDENTS AT
MY SCHOOL ARE SOCIOECONOMICALLY
DISADVANTAGED. HOWEVER, DESPITE
HOW HARD THEY WORK TO RISE UP
THE SOCIOECONOMIC LADDER, A LOT
OF THE EFFORT IS WASTED SIMPLY
BECAUSE OF POOR MONEY MANAGEMENT
. FOR MANY OF MY PEERS,
INVESTING IN STOCKS MIGHT AS
WELL BE AS COMPLICATED AND
CONVOLUTED AS ROCKET SCIENCE OR
CALCULUS IN OUR CASE. AND FOR
ONE CASE, SOUNDS LIKE A WHOLE
LOT OF MONEY. BUT SERIOUSLY, CAN
YOU BLAME THEM? THE REALITY IS,
THEY'RE NOT BEING TAUGHT ABOUT
THIS IN SCHOOL, AND A LOT OF MY
PEERS DON'T EVEN KNOW WHAT
THEY'RE MISSING OUT ON. WHAT'S
WORSE IS THAT IT'S OFTEN THE
STUDENTS WHO NEED FINANCIAL
LITERACY THE MOST THAT RECEIVE
IT. THE LEAST. YOU SEE, PARENTS
OF LOW INCOME STUDENTS ARE FAR
LESS LIKELY TO BE FINANCIALLY
LITERATE THEMSELVES, WHICH MEANS
THEY CAN'T PASS THAT KNOWLEDGE
DOWN TO THEIR CHILDREN. THIS NOT
ONLY CAUSES PAIN IN THE SHORT
TERM, BUT ALSO PERPETUATES
GENERATIONAL POVERTY. AND THIS
PROBLEM DOESN'T JUST EXIST IN
MODESTO. AROUND SIX AND TEN,
CALIFORNIA AND K THROUGH 12
STUDENTS ARE LOW INCOME AND ARE
LIKELY FACING THESE SAME
CHALLENGES. I KNOW IT'S EASY TO
THINK ABOUT THE IMPACT OF THIS
AS NUMBERS ON A PAGE OR READ IN
THE BANK, BUT I'D ARGUE THAT
THIS IS ONE OF THE BIGGEST
DETERMINANTS, IF NOT THE BIGGEST
DETERMINANT, OF YOUR QUALITY OF
LIFE. YOUR FINANCIAL HEALTH
DICTATES YOUR HOUSING, YOUR
HEALTH CARE, YOUR ACCESS TO
EDUCATION, THE FOOD YOU EAT, AND
SO MUCH MORE. THAT'S WHY I THINK
AB 2927 IS SO IMPORTANT. BY
TEACHING OUR STUDENTS CRITICAL
SKILLS LIKE BUDGETING, CREDIT
SCORES, STUDENT LOAN MANAGEMENT
AND MORE, WE CAN EDUCATE
STUDENTS ON TOPICS THAT PLAY
CRITICAL ROLES IN THEIR
FINANCIAL SUCCESS AND GIVE THEM
A HEAD START ON HEALTHY
FINANCIAL HABITS. I TRULY
BELIEVE THIS BILL IS ONE OF THE
MOST IMPACTFUL AND FEASIBLE WAYS
WE CAN COMBAT WEALTH INEQUALITY
IN OUR STATE. NO ONE, NOT EVEN
THE FASTEST RUNNERS, HAVE EVER
RUN A RACE RUNNING IN THE WRONG
DIRECTION. SIMILARLY, NO ONE,
NOT EVEN THE HARDEST WORKING
MEMBERS OF OUR SOCIETY WILL
ACHIEVE FINANCIAL SUCCESS IF
THEY DON'T UNDERSTAND THE BASICS
OF MONEY MANAGEMENT. THE
PERSONAL FINANCE CLASSES ARE
CLASSES OFFER UNDER THIS BILL
WILL EMPOWER STUDENTS TO NOT
ONLY SURVIVE, BUT THRIVE IS FOR
THESE REASONS THAT I
RESPECTFULLY URGE AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU. WELL
PRESENTED, ANY OTHER INDIVIDUALS
HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF THE MEASURE? IF
SO, PLEASE COME FORWARD, YOUR
NAME, YOUR ORGANIZATION. THÀNH
RICHARD MAHER, AMERICA FIRST
POLICY INSTITUTE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING, MR. CHAIR. FRANCO, ON
BEHALF OF FONSECA, WE HAVE A
SUPPORTIVE, AMENDED POSITION,
AND WE WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR CONTINUING TO WORK WITH US.
THANK YOU. NEXT PLEASE. THANK
YOU, MR. CHAIR. AND MEMBERS,
TRISTAN BROWN WITH CFT AND
STRONG SUPPORT. THANKS. THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING, CHAIR
MEMBERS. DIANA VU ON BEHALF OF
THE ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL ADMINISTRATORS AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING, MR. CHAIR. MEMBERS.
MISSY JOHNSON HERE IN SUPPORT ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA SOCIETY
OF CERTIFIED PUBLIC ACCOUNTANTS.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING, MELANIE
CUEVAS WITH THE CALIFORNIA
BANKERS ASSOCIATION. ALSO IN
STRONG SUPPORT. HAPPY TO ECHO
THE COMMENTS OF THE EXCELLENT
PRIMARY WITNESSES I KNOW. THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING, EMILY DEL
WITH THE CALIFORNIA CREDIT UNION
LEAGUE IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING, BELLA KERN ON
BEHALF OF JUNIOR ACHIEVEMENT IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE COME FORWARD. WE NEED TO
MAKE A LITTLE SPACE FOR YOU AT
THE TABLE. AND GOOD AFTERNOON.
WELL, IT'S STILL MORNING, SO
THEY'RE STILL MORNING, BUT GOOD.
HELLO AND EACH OF YOU HAS THREE
MINUTES EACH. WELCOME, DENISE
GUTIERREZ. I'M THE PRESIDENT AND
CEO FOR THE CALIFORNIA COUNCIL
ON ECONOMIC EDUCATION. I'M HERE
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF A TEACHER
WHO WAS NOT ABLE TO BE HERE ANY
LONGER. SHE HAD A DOCTOR'S
APPOINTMENT, SO I'LL BE RE
READING HER STATEMENT, GOOD
MORNING. HONORED MEMBERS OF THE
SENATE EDUCATION COMMITTEE. MY
NAME IS JANET MANN. I HAVE JUST
FINISHED MY 32ND YEAR IN
EDUCATION, PREDOMINANTLY
TEACHING THE HIGH SCHOOL
ECONOMICS COURSE. I OPPOSE AB
2927 AS IT IS CURRENTLY WRITTEN.
I HAVE TAUGHT ECONOMICS SINCE MY
FIRST YEAR TEACHING. I GRADUATED
HIGH SCHOOL BEFORE ECON WAS A
HIGH SCHOOL REQUIREMENT. I
DIDN'T TAKE AN ECON COURSE UNTIL
I KNEW I WANTED TO BE BE AN
TEACHER. I ALWAYS TELL STUDENTS
THAT IF I HAD THE COURSE IN HIGH
SCHOOL, I WOULD HAVE BEEN AN
ECONOMIC MAJOR IN COLLEGE. ECON
HELPS ANSWER SOCIETAL QUESTIONS
AND LEADS STUDENTS TO ROBUST USE
OF BENEFIT COST ANALYSIS. AND MY
STUDENTS TELL ME THAT THAT THAT
THEY THOUGHT THE CLASS WOULD BE
HARD AND BORING. BUT WE USE THE
REAL LIFE SITUATIONS TO
UNDERSTAND THEIR CURRICULUM. THE
2016 HHS FRAMEWORK SUGGESTS THIS
IS THIS IN THE STATEMENT IT GETS
TO GET INVESTED IN THE
DISCIPLINE. THEY CAN BEGIN THEIR
STUDY OF ECONOMICS BY SEEING
THEIR PLACE IN IT, STARTING WITH
PERSONAL BUDGETING. SO IN THE
CORE, IN THIS COURSE, MOST
TEACHERS USE HIGH, HIGH INTEREST
. SORRY. SO IN THIS COURSE MOST
TEACHERS USE HIGH INTEREST
RESOURCES TO MAKE ECON COME
ALIVE. THIS INCLUDES BUDGETING
HOW TO PLAN FOR AN UNPREDICTABLE
AND UNPREDICTABLE ECONOMY, AS
WELL USED AS USE OF BENEFIT COST
ANALYSIS TO MAKE FINANCIAL
DECISIONS, TO MAKE FINANCIAL
DECISIONS. FINANCIAL LITERACY IS
PART OF THE HIGH SCHOOL ECONOMIC
COURSE, BUT REPLACING ECONOMICS
COMPLETELY IS A HUGE MISTAKE.
ECONOMICS TEACHES STUDENTS TO
MAKE SOUND DECISIONS, UNDERSTAND
SCARCITY, COMPETITION,
INVESTMENT, AND CAPITALISM. IT
ADDRESSES WHAT IT MEANS TO BE
FINANCIALLY LITERATE, LITERATE,
LITERATE AS WELL AS SUPPORT
STUDENTS TO UNDERSTAND THE
GLOBAL MARKETPLACE, STUDY
RESOURCE ALLOCATION AND USE
STRONG DECISION MAKING. CLEARLY,
I RECOGNIZE THE IMPORTANCE OF
THE VALUE OF STUDENTS GAINING
FINANCIAL LITERACY AS I ADDRESS
IT IN MY CURRICULUM. HOWEVER, I
CANNOT SUPPORT THE LANGUAGE IN
THE BILL ALLOWING STUDENTS TO
OPT OUT OF ECON IF THEY TAKE THE
FINANCIAL LITERACY COURSE BY
MISSING OUT ON THE ECON COURSE,
STUDENTS MISS OUT ON BEING
EQUIPPED WITH CRITICAL THINKING
SKILLS. ESSENTIAL TO MAINTAINING
A OUR DEMOCRACY. STUDENTS
DESERVE BOTH. I URGE YOU TO
AMEND AB 2927 TO REMOVE THE OPT
OUT PROVISION IN THE 26 2016 HSC
FRAMEWORK CLEARLY CALLS FOR
LAYERING FINANCIAL LITERACY INTO
THE ECON SEMESTER. I ASK YOU TO
AMEND THE BILL TO CONSIDER THE
INTEGRATION OF PERSONAL FINANCE
INTO THE ECONOMICS COURSE AND
ENSURE STRONG TRAINING FOR
TEACHERS TO ENSURE STUDENTS HAVE
FINANCIAL LITERACY BEFORE THEY
GRADUATE. THANK YOU, THANK YOU
AND WELCOME. GOOD MORNING,
ESTEEMED MEMBERS OF THE SENATE
EDUCATION COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS
JOSHUA MITTEN. EXCUSE ME, I AM
THE CHIEF PROGRAM OFFICER FOR
THE CALIFORNIA COUNCIL ON
ECONOMIC EDUCATION AND ALSO AN
ADJUNCT INSTRUCTOR. I'VE SPENT
OVER A DECADE STRENGTHENING
ECONOMICS AND PERSONAL FINANCE
EDUCATION IN CALIFORNIA. VÀ I
OPPOSE AB 2927 AS IT IS
CURRENTLY WRITTEN. WHILE WE
SUPPORT THE GOAL OF PROVIDING
PERSONAL FINANCE EDUCATION, THIS
BILL WEAKENS THAT GOAL BY
SACRIFICING ECONOMICS, BEING
OVERLY RIGID, IMPOSING
ADDITIONAL BURDENS, AND LACKING
SUFFICIENT FUNDING. THE BILL
ALLOWS STUDENTS THAT TAKE THIS
PERSONAL FINANCE COURSE TO FORGO
THE ECONOMICS COURSE. WE FIND
THIS ALARMING ECONOMICS EQUIP
STUDENTS WITH DECISION MAKING
AND ANALYSIS SKILLS, AND A WIDER
PERSPECTIVE OF THE WORLD AROUND
THEM. ECONOMICS IS A VITAL
COMPLEMENT TO THE CONCEPTS OF
BUDGETING, RISK MANAGEMENT,
CREDIT USE, INVESTING, AND MORE.
ECON SIX PREPARES STUDENTS WITH
ADDITIONAL SKILLS THAT IMPROVE
ALL DECISIONS, NOT SIMPLY THOSE
THAT PERTAIN TO FINANCE, AND IT
IS AN INTEGRAL PART OF SOCIAL
STUDIES, HELPING PREPARE A
LITERATE AND CIVICALLY ENGAGED
ELECTORATE. IT ENCOURAGES,
ENCOURAGES US TO THINK ABOUT OUR
SYSTEMS AND ADDRESS FACTORS TOO
LARGE FOR ANY SINGLE INDIVIDUAL
TO ADDRESS, SUCH AS POVERTY,
INCOME INEQUALITY, INNOVATION,
AND GENERATIONAL WEALTH. AND ON
A PERSONAL NOTE, I'LL NOTE, I'LL
COMMENT THAT ON MY, IN MY OWN
ADULT LIFE, I'VE ONLY SEEN, THE
NEED FOR ECONOMIC LITERACY GROW
AS WELL. ADDITIONALLY THE RIGID
STATUTORY LANGUAGE SPECIFYING
COURSE TOPICS IS CONCERNING AS
IT MAY NOT ADAPT OR BE
RESPONSIVE ENOUGH TO THE FAST
CHANGING FINANCIAL ENVIRONMENT.
TODAY'S FINANCIAL WORLD IS
VASTLY DIFFERENT FROM THAT OF
EVEN A DECADE AGO. A NEW
REQUIREMENT WITH AN OPT OUT FOR
AN EXISTING REQUIREMENT WEAKENS
THE OVERALL MEANING OF
REQUIREMENTS GENERALLY, AND
CREATES NEW ADMINISTRATIVE
BURDENS AND POTENTIAL
UNNECESSARY CONFUSION FOR
DISTRICT SCHOOLS AND TEACHERS ON
THE PART OF STUDENTS AND
PARENTS, GRADUATION REQUIREMENTS
ARE ONLY THE START, AS THEY MUST
ALSO WEIGH REQUIREMENTS FOR UC,
CSU, AND OTHER POST-SECONDARY
EDUCATION INSTITUTIONS.
ADDITIONALLY, STUDENTS MAY NOT
KNOW WHAT TO VALUE, WHAT THEY DO
NOT KNOW, AND SO OFFERING THEM
THE CHOICE BETWEEN THE PERSONAL
FINANCE COURSE OR THE ECONOMICS
COURSE IS NOT A FAIR JUDGMENT
FOR THEM TO MAKE. FINALLY, THERE
IS NO UNIVERSALLY LEVEL PIPELINE
FOR PERSONAL FINANCE TEACHERS,
UNLIKE THE ESTABLISHED ECONOMICS
DEPARTMENT S AND THE BILL'S
UNSPECIFIED AMOUNT FOR TEACHER
TRAINING SEEMS INADEQUATE. IF
THE GOAL OF THIS BILL IS TO
ENSURE STUDENTS FINANCIAL
LITERACY SOMETHING WE SUPPORT,
AND TO PREPARE THEM FOR THE
FUTURE SUCCESS THAT WE HOPE THEY
FIND. WE URGE YOU TO AMEND THE
BILL AND BRING MORE STAKEHOLDERS
TO THE TABLE. THERE ARE
IMPORTANT SYNERGIES BETWEEN
PERSONAL FINANCE AND ECONOMICS.
THERE IS A ROLE FOR GREATER
FLEXIBILITY IN IMPLEMENTATION,
AND THERE IS A NEED TO ENSURE
REALISTIC AND ADEQUATE FUNDING
TO CREATE MEANINGFUL CHANGE IN
CONCLUSION, I URGE YOU TO AMEND
AB 2927 TO EITHER REMOVE THE
EITHER OR COMPONENT WITH RESPECT
TO THE ECONOMICS COURSE, OR TO
INTEGRATE PERSONAL FINANCE WITH
ECONOMICS AND PROVIDE NECESSARY
FLEXIBILITY. THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIRMAN. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION? WELCOME. GOOD
MORNING, FRED JONES. ON BEHALF
OF TWO ORGANIZATIONS, MY LONG
TERM CLIENT, THE SOCIAL STUDIES
TEACHERS, WHICH IS THE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL FOR SOCIAL
STUDIES. AND ALSO MY SON IS OH,
SORRY, I NEED YOU A LITTLE
CLOSER TO THE MIC. YEAH THERE
YOU GO. OKAY. FRED JONES WITH
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL FOR THE
SOCIAL STUDIES. SOCIAL STUDIES
TEACHERS ARE CONCERNED ABOUT THE
EITHER OR PROPOSITION OF THIS
BILL. AND THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF SCHOOL ECONOMICS
TEACHERS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ANYBODY ELSE, SEEING NONE. LET'S
COME BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
QUESTIONS? COMMENTS, SENATOR.
CHÁVEZ. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
MR. CHAIR. AND THANK YOU TO
FOLKS WHO GAVE WITNESS TODAY AND
PARTICULARLY MODESTO'S FINEST
FOR YOUR YOUR PRESENTATION, I
WANTED TO KNOW IF THE AUTHOR
COULD SPEAK TO SOME OF THE
CONCERNS RAISED BY THE
OPPOSITION. YOU KNOW, TODAY'S
JUNETEENTH, AND, REALLY,
JUNETEENTH IS LOOKING AT WHAT
WAS ESSENTIALLY A FAILED
ECONOMIC POLICY IN TERMS OF
SLAVERY AND WHAT IT MEANT IN
TERMS OF SUPPLY AND DEMAND. AND
I STRUGGLE WITH THIS, BECAUSE
FINANCIAL LITERACY IS SO
NECESSARY AND NEEDED, BUT ALSO
UNDERSTANDING THESE SYSTEMS ARE
ALSO NECESSARY AND NEEDED AND
JUST WANTED TO HEAR MORE ABOUT
YOUR THOUGHTS ON THAT. I WANT TO
SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY, BUT I
HOPE WE CAN GET TO A BOTH END IN
TERMS OF, BEING ABLE TO ENSURE
STUDENTS ARE GETTING THAT
INDIVIDUAL KNOWLEDGE THAT THEY
NEED AS A, AS A, AS A NECESSARY
LIFE SKILL. BUT WE ALSO CAN
UNDERSTAND, ECONOMIC POLICIES
AND THE IMPACTS ON COMMUNITIES
IN A MORE MACRO LEVEL. SO IF YOU
COULD SPEAK TO THAT, I
APPRECIATE IT. YEAH. THIS IS A
KEY ISSUE THAT WE GRAPPLED WITH
IN THE PROPONENTS OF THAT BALLOT
MEASURE, GRAPPLED WITH TRYING TO
GET THE TEACHER GROUPS WHO HAVE
REMOVED THEIR OPPOSITION AND
EDUCATOR GROUPS ON THE SAME
PAGE, BECAUSE SPEAKING OF
JUNETEENTH, A COUPLE OF YEARS
AGO, WE ADDED ETHNIC STUDIES AS
A AS A HIGH SCHOOL REQUIREMENT.
SO JUST LIKE ANY PERSON AT
THANKSGIVING, YOU CAN'T PUT A
NEW THING ON THE PLATE AND
EXPECT IT ALL TO WORK. SOMETIMES
YOU HAVE TO TAKE SOMETHING OFF
THE PLATE, RIGHT? SO THERE'S
ONLY SO MUCH TIME DURING THE
DAY, ONLY SO MANY ELECTIVES. AND
SO THAT'S ONE OF THE TRADE OFFS
THAT WE MADE. WE THINK IT'S
BETTER WITH THIS MEASURE WE HAVE
IN FRONT OF US WITH THE OPTION
THAN WHAT IT HAD IN THE BALLOT
MEASURE, SO THIS, YOU KNOW, A
STUDENT COULD CONCEIVABLY TAKE
ECONOMICS AND PERSONAL FINANCE.
THEY COULD BECAUSE THEY COULD
CHOOSE IT WAS ONE OF THEIR
ELECTIVES. BUT THIS WOULD ALLOW
THE OPTION OF THAT INDIVIDUAL TO
USING PERSONAL FINANCE IN LIEU
OF ECONOMICS. AND, YOU KNOW, I'D
ARGUE THAT SOME OF THE SAME
ELEMENTS AND COMPONENTS FOR
ECONOMICS CAN BE LEARNED IN
PERSONAL FINANCE AND FRANKLY,
MORE RELEVANT TO KIDS THESE
DAYS. I KNOW I TALKED TO MY 15
YEAR OLDS. THEY'RE ALL INTO
PERSONAL FINANCE AND MONEY
ISSUES AND LEARNING ABOUT
ECONOMICS. IN THAT SENSE, I
THINK ENGAGES YOUNG PEOPLE MAYBE
DIFFERENTLY THAN WHEN I TOOK
ECONOMICS. AND YOU DID, YOU
KNOW, A COUPLE OF DECADES AGO,
AND THEN THE OTHER QUESTION AS
FAR AS YOU KNOW, HAVING THE
WORKFORCE. YEAH, IT'S AN ISSUE
WHICH IS WHY THIS IS 2024. AND
AS IT START UNTIL THE 2031
CLASS. SO WE HAVE MULTIPLE YEARS
OF IMPLEMENTATION. WE DID,
REPURPOSE MONEY IN THE PRIOR
STATE BUDGET TO, TO FUND THE
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT NEEDS.
THIS APPROACH WILL BE MUCH, MUCH
CHEAPER FOR THE STATE BUDGET
THAN THE BALLOT MEASURE. SO, YOU
KNOW, OUR JOB IS TO MAKE
SOMETIMES IMPERFECT CHOICES AND
MAKE, YOU KNOW, THE BEST
BALANCED APPROACH. AND I THINK
THIS PROVIDES FLEXIBILITY. IT'S
NOT NOT GOING TO WIN THAT PURITY
TEST HERE, BUT I THINK IT
ANSWERS THE CALL THAT IT BOTH
WOULD BE AVAILABLE. PERSONAL
FINANCE AND ECONOMICS. SENATOR
CORTEZ. THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR.
MORE OF A COMMENT THAN A
QUESTION. I MEAN, I THINK RIGHT
NOW THE TIPPING POINT FOR ME AND
SUPPORTING THE BILL IS MY
FAMILIARITY WITH THE ISSUE OF
HOMELESS STUDENTS OUT THERE THAT
WE HAVE OR GRADUATING ABOUT
15,000 A YEAR. AND WE'VE HEARD
TESTIMONY ON THE FLOOR. WE'VE
HEARD IT HERE IN COMMITTEE OVER,
YOU KNOW, A VARIETY OF DRIVERS,
IF YOU WILL, SOCIAL, ECONOMIC
DRIVERS THAT ARE NOT ONLY
PUSHING THAT POPULATION UP,
SADLY, MY HOME CITY IS THE
NATION'S LEADER IN YOUTH
HOMELESSNESS. BUT NOT ONLY DO
THOSE DRIVERS PUSH, SOME OF
THOSE DRIVERS PUSH UP THAT
POPULATION, BUT THEY COME RATHER
SUDDENLY AND, YOU KNOW, IT
ALMOST SEEMS LIKE A HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENT NEEDS TO BE READY AT ANY
TIME. TO BE FENDING FOR
THEMSELVES THESE DAYS. AND I
THINK FOR ME, YOU KNOW, I
UNDERSTAND THE TENSION AROUND
CURRICULUM, EXISTING CURRICULUM
AND SO FORTH, AND HOPEFULLY THAT
ALL CAN BE WORKED OUT. BUT I'M
GOING TO BE AN AYE VOTE TODAY IF
WE'RE IF FOR NO OTHER REASON, I
THINK WE'RE SEEING THE, YOU
KNOW, SOME OF THE INDIRECT
EFFECTS OF NOT HAVING, THOSE,
THESE KIND OF TOOLS AVAILABLE AT
ALL TIMES FOR STUDENTS THAT
REALLY NEED THEM. THANK YOU.
YES. SENATOR GLASER, WHEN I
THINK ABOUT MY HIGH SCHOOL
EDUCATION, CERTAINLY A TOP THREE
MEMORY IS THE REQUIREMENT THAT I
CREATE A BUDGET, A GROUP PROJECT
WHICH ALWAYS HATED GROUP
PROJECTS, CREATE A BUDGET, GO
OUT, LOOK AT APARTMENTS, GO TO
THE GROCERY STORE AND CREATE A
BUDGET. BALANCE YOUR CHECKBOOK.
THOSE ARE REAL PRAGMATIC LESSONS
THAT HAVE ALWAYS REMAINED WITH
ME. I STILL BALANCE MY CHECKBOOK
OR PEOPLE DON'T DO THAT THESE
DAYS. OKAY, BOOMER. BUT SO AND,
IN RECOGNITION OF MY GREAT
TEACHER, I THINK HE WAS AN
ECONOMICS TEACHER. MR. ANSPAUGH,
I'M HAPPY TO MOVE THIS BILL. I
THINK, YOU KNOW, YOU YOUR POINT
ABOUT WHAT GOES ON THE PLATE AND
WHAT HAS TO BE TAKEN OFF IS AN
IMPORTANT ONE. BUT PRAGMATIC
SKILLS IN HIGH SCHOOL ARE REALLY
IMPORTANT. UNDERSTANDING THE
WORLD. AND, YES, ECONOMICS, BUT
PRAGMATIC SKILLS. I THINK WE'VE
LOST THAT. I'M NOT SAYING WE
BRING BACK SHOP, BUT I THINK
THAT THESE ARE HEALTHY SKILLS
THAT WE DO WANT TO HAVE PEOPLE
GRADUATE HIGH SCHOOL WITH TO
HELP THEM WITH THEIR LIFE.
SENATOR WILK. FIRST YEAR WELDER
WITH A LITTLE OVERTIME CAN MAKE
90,000 A YEAR, SO DON'T DISS
SHOP. I SAID WE SHOULD BRING
BACK SHOP. YOU SAID. YOU SAID
WE. YOU SAID THE EXACT OPPOSITE.
ROLL BACK THE TAPE. YOU SAID YOU
WERE NOT. YEAH, YOU DID SAY
THAT. I'M THE SAME WITH SENATOR
GLASER. SO IN MY SOPHOMORE YEAR
OF HIGH SCHOOL, ONE SEMESTER WAS
HEALTH, SEX EDUCATION, AND THE
OTHER SEMESTER I DON'T I DON'T
KNOW WHAT THEY CALLED IT BACK
THEN, BUT IT WAS ALL THESE LIFE
SKILLS THAT YOU NEED TO HAVE AND
WITH THE BREAKDOWN OF THE FAMILY
AND ALL THESE OTHER CHALLENGES,
WE HAVE TO EQUIP THESE YOUNG
PEOPLE. SO I'M HAPPY TO SUPPORT
YOUR BILL TODAY. I THINK IT'S A
GREAT IDEA AND LONG OVERDUE.
SENATOR CHROBOG, I HAVE A
QUESTION. SO IF IT'S CONSIDERED
AN ELECTIVE, WHY DOES IT HAVE
TO, REPLACE? ECONOMICS? I MEAN,
BECAUSE YOU'RE SAYING EITHER ONE
OR THE OTHER BECAUSE THERE'S NOT
ROOM OF. YEAH, RIGHT NOW
ECONOMICS I'M ASSUMING IS
REQUIRED REQUIRED. SO WHY CAN'T
IT JUST BE ADDED AS AN ELECTIVE
FOR THE STUDENTS TO BE ABLE TO
TAKE IT WITHOUT JEOPARDIZING THE
ABILITY TO TAKE ECONOMICS? AND
THE ONLY REASON I SAY THAT IS
BECAUSE IS IN LIGHT OF OUR
CURRENT ECONOMIC STATUS OF OUR
STATE, AND INCLUDING, YOU KNOW,
AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL WHERE WE
ARE, I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO
HAVE THOSE KNOWLEDGE. AS A
MATTER OF FACT, I HAVE TO MAKE A
COMMENT. I WAS TRYING TO REACH
MY SON, WHO JUST GRADUATED, FROM
HIGH SCHOOL, AND IT WAS VERY
INTERESTING. HIS PERSPECTIVE AS
WE WERE TALKING ABOUT CALIFORNIA
AND THE STATE OF ECONOMICS FOR
THE STATE, AND IT WAS FUNNY
BECAUSE HE ACTUALLY MADE A
STATEMENT THAT SAID, WELL, IT'S
GOING TO HE GOES, THE STATE IS
IN THIS TYPE OF ECONOMIC
SITUATION. AND I REMEMBER
EXACTLY WHAT HE SAID. HE GOES
AND IT SHOULD BE PURSUING, YOU
KNOW, SOMETHING ELSE LIKE VERY,
VERY WELL ARTICULATED. AND I
THOUGHT, WAIT, YOU UNDERSTAND,
YOU KNOW, THE STATE OF ECONOMICS
FOR, FOR THE STATE. AND I WAS
REALLY ACTUALLY VERY IMPRESSED
AND VERY SURPRISED, PLEASANTLY
SURPRISED. SO I THOUGHT IT WAS
VERY IMPORTANT FOR, FOR ADULTS
TO KNOW WHERE WE ARE AND HOW
WE'RE HANDLING OUR ECONOMICS AT
THE STATE LEVEL AND FEDERAL. SO
I THINK I VALUE THAT KNOWLEDGE,
BUT NOT IN LIEU OF FINANCIAL
LITERACY. AND AS A MATTER OF
FACT, I'VE BEEN AN ABSOLUTE
PROPONENT OF FINANCIAL LITERACY,
EVERY BILL THAT HAS COME
THROUGH, WITH REGARDS TO
INCLUDING FINANCIAL LITERACY FOR
OUR STUDENTS, INCLUDING SENATOR
SEYARTO, WHO JUST HAD A BILL ON
FINANCIAL LITERACY, I BELIEVE
LAST YEAR. WAS IT I BELIEVE IT
WAS LAST YEAR. WE SUPPORTED THAT
BILL. AND I THINK IT DIED, YEAH.
SO GOOD. SO THAT'S THE KEY
ISSUE. AND THAT GOES BACK TO THE
PLATE. AND WE THOUGHT ABOUT
THAT. THAT WAS OUR OPTION IS TO
ADD THIS AS AN ELECTIVE. BUT
THEN I THINK THE PEOPLE THAT
SCHEDULE CLASSES,
ADMINISTRATORS, TEACHERS TOLD US
RIGHTFULLY SO, WITH EVERYTHING
STUDENTS HAVE TO DO WITH THEIR
NEW THING THAT I FULLY SUPPORT
ETHNIC STUDIES, THAT THERE'S
JUST TOO MUCH ON THAT PLATE. SO
WE CAME WITH A COMPROMISE TO
ALLOWING THIS TO BE UTILIZED IN
LIEU OF ECONOMICS. I MAY HAVE
MISSPOKE. IT CAN BE AN ELECTIVE
IN THAT IF A STUDENT ELECTS TO,
THEY CAN GRADUATE TAKING ECON
AND PERSONAL FINANCE, THEY'D
HAVE TO GET RID OF SOME OTHER
ELECTIVE ALONG THEIR FOUR YEARS
ALONG THE WAY, WHICH THEY DO
HAVE A FEW ELECTIVE OPTIONS SO
THEY CAN DO THAT. MAYBE THE NEXT
GEN PERSON COULD EXPLAIN A BIT
MORE. SURE, MR. CHAIRMAN,
MEMBERS JOE LANG, REPRESENTING
NEXT GENERATION PERSONAL FINANCE
. A CRITICAL PART OF THE BILL
ACTUALLY ALLOWS LOCAL SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TO REVISE THEIR
LOCALLY DETERMINED ELECTIVES TO
MAKE ROOM TO AVOID THIS KIND OF
COLLISION BETWEEN PERSONAL
FINANCE AND ECONOMICS. SO WE
THINK WITH THAT TOOL, IT
ACTUALLY WILL WORK IN REAL LIFE
AS SORT OF A COMPROMISE WHERE
THEY CAN WORK TOGETHER. OKAY.
BECAUSE I DO. AND THE REASON
BEING IS THAT, QUITE FRANKLY,
K-12 IS PRETTY MUCH MANDATORY.
HIGHER EDUCATION IS NOT. AND SO
IF STUDENTS DO NOT OPT, YOU
KNOW, DO NOT OPT INTO PURSUING
HIGHER EDUCATION, THEY WILL
NEVER HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO GET
THE UNDERSTANDING OF EDUCATION
WHEN IT COMES TO ECONOMICS. AND
THAT AS A POPULACE, IN ORDER TO
BE AS CIVICALLY ENGAGED PERSON,
ALL YOU KNOW, A WELL-EDUCATED,
WELL-ROUNDED, CIVIC, ENGAGED
PERSON, ECONOMICS IS IMPERATIVE
AND UNDERSTANDING OF AT LEAST
THE BASIC UNDERSTANDING OF
ECONOMICS WHEN IT COMES TO,
ESPECIALLY OUR COUNTRY AND THE
WAY THAT WE ARE. WE ARE
ACTUALLY, ESTABLISHED. SO THAT'S
THAT'S ONE OF THE REASONS WHY
I'M NERVOUS ABOUT BECOMING AN
ELECTIVE FOR HIGH SCHOOL,
BECAUSE WE WANT THEM TO LEAVE
HIGH SCHOOL WITH BASIC, BASIC
UNDERSTANDINGS OF THEIR WORLD.
AND SO WHEN WE TAKE SOMETHING AS
BASIC AS ECONOMICS, I THINK IT
IT'S A DETRIMENT TO OUR SOCIETY,
TO OUR CULTURE, TO OUR STATE AND
OUR NATION AS A WHOLE. SO THAT'S
THAT'S A CONCERN THAT I HAVE,
AND THAT'S WHY I WOULD LIKE TO
SEE IT, AS YOU KNOW, INCLUDED
AND WITHOUT ONE OR THE OTHER,
YOU KNOW. SO JUST TO FOLLOW UP
ON THAT, SORT OF LIKE THE PLATE
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT, THAT ONE
PROVISION IN THE BILL THAT
ALLOWS THE LOCAL DISTRICTS TO
ADJUST THEIR ELECTIVES TO
INCLUDE BOTH PERSONAL FINANCE
AND ECONOMICS, WE THINK IS KIND
OF A TOOL THAT WILL BE USEFUL IN
REAL LIFE TO AVOID THAT SORT OF
CONFLICT SO THAT STUDENTS WILL
ACTUALLY GET BOTH. COULD I SAY
JUST ONE FOLLOW ON, IN
CONNECTION TO THAT, I APPRECIATE
THE SPIRIT OF IT, BUT IN
PRACTICALITY, I AM CONCERNED
THAT THE GIVEN THE FACT,
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY, YOUR
OWN CHILDREN'S INTEREST IN
PERSONAL FINANCE, I DON'T THINK
THAT THE STUDENTS ARE AT A LACK
OF INTEREST AND WILL SEEK OUT
PERSONAL FINANCE IF IT'S AN
OPTION, ECONOMICS SUFFERS A
LITTLE BIT OF A BRANDING
PROBLEM. AND SO THEY'RE GOING TO
REACH FOR THE CANDY AND SKIP THE
VEGETABLES IS OUR FEAR AND
CONCERN. AND THE WAY THAT THE
BILL IS WRITTEN, THE OPTIONALITY
IS ONE DIRECTIONAL WHERE THE
PERSONAL FINANCE BECOMES A
REQUIREMENT AND THE ECONOMICS
COURSES AT THE EXPENSE. IF
THERE'S SOME WAY TO MEDIATE
THAT, WE'D BE HAPPY TO SUPPORT.
AND SO, YOU KNOW, SO ON THAT
NOTE, LET ME LET ME WEIGH IN. I
LET ME SAY REALLY CLEARLY, I'M A
HUGE ADMIRER OF THE WORK THAT,
CC DOES AND, AND I AND I
APPRECIATE THIS TENSION THAT
THEY'VE POINTED TO BETWEEN
ECONOMICS AS A FOUNDATIONAL
DISCIPLINE AND PERSONAL FINANCE,
WHICH CLEARLY, YOU KNOW, THERE'S
A NEED, THERE'S A BACKDROP TO
THIS THAT I'D LIKE YOU TO SPEAK
TO. ASSEMBLY MEMBER. AND THAT'S
THE BALLOT INITIATIVE. AND I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT HERE. HOW
SHOULD WE HOW SHOULD WE CONSIDER
YOUR BILL IN LIGHT OF THE
PROSPECTIVE BALLOT INITIATIVE
THAT WOULD FORCE THIS INTO THE
CURRICULUM? IT'S A COMPROMISE,
SIMPLE AS THAT. THE PROPONENT
HAS BEEN WORKING WITH OUR BILL
FOR TWO YEARS AS WELL, WE
REMOVED OPPOSITION FROM THE ED
COALITION ORGANIZATIONS. WE
REALIZED THERE'S SOME EDUCATORS
HERE WHO DON'T SUPPORT IT, BUT
TEACHERS GROUPS, CTA, CFT ARE
NEUTRAL. THE ACCESS, THE SBA,
ALL THE OTHERS. WE'VE WE'VE
WE'VE WORKED ON THE ISSUE AND WE
REDUCED THE COST TREMENDOUSLY.
HAVING MULTIPLE OUT YEARS IN
IMPLEMENTATION. SO I THINK, AS
I'M SURE YOU APPRECIATE TO THE
LEGISLATURE, DOES A BETTER JOB
IN CRAFTING POLICY AND WORKING
OUT THE ISSUES THAN SOMETIMES
THE VOTERS ON JUST UNDERSTOOD.
I'M NOT SURE THAT'S TRUE, BUT IT
IS OBJECTIVELY TRUE THAT IT'S
MUCH HARDER TO MODIFY A BALLOT
PROPOSITION INSTIGATED CHANGE TO
ANY POLICY. AND I THINK I THINK
THAT IS TRULY IMPORTANT HERE.
AND THAT IS THE CONTEXT, BY THE
WAY, YOU KNOW, WHICH WHICH WE'RE
HAVING THIS CONVERSATION, WHICH
IS, YOU KNOW, SHOULD THIS, PASS
AT THE BALLOT, IT'S SO MUCH
HARDER TO AT THAT POINT TO MAKE
MODIFICATIONS OR AMENDMENTS TO
THAT THAN IT IS TO DO IF WE DO
IT LEGISLATIVELY. SO I THINK THE
GOAL HERE IS IF THIS BILL
PASSES, UNDERSTOOD. SPEED IT UP
IN THE NEXT NINE DAYS. I JUST
WANT TO MAKE THAT EXPLICIT.
THERE'S THE OPPORTUNITY TO PULL
IT OFF THE BALLOT BY, AS WE
KNOW, THE 27TH. I APPRECIATE
THAT, BUT BUT I DO THINK THAT
CONVERSATION ABOUT HOW TO FIND
SPACE IN THE DAY AND PRIORITIES
WITHIN OUR BUDGET AND CURRICULA
FOR ECONOMICS, IN ADDITION TO
PERSONAL FINANCE, THESE TWO
THINGS ARE NOT ONLY NOT MUTUALLY
EXCLUSIVE, THEY'RE SYMBIOTIC.
AND, YOU KNOW, AGAIN, I THINK
THAT THE WORK THAT THE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL ON ECONOMIC
EDUCATION PROVES THAT IN SOME
REALLY IMPRESSIVE WAYS. SO THANK
YOU. THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
I'M GLAD TO SUPPORT THE BILL
TODAY. DO WE HAVE A MOTION, WITH
THE CAVEAT THAT SENATOR GLAZER
DOES LIKE HE MAKES THE MOTION.
AND I WANT TO I WANT YOU TO BE.
I MEAN, IT'S SORT OF INFERRED
HERE, BUT YOU DID ACCEPT THE
AMENDMENTS. YES. YES. OKAY.
APPRECIATE THAT, AND WE HAVE A
MOTION FROM, FROM THE HANDYMAN,
SENATOR GLAZER, MADAM STOLTMAN,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL WHILE ITEM
23 AB 2927. CARDI, THE MOTION IS
TO PASS, AS AMENDED, TO SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. NEWMAN
NEWMAN. I OTOBO CORTEZ. CORTESE
I. GLASER. GLASER I. GONZALEZ.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS I. WILK. WILK I. ALL
RIGHT THEN. MEASURE CURRENTLY
HAS SIX VOTES AND WE WILL LEAVE
IT OPEN FOR THE MISSING MEMBER.
THANK YOU TO ALL THE WITNESSES,
ESPECIALLY THE CCE FOLKS. GOOD
TO SEE YOU. ALL RIGHT. SO WE'RE
GOING TO GO AND ASSUME MIMICRY.
I'M REALLY SORRY. I KNOW YOU'VE
BEEN WAITING A LONG TIME, BUT
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BERMAN IS
ACTUALLY AHEAD IN FILE ORDER AND
HAS A COUPLE OF OBLIGATIONS. MY
APOLOGIES, SIR, BUT. BUT WE'RE
AT NOON. I WANT TO REMIND
EVERYBODY THAT WE HAVE A HARD
STOP. NO LATER THAN ONE. WE
ACTUALLY ACTUALLY SHOULD GET
DONE SOONER THAN THAT TO ALLOW
FOR THE CHANGE OVER HERE. FOR
THOSE OF YOU WHO LISTEN TO YOUR
PODCAST FASTER THAN NORMAL,
LET'S DO THESE BILLS. IN THE
SAME SPIRIT. THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR. ASSEMBLYMEMBER, CAREER
WILL BE VERY QUICK. I REGRET
LETTING ASSEMBLYMEMBER MCCARTY
GO IN FRONT OF ME. AB 2057 WOULD
BUILD UPON MY PREVIOUS TRANSFER
LEGISLATION, AB 928, WHICH
ESTABLISHED THE ASSOCIATE DEGREE
FOR TRANSFER INTERSEGMENTAL
IMPLEMENTATION COMMITTEE TO
FACILITATE GREATER COORDINATION
BETWEEN OUR HIGHER EDUCATION
SEGMENTS. THIS PAST DECEMBER,
THE COMMITTEE, WHICH INCLUDES
STUDENT INSTITUTIONAL AND
FACULTY REPRESENTATIVES,
RELEASED A REPORT WITH NUMEROUS
RECOMMENDATIONS. THIS BILL WOULD
ENACT FIVE LOW COST AND HIGH
IMPACT RECOMMENDATIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE REPORT. THESE
RECOMMENDATIONS WOULD SET GOALS
FOR INCREASING TRANSFER RATES
AND WOULD IMPROVE TRANSFER FOR
HIGH UNIT STEM MAJORS. AB 2057
WOULD ALSO EXTEND THE COMMITTEE
BY TWO YEARS TO CONTINUE STUDENT
CENTERED EFFORTS TO IMPROVE
TRANSFER. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. AND TO
YOUR WITNESSES, MR. RAMIREZ. OR
GO AHEAD. ANY ORDER? I'M GOOD. I
WILL KICK US OFF. AND I THINK I
HAVE THE PLEASURE OF BEING THE
FIRST TO SAY GOOD AFTERNOON
INSTEAD OF GOOD MORNING. DON'T
REMIND US. I WILL. I WILL MOVE
US ALONG MUCH. GOOD AFTERNOON,
CHAIR NEWMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS JOSH
HAGEN, AND I'M THE DIRECTOR OF
POLICY AND ADVOCACY FOR THE
CAMPAIGN FOR COLLEGE
OPPORTUNITY, A POLICY RESEARCH
AND ADVOCACY ORGANIZATION
DEDICATED TO ENSURING THAT ALL
CALIFORNIA FANS HAVE AN EQUAL
OPPORTUNITY TO ATTEND AND
SUCCEED IN COLLEGE. I'LL KEEP MY
REMARKS BRIEF, NOTING THAT THESE
RECOMMENDATIONS IN THIS BILL
WERE UNANIMOUSLY APPROVED BY THE
AB. 928 INTERSEGMENTAL COMMITTEE
AND JUST BRIEFLY HIGHLIGHT THE
STEM UNIT THRESHOLD COMPONENT OF
THIS BILL FOR THE FIRST TIME IN
THE NEARLY 15 YEAR HISTORY OF
THE ASSOCIATE DEGREE FOR
TRANSFER, OR ADT, AB 2057
PROVIDES AN OPPORTUNITY TO
BROADEN THIS PROVEN TRANSFER
PATHWAY TO BETTER ACCOMMODATE
HIGH UNIT STEM MAJORS. ALIGNING
STREAMLINED PATHWAYS TO TRANSFER
TO MEET CALIFORNIA'S EVOLVING
WORKFORCE DEMANDS. THIS
REASONABLE ADJUSTMENT TO THE ADT
FOR HIGH UNIT STEM MAJORS OF UP
TO SIX ADDITIONAL UNITS,
VALIDATED WITH SUFFICIENT
SUPPORTING EVIDENCE, IS A
PARTICULARLY TIMELY INTERVENTION
IN THE WAKE OF LAST SUMMER'S US
SUPREME COURT DECISION TO
CURTAIL THE RACE OF THE USE OF
RACE CONSCIOUS COLLEGE
ADMISSIONS IN THE AFTERMATH OF
PROPOSITION 209 BEING ENACTED,
WHICH LIMITED CALIFORNIA'S
ABILITY TO ENACT RACE CONSCIOUS
POLICY, OUR HIGHER EDUCATION
INSTITUTIONS SAU THE ENROLLMENT
OF BLACK AND LATINX STUDENTS
PLUMMET DRAMATICALLY,
PARTICULARLY IN STEM PATHWAYS.
AS WE ANTICIPATE A SIMILAR
CHILLING EFFECT IN THE WAKE OF
THIS SUPREME COURT DECISION ON
AB 2057 PROVIDES A TIMELY AND
SALIENT SET OF INTERVENTIONS TO
ENSURE ACCESS TO STEM PATHWAYS
AND ESTABLISHES CLEAR GOALS TO
ENSURE THE CONTINUED PROGRESS IN
OUR EFFORTS TO CLOSE RACIAL AND
ETHNIC EQUITY GAPS IN TRANSFER.
THANK YOU. AND WE RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU,
NEXT, PLEASE. GOOD AFTERNOON,
CHAIR NEWMAN AND SENATORS. MY
NAME IS DAVID RAMIREZ. I SERVE
AS THE GOVERNMENT RELATIONS
CHAIR FOR THE UC STUDENT
ASSOCIATION, AND I ALSO SERVE AS
THE GOVERNOR'S STUDENT APPOINTED
MEMBER ON THE AB. 928
INTERSEGMENTAL IMPLEMENTATION
COMMITTEE, WHICH THIS BILL
INTENDS TO EXTEND BY TWO YEARS.
THIS COMMITTEE WAS HAS CREATED A
FORUM FOR THE THREE PUBLIC
HIGHER EDUCATION SEGMENTS AND
THE PRIVATE INSTITUTIONS TO
DISCUSS WHAT IT WOULD MEAN TO
IMPLEMENT THE SINGULAR
GUARANTEED TRANSFER PATHWAY,
ALBEIT DIFFICULT AT TIMES. THE
WORK OF THIS COMMITTEE HAS
PRODUCED THE FINAL REPORT OF
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT WE BELIEVE
WOULD RESULT IN AN EQUITABLE AND
TIMELY TRANSFER PATHWAY,
INCLUDING SHORTENING
HISTORICALLY LENGTHY STEM
PATHWAYS. THE FINAL REPORT WAS
APPROVED BY THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERSHIP, CREATING CONSENSUS
FOR THE FIRST TIME AMONG THE
FOUR SEGMENTS OF HIGHER
EDUCATION, INCLUDING THE
INDEPENDENT, NONPROFIT COLLEGES.
ON A MAJORITY OF THE TANGIBLE
RECOMMENDATIONS SET FORTH IN THE
FINAL REPORT TO IMPROVE OUR
TRANSFER PATHWAYS. RECOGNIZING
THE HISTORICAL GAP IN
INTERSEGMENTAL COORDINATION. TO
THIS DAY, THE COMMITTEE
CONTINUES TO BE THE ONLY PLACE
WHERE ALL FOUR SEGMENTS CONVENE
IN A PUBLICLY ACCESSIBLE FORUM
TO DISCUSS AND COORDINATE
IMPROVEMENTS IN OUR TRANSFER
PATHWAYS. JUST LAST WEEK, WE
CONVENED AT UCLA TO CONTINUE THE
WORK OF DEVELOPING THE
COMMUNICATIONS PLAN THAT WILL BE
TRANSMITTED TO OUR
PRACTITIONERS, COUNSELORS, AND
STUDENT FACING PROFESSIONALS
ABOUT HOW TO CONVEY THE BENEFITS
OF THE ASSOCIATE DEGREE FOR
TRANSFER FOR ALL KINDS OF
STUDENTS. WE HEARD FROM A PANEL
OF STUDENTS WHO WERE FORMERLY
INCARCERATED, UNDOCUMENTED
PARENTING, AND WERE
NONTRADITIONAL IN AGE. THE
FEEDBACK OF COMMITTEE MEMBERS
WAS CONSISTENTLY THIS THAT
STUDENT EXPERIENCES NEED TO
INFORM AND DRIVE OUR WORK. WE
NEED COMMITTEES LIKE THIS TO
CONTINUE TO REMIND THE SYSTEM
LEADERS ABOUT WHAT IT MEANS TO
CREATE A SYSTEM THAT IS TRULY
CENTERED, STUDENT CENTERED. AND
WITH THAT, I RESPECTFULLY URGE
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. ANY
OTHER WITNESSES TO SUPPORT? I
SEE AT LEAST ONE. PLEASE COME
FORWARD. GOOD AFTERNOON, MR.
CHAIR. MEMBERS Dð ASPIRE AND
STRONG SUPPORT. AND TO MY FRIEND
DAVID GO, BRUINS. THANK YOU. HI,
CAROL GONZALEZ ON BEHALF OF HOPE
HISPANAS ORGANIZED FOR POLITICAL
EQUALITY AND THE EDUCATION TRUST
WAS IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON. GENESIS
GONZALEZ, ON BEHALF OF
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR ELENI
KOUNALAKIS, AS A PROUD
CO-SPONSOR IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. ANY ANY
OPPOSITION HERE TODAY IN
RESPONSE TO THIS MEASURE, NOT
SEEING ANY. IS THAT GOOD? THAT'S
YOUR CLOSE. SENATOR WILK, AS A
QUICK ASIDE, I LOVE YOU ROCKING
THE MICHAEL JACKSON LOOK. IT'S
THANKS. SO THAT'S GOOD. SO I I'M
I'M MOVING THE BILL I LOVE THE
BILL. YOU KNOW 64 YEARS AGO IS
WHEN WE ADOPTED, CALIFORNIA'S
MASTER PLAN FOR HIGHER
EDUCATION. AND IF YOU GO BACK
AND YOU READ THAT I HAVEN'T READ
IT IN A LONG TIME, BUT I'VE READ
IT A COUPLE OF TIMES. THEY'RE
TALKING ABOUT THE CHALLENGES OF
TRANSFERRING FROM BACK THEN IT
WAS JUNIOR COLLEGE, TO UC OR
CSU. AND I THANK YOU FOR
CONTINUING TO WORK ON THIS. AND
YOU THINK AFTER 64 YEARS WE
COULD GET IT RIGHT, BUT WE WILL
ONE DAY. WE WILL APPRECIATE
THAT. ANYWAY. THANK YOU.
APPRECIATE YOU. SOMEDAY, THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WILL BE 64 YEARS
OLD. THAT'S A LONG WAY OFF. I
HOPE YOUR MOTION. ANYBODY ELSE,
WE DO A MOTION. WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE? I APPRECIATE THE
CONVERSATION. APPRECIATE MY
WITNESSES. RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR.
I VOTE. WE HAVE A MOTION FOR
SENATOR WILK. PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL FILE. ITEM NINE, AB 2057.
BERMAN. MOTION IS Dð PASSED A
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
NEWMAN. A NEWMAN I OKOBOJI.
OKOBOJI. CORTEZ CORTEZ I GLASER.
GONZALEZ SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS I WILK I WILK
I. THAT MEASURE HAS FIVE VOTES
AT FIVE. CURRENTLY HAS FIVE.
WE'LL LEAVE IT OPEN. THANK YOU
TO THE WITNESSES, AND THANK YOU
TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER CARRILLO FOR
BEING SO PATIENT. I'M SORRY WE
KEPT YOU WAITING. I SAW YOU
EARLIER AND THAT I DIDN'T SEE
YOU AGAIN. AND YOU CAME SO CLOSE
TO GETTING IN SO EARLY, SO THIS
IS LIKE GOING TO DMV ONCE IN A
WHILE. IT WORKS OUT. SOMETIMES
IT DOESN'T. I'M SORRY. SO AT
YOUR LEISURE HERE. THANK YOU,
MR. CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
THANKS FOR LETTING ME BE HERE IN
FRONT OF YOU TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY
BILL 2245, CAREER TECHNICAL
EDUCATION IS AN ASSET TO PEOPLE
FROM ALL WALKS OF LIFE. WHILE MY
BILL WILL DO IS PROVIDE THE
TEACHERS PERMANENT STATUS FOR
SENATOR GLAZIER'S SHOP CLASS AS
HE TALKED A LOT ABOUT SHOP
CLASS, PEOPLE MAY TAKE K¾T
CLASSES TO GET THEIR FOOT IN THE
DOOR OF A SPECIFIC VOCATION OR
IMPROVE AN EXISTING SKILL SET.
THIS IS ESPECIALLY IMPORTANT FOR
RURAL DISTRICTS LIKE MINE, WHERE
BUILDING A LOCAL WORKFORCE IS
IMPERATIVE TO JOB CREATION AND
ECONOMIC GROWTH IN THE REGION.
GIVEN THE LIFE CHANGING
OPPORTUNITIES THAT CTE CAN
PROVIDE. RETAINING THESE
WORKFORCE IS ESPECIALLY
IMPORTANT. UNFORTUNATELY, THERE
ARE THERE REMAIN GAPS IN THE
RIGHTS AFFORDED TO THESE CTE
TEACHERS. CURRENTLY, ONLY OLDER
TRADITIONAL CTE TEACHERS
EMPLOYED BY A SCHOOL DISTRICT
MAY BE GRANTED PERMANENT STATUS
WHEN EMPLOYEES ARE ABLE TO BE
PERMANENT, THIS MEANS THEY ARE
NO LONGER EMPLOYED AT WILL AND
CAN RECEIVE DUE PROCESS.
PERMANENCY ALLOWS FOR BASIC
LABOR RIGHTS SUCH AS A NOTICE OF
DISCIPLINE OR LAYOFF, AND
PROCEDURES FOR APPEAL. IT DOES
NOT MEAN THAT THE TEACHER CANNOT
BE TERMINATED FOR CAUSE OR IF
THEIR PROGRAM IS CANCELED OR
REDUCED. THOUGH THIS MAY SEEM
LIKE VERY BASIC PROTECTIONS, CTE
TEACHERS WHO WORK AT REGIONAL
OCCUPATIONAL CENTERS AND
PROGRAMS DO NOT HAVE THEM. THIS
CREATES A SITUATION WHERE THESE
TEACHERS HAVE NO CERTAINTY ABOUT
THEIR EMPLOYMENT, ARE DIFFICULT
TO RETAIN, AND RELUCTANT TO
BEGIN AND STAY WORKING. TO BE
CLEAR, NOTHING IN THIS BILL DOES
PREVENT EMPLOYERS FROM LAYING
OFF EMPLOYEES DUE TO CHANGES IN
FUNDING OR STUDENT NEEDS. IT IS
SIMPLY REQUIRES THEM TO FOLLOW
THE PROCESS WHEN THEY DO SO.
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT THE
IMPORTANCE OF CTE PROGRAMS, WE
MUST START BY RETAINING AND
PROTECTING THE CTE WORKFORCE.
WHO IS THE SOLE FOUNDATION OF
DRIVING THE DRIVING FORCE OF
KEEPING THESE PROGRAMS AVAILABLE
FOR STUDENTS? WE NEED TO REMIND
OURSELVES THAT WITHOUT TEACHERS,
OUR STUDENTS ARE UNABLE TO
THRIVE AND ACCESS HANDS ON
TRAINING PROGRAMS. SOME MIGHT
SAY THAT THIS BILL WOULD REDUCE
CTE PROGRAMS, WHICH IS NOT TRUE,
AND ANECDOTAL. THIS PROGRAMING
WILL EVENTUALLY BECOME AN
APPEALING IF WE DON'T ENSURE
MORE TEACHERS CAN JOIN THE
PROFESSION AND HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO INVEST AND STAY
IN THE CASE. IN THAT CASE, WE'LL
RISK LOSING THESE PROGRAMS ALL
TOGETHER. JOINING ME TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF AB 2245 ARE KATIE
HARDMAN, LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE
FOR THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION, AND MICHAEL
PEDERSEN, GRAPHIC DESIGN TEACHER
FROM CANYON HILLS HIGH SCHOOL IN
THE SAN DIEGO UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT. THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
WELCOME SIR. HI. MY NAME IS
MICHAEL PETERSON. I'M A GRAPHIC
DESIGN TEACHER AT SAN DIEGO
CANYON HILLS HIGH SCHOOL IN SAN
DIEGO UNIFIED. I JUST COMPLETED
MY 22ND YEAR TEACHING AT THAT
SAME SCHOOL, TEACHING THE SAME
SUBJECTS, AND I'M EXCITED TO
ADVOCATE FOR THIS BILL. THE
HUNDREDS OF CTE TEACHERS LIKE ME
IN MY DISTRICT ARE TREATED AS
SECOND CLASS CITIZENS, DESPITE
MANY OF US HAVING DECADES OF
TEACHING AND INDUSTRY
EXPERIENCE. WE'RE ON A YEAR TO
YEAR CONTRACT AND LIVE IN
UNCERTAINTY THAT OTHER TEACHERS
DO NOT FACE. WILL WE HAVE HEALTH
INSURANCE FOR OUR FAMILIES? WILL
WE HAVE A JOB IN THE FOLLOWING
SUMMER AFTER THE SUMMER? THIS IS
NOT EQUITABLE. WE PROVIDE
STUDENTS INDUSTRY KNOWLEDGE FOR
HIGH DEMAND JOBS AS WELL AS
COLLEGE CREDIT FOR OUR COURSES.
STUDENTS AND CLASSES LIKE
BIOMED, CULINARY ARTS,
ENGINEERING, DIGITAL MEDIA AND
EVEN AUTO SHOP. I GREATLY
BENEFIT FROM OUR INDUSTRY
EXPERIENCE AND EXPERTISE AS WELL
AS INSTRUCTIONAL KNOWLEDGE. YET
WE HAVE NO OPPORTUNITY FOR
PERMANENT STATUS LIKE ALL OTHER
TEACHERS ON OUR CAMPUS. HOW IS
THIS EQUITABLE? IN 2012, I WAS
OUR DISTRICT'S HIGH SCHOOL
TEACHER OF THE YEAR RUNNER UP,
AND THE WOMAN WHO WON FIRST
PLACE. WE WERE BOTH CTE TEACHERS
. AT OUR AWARDS CEREMONY, WE
TALKED ABOUT HOW IRONIC IT WAS
TO RECEIVE SUCH ACCOLADES WHEN
WE ALSO RECEIVED A LETTER A
MONTH EARLIER THANKING US FOR
OUR TEMPORARY SERVICE AT THAT
POINT IN TIME, WE'D BEEN
TEACHING FOR OVER A DECADE THIS
INEQUITY NOT ONLY AFFECTS US
TEACHERS, BUT IT IMPACTS OUR
STUDENTS AS WELL. MOST OF US ARE
PART OF A CAREER PATHWAY WHERE
STUDENTS TAKE 2 TO 3 CLASSES IN
ONE INDUSTRY SECTOR. WE'RE
TEACHING THESE STUDENTS FOR
MULTIPLE YEARS, ALLOWS ME TO
INDIVIDUALIZE MY INSTRUCTION AND
TRULY BUILD TRUST AND
CONNECTIONS WITH STUDENTS. THIS
IS THE MOST AMAZING PART OF MY
ENTIRE JOB. THESE POWERFUL
RELATIONSHIPS AND VALUABLE
INSTRUCTIONAL INSIGHTS ARE AT
RISK EVERY YEAR BECAUSE OF OUR
INABILITY TO EARN PERMANENT
STATUS. EVEN AFTER TEACHING FOR
2 TO 3 DECADES, THE THIS LACK OF
CONTINUITY CLEARLY HAS ADVERSE
EFFECTS ON STUDENTS, BOTH
ACADEMICALLY AND EMOTIONALLY. ON
BEHALF OF OUR STUDENTS AND MY
CTE COLLEAGUES, I ASK THAT YOU
VOTE YES ON THIS BILL THAT WILL
ENSURE EQUITABLE TREATMENT OF
ALL TEACHERS AND PROVIDE
CONSISTENT CÁC FOR OUR STUDENTS
THAT DESERVE THIS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, MISS HARDIMAN.
WELCOME GOOD AFTERNOON, MR.
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS,
KATIE HARDIMAN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION.
K¾T IS A PROUD CO-SPONSOR OF
THIS BILL, ALONG WITH CFT. AND I
WANT TO THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CARRILLO FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD. AND OUR WITNESS FOR
COMING UP FROM SAN DIEGO. AND
HE'S VERY PASSIONATE ABOUT THIS
ISSUE. AS YOU KNOW, MOST
TEACHERS ARE PROVIDED THE
OPPORTUNITY TO OBTAIN PERMANENT
STATUS AFTER THEY COMPLETE THEIR
PROBATIONARY PERIOD. THAT MEANS
THAT THEY ARE PROVIDED WITH
CERTAIN JOB PROTECTIONS AND DUE
PROCESS IF DISAGREEMENTS ARISE,
HOWEVER, WE'VE HEARD FROM MANY
TEACHERS ACROSS THE STATE THAT
THESE PROTECTIONS ARE NOT
PROVIDED TO ALL EDUCATORS.
CERTAIN TEACHERS ARE EXCLUDED,
INCLUDING CAREER TECHNICAL
EDUCATION TEACHERS AND REGIONAL
OCCUPATIONAL CENTERS, THIS BILL
WILL CHANGE THAT TO PROVIDE
THOSE EMPLOYEES WITH THE SAME
OPPORTUNITY AS OTHER TEACHERS IN
OBTAINING PERMANENT STATUS. CTA
BELIEVES ALL TEACHERS SHOULD BE
TREATED AS PROFESSIONALS AND
AFFORDED DUE PROCESS RIGHTS,
REGARDLESS OF WHAT SUBJECT THEY
TEACH, AS THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MENTIONED, THIS BILL DOES NOT
PREVENT SCHOOL DISTRICTS FROM
LAYING OFF STAFF OR ELIMINATING
PROGRAMS DUE TO CHANGING
INDUSTRY NEEDS, THERE IS A
PROCESS IN PLACE FOR THAT, WE
ARE JUST, YOU KNOW, ASKING THAT
THEY SIMPLY, TEACHERS ARE
TREATED FAIRLY AND
PROFESSIONALLY IN THAT PROCESS,
AS YOU KNOW, MANY OF OUR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ARE EXPERIENCING
UNPRECEDENTED TEACHER AND
STAFFING SHORTAGES, ESPECIALLY
IN THE CTE AREAS. AND THIS BILL
WILL PROVIDE MORE STABILITY FOR
OUR TEACHER WORKFORCE, WHICH WE
KNOW IS BETTER FOR STUDENTS. SO
I ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT. THANKS.
THANK YOU, OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC IN SUPPORT. WELCOME.
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. AND
MEMBERS, JASON BROWN OF CFT, A
PROUD CO-SPONSOR OF THIS BILL
ASKING FOR YOUR I VOTE THIS
MORNING. THANK YOU. ANYBODY
ELSE, OPPOSITION. IS THERE
ANYBODY HERE WHO'D LIKE TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION TO THE MEASURE?
PLEASE COME FORWARD.
WELCOME TO BOTH OF YOU, YOU EACH
HAVE THREE MINUTES, PLEASE
PROCEED. ONE READY. GOOD
AFTERNOON, CHAIRMAN NEWMAN AND,
SENATE EDUCATION COMMITTEE. MY
NAME IS FABRIZIO LOFARO, AND I'M
THE SUPERINTEND FOR VALLEY
REGIONAL OCCUPATIONAL PROGRAM.
AND WE SERVE, 9000 STUDENTS IN
FRESNO, TULARE AND KINGS
COUNTIES. I'VE BEEN WITH LAUP
FOR 22 YEARS. I STARTED MY
CAREER THERE AS A TEACHER, AND I
REMAIN WITH LAUP. I WANT TO
EXPRESS MY CONCERN ABOUT AB
2245, THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE
ESTABLISHED ROP PROGRAMS BACK IN
THE 70S TO CREATE A FLEXIBLE AND
ADAPTABLE PROGRAM FOR STUDENTS
SERVING MULTIPLE STUDENTS WITH
MAXIMUM FLEXIBILITY. THEY LABOR
THE LABOR MARKET CHANGES ALL THE
TIME. OUR SUCCESS IS EVIDENT,
OUR PROGRAMS ARE FLOURISHING,
AND THE MOST RELEVANT DUE TO THE
TO THE ABILITY TO EVOLVE WITH
THE JOB MARKET. ALRP PROGRAMS
ARE ESSENTIAL AND HAVE BEEN
REMARKABLY SUCCESSFUL IN
PREPARING STUDENTS FOR THE
FUTURE WORKFORCE. ADDITIONALLY,
OUR OPP'S REGIONAL OCCUPATIONAL
PROGRAMS OPERATE IN AN
ENVIRONMENT OF ECONOMIC
UNCERTAINTIES, RELYING HEAVILY
ON COMPETITIVE GRANTS THAT ARE
AWARDED YEAR BY YEAR. SINCE THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE LOCAL
CONTROL FORMULA, LCFF HAS NO
DIRECT STATE FUNDING HAS BEEN
ALLOCATED TO OUR ÁP SINCE 2011,
GUARANTEEING PERMANENCY FOR OUR
TEACHERS UNDER THESE CONDITIONS
IS COUNTERPRODUCTIVE OR
COUNTERINTUITIVE. BECAUSE OF THE
INCREASE OF FINANCIAL
COMMITMENT. WITHOUT INSURANCE,
THE RESOURCES TO SUPPORT THEM.
SCHOOL DISTRICT SUPPORTED BY
GUARANTEED LCFF HAVE A MORE
PREDICTABLE AND STABLE FUNDING
MODEL AND ALLOW DISTRICT TO PLAN
AND IMPLEMENT PERMANENCY
POLICIES WITH GREATER CONFIDENCE
. IN CONCLUSION, I INTEND THE
INTENT OF AB 20 2245 TO SUPPORT
TEACHERS IS COMMENDABLE. IT
OVERLOOKS THE UNIQUE NEEDS OF
K¾T PROGRAM AND ALRP PROGRAMS TO
CONTINUE TO PROVIDE FLEXIBLE,
QUALITY PATHWAYS FOR STUDENTS
WITHOUT DIRECT FUNDING.
PERMANENT STATUS ALONE WILL NOT
ENHANCE THE QUALITY OR
SUSTAINABILITY OF THESE
PROGRAMS. FOR THE STUDENTS.
ADDITIONALLY, THE NEW STATE PLAN
CALLS FOR A NEW DYNAMIC AND
APPROACH TO CTE, AND WE MUST
ENSURE THAT THE POLICIES REFLECT
THAT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
WELCOME GOOD AFTERNOON. MY NAME
IS JULIE DUNCAN, AND I'M
SUPERINTENDENT OF TRI-VALLEY
ROP, WHICH IS ONE OF THE ROPES
THAT SERVES IN THE ALAMEDA
COUNTY DISTRICT. COUNTY. I'M NOT
HERE TO OPPOSE OUR TEACHERS
HAVING ACCESS TO DUE PROCESS. I
WANT TO MAKE THAT REALLY CLEAR.
IN THE LAYOFF PROCESS. IN FACT,
WE BELIEVE OUR TEACHERS ARE MORE
A PART OF OUR ANNUAL MASTER
SCHEDULING PROCESS THAN MOST OF
OUR TRADITIONAL DISTRICTS. AND
LISTENING TO MR. PETERSON, FIRST
OF ALL, THANK YOU. I'M VERY
CONFUSED. THIS BILL IS ABOUT
ROPES AND ROPE CENTERS AND HE IS
A DISTRICT. SO I AM CONFUSED AS
TO WHY A DISTRICT WOULD NOT BE
PUTTING THEM INTO THE PERMANENCY
PIECE. SO THIS BILL IS SPECIFIC
TO ROPES, AND WITH THAT, THE
WORD REGIONAL IS THE KEY THAT
YOU NEED TO HEAR HERE. BECAUSE
WE ARE A REGIONAL, WE WORK IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH OUR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS. AND FOR SOME OF US,
LIKE FABRIZIO, WE'RE TALKING TEN
DIFFERENT SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND
40 DIFFERENT SCHOOL SITES WITH
VARIOUS BELL SCHEDULES, RANGING
FROM ONE HOUR COURSES OF SIX
PERIODS TO OTHER SCHOOL SITES
THAT HAVE A MODIFIED BLOCK WHERE
THEY HAVE THREE CLASSES A DAY,
AND MAYBE ALTERNATING EVERY
OTHER DAY. IN MY CASE WITH MY
HIGH SCHOOL DISTRICTS I SERVE, I
HAVE DIFFERENT BELL SCHEDULES
AND CALENDARS FOR EVERY SINGLE
DISTRICT AND HIGH SCHOOL. THE
DISTRICTS PROVIDE US THE
ENROLLMENT NUMBERS WHEN THEY
SIGN UP FOR OUR CLASSES. WE DO
NOT RECEIVE THOSE NUMBERS TILL
WAY PAST THE MARCH 15TH AND MAY
15TH DEADLINES. NOT BECAUSE THEY
DON'T WANT TO, IT IS BECAUSE IT
TAKES THAT LONG FOR THOSE
PROCESSES TO ACTUALLY HAPPEN AND
GET TO US, BECAUSE WE'RE VERY
SPECIFIC ON WHAT KIDS SIGN UP
FOR IS THE CLASS THAT THEY
ACTUALLY RECEIVE. AND THEN WE
THEN HAVE TO PUT THAT ALL
TOGETHER AND DEVELOP A MASTER
SCHEDULE WHERE TEACHERS AND
STUDENTS TRAVEL BETWEEN THE
SITES VERY, VERY COMPLEX. I LOVE
IT, BUT IT'S VERY, VERY COMPLEX
WITH THE REGIONAL APPROACH AND
LEVERAGING OF THE RESOURCES,
MANY OF THESE PATHWAY OPTIONS
WOULD NOT EXIST AS DISTRICTS
CANNOT AFFORD THESE PROGRAMS
SOLELY ON THEIR OWN. IT'S A
REALLY BIG POINT. I BELIEVE THIS
BILL IS TRYING TO CREATE A
SOLUTION, WHICH I HEARD HERE
TODAY TO ALLEVIATE STRESS AND
GIVE THAT SENSE OF SECURITY.
HOWEVER, WE IN THE ROP WORLD
WILL ACTUALLY THINK IT WILL DO
THE OPPOSITE BECAUSE MY TEACHERS
KNOW I'M HERE TODAY. I'VE HAD
VERSIONS OF THIS BILL FOR MANY
YEARS THAT I HAVE COME TO
TESTIFY. I DON'T WANT TO LOSE
THEM DUE TO THE MARCH 15TH
DEADLINES. YOU MAY SAY, WHY IS
SHE SAYING THAT IF THIS BILL
PASSES, I LITERALLY WILL NOT
HAVE MY NUMBERS BY MARCH 15TH OR
MAY 15TH TO MAKE DECISIONS? IT
ISN'T LIKE WHAT CREDENTIAL THEY
HAVE, WHAT SPECIFIC I WILL HAVE
TO BLANKET PINK SLIP ALL OF
THEM. THESE FOLKS COME FROM
INDUSTRY. WHAT MESSAGE DOES THAT
SEND? THAT'S WHAT I'M TALKING
ABOUT WITH THE OPPOSITE EFFECT,
THIS ANXIETY THAT WOULD BE
CREATED, THAT WASN'T THERE
BEFORE. IT ISN'T A MATTER OF
DECIPHERING CREDENTIALS. WHO'S
MORE QUALIFIED? WE LITERALLY
DON'T HAVE OUR NUMBERS DUE TO
THIS FACTOR. IT'S INTEGRAL THAT
WE INVOLVE OUR INSTRUCTORS IN
POSITIONING. I WORK WITH ALL MY
TEACHERS. WE'RE VERY, VERY CLOSE
. ALL OF OUR DIFFERENT REPS. IN
FACT, THE TIME FRAME, THE TIME
EMPLOYMENT OR TO MAINTAIN THEIR
LEVEL OF WHATEVER PERCENTAGE OF
FTE THEY WERE. SO WE WORK ON
THAT FOR EXAMPLE, SCHOOL SITES
WILL PROVIDE ME WITH
REGISTRATIONS DURING THE MONTH
OF MAY, AND ON PAPER, THERE MAY
BE A FULL TIME. I'M GONNA HAVE
TO ASK YOU TO WRAP UP. OKAY.
THERE MIGHT BE A FULL TIME JOB,
BUT THAT PERSON PHYSICALLY CAN'T
GET TO THREE OR 2 TO 3 DIFFERENT
SITES. SO SO I WILL HAVE TO I'LL
TRY TO FIND SOMETHING FOR THAT
TEACHER SO THAT FULL TIME
ASSIGNMENT, I MIGHT HAVE TO ADD
AN EXTRA SECTION FOR ANOTHER
TEACHER BECAUSE WE'RE REGIONAL.
THIS DOESN'T WORK FOR ROP
PROGRAMS. AND I WOULD ASK YOU IF
YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS YOU'D
LIKE TO ASK FOR A BREEZY OR
NIGHT ON FROM CLARIFICATION ON
THE COMMITTEE BILL, I WOULD LOVE
TO ANSWER THEM. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME. THANK YOU. ANY OTHER
OPPOSITION? I'D LIKE TO WEIGH
IN. SEEING NONE. LET'S COME BACK
TO THE DAIS. COLLEAGUES UP Þ.
WELCOME. SORRY FOR THE DELAY.
OKAY. THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR.
MEMBERS. ANDREA BAHL, ON BEHALF
OF TWO ORGANIZATIONS IN
OPPOSITION, THE CENTRAL VALLEY
EDUCATION COALITION AND THE
ORANGE COUNTY DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION. THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
NEXT, PLEASE. BELLA KERN, ON
BEHALF OF SMALL SCHOOL DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU. STELLA JOHNSON, ON BEHALF
OF THE SCHOOL EMPLOYERS
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA, IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU, LUCY
SALCIDO CARTER WITH THE ALAMEDA
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. RON FRASE
, BOARD MEMBER, DINUBA UNIFIED
TULARE COUNTY IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON.
MEMBERS LEE ANGELA REED, ON
BEHALF OF THE CAREER, THE
ASSOCIATION OF CAREER AND
COLLEGE READINESS ORGANIZATIONS,
ACSA, THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATORS, AND THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION, ALL IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU. NEXT, PLEASE. GOOD
AFTERNOON. LEILANI AGUINALDO. ON
BEHALF OF THE CTE JPA COALITION.
OUR COALITION INCLUDES METRO
EDITOR, NORTH ORANGE COUNTY
REGIONAL OCCUPATIONAL PROGRAM,
AS WELL AS THE COLTON, REDLANDS,
YUCAIPA REGIONAL OCCUPATIONAL
PROGRAM. IN ADDITION, I'M ALSO
TESTIFYING IN OPPOSITION ON
BEHALF OF COASTLINE ROP COLLEGE
AND CAREER ADVANTAGE, EDEN AREA,
MISSION VALLEY, AND TRI CITIES
REGIONAL OCCUPATIONAL PROGRAMS.
THANK YOU. NEXT PLEASE. GOOD
AFTERNOON, BRIANNA SOLIS, ON
BEHALF OF THE OFFICE OF THE
RIVERSIDE COUNTY SUPERINTENDENTS
OF SCHOOLS IN OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU. LETICIA GARCIA, ON BEHALF
OF THE 23 RIVERSIDE COUNTY
SCHOOL DISTRICT SUPERINTENDENTS.
THANK YOU. LET'S LET'S COME BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE. QUESTIONS?
COMMENTS? I WANT TO NOTE, YOU
KNOW, MORE OPPOSITION THAN I
THINK WE WERE LED TO BELIEVE DID
NOT GET LETTERS OR OTHER FORMAL
OPPOSITION FROM MUCH OF THESE
FOLKS. A LITTLE BIT SURPRISED,
CAN I AGREE? IF YOU WOULDN'T
MIND, CHAIR, WE DID SEND IT TO
THE ASSEMBLY SINCE THERE WAS NO
AMENDMENTS MADE. WE THOUGHT
THOSE LETTERS WERE GOING TO BE
TRANSFERRED OVER SO I DO KNOW
THAT OUR CAPITAL ADVISORS AND
SCHOOL SERVICES WERE LED TO
BELIEVE THAT. SO THAT IS WHY YOU
DID NOT APPRECIATE THAT THIS IS
A LITTLE BIT SURPRISING. I THINK
WE WOULD HAVE HAD A NUMBER OF
CONVERSATIONS PRIOR TO THIS
HEARING. BUT THAT BEING THE
CASE, SENATOR BOGUE. SO WE'VE
SEEN SIMILAR BILLS LIKE THIS
COMING IN EVERY SINGLE YEAR
SINCE I'VE BEEN IN EDUCATION,
AND I HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE TO
SUPPORT THE BILLS MOVING
FORWARD. JUST WE HAVE A LOT OF
OPPOSITION FROM MY PERSONAL
DISTRICT BECAUSE WE HAVE A VERY
SUCCESSFUL, VERY ENGAGED RFP
PROGRAMS, WHICH I VISIT. I, I'VE
, YOU KNOW, SPOKEN TO THE
TEACHERS, I'VE SPOKEN TO THE
STUDENTS, TOURED THE SCHOOLS AND
SO FORTH. AND I UNDERSTAND DODD
THE COMPLEXITIES OF HAVING THE
IMPLEMENTATION BE ABLE TO PUT
EVERYTHING TOGETHER, AND
ESPECIALLY WITH REGARDS TO, THE
TEACHERS WHO ARE MANY ARE
INDUSTRY BASED INSTRUCTORS WHO
COME IN AND HAVE TO MEET, YOU
KNOW, THE ASSESSMENT OF WHAT IS
REGIONALLY NEEDED AND COME IN AT
THAT TIME, SEEK THEM OUT AND SO
FORTH. SO THAT'S ONE OF THE
REASONS WHY I HAVEN'T SUPPORTED
I DON'T SUPPORT THE BILL, HAVING
SUPPORTED THE INTENT OF THE BILL
WITHIN THE SCOPE OF RFP, BECAUSE
THEY ARE REGIONAL, THEY ARE
TECHNICAL, THEY ARE OUR INDUSTRY
LED, WHICH FLUCTUATES WITH TIME.
THERE IS NO PERMANENT COMPONENT
TO IT BECAUSE IT'S CONTINUOUSLY
CHANGING. BUT WHAT INTRIGUED ME
TODAY WAS, YOUR TESTIMONY AND
YOUR COMMENT WITH REGARDS TO WHY
HE HIS CAPACITY IS DIFFERENT, IN
COMPARISON TO SOMEONE, A
DIFFERENT TYPE OF INSTRUCTOR. SO
I WAS HOPING THAT IF YOU
WOULDN'T MIND, THROUGH THE
CHAIR, WITH HIS PERMISSION OF
COURSE, IF YOU WOULDN'T MIND
EXPLAINING THE DIFFERENCE AS TO
WHY HE WOULD BE IN A DIFFERENT
CATEGORY THAN IN IN A DIFFERENT,
TEACHER. THANK YOU FOR THAT
QUESTION. SO FIRST, I CAME FROM
INDUSTRY. ALL OUR INSTRUCTORS
COME FROM INDUSTRY, CTE
INSTRUCTORS COME FROM INDUSTRY.
THEY HAVE TO HAVE THAT
BACKGROUND IN ORDER TO EVEN
RECEIVE THE CREDENTIAL. SO JUST
FOR THAT PIECE, FIRST, ONCE
THEY'RE IN, I STARTED WITH
PLEASANTON UNIFIED. I WAS A CTE
TEACHER. I WAS PART OF THE
UNION, I'M PART OF THEIR
BARGAINING. YOU WERE HIRED
WITHIN A DISTRICT THAT WAY
BECAUSE THE DISTRICT HAS CONTROL
OVER THEIR OWN FUNDS. THEY ARE
DIRECTLY FUNDED BY THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA, AND THEY KNOW THEIR
BUDGETS AND THEY KNOW THE THEY
KNOW WHAT THEIR OPERATION LOOKS
LIKE. IT'S ALL GOING TO BE ON
THAT CAMPUS. A REGIONAL
OCCUPATIONAL PROGRAM HAS A CTE
CREDENTIAL AS WELL. HOWEVER,
THOSE TEACHERS, THEY TO COME
FROM INDUSTRY. BUT WE OFFER
CLASSES. OUR STUDENTS COME FROM.
I. I'LL GIVE MY EXAMPLE. I HAVE
STUDENTS THAT GO TO LIVERMORE
FOR AUTO FROM DUBLIN AND
PLEASANTON, AND I DON'T GET ALL
THREE OF THOSE NUMBERS. I DON'T
GET ALL THE DISTRICT NUMBERS. WE
DON'T GET THOSE ENROLLMENT
NUMBERS WAY PAST MARCH 15TH. AND
THAT IS AND WE ALSO ARE
REGIONALLY DOING PROGRAMS THAT
GO TO OUR LABOR MARKET. SO WHEN
THOSE NEEDS COME UP, WE ADDRESS
THOSE RIGHT AWAY. WE'RE ABLE TO
DO THAT VERY, VERY QUICKLY. HOPE
THAT ANSWERS IT JUST A LITTLE
BIT. WHAT THE WHAT THE
DIFFERENCES ARE. WE DON'T
PHYSICALLY WE CAN'T ADHERE TO
MARCH 15TH BECAUSE WE DON'T KNOW
. WE DON'T HAVE ANY FUNDING AT
THAT POINT. OUR DISTRICTS ARE
PART OF OUR DISTRICTS. THEIR
BUDGETS AREN'T EVEN PASSED WITH
LCAP TILL MAY AND JUNE. WE DON'T
EVEN KNOW WHAT THAT'S GOING TO
LOOK LIKE. WE DON'T EVEN KNOW
WHAT OUR MONEY IS GOING TO BE.
WE DON'T EVEN HAVE THE
ENROLLMENT NUMBERS FROM OUR
DISTRICTS FOR THAT TIME. SO
REGIONAL OCCUPATIONAL PROGRAMS,
BECAUSE THE FLEXIBILITY OF THAT,
HOW THE BUDGETS ARE GOING, WE
ALWAYS OUR DECISIONS ARE ALWAYS
MADE INTO JUNE AND GOING INTO
THE SUMMERTIME. SO THOSE ARE THE
DIFFERENCES. THAT'S THAT'S THE
MAIN DIFFERENCE. SO A CT TEACHER
WITHIN A DISTRICT IS WITHIN THAT
DISTRICT BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT
HAVING TO DEAL WITH 40 DIFFERENT
SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND BELL
SCHEDULES AND ALL THAT. I HOPE
THAT ANSWERS YOUR QUESTION A
LITTLE BIT. IF YOU CAN ADD TO
IT. HE'S GOT A LOT MORE
DISTRICTS THAN I DO. IF I COULD
ADD ON TO THAT. ACTUALLY SO THE
EXEMPTION IN EXISTING LAW IS FOR
DIFFERENT TYPES OF PROGRAMS. SO
DISTRICT RUN PROGRAMS, COUNTY
OFFICE RUN PROGRAMS, AND JPA RUN
PROGRAMS. I THINK YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT A COUNTY RUN OR JPA
OPERATED PROGRAM, BUT WE HAVE
DISTRICT RUN PROGRAMS AS WELL,
WHICH IS WHAT, MR. PATTERSON IS
SO I WANTED TO ALSO SAY, I THINK
THAT DATES BACK TO BEFORE WE HAD
LCFF, WHERE WE HAD A CATEGORICAL
FUND FUND FOR ROCK ÁP PROGRAMS
BACK IN 2013. THAT MONEY WAS
ROLLED INTO THE LCFF. SO YOU GET
THE MONEY THROUGH THE LCFF
VERSUS THE CATEGORICAL PROGRAM,
AND THEN TO THE POINT AROUND THE
MARCH 15TH DEADLINE, ALL LEAS
FACE THAT SAME, SORT OF TIMING
ISSUE, RIGHT? THEY HAVE TO DO
PINK SLIPS AT MARCH 15TH, WHEN
THEY DON'T GET THEY DON'T HAVE
THE STATE BUDGET UNTIL, YOU
KNOW, END OF JUNE. SOMETIMES SO
WE RECOGNIZE THERE IS A TIMING
ISSUE, BUT THAT EXISTS SORT OF
FOR ALL LEAS. AND MAY I GO TO
THAT POINT BECAUSE IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT POINT THAT WAS IN THE
BILL, IF YOU'LL ALLOW ME, MR.
CHAIRMAN, IF THAT'S OKAY. I JUST
WANTED TO TALK ABOUT THAT
PARTICULAR ABOUT THE MARCH 15TH
IN BRIEF. SO I HAVE BEEN AND
I'VE BEEN AN ADMINISTRATOR FOR
ON THE DISTRICT SIDE, AS WELL AS
OUR OP, WHEN A DISTRICT KNOWS
THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE TO MAKE
CUTS, 4 MILLION, LET'S SAY THEY
DO THAT BY THE FIRST THING WE
LOOK AT IS WE LOOK AT ALL
TEMPORARY TEACHERS. RIGHT. THAT
IS THAT'S WHAT HAPPENS. THEN WE
LOOK AT WHAT PROGRAMS THEY'RE
NOT LOOKING. WHAT DO KIDS SIGN
UP FOR BECAUSE THEY STILL DON'T
HAVE THAT TYPE OF INFORMATION.
THEY'RE LOOKING AT THE BUDGET IN
TOTALITY THAT THAT'S WHY THEY'RE
ABLE TO DO THAT BY MARCH 15TH.
THEY'RE GOING OFF OF A BIG
NUMBER. THEY'RE TAKING EACH HIGH
SCHOOL AND SAYING, YOU GET 100
SECTIONS. YOU FIGURE THAT OUT,
WHETHER THAT'S 30 KIDS OR 20
KIDS. IT IS NOT THE SAME FOR US.
AND IF I WANTED TO ADD TO THAT
AT ALL, JUST ONE THING ABOUT THE
LCFF, SO WHEN THE LCFF RULING,
WHEN THE FUNDING ROLLED INTO
LCFF, THAT WENT TO THE
DISTRICTS, NOT TO THE RFPS, WE
ARE NOT FUNDED ANYMORE. WE'RE
FUNDED ONLY BY THE GRACE OF THE
DISTRICTS THAT LIKE OUR
PROGRAMS. SO WE USED TO BE
FUNDED WITH ADA, JUST LIKE ALL
THE OTHER DISTRICTS AS WELL. AND
WE'RE NOT ANYMORE. SO THAT
DIRECT FUNDING THAT NOW IS BEING
ROLLED OVER, THE DISTRICT CAN DO
WHAT THEY WANT TO WITH THE
FUNDING. SO I THINK TO SPEND IT
I MEAN, I WOULD AGREE THAT'S A
STRUCTURAL PROBLEM. BUT I MEAN,
CLEARLY THAT'S NOT A PROBLEM
WITH SOUTH HERE TODAY. ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS, SENATOR CHUBBUCK? AND
SO FOR MY PART, I WANT TO MAKE
CLEAR I HAVE SYMPATHY FOR THE
PROBLEM THAT I THINK WE'RE
TRYING TO SOLVE HERE, WHICH IS
AND MR. PETERSEN REPRESENTS THAT
PROBLEM, WHICH IS DECADES OF
SERVICE, AS A SEPARATE CLASS OF
EDUCATOR. AND, YOU KNOW, IT'S
FUNDAMENTALLY UNFAIR. AND SO
FIRST ORDER OF BUSINESS, I
THINK, IS TO ADDRESS THAT AND
THEN TO ADDRESS THE FOLLOW ON
COMPLICATIONS THAT ARISE OUT OF
THAT. I THINK THE LEGISLATURE
DOES HAVE AN OBLIGATION TO DO
THAT, YOU KNOW, FOR LOTS OF
REASONS, NOT THE LEAST OF WHICH
IS TO LET FOLKS MAKE PLANS AND,
AND FUND PROGRAMS AS NECESSARY.
TO MISS HARTMAN'S POINT, THERE
ARE PROVISIONS FOR MAKING,
STAFFING CHANGES RIGHT AS, AS
NEEDED, AND SO ANY OTHER
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS?
YOU KNOW, AGAIN, I THINK THESE
THINGS WIND UP BEING IN A
SEQUENCE WE SOLVE FOR A
PARTICULAR PROBLEM, THEN WE
ADDRESS THE OTHER ISSUES AROUND
THAT. THIS PROBLEM, I DO
BELIEVE, NEEDS SOLVING. I THINK
THESE EDUCATORS ARE AS DESERVING
AS ANYBODY OF THE RESPECT AND
SECURITY THAT SHOULD COME WITH
BEING A DEDICATED TEACHER, AND I
RESPECT THAT'S WHAT YOU'RE
TRYING TO DO HERE. AND I WANT TO
I WANT TO THEN STIPULATE THAT WE
THEN HAVE TO FIGURE OUT IN SO
MANY OTHER WAYS HOW TO MAKE
CALIFORNIA'S EDUCATION SYSTEM
WORK. AND IT IS HUGELY COMPLEX,
LCFF AND OTHER KIND OF PROP 98
DRIVEN ISSUES HAVE MADE IT IN
SOME CASES, MORE COMPLEX RATHER
THAN LESS AS WE'VE ASPIRED
TOWARD EQUITY AND A BUNCH OF
OTHER GOALS, AND I'M ALWAYS
IMPRESSED THAT, YOU KNOW,
PARENTS SAY TO ME, WHY IS IT SO
COMPLICATED? AND AS IT RELATES
TO, TECHNICAL EDUCATION, IT
SHOULDN'T BE, ESPECIALLY GIVEN
THE NEEDS OF THE ECONOMY. AND SO
I RESPECT WHAT ALL THE REPS DO.
I HAVE AN EQUAL MEASURE OF
RESPECT FOR THE FOR THE TEACHERS
WHO PARTICIPATE WITHIN THAT. AND
I THINK THIS BILL IS ABOUT
RECOGNIZING THAT VALUE. AND THEN
IT IS OUR OBLIGATION TO SOLVE
FOR THOSE OTHER PROBLEMS FROM
THERE, ANY OTHER QUESTIONS?
COMMENTS. HAPPY TO MOVE THE
BILL. I'VE GOT A MOTION FROM
SENATOR SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS, AND
WITH THAT, MADAM CONSULTANT,
PLEASE, PLEASE CLOSE. I'M SORRY.
WELL, THANK YOU FOR THE
DISCUSSION. AND, YOU KNOW, I DO
SEE A SHIFT IN THE INTEREST IN
VOCATIONAL CAREERS. NOW, THE WAY
THAT OUR WORKFORCE IS, MOVING ON
TO RETIREMENT THROUGHOUT
DIFFERENT PROFESSIONS AND
CAREERS, I SEE THE BENEFIT OF
SUPPORTING THE VOCATIONAL
CAREERS BECAUSE WE'VE INVESTED
IN THAT. WE'VE INVESTED IN K¾T
PROGRAMS, AND WE DON'T SUPPORT
THE TEACHERS THAT ARE DOING
THIS. I THINK THAT WE ARE GOING
TO BE SETTING FOR FAILURE IN NOT
PREPARING THE WORKFORCE THAT IS
NEEDED. NOW, WITH THAT, I JUST
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND
MADAM CONSULT, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL WHILE. ITEM 16 AB 2245,
JUAN CARRILLO. THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED THE SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. NEWMAN NEWMAN I OKOBO
OKOBO. NO CORTEZ. CORTEZ I.
GLASER. GONZALEZ SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS I WILK
. THAT MEASURE HAS THREE VOTES.
WE'LL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. AND THANK YOU TO
THE WITNESS. THIS THIS
CONVERSATION WILL BE CONTINUED
IN LOTS OF DIFFERENT WAYS,
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BAINS, WELCOME.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE.
YOU MAY PROCEED WHEN READY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU.
CHAIRMAN, I'D LIKE TO START BY
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE'S
SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS TO ALLOW
THE LEGISLATURE TO APPROPRIATE
FUNDING FROM THE ENDOWMENT FUND
TO THE èC FOR THE PURPOSE OF
CONDUCTING A FEASIBILITY STUDY.
AB 2357 CREATES AN ENDOWMENT
FUND WITHIN THE STATE TREASURY
AS A FOUNDATIONAL FIRST STEP
TOWARDS ESTABLISHING A
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
SCHOOL IN KERN COUNTY, A MEDICAL
SCHOOL WILL PROVIDE THE CATALYST
WE NEED TO IMPROVE HEALTH CARE
ACCESS FOR ONE OF CALIFORNIA'S
MOST MEDICALLY UNDERSERVED AREAS
BY TRAINING FOR THE NEXT
GENERATION OF MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS ROOTED RIGHT IN
THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY AND ITS
RESEARCH, THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA ITSELF IDENTIFIED THE
VALLEY AS THE STATE'S FASTEST
GROWING, MOST IMPOVERISHED, AND
LEAST HEALTHY REGION IN THE
ENTIRE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THE
VALLEY HAS THE LOWEST RATIO OF
LICENSED MDS, DOS, AND RNS,
MARRIAGE AND FAMILY THERAPISTS,
COUNSELORS, AND SOCIAL WORKERS.
THE SITUATION ON THE GROUND IS
EXPECTED TO GET EVEN WORSE. THE
ASSOCIATION OF AMERICAN MEDICAL
COLLEGES HAS HIGHLIGHTED THAT
MANY RURAL PHYSICIANS ARE
NEARING RETIREMENT AGE, WITH
NEARLY 25% EXPECTED TO RETIRE BY
2030. AT THE SAME TIME, THE
NUMBER OF MEDICAL STUDENTS FROM
RURAL BACKGROUNDS WHO ARE THE
MOST LIKELY TO PRACTICE MEDICINE
IN RURAL AREAS HAS DECLINED BY
28% OVER THE LAST 15 YEARS.
CURRENTLY THE NUMBER OF MEDICAL
STUDENTS FROM RURAL BACKGROUNDS
IS JUST 4.3. LET ME STATE THAT
AGAIN. CURRENTLY, THE NUMBER OF
MEDICAL STUDENTS CGRTS FROM
RURAL BACKGROUNDS IS. JUST 4.3,
BUT THE NUMBER OF MEDICAL
STUDENTS HAILING FROM A RURAL
AREA WHO ARE ALSO PART OF AN
UNDERREPRESENTED RACIAL OR
ETHNIC GROUP IS POINT 5% OF ALL
MEDICAL STUDENTS. LET ME PUT
THIS ANOTHER WAY. BLACK AND
BROWN KIDS FROM RURAL AREAS
ACCOUNT FOR LESS THAN ONE HALF
OF 1% OF ALL MEDICAL STUDENTS BY
RECRUITING, EDUCATING, AND
TRAINING THE NEXT GENERATION OF
PHYSICIANS LOCALLY, THE SOUTHERN
SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY CAN BEGIN TO
ERODE THE INEQUITY OF A DECADES
LONG DOCTOR SHORTAGE THAT HAS
CONTRIBUTED TO THE POOR HEALTH
OUTCOME OF OUR RESIDENTS. I SEE
IT EVERY SINGLE DAY AS A
PHYSICIAN, AND THOSE PERCENTAGES
ARE ME. I AM ONE OF THOSE
PERCENTAGE POINTS. AS A BROWN
KID GROWING UP IN DELANO, I AM A
PHYSICIAN WORKING RIGHT ACROSS
THE STREET FROM MY OLD
PRESCHOOL. EVEN CURRENTLY AS AN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. AND WHEN I LOOK
AROUND TO PEOPLE THAT I WENT TO
SCHOOL WITH GROWING UP IN DELANO
, I SEE NOBODY ELSE STANDING
WITH ME BUT ME. THIS BILL IS AN
ESSENTIAL STEP IN EXPANDING
HEALTH CARE ACCESS. NO, IT IS
NOT PREMATURE. IT IS LATE. WE
ARE LATE TO THE TABLE OF
ESTABLISHED. BEING A MEDICAL
SCHOOL IN KERN COUNTY, ENHANCING
OUR LOCAL ECONOMY AND IMPROVING
CAREER PATHS IN THE VALLEY WITH
ME TODAY TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT,
I HAVE DENNIS CUEVAS ROMERO WITH
THE CALIFORNIA PRIMARY CARE
ASSOCIATION ADVOCATES. WELCOME.
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. DENNIS ROMERO WITH THE
CALIFORNIA PRIMARY CARE
ASSOCIATION ADVOCATES. WE
REPRESENT HEALTH CENTERS ACROSS
THE STATE, 1300 HEALTH CENTERS
THAT PROVIDE CARE TO 7.8 MILLION
PATIENTS. THIS BILL IS REALLY
CRITICAL AS THE AS DOCTOR BAINES
MENTIONED, YOU KNOW, WE'RE IN
THE MIDST OF A PHYSICIAN
SHORTAGE. THE AMERICAN,
ACCORDING TO THE ASSOCIATION OF
AMERICAN MEDICAL COLLEGES, IT
PROJECTS THAT THE UNITED STATES
COULD SEE AN ESTIMATED SHORTAGE
OF 124,000 PHYSICIANS BY 2020
2034, THE MAJORITY OF THOSE
SHORTAGES IN PRIMARY AND
SPECIALTY CARE, YOU KNOW, IT'S
BEEN NOTED THAT THE PHYSICIAN
SHORTAGE IS PARTICULARLY ACUTE
IN THE SIERRAS AND THE SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY. AND THIS WOULD
BE A STEP TO ADDRESS THOSE
ISSUES. IN KERN COUNTY IN
PARTICULAR, THE POPULATION IS
ABOUT 55% THAT IDENTIFY AS
HISPANIC, AS DOCTOR BAINES
MENTIONED, YOU KNOW, THERE'S A
HISTORIC UNDERREPRESENTATION OF
LATINO AND HISPANIC PHYSICIANS
AND, YOU KNOW, INCREASING THE
NUMBER OF MEDICAL SCHOOLS IS
INCREDIBLY, INCREDIBLY CRITICAL.
LAST THING I'LL SAY, THERE'S
ABOUT A STATISTIC ABOUT IT'S
ABOUT 77% OF MEDICAL STUDENTS
THAT TRAIN IN CALIFORNIA REMAIN
IN CALIFORNIA. SO THE NEED TO
INCREASE MEDICAL SCHOOLS AND
RESIDENCIES, PARTICULARLY IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY AND KERN COUNTIES
, IS CRITICAL. SO I ASK FOR YOUR
I VOTE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT?
PLEASE COME FORWARD. CHER
GONZALEZ, ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA LIFE SCIENCES AND
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU, DYLAN
ELLIOTT ON BEHALF OF KERN COUNTY
AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU TO THE
AUTHOR. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON, CHAIR. MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE, RON BRUDER HERE ON
BEHALF OF KAISER PERMANENTE AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION, ANY
WITNESSES LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION? WELCOME. GOOD
AFTERNOON. CHAIR MEMBERS. CHEN
CHASE, ON BEHALF OF THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA, WE
HAVE OPPOSED UNLESS AMENDED,
POSITION ON THE BILL. WE REALLY
APPRECIATE THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
TAKING THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENT.
AND BUT WE REMAIN OPPOSED TO DO
THE OTHER CONCERNS OPPOSED
UNLESS AMENDED DUE TO OUR OTHER
CONCERNS IN THE BILL. THANK YOU.
APPRECIATE THAT. THANKS. MISS
CHASE, QUESTIONS COMMENTS FROM
MY COLLEAGUES. I'LL BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL TODAY.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DOCTOR, WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE? OH, SORRY. GO
AHEAD. JUST JUST REALLY QUICK.
JUST GRATEFUL FOR THIS BILL. I
AM REALLY, AND I AGREE WITH YOU.
I THINK IT'S DELAYED IN TIME. I
VERY MUCH, AS A MATTER OF FACT,
I THINK IN ALL OF CALIFORNIA WE
HAVE SPEAKING ABOUT THE INLAND
EMPIRE, WE ARE GREAT SHORTAGE OF
THE HEALTH CARE WORKFORCE IN
CALIFORNIA. ANYTHING THAT WE CAN
DO TO HELP PROMOTE AND ENCOURAGE
OUR, OUR STUDENTS BE A GREAT.
BUT ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I DO
WANT TO PUT WITHIN THAT, WITHIN
THAT SCOPE OF OUR FUTURE HEALTH
CARE WORKFORCE, ESPECIALLY OUR
DOCTORS, IS THE IMPORTANCE OF
OUR STEM PREPARED TEACHERS, THAT
ARE WELL PREPARED AS WELL AS
OPPORTUNITIES FOR OUR STUDENTS
TO BE ABLE TO HAVE ACCESS TO THE
COURSEWORK, INCLUDING DOING THE
MATH, BILLS THAT I DID THIS THIS
PAST THIS YEAR, ACTUALLY,
CURRENTLY WITH GREAT CONCERN
ABOUT PREPARING OUR STUDENTS
WITH THE RIGHT KNOWLEDGE AND
SKILL SETS TO BE ABLE TO PURSUE
THESE STEM OR HEALTH CARE
WORKFORCE, BECAUSE WE UNDERSTAND
THAT WHEN THEY'RE NOT PREPARED
WITH THE ACADEMIC RIGOR, THEN AS
THEY TAKE THESE CLASSES MOVING
FORWARD, WITHOUT THE SUPPORT
SYSTEM IN PLACE OR THE
CONFIDENCE BECAUSE OF THE LACK
OF SKILLS, THEY'RE DETERRED FROM
PURSUING THOSE HEALTH CARE
WORKFORCE. I HAVE SO MANY, I'VE
KNOWN SO MANY STUDENTS WITHIN MY
CLASS WHEN I WAS GROWING UP WITH
MY AND THEN WITH MY WITH MY
CHILDREN'S CLASSMATES WHO WERE
NOT PREPARED AND WANTED TO
BECOME DOCTORS, GOT TO THE
COLLEGE COURSES, TOOK THE MATH
CLASSES OR THE SCIENCE CLASSES,
AND DECIDED WAY TOO HARD. I'M
GOING TO FAIL. I'M NOT GOING TO
TAKE AND DEFERRED TO OTHER
MAJORS IN THE SOCIAL SCIENCES IN
ORDER NOT TO TAKE ANYTHING THAT
REQUIRED MATH OR SCIENCE. SO
WITH THAT, YOU KNOW, THAT'S THE
CONCERN THAT I HAVE MOVING
FORWARD, IS THAT WE REALLY HAVE
TO LOOK AT OUR THE PREPARATION,
AT THE LOWER GRADES IN ORDER TO
ENSURE THAT THEY HAVE THE
CONFIDENCE AND THE SKILL SETS TO
TAKE THOSE CLASSES WITH THAT
TYPE OF RIGOR AND CONTINUE ON
THEIR JOURNEY TO BECOMING
DOCTORS, ESPECIALLY FOR BLACK
AND BROWN COMMUNITY MEMBERS,
BECAUSE THERE ARE AT THE BIGGEST
DISADVANTAGE IN GAINING THOSE
THAT KNOWLEDGE AND THAT SKILL
SET. SO WITH THAT, I'M HAPPY TO
SUPPORT THE BILL. THANK YOU FOR
MOVING IT FORWARD. ANY OTHER
COMMENTS WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
DOCTOR BANK? YEAH, I SPENT FOUR
YEARS AS A CHAIR OF THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTH CARE WORKFORCE
POLICY COMMISSION. THIS IS
SOMETHING I'VE WORKED ON FOR A
VERY LONG, LONG TIME. NO, THIS
IS NOT PREMATURE. IT'S ACTUALLY
OFFENSIVE TO CAUSE SOMETHING
LIKE THIS. PREMATURE. AND
ANYBODY THAT DOES NOT SUPPORT A
MEDICAL SCHOOL IN KERN COUNTY
TAKE A STEP BACK AND LISTEN TO A
STORY THAT I'M JUST ABOUT TO
TELL YOU, GOING THROUGHOUT THE
DISTRICT IN KERN COUNTY, I WOULD
ASK STUDENTS, RAISE YOUR HAND IF
YOU WANT TO BE A DOCTOR. I WOULD
HAVE MAYBE ONE. SOMETIMES NOBODY
RAISED THEIR HAND. NOW, JUST
BECAUSE I INTRODUCE A BILL, I GO
INTO FIFTH GRADE CLASSES AND I
ASK, WHO WANTS TO BE A DOCTOR? I
HAVE THE MAJORITY OF THE CLASS
RAISING THEIR HAND. THAT IS THE
POWER OF JUST HAVING THE IDEA OF
HAVING A MEDICAL SCHOOL IN KERN
COUNTY. HAVING THIS SCHOOL IS
GOING TO BRING A MUCH, MUCH
BIGGER IMPACT. AND ANYBODY THAT
DOES NOT SUPPORT A BILL LIKE
THIS, I ASK THEM THE NUMBER OF
MEDICAL STUDENTS FROM RURAL
BACKGROUNDS IS JUST 4.3. WHAT
HAVE YOU DONE ON THAT? AND THE
NUMBER OF MEDICAL STUDENTS
HAILING FROM A RURAL AREA WHO
ARE ALSO PART OF AN
UNDERREPRESENTED RACIAL OR
ETHNIC GROUP, IS 0.5% OF ALL
MEDICAL STUDENTS, AND YOU SHOULD
FEEL ASHAMED OF YOURSELVES TO
OPPOSE A BILL LIKE THIS THAT
BRINGS HIGHER EDUCATIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES TO AN AREA THAT
NEEDS IT MOST. THANK YOU, GLAD
TO SUPPORT THE BILL. MADAM
CONSULTANT, PLEASE. WE HAVE A
MOTION FROM SENATOR BOGUE. IS
THAT CORRECT? YES. SURE, SURE,
PLEASE, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL FOR
ITEM 17. AB 2357. BAIN'S MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED, TO SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
NEWMAN, A UMMINI OKOBO OKOBO GUY
CORTESE. CORTESE. AYE. GLAESER.
GONZALEZ. SMALL CUEVAS. WILK.
WILK. AYE ALL RIGHT. THAT
MEASURE HAS FOUR VOTES. WE'LL
LEAVE IT OPEN FOR REMAINING
MEMBERS. THANK YOU, DOCTOR
BAINS, LET'S SEE NEXT WE HAVE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RIVAS, I THINK.
IS THAT CORRECT? I'M SORRY. NO,
I SPOKE TOO SOON. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER IRWIN, FILE ORDER. GOT
YOUR HOPES UP. REALLY? SORRY.
YOUR BILL IS DOUBLE REFERRED.
IMPORTANT TO GET TO IT, AND JUST
JUST ONE SECOND, THOUGH, PLEASE
LET ME. CAN I TALK TO YOU FOR A
SECOND? YEAH.
I'LL TALK FAST. NO, NO. THE
INTEGRITY OF THE PROCESS IS
STILL IMPORTANT. SO WE'RE JUST.
WE'RE GOING TO RUN OUT OF TIME
BECAUSE THERE'S ANOTHER
COMMITTEE COMING IN HERE. I'M
TRYING TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
DOUBLE REFERRED BILLS ARE
PROPERLY ACCOUNTED FOR HERE. BUT
YOU ARE ONE OF THOSE BILLS, SO
PLEASE PROCEED. OKAY. I'M
PLEASED TO PRESENT AB 2723,
WHICH PROVIDES SOME UPDATES TO
THE CRADLE TO CAREER DATA SYSTEM
REFERRED TO AS CðC. I'VE BEEN
INVOLVED WITH CTC SINCE ITS ITS
INCEPTION IN THE STATE BUDGET
AND CURRENTLY SERVE AS THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ON THE GOVERNING
BOARD. I WANT TO HIGHLIGHT FOR
THE COMMITTEE THE IMPORTANCE OF
HAVING LONGITUDINAL LONGITUDINAL
DATA SYSTEM LINKING EXISTING
EDUCATIONAL WORKFORCE, FINANCIAL
AID AND SOCIAL SERVICE
INFORMATION. THIS SYSTEM WILL
ALLOW CALIFORNIA TO ANSWER KEY
QUESTIONS ABOUT EQUITY WHILE
ALLOWING US TO ADDRESS
DISPARITIES IN OPPORTUNITY AND
IMPROVE OUTCOMES FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS. UNFORTUNATELY, IN
THIS SPACE, CALIFORNIA HAS NOT
BEEN A LEADER, BUT ONE OF THE
LAST STATES TO STAND UP A
LONGITUDINAL DATA SYSTEM,
MEANING WE ARE CATCHING UP, BUT
BY NO MEANS BREAKING GROUND.
THANKFULLY CTC CELEBRATED ITS
FIRST ROUND OF DATA SUBMISSIONS
FROM DATA PROVIDERS LAST FALL
AND ANTICIPATES MAKING ITS FIRST
ANALYTICAL TOOLS DATA DASHBOARDS
AVAILABLE THIS YEAR. AS WITH ANY
MATURING STATE ENTITY, THERE ARE
ASPECTS OF ITS GOVERNING STATUTE
THAT WOULD BENEFIT FROM
REFINEMENT, WHICH IS WHAT THIS
BILL SEEKS TO DO. THIS BILL WILL
CLARIFY THE ROLE THAT C2 C HOLDS
IN RELATION TO THE DATA THEY
MAINTAIN ON BEHALF OF THE DATA
PROVIDERS AND REINFORCES HOW
CTC, CTC WORKS WITHIN THE
INFORMATION PRACTICES ACT. WHEN
THE DATA SYSTEM WAS CREATED, THE
STRUCTURE WAS THOUGHTFULLY
CRAFTED TO ENSURE DATA PROVIDERS
WOULD WILLINGLY PARTICIPATE.
THIS IMPORTANTLY MEANT THAT DATA
PROVIDERS WOULD RETAIN OWNERSHIP
AND CONTROL OVER THEIR SOURCE
DATA. IT ALSO MEANT THAT CTC WAS
NOT GRANTED ANY AUTHORITY TO
DIRECT OR DEMAND ANY ACTION BY
DATA PROVIDERS. THESE STRUCTURAL
LIMITATIONS PROVIDE A BARRIER TO
CTC AND HONORING THE IMPORTANT
RIGHTS PROVIDED BY THE
CALIFORNIANS BY THE TWO
CALIFORNIANS, BY THE INFORMATION
PRACTICES ACT. THIS MAKES
DIRECTING CALIFORNIA'S DATA
PROVIDERS WHO DO NOT FACE THE
SAME BARRIERS, AN APPROPRIATE
SOLUTION TO HONOR THESE RIGHTS.
I HAVE TWO WITNESSES WITH ME
TODAY, ERIC FLORES, THE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR FOR LEGISLATIVE AFFAIRS
OF THE OFFICE OF CRADLE TO
CAREER, AND SARA ARCE, VICE
PRESIDENT OF POLICY AND ADVOCACY
FOR THE CAMPAIGN FOR COLLEGE
OPPORTUNITY AND WHO'S FIRST, MR.
FLORES? MR. ROSS, OF COURSE.
PLEASE PROCEED BRIEFLY, MR.
CHAIR. AND MEMBERS, ERIC FLORES
WITH CRADLE TO CAREER. REALLY
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS
ON THIS BILL. THANK YOU. WELL
PRESENTED, MR. DARCY. CHAIR
NEWMAN, MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU. I WILL BE
SHORT. JUST IN THE INTEREST OF
TIME, CALIFORNIA'S ABILITY TO
ADDRESS PERSISTENT RACIAL EQUITY
GAPS IN EDUCATIONAL SUCCESS AND
MEET FUTURE WORKFORCE DEMANDS
RESTS ON OUR ABILITY TO ACCESS
COMPLETE AND DISAGGREGATED DATA
ABOUT STUDENTS PATHWAYS, FROM
K-12 EDUCATION TO THE WORKFORCE,
THE TOOLS THAT THE DATA SYSTEM
WILL ULTIMATELY PROVIDE DODD ARE
VITAL FOR POLICYMAKERS,
RESEARCHERS AND PRACTITIONERS IN
CRAFTING TARGETED POLICY
INTERVENTIONS ACROSS THE
EDUCATION TO WORKFORCE PIPELINE,
IMPORTANTLY, I WANT TO NOTE THAT
SINCE THE DATA SYSTEM LAUNCHED A
COLLABORATION, TRANSPARENCY AND
ENGAGEMENT OF THE PUBLIC HAVE
BEEN A CORNERSTONE OF THE EFFORT
. SINCE ITS INCEPTION. THE DATA
SYSTEM HAS COLLABORATIVELY AND
TRANSPARENTLY ENGAGED THE PUBLIC
TO ENSURE THAT THE RIGHT DATA IS
AGGREGATED ACROSS MULTIPLE
SYSTEM AND AGENCY PARTNERS. WITH
OVER 100 PUBLIC MEETINGS, MORE
THAN 200 PEOPLE FROM 15 STATE
AGENCIES AND MANY EDUCATIONAL
AND RESEARCH AND POLICY
ORGANIZATIONS. ÓRDENES INCLUDED
IN THAT PROCESS, THE COMMITMENT
TO A PUBLIC, TRANSPARENT PROCESS
IN SHAPING A COMPLETE DATA
NARRATIVE THAT IS RESPONSIBLY
MANAGED IS ESSENTIAL TO CREATING
STRONGER, DATA DRIVEN POLICY,
AND FOR THAT REASON, WE SUPPORT
AB 2723. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT?
PLEASE COME FORWARD. MICHAEL
MORALES, ON BEHALF OF FAIR TRUST
AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU. ANYBODY
ELSE SEEING NONE ANY ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
WELCOME. GOOD AFTERNOON. LEAH
JONES, ON BEHALF OF VOICE FOR
CHOICE ADVOCACY, I'M OPPOSING.
LET'S AMEND. WE WANT WE ARE
REQUESTING ACTUALLY THAT THE OPT
OUT OPTION SUGGESTED BY C2C'S
LEGAL SUBCOMMITTEE BE
REINSTATED. WE THINK IT'S
OVERBURDENED, FOR STUDENTS AND
PARENTS TO HAVE TO GO TO 12
DIFFERENT ENTITIES, AT LEAST TO
FIND OUT WHAT DATA IS BEING
TRACKED, ON THEIR STUDENT, ON
THE STUDENT OR A PARENT'S CHILD.
AND ALSO THERE'S AN EQUITY ISSUE
IN THAT, PUBLIC SCHOOLS, THIS IS
A PUBLIC SCHOOL DYNAMIC, BUT
PRIVATE SCHOOLS ARE COMPLETELY
THEY'RE NOT INVOLVED. SO IF YOU
CAN AFFORD TO SEND YOUR KID TO
PRIVATE SCHOOL, THEN YOU DON'T
HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT THE DATA
TRACKING AND TRYING TO FIND OUT
WHAT'S BEING, UPLOADED ABOUT
YOURSELF OR YOUR STUDENT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. ANY OTHER
OPPOSITION, ANY QUESTION OR
COMMENTS FROM MY COLLEAGUES?
SEEING NONE, YOU HAVE THE
ADVANTAGE OF BEING LATE IN THE
PROCESS HERE. SO I WILL JUST
JUST POINT OUT THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT INITIATIVE AND IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE MOVE FORWARD
WITH ALL DUE HASTE. TO YOUR
POINT, CALIFORNIA IS NOT AHEAD
OF THE REST OF THE COUNTRY, AND
THIS DATA IS ESSENTIAL IF WE'RE
GOING TO MAKE SMART CHOICES AND
PRIORITIZE PRIORITIES AS WE MOVE
FORWARD. SO I'M GLAD TO SUPPORT
THE BILL. I DO APPRECIATE SOME
OF THE CONCERNS THAT ARE RAISED,
AND I'M SURE THAT YOU KNOW
YOU'RE OPEN TO THEM, GLAD YOU
KNOW YOU'RE GOING TO WORK,
PARTICULARLY TO PROTECT PRIVACY
AS WE DO THIS, ANY OTHER
COMMENTS, WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE, JUST RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR. AYE. VOTE. DO WE HAVE A
MOTION? SO MOVED A MOTION FOR
SENATOR WILK, MADAM CONSULTANT,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL FILE. ITEM
21 AB 2723. ERWIN MOTION IS DUE.
PASSED THE SENATE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE. NEWMAN Ã NEWMAN I
OKOBOJI. OKOBOJI. CORTEZ CORTEZ
I. GLASER. GONZALEZ SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. WILK. WILK I. THAT
MEASURE CURRENTLY HAS FOUR
VOTES. WE WILL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS. THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU TO THE
WITNESSES, NEXT UP, WE HAVE.
YOU'RE COMING IN HOT. COMING IN
HOT. RUNNING. RIVAS LET'S BE
FAST, BUT LET'S BE SAFE. OKAY,
SO WELCOME, AND PLEASE PROCEED
WHEN READY. THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR
AND SENATORS. TODAY I'M
PRESENTING ON AB 29 2595. THE
CALIFORNIA SUMMER CAREGIVER MEAL
PILOT, AND I HAVE TWO WITNESSES,
TO PROVIDE TESTIMONY, ITZEL
GUTIERREZ, SENIOR POLICY
ADVOCATE OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF FOOD BANKS AND
JIM MCGOWAN, VICE PRESIDENT OF
THE YMCA OF THE SILICON VALLEY,
WELCOME TO BOTH OF THE
WITNESSES. PLEASE PROCEED. HI.
THANK YOU, YES. AS I MENTIONED,
MY NAME IS ESAU GUTIERREZ AT THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF FOOD
BANKS, WHERE WE REPRESENT OUR 41
FOOD BANKS, LEADING THE
COLLECTIVE EFFORT TO END HUNGER
IN CALIFORNIA. NO CHILD SHOULD
GO HUNGRY YET. CALIFORNIA'S HIGH
COST OF LIVING LEADS MANY
FAMILIES TO STRUGGLE TO MAKE
ENDS MEET. CURRENT DATA SHOWS
THAT OVER 1 IN 3 HOUSEHOLDS WITH
CHILDREN IN CALIFORNIA ARE FOOD
INSECURE, WITH DEEP DISPARITIES
FOR LATINO AND BLACK HOUSEHOLDS.
THANKS TO THE TREMENDOUS
LEADERSHIP FOR, BY THE
LEGISLATURE AND ADMINISTRATION.
IN 2021, CALIFORNIA BECAME THE
FIRST STATE TO PASS STATEWIDE
UNIVERSAL MEALS PROGRAM FOR
SCHOOL CHILDREN. NOW WE LOOK TO
ADDRESSING HUNGER DURING THE
SUMMER MONTHS WHEN SCHOOLS ARE
CLOSED, WHICH NOT ONLY AFFECTS
CHILDREN BUT THE WHOLE FAMILY.
PRIOR TO JOINING CFB, I WORKED
AT THE REDWOOD EMPIRE FOOD BANK,
ONE OF THE HARDEST PARTS OF THE
PROGRAM WAS SERVING MEALS TO
CHILDREN, KNOWING THE PARENTS
WERE HUNGRY THEMSELVES TO
FEDERAL USDA RULES PROHIBIT
CAREGIVERS FROM RECEIVING MEALS
ALONG WITH THEIR CHILDREN, BUT
ONE SUMMER, WE WERE FORTUNATE TO
RECEIVE TEMPORARY GRANT FUNDING
TO PILOT PROVIDING CAREGIVER
MEALS. WE ACHIEVED REMARKABLE
SUCCESS IN ADDRESSING HUNGER FOR
ENTIRE FAMILIES, INCLUDING
PARENTS AND GRANDPARENTS, WHILE
FOSTERING A POSITIVE ATMOSPHERE
FOR CHILDREN THROUGHOUT THE
SUMMER MONTHS. HERE'S A QUOTE
FROM RHEA FUENTES AT THE REDWOOD
EMPIRE FOOD BANK. WE WOULD BE
VERY THANKFUL FOR THE BILL TO
PASS AS WE KNOW THAT SEVERAL
GUARDIANS AND FAMILIES ARE ALSO
FACING FOOD INSECURITY AND HAVE
TROUBLE AT TIMES BRINGING THEIR
CHILDREN TO SITES. AND WHAT A
BETTER OPPORTUNITY FOR BOTH
PARENT AND CHILD TO GET A
HEALTHY MEAL. AND FROM THE
SONOMA COUNTY LIBRARY WHO THEY
PARTNER WITH. WE WOULD BE
THRILLED IF THIS BILL PASSED
BECAUSE WE SEE SO MANY FAMILIES
WHERE THE PARENTS AND CAREGIVERS
ARE AS IN NEED OF A HEALTHY
LUNCH AS THEIR CHILD. NOT ONLY
IS THERE A HUNGER ISSUE HERE,
BUT FOR ADULTS TO MODEL HEALTHY
EATING HABITS FOR THEIR KIDS
CRITICAL TO LIFELONG HEALTHY
EATING HABITS FOR CHILDREN. SO
REGARDLESS OF WHETHER KIDS LIVE
IN BLUE OR RED DISTRICTS, OR HOW
A PARENT VOTES, HUNGER IS
EXPERIENCED EQUALLY AND IS WHY
WE APPRECIATE A BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT FOR CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES AND CALIFORNIA HAS
WORKED ON MAKING HUNGER A
NONPARTISAN ISSUE AND WORKED
HARD ON THESE BILLS TO END
HUNGER. SO FOR, SO FOR CHILDREN
EXPERIENCING HUNGER, PART OF THE
TRAUMA IS WATCHING THEIR PARENTS
STRUGGLE WITH HUNGER. AND
CHILDREN REMEMBER VERY STRONGLY
THAT THEIR PARENTS DIDN'T EAT.
AB 2595 ENSURES THAT CAREGIVERS
CAN SIT DOWN AND HAVE A MEAL
WITH THEIR CHILDREN AT THE
SUMMER MEAL SITES, AT PUBLIC
LIBRARIES DURING THE HUNGRIEST
TIME OF THE YEAR IN THE SUMMER.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK AND, RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY, MR. MCGOWAN. WELCOME.
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. MEMBERS,
MY NAME IS JIM MCGOWAN. I'M THE
VICE PRESIDENT OF GOVERNMENT
RELATIONS FOR THE YMCA OF
SILICON VALLEY. AS PART OF A
YEAR ROUND EFFORT TO ADDRESS
CHILD HUNGER ACROSS THE COUNTRY,
YMCAS AROUND THE COUNTRY HAVE
ENGAGED IN SUMMER FOOD PROGRAMS
THAT HAVE SERVED OVER 100
MILLION MEALS SINCE 2011,
INCLUDING HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
OF USDA. USDA FUNDED SUMMER
MEALS THAT THE YMCA OF SILICON
VALLEY HAS SPONSORED TO BOTH
CHILDREN AND CAREGIVERS. AS MANY
OF THE SITES WE'VE SPONSORED
INCLUDE PUBLIC LIBRARIES, THE Y
LOVES MEALS AT LIBRARIES BECAUSE
IN ADDITION TO PROVIDING
CHILDREN AND YOUTH WITH MEALS,
THEY ALSO OFFER AN ENVIRONMENT
FOR KIDS AND FAMILIES TO ENGAGE
IN SOCIAL CONNECTION,
EXPLORATION AND LEARNING
ACTIVITIES IN A SAFE, WELCOMING
ENVIRONMENT. WE FEEL STRONGLY
THAT WELCOMING CAREGIVERS TO THE
TABLE IS AN IMPORTANT, AFFIRMING
ASPECT OF THIS EXPERIENCE. I'D
LIKE TO SHARE WITH YOU SOME
INSIGHTS FROM CASSANDRA WONG,
COMMUNITY LIBRARIAN AT THE
GILROY LIBRARY, ON THE IMPACT OF
NO LONGER BEING ABLE TO OFFER
CAREGIVER MEALS IN SUMMER FOOD
PROGRAMS. SHE SAYS THAT IN THE
11.5 YEARS WE'VE HAD THE
PROGRAM, WE'VE GIVEN OUT ALMOST
30,000 MEALS. THIS IS THE FIRST
TIME WE HAVE HAD TO ASK ADULTS
NOT TO PARTICIPATE, PROVIDE
ADULT MEALS DECREASES THE STIGMA
RESULTING FROM FOOD INSECURITY,
AND CREATES COMMUNITY BY SHARING
A COMMON MEAL. WE KNOW THAT NOT
ALL ADULTS OSTENSIBLY NEED OR
DESIRE A MEAL, BUT THE FACT THAT
WE WERE OFFERING THEM TO ALL
FAMILY MEMBERS MEANS ADULTS WHO
MAY BE FEELING THE ANXIETY AND
DIFFICULTY OF HAVING, OF HAVING
ENOUGH MEALS TO SATISFY THEIR
HUNGER, FEEL MORE COMFORTABLE IN
ACCEPTING A MEAL. FOOD
INSECURITY IS OFTENTIMES NOT AN
ALL OR NOTHING SITUATION. TO BE
ABLE TO PROVIDE MEALS FOR ADULTS
MAKES THE WHOLE FAMILY FEEL
SUPPORTED, NURTURED, AND FREE
FROM STIGMA. IT FEELS INVITING
AS OPPOSED TO A PURELY BEING A
FOOD DISTRIBUTION. WE ALSO
SUPPORT THIS TYPE OF ENVIRONMENT
BY ASKING ALL FAMILIES TO JOIN
US, NOT JUST THOSE WHO ARE
REFERRED FROM AN ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM, CBO OR ETC. THIS
DIFFERENCE AGAIN ALLOWS FOR
FAMILIES TO FEEL WELCOME BY THE
LIBRARY AND READY TO LEARN AFTER
A NUTRITIOUS, HOT MEAL THAT THEY
CAN SHARE WITH FAMILY AND
COMMUNITY MEMBERS. COMMUNITY
BUILDING IS THE TENANT OF OUR
PROFESSION. FOOD INSECURITY CAN
BE AN ISOLATING ISSUE IN ORDER
TO CREATE COMMUNITY CONNECTION.
THERE IS NOTHING MORE COMMUNAL
THAN SHARING A MEAL. SHARED
MEALS LEAD TO A WELCOMING
ENVIRONMENT WHERE WE CAN
LITERALLY, LITERALLY REACH
ACROSS THE TABLE TO GET TO KNOW
OUR NEIGHBORS IN DIVISIVE TIMES,
CREATING COMMON EXPERIENCES AND
SHARED JOY ARE IMPORTANT WAYS TO
ESTABLISH LONG TERM CONNECTION
WITH ONE ANOTHER. COMMUNITY
SUPPORTS ITSELF, AND WE CAN BE
THE CATALYST FOR PROVIDING FOR
THE SUPPORT BY PROVIDING
ENRICHMENT THROUGH FAMILY MEALS
AND EDUCATIONAL OPPORTUNITIES.
WE URGE YOU TO SUPPORT THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO HELP MORE
FAMILIES PARTICIPATE, AND FOR US
TO MORE FULLY MEET THE NEEDS OF
THE FAMILIES WE SERVE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. THANKS FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY, WITNESSES IN SUPPORT,
PLEASE COME FORWARD. NAME.
ORGANIZATION GOOD AFTERNOON.
LIZZIE KUTSUNA HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE OFFICE OF KAT TAYLOR AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
LEILANI AQUINALDO, ON BEHALF OF
FRESNO UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU. HI.
KELLY O'BRIEN WITH WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY. PROUD
TO BE IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK
YOU, RICHARD MAHER WITH AMERICA
FIRST POLICY INSTITUTE IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU, DO WE HAVE
ANY WITNESSES HERE IN OPPOSITION
? DOES ANYBODY HERE LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO THE
MEASURE, SEEING NONE, LET'S COME
BACK TO THE DAIS. COLLEAGUES,
QUESTIONS, COMMENTS, MOTIONS.
APPRECIATE THAT. WE HAVE A
MOTION FROM SENATOR CUEVAS.
SENATOR CHURBERG. SO, I, IF I
RECALL CORRECTLY, THE BILL LAST
YEAR THAT YOU PROPOSED PUT A CAP
ON, ONE ADULT FOR REIMBURSEMENT
PURPOSES, FOR THE MEALS. IS THAT
CORRECT? IS THAT WHAT I
UNDERSTOOD THAT I READ HERE ONE.
SO LAST ONE, GUARDIAN PER CHILD.
WHAT'S THAT? DO YOU MEAN ONE
GUARDIAN PER CHILD? ONE GUARDIAN
PER CHILD? THIS ONE DOES NOT
PARTAKE, DOES NOT HAVE A CAP ON
ON HOW MANY ADULTS ARE GOING TO
BE SERVED OR REIMBURSED FOR. I
BELIEVE IT DOES. SO DO YOU WANT
TO? I'LL SO LAST YEAR, AB 1170
INCLUDED A PROVISION FOR
REIMBURSEMENT THAT WAS SUBMITTED
TO ONE GUARDIAN PER ELIGIBLE
PUPIL. THIS, THIS AND IN THIS
BILL DOES NOT ACTUALLY HAVE A
DEFINITION OF WHO THE GUARDIAN
WILL BE, WHICH IS FINE. NOT A
BIG DEAL. WHOEVER TAKES THE
CHILD, CAN PARTAKE AT THE SAME
TIME, BUT I BUT I BUT THIS BILL
IS JUST KIND OF OPEN ENDED, SO
IT DOESN'T SPECIFY ONE ADULT. IT
JUST ANYONE AND EVERYONE THAT
COULD COME WITH THAT CHILD COULD
STAY, SO CLARIFICATION THAT'S
I'M, I'M GOING TO ASSUME THAT'S
THE CASE. YES. YES IT IS. YEAH.
OPEN ENDED. YEAH. IT'S AVAILABLE
SO THAT IF BOTH PARENTS WERE
THERE THEY COULD HAVE IT. AND
SOMETHING WITH PARENTS, BUT IT
COULD BE MORE THAN, YOU KNOW, IT
COULD BE OPEN TO ANY NUMBER OF
ADULTS THAT ACCOMPANY THE CHILD
BECAUSE AT THIS POINT IT DOESN'T
CAP, YOU KNOW, SAY TWO PARENTS
OR TWO GUARDIANS OR ONE
GUARDIAN, WHATEVER IT MAY BE.
THERE IS NO CAP. SO IT'S OPEN
ENDED. SO IT COULD BE ANY NUMBER
OF INDIVIDUALS COMING WITH THE
CHILD. COULD BE, THERE IS, THERE
IS. I MEAN, THERE'S A DEFINITION
OF GUARDIAN IN THE BILL. SO, SO
THERE'S, THERE'S SORT OF A
REASONABLE DEFINITION. I DON'T
BELIEVE THEY CAN BRING, YOU
KNOW, THEIR NEIGHBORS AND OTHER
ADULTS. RIGHT. IT'S RIGHT.
PARENTS, STEPPARENT,
GRANDPARENT, GUARDIAN OR OTHER
FAMILY MEMBER, CARETAKER, SO
THERE'S SOME LEVEL THERE'S A
COMMON SENSE ASPECT, I ASSUME,
TO THIS. YOU CAN'T BRING THAT
DEFINITION IS IRRELEVANT. I'M
JUST I'M JUST WANTING FOR
CLARIFICATION PURPOSES. THERE IS
NO NUMBER OF INDIVIDUALS THAT
ARE ALLOWED TO ACCOMPANY THE
CHILD THAT WILL RECEIVE A MEAL.
IF THE CHILD COMES IN WITH, YOU
KNOW, THREE, FOUR ADULTS, ALL
THOSE THREE, FOUR ADULTS COULD
QUALIFY FOR THAT FREE MEAL AS
WELL BECAUSE THERE IS NO
SPECIFICATION IN THE BILL THAT
STIPULATES HOW MANY INDIVIDUALS,
CAN BE CONSIDERED GUARDIANS FOR
THAT CHILD JUST BECAUSE. AND I'M
COMPARING IT TO THE BILL LAST
YEAR, WHICH CAPPED IT AT ONE
GUARDIAN. THIS PARTICULAR BILL
JUST SAYS OPEN ENDED GUARDIAN,
WHICH IS FINE, BUT NO CAP AS TO
HOW MANY ADULTS PER CHILD COULD
QUALIFY FOR THIS. SO IT'S OPEN
ENDED, THE OTHER COMPONENT, FOR
THE RECORD, I JUST WANTED TO
MAKE SURE, AS WE TALK ABOUT, YOU
KNOW, INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE,
SUFFERING FROM HUNGER IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA, I JUST WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ALSO
RECOGNIZE THE FACT THAT WE HAVE
CALFRESH THAT'S AVAILABLE. WE
HAVE SUMMER. SO I'M ALSO, BEEN
PRIVY TO THE FACT THAT WE HAVE
SUMMER EBT PROGRAMS THAT
PROVIDES FAMILIES WHOSE CHILDREN
ARE ELIGIBLE FOR FREE AND
REDUCED PRICE SCHOOL MEALS WITH
GROCERY BENEFITS AND A DEBIT
TYPE CARD DURING THE SUMMER.
MONTHS. SO I JUST WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE HAVE ON RECORD THAT
THE STATE HAS BEEN VERY, VERY
COGNIZANT OF THE NEEDS AND
ENSURING THAT WE HAVE PROGRAMS
THROUGHOUT, WHETHER IT'S THROUGH
THE STATE OR THROUGH, FOOD BANKS
IN OUR LOCAL COMMUNITIES,
THROUGH THE NONPROFITS, SERVICE
ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE
CONTINUOUSLY VERY COGNIZANT OF
THE NEEDS OF OUR COMMUNITIES AND
ENSURING THAT THERE'S FOOD,
PROVIDED ALL THROUGHOUT OUR,
OUR, OUR COMMUNITIES, PER SE, I
AM KIND OF CURIOUS AND I DON'T
KNOW THIS, SO MAYBE THE
COMMITTEE CONSULTANTS COULD
ANSWER THE FOLLOWING QUESTION. I
KNOW SINCE I'VE BEEN ELECTED,
WE'VE HAD SUMMER PROGRAMS
THROUGH THE LOCAL SCHOOL
DISTRICTS THAT PROVIDE, FREE
MEALS, UNLIMITED NUMBER THROUGH
ANY HOUSEHOLD. HOW MANY EVER YOU
COME IN THROUGH WITH YOUR CAR
AND SAY YOU NEED THESE MANY
MEALS, YOU'LL GIVE THEM MEALS.
ARE WE STILL PROVIDING THAT
MOVING FORWARD? BECAUSE I DON'T
KNOW IF WE ARE NOT. NO. IT WAS,
IT WAS IT WAS ONLY DURING COVID.
THAT WAS DURING COVID. YEAH.
ONLY MAYBE YOU CAME IN DURING
COVID. I'M NOT SURE IF WHEN YOU
STARTED IN THE SENATE, BUT IN
2020 THAT WAS UNIQUE TO THE
PANDEMIC. WHEN DO WE NOT
SOMETHING SUMMER PROGRAM THAT
THE STATE HAS DONE. YEAH. THAT
THAT ENDED TO DO SORRY. NO GO
AHEAD GO AHEAD. THAT THAT ENDED
IN IN 2022 IS WHEN IT WAS THE
LAST SUMMER THAT IT WAS
AVAILABLE. THERE WAS A WAIVER
THAT WAS EXTENDED, BUT IT CAME
LATER AND IT WAS ONLY FOR THE
REMAINDER OF THE SUMMER. AND SO
THESE SITES WERE NOT ABLE TO
START UP TO DO THAT, ABILITY TO
DO BULK MEALS OR GRAB AND GOES,
WHICH AT THIS POINT IS NOT
AVAILABLE EXCEPT FOR RURAL
NON-CONGREGATE SITES. THEY DO
HAVE THE ABILITY TO HAVE THOSE
MEALS, BUT THOSE ARE JUST FOR
KIDS. SO THERE WASN'T ADDITIONAL
FOOD THAT WAS BEING GIVEN OUT,
THERE TO CAREGIVERS. THAT'S ONLY
BEEN PILOTS LIKE, AT SANTA CLARA
COUNTY WHERE THEY'VE HAD THEM,
BUT THERE HASN'T BEEN AN ACTUAL
ACTION. YEAH. THAT'S RIGHT. SO
THIS BILL IS ABOUT PROVIDING THE
MEAL TO THE GUARDIAN. AND THE
OTHER PROGRAMS THAT WE HAVE ARE
ABOUT CHILDREN PROVIDE AT THE
SCHOOL SITES AT THE SCHOOL THAT
YOU JUST MENTIONED. THOSE ARE
MEALS FOR CHILDREN, EXCEPT FOR
THE EBT PROGRAM THAT PROVIDES,
THE SUMMER ATE PROGRAM, WHICH
PROVIDES FAMILIES WHOSE CHILDREN
ARE ELIGIBLE FOR FREE AND
REDUCED PRICE SCHOOL MEALS WITH
GROCERY BENEFITS AND A DEBIT
CARD DURING THE SUMMER MONTHS
THAT I. IF I IF I CAN THAT YEAH.
THAT YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT THE
SUMMER SUN BOX. VERY EXCITING
BECAUSE IT'S THE FIRST TIME IN A
GENERATION THAT WE HAVE THIS
PROGRAM ROLLING, THANKS TO THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT, AND THAT
PROGRAM IS ACTUALLY WAS DESIGNED
TO COMPLEMENT THE SUMMER MEALS
FOOD SERVICE PROGRAM SO THAT
CHILDREN CAN GET A HOT MEAL AND
CAN ALSO GET THE EBT CARD TO
SPEND AT THEIR GROCERY STORE.
IT'S $120. SO AS YOU CAN
IMAGINE, $120 GOES BY REAL FAST,
SO THEY DEFINITELY ARE BOTH
NEEDED, AND THEY COMPLEMENT EACH
OTHER. OKAY. SO WE'LL MAKE SURE
THAT WE HAVE ON RECORD THOSE
PROGRAMS THAT WE DO HAVE IN
PLACE, ACCOMMODATING OUR, OUR
CHILDREN DURING THE SUMMER.
THANK YOU. ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FROM MY COLLEAGUES?
I THINK WE HAD A MOTION FOR
SENATOR SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS I'M
GLAD TO SUPPORT THIS BILL. WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE? I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU, MADAM KANSEN.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL FOR ITEM 25
AB 2595 THREE OF US MOTION IS
DUE PASSED THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE NEWMAN
NEWMAN I OTOBOKE. CORTESE.
CORTESE. I GLASER. GLASER I.
GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ I. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS I.
WILK AND MEASURE HAS FIVE VOTES
AND IT IS OUT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MUCH, NEXT WE HAVE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FRIEDMAN. WELCOME. AND
I'M SAYING THIS NOT TO RUSH YOU.
WE'RE GOING TO COME UP ON A TIME
CONSTRAINT. DO NOT RUSH, BUT
THAT'S JUST SORT OF THE HEADS UP
ON THIS, AND WE'LL DEAL WITH IT
WHEN WE GET TO THAT. I WILL TRY
TO SAY EVERY THIRD WORD, ONLY MY
TALKING POINTS. I WILL LISTEN
CLOSELY. THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR
AND MEMBERS. HAPPY JUNETEENTH,
IN THE AFTERMATH OF THE HAMAS
TERROR ATTACK IN OCTOBER 7TH,
JEWISH AND PRO-ISRAEL STUDENTS
ARE FEELING PRESSURED TO HIDE
THEIR IDENTITIES ON CAMPUS
BECAUSE MANY OF THEM FEEL
UNSAFE, ACCORDING TO THE
ANTI-DEFAMATION LEAGUE, THERE
HAVE BEEN A 2,000% INCREASE IN
ANTI-SEMITIC INCIDENTS ON
CALIFORNIA COLLEGE CAMPUSES
FOLLOWING OCTOBER 7TH COMPARED
TO A YEAR AGO. OUR COMMUNITIES
ARE ASKING US WHAT IS BEING DONE
TO ASSURE THAT JEWISH STUDENTS
CAN ATTEND CLASS AND EXIST IN
THE ACADEMIC SETTING, FREE FROM
DISCRIMINATION. THÀNH. WE ARE
ANSWERING THIS DIFFICULT
QUESTION THROUGH AB 2925, WHICH
REQUIRES COLLEGE CAMPUSES TO
INCLUDE TRAINING TO COMBAT AND
ADDRESS DISCRIMINATION AGAINST
THE FIVE MOST TARGETED GROUPS IN
THE STATE AS PART OF ANY ANTI
DISCRIMINATION TRAINING OR
DIVERSITY, EQUITY AND INCLUSION
TRAINING THAT IS ALREADY OFFERED
BY THE INSTITUTION. AND TO BE
CLEAR, THIS BILL DOES NOT TARGET
ANTI-SEMITISM. IT INCLUDES
ANTI-SEMITISM BECAUSE IT IS IN
THE TOP FIVE OF THOSE GROUPS. WE
THINK IT'S INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT
THAT ANY GROUP THAT'S BEING
TARGETED FOR DISCRIMINATION AND
HATRED BE INCLUDED IN DEI
TRAININGS TO MAKE SURE THAT IF A
MEMBER OF THOSE GROUPS FACES
DISCRIMINATION, THEN THEY HAVE
PEOPLE WHO ARE CULTURALLY
COMPETENT TO UNDERSTAND THE
SCOPE OF THAT DISCRIMINATION AND
TO UNDERSTAND HOW TO REACT. WE
ALSO THINK IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
THAT DEI PEOPLE, THE PEOPLE WHO
ARE TASKED WITH WORKING ON AN
INCLUSIVE CLIMATE AND A DIVERSE
CLIMATE ON UNIVERSITIES,
UNDERSTAND THE CHALLENGES FACED
BY THE DIFFERENT GROUPS THAT ARE
EXPERIENCING DISCRIMINATION IN
THE STATE. AND WHAT WE HAVE
DISCOVERED IS THAT IS NOT ALWAYS
THE CASE. I HAVE HAD A PROFESSOR
COME TO ME ABOUT ISSUES ON HIS
CAMPUS AND FEELING UNSAFE, AND I
ASKED HIM IF HE HAD GONE TO THE
DEI TRAINERS AT HIS SCHOOL, AND
HE SAID THAT THERE WAS NO JEWISH
VOICE REPRESENTED IN THE DEI
PROGRAM AT THE AT HIS COLLEGE AT
ALL. THERE WAS NOBODY WHO
UNDERSTOOD ANTI-SEMITISM, WAS
TRAINED IN IT, AND KNEW AND
UNDERSTOOD AND UNDERSTOOD WHAT
HIS CONCERNS WERE ABOUT
ANTI-SEMITIC ACTIVITIES ON
CAMPUS. THE CURRENT LAW SAYS
THAT ALL STUDENTS HAVE THE RIGHT
TO PARTICIPATE FULLY IN THE
EDUCATIONAL PROCESS, FREE FROM
DISCRIMINATION AND HARASSMENT,
BUT NO ONE CAN FOCUS ON THEIR
EDUCATION IF THEY DON'T FEEL
SAFE. WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT
OUR SCHOOLS ARE PROTECTIVE.
UNFORTUNATELY, THERE IS NO
STANDARD FOR DEI TRAINING ACROSS
OUR COLLEGE CAMPUSES. IT'S
REALLY UP TO THE INDIVIDUAL
UNIVERSITIES AS TO WHAT THEY
WANT TO FOCUS ON. IF CURRENT LAW
SAYS THAT CALIFORNIA'S COLLEGES
HAVE AN AFFIRMATIVE OBLIGATION
TO COMBAT RACISM, SEXISM, AND
OTHER FORMS OF BIAS, THEN LET'S
ENSURE THAT HATEFUL ACTS AND
DISCRIMINATIONS AGAINST TARGETED
COMMUNITIES LIKE THE JEWISH
COMMUNITY IS NOT LEFT OUT IN
THOSE TRAININGS IF IT'S ALREADY
BEING DONE ON THE CAMPUS.
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT THIS
AFTERNOON IS CLIFF BERG WITH THE
JEWISH, WITH THE JEWISH PUBLIC
AFFAIRS COMMITTEE OF CALIFORNIA.
I'D LIKE TO POINT OUT THAT THIS
BILL HAS RECEIVED WIDE
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT. IT IS ALSO
ONE OF THE, I BELIEVE, ONLY
THREE PRIORITIES FOR THE JEWISH
CAUCUS PRIORITY BILLS. SO I
WOULD APPRECIATE YOUR THOUGHTFUL
CONSIDERATION OF THIS BILL AND
REQUEST ORPHALI REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE ON AB 2925. MR. BERG,
WELCOME, MR. CHAIRMAN. CLIFF
BERG, ON BEHALF OF THE JEWISH
PUBLIC AFFAIRS COMMITTEE OF
CALIFORNIA, WHICH IS THE LARGEST
SINGLE STATE COALITION OF JEWISH
ORGANIZATIONS IN THE NATION,
WHICH IS PLEASED TO BE ABLE TO
SPONSOR THIS BILL ALONG WITH THE
JEWISH CAUCUS, AS THIS BILL
WOULD REQUIRE THE COLLEGE
CAMPUSES INCLUDE TRAINING TO
COMBAT AND ADDRESS ANTI-SEMITISM
AS PART OF ANY
ANTI-DISCRIMINATION TRAINING OR
DIVERSITY, EQUITY AND INCLUSION
TRAINING THAT IS OFFERED BY THE
INSTITUTION. I WANT TO BE CLEAR,
IN BEHALF OF JPAC, THAT OUR
PRIORITY AND OUR CONCERN THAT WE
SEE ON COLLEGE CAMPUSES AT THIS
MOMENT IN TIME IS A EXTREMELY
HIGH LEVEL OF VIOLENCE AND
HARASSMENT FOCUSED ON JEWISH
STUDENTS. BUT WE HAVE BEEN
CAREFUL IN DRAFTING THIS BILL TO
ENSURE THAT THIS BILL IS NOT
JUST ABOUT ANTI-SEMITISM, BUT IS
ABOUT DISCRIMINATION AND
HARASSMENT OF STUDENTS, WHETHER
THEY BE BASED ON RELIGION,
NATIONALITY, AND JUST JUST TO
QUOTE THE BILL, I WOULD POINT
OUT THAT THE BILL SAYS NO PERSON
SHALL BE SUBJECTED TO
DISCRIMINATION ON THE BASIS OF
DISABILITY, GENDER, GENDER
IDENTITY, GENDER EXPRESSION,
NATIONALITY, RACE OR ETHNICITY,
RELIGION, SEXUAL ORIENTATION, OR
ANY CHARACTERISTIC LISTED AS
DEFINED IN SECTION 1135 OF THE
GOVERNMENT CODE, I WOULD ALSO
WANT TO POINT OUT THAT THE BILL
CLEARLY STATES THAT IT IS THE
INTENT OF THE LEGISLATURE THAT
EACH POST SECONDARY EDUCATIONAL
INSTITUTION UNDER UNDERTAKE
EDUCATIONAL ACTIVITIES TO
COUNTER DISCRIMINATION. THREE
INCIDENTS ON CAMPUS AND WITHIN
CONSTITUTIONAL BOUNDS TO
MINIMIZE AND ELIMINATE A HOSTILE
ENVIRONMENT ON CAMPUS THAT
IMPAIRS THE ACCESS OF STUDENTS
TO EQUAL EDUCATIONAL OPPORTUNITY
. IN THE FIVE MONTHS FOLLOWING
THE HAMAS TERROR ATTACKS ON
OCTOBER 7TH, THE ADL REPORTED A
2,000% INCREASE OF INCIDENTS OF
ANTI-SEMITISM ON COLLEGE
CAMPUSES ACROSS THE STATE. THIS
BILL IS NEEDED. IT IS TIMELY AND
WE WOULD URGE YOUR SUPPORT. I
HAVE BEEN SOMEWHAT BRIEF IN
RESPECT TO THE COMMITTEE'S
TIMELINE HERE, BUT URGE, URGE
YOUR SUPPORT OF THIS
LEGISLATION. IT IS VERY MUCH
NEEDED. I APPRECIATE YOUR
TESTIMONY, OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF THE MEASURE. JESSICA
DUONG WITH THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA. WE HAVE A
SUPPORTIVE, AMENDED POSITION,
AND WE'RE HAPPY TO MOVE OUR
POSITION TO SUPPORT IN THE NEXT
COMMITTEE ONCE THE AMENDMENTS
HAVE BEEN CROSSED. THANK YOU.
APPRECIATE THAT, WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION, PLEASE COME FORWARD.
DO YOU CAN COME TO THE TABLE IF
YOU LIKE, SIR. WELCOME. THANK
YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON, CHAIR
NEWMAN. AND SENATE EDUCATION
COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS OMAR
AL-TAMIMI. I'M A SENIOR POLICY
COORDINATOR WITH THE COUNCIL OF
AMERICAN ISLAMIC RELATIONS IN
CALIFORNIA. I'M HERE ON BEHALF
OF CARE CALIFORNIA TO,
RESPECTFULLY EXPRESS OUR
OPPOSITION UNTIL AMENDED TO AB
2925, FOR THE FOLLOWING REASONS.
DESPITE THE BILL'S ORIGINAL
INTENT TO ADDRESS THE DRASTIC
RISE OF ISLAMOPHOBIA AND
ANTI-SEMITISM OCCURRING ON
COLLEGE CAMPUSES AS A RESULT OF
OCTOBER 7TH, NO MUSLIM
ORGANIZATIONS OR LEADERS,
INCLUDING CARE, THE LARGEST
MUSLIM CIVIL RIGHTS ORGANIZATION
IN THE COUNTRY, WERE CONSULTED
IN THE DRAFTING OF THIS BILL AS
A RESULT OF RECENT AMENDMENTS,
ANTI DISCRIMINATION TRAININGS ON
ISLAMOPHOBIA ARE, SORRY, ANTI
DISCRIMINATION TRAININGS ON
ISLAMOPHOBIA ARE NO LONGER
REQUIRED TO BE INCLUDED IN
HIGHER EDUCATION INSTITUTIONS.
ANTI-DISCRIMINATION AND DEI
TRAININGS. DESPITE THE ORIGINAL
INTENT OF THE BILL SEEKING TO
ADDRESS ANTI-SEMITISM AND
ISLAMOPHOBIA AND THE DRASTIC
RISE IN ISLAMOPHOBIA ACROSS THE
STATE IN THE COUNTRY THESE PAST
FEW MONTHS, LASTLY, WE'RE
CONCERNED THAT THE BILL COULD BE
USED TO CONFLATE FIRST AMENDMENT
PROTECTED SPEECH, SUCH AS
CRITICISM OF A FOREIGN COUNTRY
WITH DISCRIMINATION OR
HARASSMENT ON THE BASIS OF
NATIONALITY OR RELIGION. AS A
RESULT OF THE BILL'S OVER
BROADENING THE DEFINITION OF
NATIONALITY, WE'VE SPOKEN TO THE
AUTHOR'S OFFICE REGARDING THESE
CONCERNS, AND WE SUGGESTED THE
FOLLOWING AMENDMENTS TO ADDRESS
THESE CONCERNS. FIRST, REQUIRING
UNIVERSITIES TO INCLUDE
TRAININGS TO ADDRESS
DISCRIMINATION NOT ONLY AGAINST
THE TOP FIVE, MOST OR NOT ONLY
FOR THE TOP FIVE MOST TARGETED
GROUPS IN CALIFORNIA, BUT TO
ALSO INCLUDE THE TOP THREE MOST
TARGETED RELIGIOUS GROUPS, THIS
AMENDMENT OR SIMILAR AMENDMENTS
WOULD ENSURE THE BILL'S INTENT
TO ADDRESS ISLAMOPHOBIA AND
ANTI-SEMITISM IS MET, AND IN A
WAY THAT IS STILL NEUTRAL, STILL
CONTENT, NEUTRAL, AND ALSO
BOLSTER THE NUMBER OF GROUPS
REPRESENTED BY THE BILL ADOPTING
LANGUAGE DIRECTLY FROM THE U.S.
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION. AND
SECOND, SORRY, ADOPTING LANGUAGE
DIRECTLY FROM THE US DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION, OFFICE OF CIVIL
RIGHTS. THAT CLARIFIES THAT
SPEECH EXPRESSING VIEWS
REGARDING A PARTICULAR COUNTRY'S
POLICIES OR PRACTICES IS
PROTECTED BY THE FIRST AMENDMENT
AND DOES NOT NECESSARILY
IMPLICATE FEDERAL CIVIL RIGHTS
LAWS OR OTHER
ANTI-DISCRIMINATION LAWS COVERED
BY THIS BILL. THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION HAS PROVIDED SUCH
CLARIFYING LANGUAGE REGARDING
THE FIRST AMENDMENT, AND THERE
IS STRONG PRECEDENT TO INCLUDE
SUCH LANGUAGE IN THIS BILL, WITH
RESPECT, YOU KNOW, THE INTENT OF
THE BILL AND THE AUTHOR'S WORK
ON THE BILL, THEY DECIDED NOT TO
MOVE WITH OUR PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS. UNFORTUNATELY, WE'RE
DISAPPOINTED THAT THE BILL
CONTINUES TO IGNORE THE MUSLIM
PERSPECTIVE, BUT WE'RE WILLING
TO TRY, IN GOOD FAITH, TO
PROPOSE REASONABLE AMENDMENTS
AND WORK WITH THE AUTHOR'S
OFFICE TO ACCOMPLISH THAT. WHILE
WE APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S
INTENT, AGAIN, TO ADDRESS
ISLAMOPHOBIA AND ANTI-SEMITISM,
THERE'S A CLEAR GAP IN THE
BILL'S INTENT IN THE EXECUTION
OR THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
BILL, AND IT FAILS TO
SUBSTANTIVELY INCLUDE MUSLIMS OR
ADDRESS THE RISE OF ISLAMOPHOBIA
IN ANY MEANINGFUL WAY. THANK
YOU, THANK YOU. ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION SEEING
NONE. OH, COME BACK TO THE DAIS,
COLLEAGUES. QUESTIONS, COMMENTS?
GO AHEAD. SENATOR CORTEZ. JUST A
QUESTION FOR THE OPPOSITION
WITNESS, IN READING THE ANALYSIS
ON THE BILL, WHAT IS LISTED AS
PARAGRAPH 12 OF THE, THE PORTION
OF THE ANALYSIS THAT DESCRIBES
THE BILL ITSELF, IT TALKS ABOUT.
WELL, IT'S JUST ONE SENTENCE. SO
I'M GOING TO GO AHEAD AND READ
IT, IF THAT'S ALL RIGHT. SURE IT
SAYS EXPANDS THE DEFINITION OF
RELIGION TO ALSO DEFINE, QUOTE,
DISCRIMINATION ON THE BASIS OF
RELIGION. END QUOTE, TO INCLUDE
BUT NOT BE LIMITED TO
ANTI-SEMITISM AND ISLAMOPHOBIA.
SO IT SEEMS TO ME, ON ITS FACE,
THAT THE BILL IS CERTAINLY
BALANCED, AT LEAST AS TO THOSE
TWO. ISSUES, WHAT? I'M NOT. I
ALSO HAVE RECEIVED KIND OF A
LATE, LATE FOR ME. ANYWAY, A
LETTER, YOU KNOW, INDICATING
WHAT YOUR OPPOSITION IS BASED
ON. YOU KNOW, I'M TRYING TO
BETTER UNDERSTAND, THE FINER
POINTS OF YOUR OPPOSITION
BECAUSE IT SEEMS LIKE YOU ARE
MAKING, YOU KNOW, SOME
RELATIVELY TECHNICAL ISSUES. I'M
AN ATTORNEY. I UNDERSTAND THE
FIRST AMENDMENT. YOU WANT THAT
TO STAND ON ITS OWN. YOU DON'T
WANT THE BILL YOU WANT TO MAKE.
IT SOUNDS LIKE YOU WANT TO MAKE
THE MAKE IT CLEAR IN THE BILL
THAT, THAT FIRST AMENDMENT
RIGHTS ARE NOT COMPROMISED OR
TRAMPLED BY ANY REFERENCES IN
THE BILL TO FEDERAL CIVIL RIGHTS
LAW OR SOMETHING ALONG THOSE
LINES, MAYBE CLARIFY THAT WHAT
THE OTHER ISSUE IS ON TRAINING.
I'VE SEEN REFERENCE TO YOUR
DESIRE FOR SPECIFIC LANGUAGE
THAT ISLAMOPHOBIA WOULD BE
INCLUDED IN TRAINING, OR AT
LEAST THAT'S IN THE NOTES
PROVIDED BY MY STAFF. IS THAT
IT? IS THAT WHAT'S NEEDED IN
TERMS OF AMENDMENTS? BECAUSE I
WANT TO A POINT HERE. I WANT TO
GO BACK TO THE AUTHOR AND ASK
FOR THE AUTHOR'S RESPONSE TO
THAT. ABSOLUTELY, ON THAT FIRST
POINT, I THINK WE'D AGREE ON ON
THE CONCERN FOR THE FIRST
AMENDMENT. I THINK THAT ANYTHING
IN THERE JUST STIPULATING,
NATIONALITY WOULD, YOU KNOW,
SEPARATE IT IT WOULD BE A
SEPARATION BETWEEN IDENTITY AND
SPEECH THAT WAS CRITICAL OF A
NATION. AND I THINK THAT'S
THAT'S REALLY WHERE THE CONCERN
STEMS FROM, AND WITH REGARDS TO
THE SECOND POINT, I BELIEVE IF
WE GO TO THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S,
KIND OF DOCUMENT VERSION OF, YOU
KNOW, THE YEARLY REPORT THAT'S
PRESENTED, THERE ARE DIFFERENT
CATEGORIES BASED ON NATIONAL
ORIGIN, ETHNICITY AND RELIGION.
AND THOSE ARE TWO SEPARATE, KIND
OF FACTORS IN DETERMINANTS. AND
SO ISLAMOPHOBIA, WHICH IS MORE
SO RECOGNIZED AS RELIGIOUS
DISCRIMINATION AND NOT ETHNIC
DISCRIMINATE THÀNH WOULD BE LEFT
OUT, BUT WE SEE THAT AS, AS A
SAU OVERSIGHT, CONSIDERING THE
DRASTIC RISE IN ISLAMOPHOBIA
THIS PAST YEAR, YOU'RE SAYING
IT'S LEFT OUT ON THE TRAINING
SIDE? CLEARLY, IT'S NOT LEFT OUT
OF THE BILL. I MEAN, THE BILL IS
EVIDENTLY AT LEAST BASED ON OUR
COMMITTEE'S ANALYSIS, PUTTING
ANTI-SEMITISM AND ISLAMOPHOBIA
SIDE BY SIDE IN TERMS OF LEVEL
OF CONCERN, I DON'T I DON'T SEE
ANY DISPARITY IN THE CONCERN
LEVEL IN THE BILL, SO I'M TRYING
TO UNDERSTAND I WANT TO PUT
WORDS IN YOUR MOUTH. IT LOOKED
LIKE MAYBE YOUR CONCERN WAS DOES
IS, IS THE TRAINING GOING TO BE
EQUALLY SITUATED BETWEEN THOSE
TWO ISSUES? CORRECT AND I
BELIEVE THE BILL IS WRONG. JUST
TELL ME WHAT IT IS. I BELIEVE
THE BILL ACTUALLY DROPPED THE
LANGUAGE ON ANTI-SEMITISM AND
ISLAMOPHOBIA AND KIND OF JUST
MADE IT BROADLY DEFINED TO
DISCRIMINATE THÀNH, AND WE
WELCOMED BOTH VERSIONS, BUT
YEAH, WE DON'T NECESSARILY HAVE
A PROBLEM OF IT NOT BEING
EQUALLY FOOTED OR, YOU KNOW,
EQUALLY MISREPRESENTED, IN THAT
SENSE, BUT RATHER WHEN THIS DATA
IS TAKEN, THE QUESTION AND FROM
OUR END, IT'S THE LOGISTICAL
QUESTION OF IMPLEMENTATION FOR
THESE TRAININGS IS, YOU KNOW, AS
THIS IS PUBLISHED FROM YEAR TO
YEAR, HOW DO WE ASSESS WHAT
THOSE FIVE GROUPS ARE GOING TO
BE, AND HOW DO WE MAKE SURE THAT
STUDENTS ON COLLEGE CAMPUSES ARE
REPRESENTED? WELL, IF WE'RE
LIMITING IT TO FIVE GROUPS IN
TERMS OF THIS KIND OF
DISCRIMINATION TRAINING, AND WE
FEEL THAT, IF WE WERE TO KEEP
THE FIVE OR THE FIVE GROUPS
BASED ON NATION OR IDENTITY, AS
WELL AS INCLUDE THREE MORE
GROUPS FROM RELIGIOUS
BACKGROUNDS, IT WOULD CREATE OR
EVEN EXPAND THE FIVE TO A LARGER
NUMBER. IT WOULD IT WOULD CREATE
A MORE REPRESENTATIVE, KIND OF
TRAINING FOR, FOR STUDENT BODY
ON CAMPUSES. RIGHT. OKAY. THANK
YOU. I DON'T WANT TO DIVE ANY
MORE INTO INTO THE WEEDS FOR A
COUPLE OF REASONS HERE. ONE IS
JUST IN CONSIDERATION OF TIME
CONSTRAINTS. BUT I WOULD,
THROUGH THE CHAIR, LIKE TO JUST
ASK THE AUTHOR, SURE. THAT'S
STILL BEING CONSIDERED OR WORKED
ON. IT'S REALLY KNOW AS A MEMBER
HERE. IT'S THE FIRST I'VE HEARD
OF THOSE SPECIFIC CONCERNS
TODAY. THAT'S WHY I WANTED TO
ASK THE QUESTIONS ABOUT THEM.
AND I WANT TO BE REALLY CLEAR.
THE ORIGINAL VERSION OF THE BILL
CALLED OUT ANTI-SEMITISM AND
ISLAMOPHOBIA. THE REASON IT WAS
TAKEN OUT IS AT THE INSISTENCE
OF THE COMMITTEES ON THE
ASSEMBLY SIDE, JUDICIARY AND
HIGHER EDUCATION, THAT DID NOT
WANT TO START NAMING GROUPS THAT
NEED TO BE INCLUDED. WHAT WE
PIVOTED TO INSTEAD WAS TO SAY,
YOU CAN TEACH AS MANY GROUPS AS
YOU WANT. NOTHING LIMITS A
UNIVERSITY FROM TEACHING, FROM
TRAINING ON TEN GROUPS, ON 20
GROUPS. WHAT WE SAID IS WE WANT
YOU TO AT LEAST INCLUDE THE
GROUP AT THAT MOMENT AND THAT
YEAR, WHOEVER IS IN THE TOP
FIVE, BECAUSE THAT LIST CAN
CHANGE RIGHT NOW. MAYBE
ANTI-SEMITISM AND ISLAMOPHOBIA
IS A PROBLEM. SEVERAL YEARS AGO,
ANTI-ASIAN HATE WAS A BIG
PROBLEM, AND I DIDN'T LOOK AT
THE STATISTICS. BUT SOMETIMES
GROUPS MOVE UP. UNFORTUNATELY
INTO THE GROUPS THAT ARE BEING
MOST TARGETED AT THAT MOMENT. SO
WE LEFT IT TO WHERE THE
UNIVERSITIES ARE FREE TO HAVE
TRAININGS ON WHATEVER GROUPS
THEY WANT, BUT WE WANT THEM TO
AT LEAST INCLUDE THE GROUPS, THE
TOP FIVE GROUPS EXPERIENCING THE
MOST DISCRIMINATION. NOW, IN
THAT LIST, THERE ARE GROUPS THAT
ARE RELIGIONS AND THERE ARE
GROUPS THAT ARE ETHNICITIES. SO
SOMETIMES YOU'LL SEE A GROUP
THAT MAYBE IT'S AN ISLAMIC, FOR
INSTANCE, OR MUSLIMS MIGHT MOVE
UP INTO THAT GROUP. IT'S NOT
JUST ABOUT RACIAL GROUPS THAT
THAT THAT LIST IS GROUPS WITH
LARGE. SO THAT WAS REMOVED AT
THE INSISTENCE ON THE COMMITTEES
ON THE OTHER SIDE OF THE HOUSE
FOR A VARIETY OF LEGAL REASONS
AND OTHER REASONS. THEY WANTED
TO NOT START CALLING OUT
SPECIFIC GROUPS. SO WE CANNOT GO
BACK AND GO BACK TO THE ORIGINAL
VERSION OF THE BILL. AND THEY
WERE VERY VALID REASONS THAT
THEY HAD FOR NOT DOING IT THAT
WAY. BUT THIS IS NOT LIMITED TO
FIVE GROUPS. THIS IS NOT THERE'S
NOTHING IN THE BILL THAT TELLS
THE UNIVERSITY YOU CAN ONLY
TEACH THESE FIVE GROUPS WE WANT.
THIS IS ADDITIVE. WHAT WE SAW
WAS THAT THEY ARE TEACHING
SEVERAL OF THESE GROUPS, BUT
MANY OF THEM ARE NOT, INCLUDING
GROUPS LIKE LET'S SAY, ISLAMIC
STUDENTS OR THEY'RE NOT, YOU
KNOW, THEY DON'T PROVIDE
TRAINING ON ANTI-SEMITISM. WE
WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT IF A
GROUP IS EXPERIENCING
DISCRIMINATION AND HATRED, THAT
THEY ARE BEING INCLUDED IN DEI
TRAINING. SO WHAT IS WHAT I'M
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND IS WHAT
WHAT INFORMS THE NECESSITY FOR
THE TRAINING IS IT IS IT
FREQUENCY OR DATA OF NÓ? THERE
IS DATA ABOUT THE GROUPS THAT
ARE BEING DISCRIMINATED AGAINST
IN CALIFORNIA. SO THAT THAT SETS
YOUR STANDARD FOR THE FIVE
GROUPS THAT HAVE TO BE INCLUDED.
MOST DISCRIMINATED AGAINST, MOST
DISCRIMINATED AGAINST. RIGHT.
THE TOP SITTING IN THE BACK OF A
CLASSROOM AND A PROFESSOR REFERS
TO ITALIAN AMERICANS AS WITHOUT
PAPERS. THIS IS A SLUR, WOULD
YOU SAY THE FACULTY OUGHT TO BE
TRAINED NOT TO DO THAT? OR DOES
THAT DEPEND ON HOW MANY TIMES
THOSE PROFESSORS EITHER WE DON'T
REQUIRE ANY DEI TRAINING TO
UNDERSTAND. SURE. SO OKAY, LET
ME LET ME TAKE A STEP BACK,
TAKING IT AWAY FROM SO THIS HAS
NOTHING TO DO. LET ME USE MY
GROUP AS AN EXAMPLE. RIGHT. TO
AVOID THE APPRECIATE THAT THIS
HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH THEIR
RESPONSIBILITY IN TERMS OF A
COMPLAINT THAT MIGHT BE MADE IN
YOUR CASE WITH THE SLUR. THIS
HAS TO DO WITH SCHOOLS THAT ARE
ALREADY GIVING DEI TRAINING. SO
WE'RE NOT SETTING UP ANY NEW
TRAINING. THIS IS NOT REQUIRING
ANY NEW TRAINING. MANY OF OUR
COLLEGE CAMPUSES, INCLUDING THE
UCS, ALREADY PROVIDE DEI
TRAINING, SOMETIMES TO STUDENTS,
OFTEN TO FACULTY. SOMETIMES THEY
HAVE A DEI DEPARTMENT THAT LOOKS
AT THEIR POLICIES. ALL WE SAY
IS, IF YOU ALREADY ARE DOING
DIVERSITY, INCLUSION AND EQUITY
TRAINING, WE WANT YOU TO INCLUDE
IT TO HAVE THESE FIVE GROUPS
INCLUDED. WE DON'T WANT YOU OFF
JUST TEACHING GROUPS THAT YOU
FEEL THAT YOU WANT TO TEACH, AND
IGNORING GROUPS THAT ARE FACING
DISCRIMINATION. SO WE'RE NOT
REQUIRING ANY NEW TRAINING. IF
YOU'RE A IF YOU'RE A PRIVATE
UNIVERSITY AND YOU DON'T DO DEI,
WE DON'T FORCE YOU TO DO IT. SO
WE'RE NOT CREATING NEW PROGRAMS.
WE'RE SAYING IF YOU ALREADY HAVE
A DEI PROGRAM, WHICH WHERE THERE
IS NO STANDARD FOR IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA, THERE ARE MANY.
ALL THE SCHOOLS THAT HAVE DEI
HAVE COME UP WITH THEM PRETTY
MUCH ON THEIR OWN. THEY GO OUT
AND THEY HIRE SOMEONE WHO'S A
DEI EXPERT, OR THEY CREATE THEIR
OWN DEI PROGRAM. SO THIS IS A
RELATIVELY NEW PHENOMENA OF
THESE DEI PROGRAMS. THERE'S NO
STATE STANDARD AS FAR AS I KNOW,
AS TO WHAT'S TAUGHT OR HOW OR BY
WHOM. SO IT'S BECOMING MORE AND
MORE COMMON ACROSS THE STATE.
BUT IT'S BY NO MEANS A UNIVERSAL
AT OUR AT OUR HIGHER EDUCATION
INSTITUTIONS. SO I JUST WANTED
TO CLARIFY FOR YOUR QUESTION.
THE BILL REFERS TO THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S REPORT ON INCIDENCES
OF HATE. SO THE FIVE ARE WHAT
ARE DETERMINED BY THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S DATA COMPILATION THÀNH
AS BEING THE FIVE GROUPS THAT
ARE THE MOST TARGETED OF HATE.
HATE IN CALIFORNIA. BUT AS THE
ASSEMBLYWOMAN SAID, THE BILL
SCHOOLS ARE NOT LIMITED FROM
INCLUDING ANY OTHERS THAT THEY
WANT TO INCLUDE. AND WE
CERTAINLY WOULD ENCOURAGE AS YOU
KNOW, AND THE BILL CALLS OUT, AS
YOU MENTIONED, ISLAMOPHOBIA AS
AS BEING SOMETHING PARTICULARLY
OF CONCERN. SO AND TO BE CLEAR,
IS THAT AN ANNUAL REPORT OR IS
IT WHAT'S THE IT'S A DATA SET
FOR WHAT I BELIEVE IT'S ANNUAL
OKAY. YEAH. RIGHT. SO YOU KNOW
FAIRLY DYNAMIC. IT'S GOING TO
CHANGE ON AN ANNUAL BASIS. AND
THAT'S WHY THEY DIDN'T WANT US
TO START NAMING PARTICULAR
GROUPS BECAUSE HOPEFULLY WE HAVE
PEACE IN THE MIDDLE EAST SOON.
AND THIS IS LESS OF AN ISSUE
GOING FORWARD. RIGHT. WELL, IF I
MAY, I WOULD ALSO SAY THE HARM
IN NAMING SPECIFIC GROUPS IS IF
EVEN ONE STUDENT IS
DISCRIMINATED AGAINST OR ARE THE
RECIPIENT OF HATE CRIME, AS
DEFINED, REGARDLESS OF WHETHER
THEY'RE IN IN A TOP FIVE OR NOT.
IT'S MY OPINION THAT THAT SHOULD
BE ADDRESSED. IF WE'RE GOING TO
DO LEGISLATION, WE OUGHT TO BE
MAKING SURE THAT, IN EFFECT, YOU
KNOW, NOBODY, NOBODY IS STANDING
ALONE. NOBODY'S LEFT ALONE TO
FIGHT FOR THEMSELVES. AND THAT
AND THAT THE NECESSARY TRAINING
OCCURS AND I WAS JUST TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT WHETHER OR NOT AN
INDIVIDUAL OCCASION WOULD
TRIGGER, WOULD TRIGGER TRAINING.
AND IT SOUNDS LIKE THAT'S UP TO
THE UNIVERSITY BASED ON WHAT
YOU'RE SAYING. NOT PRESCRIBED BY
LAW. RIGHT. SO IT'S NOT
PRESCRIBED BY LAW. IT'S NOT
PRESCRIBED BY LAW. NOW, THEY
DON'T HAVE TO HAVE DEI PROGRAMS
AT ALL. THEY DON'T HAVE TO THEY
HAVE TO ADDRESS DISCRIMINATION
UNDER FEDERAL LAW. SO THEY
ALREADY HAVE TO DO THAT. BUT
THEY DON'T HAVE TO RESPOND BY
HAVING A DEI PROGRAM. AND I
WOULD THINK THAT IN CERTAIN
PARTS OF THE STATE, THEIR DEI
PROGRAMS MIGHT HAVE DIFFERENT
GROUPS BECAUSE THEY MAY HAVE A
HIGH CONCENTRATION OF A GROUP
THAT'S NOT SEEN IN OTHER PARTS
OF THE STATE. FOR INSTANCE. I
APPRECIATE THAT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FOR THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER? GO AHEAD. SENATOR THANK
YOU, MR. CHAIR. AND THANK YOU
FOR THIS DISCUSSION. AND MY
QUESTION HAD TO DO WITH THE
NATIONALITY PIECE OF THIS. AND,
UNDERSTANDING HOW IMPORTANT
TITLE SEVEN IS AND WHAT
PROTECTED CLASSES ARE UNDERNEATH
THAT. THE ANALYSIS SEEMS TO SHOW
TWO THAT THAT THIS WOULD ALSO
SORT OF BE PUTTING NATIONALITY
UNDER A PROTECTED CLASS. AND I'M
CONCERNED ABOUT, TAMPERING WITH
WHAT ARE PROTECTED CLASSES AND
WHAT ISN'T A PROTECTED CLASS.
WHAT IS INCLUDED IN THE DI AND
WHAT WE'RE ADDING, PARTICULARLY
WHERE IT COMES FROM, FROM THE
STANDPOINT OF NATIONALITY, I, I
UNDERSTAND AND THE INTENTION OF
THIS AND I AND I APPRECIATE IT.
AND I'M ALWAYS ABOUT EXPANDING,
ANTI-DISCRIMINATION PROTECTIONS,
BUT I AM A BIT THIS QUESTION OF
NATIONALITY IS ONE THAT'S
STICKING WITH ME BECAUSE I'M,
I'M UNCLEAR IF WE ARE PULLING
THAT INTO THIS SORT OF FRAME OF
A PROTECTED CLASS AND WHAT THE
IMPLICATIONS OF THAT ARE,
BECAUSE RIGHT NOW THAT IS NOW
FALLING UNDER THE DISCRIMINATION
UMBRELLA, WHICH I FOR ME IS A
TITLE SEVEN FRAMEWORK. AND I'M
TRYING TO MAKE SURE I'M, I'M
UNDERSTOOD HOW THIS MIGHT AFFECT
THAT. IT'S NOT MY UNDERSTANDING
THAT THE BILL IS REDEFINING WHAT
IS UNDER TITLE SEVEN OR, OR
REDEFINING DISCRIMINATION AND
CHANGING NATIONALITY. IT IS
SIMPLY GOING BY. IT IS SAYING
THAT IN DEI PROGRAMS, YOU HAVE
TO INCLUDE THE TOP FIVE GROUPS
THAT THE AG DETERMINES AS THE
TARGET OF DISCRIMINATION AND
HATE INCIDENCES ACROSS THE
STATE. IT MIGHT BE A
NATIONALITY. IT'S POSSIBLE THAT
A GROUP FROM A CERTAIN
NATIONALITY BECOMES A TARGET OF
DISCRIMINATION. I DON'T KNOW IF
THAT'S THE CASE RIGHT NOW. AND
THAT LIST, I DON'T THINK IT IS,
ACTUALLY. BUT IF FOR SOME REASON
A PARTICULAR ETHNICITY,
PARTICULAR NATIONALITY OF A
GROUP WAS BEING TARGETED, I
WOULD THINK THAT WE WOULD WANT
THAT GROUP REPRESENTED IN DEI
TRAINING. WE'RE NOT CHANGING ANY
DEFINITIONS OF WHAT
DISCRIMINATION IS OR, THIS THIS
BILL IS NOT SO EXPANSIVE AS TO
BE CHANGING ANY OF THOSE
DEFINITIONS. IT SIMPLY IS SAYING
THAT IF YOU HAVE A DEI PROGRAM,
YOU NEED TO INCLUDE AND YOU CAN
EXPAND, HOPEFULLY THEY EXPAND
WHAT THEY'RE ALREADY DOING TO
INCLUDE GROUPS THAT WE KNOW ARE
EXPERIENCING DISCRIMINATION AND
HATRED IN THE STATE. WE WANT OUR
DEI PROGRAMS TO ACTUALLY BE
RESPONSIVE TO THE EXPERIENCES OF
STUDENTS AND TO THE EXPERIENCES
OF COMMUNITIES, NOT TO BE OFF
TEACHING SOMETHING THAT'S THAT'S
NOT GERMANE TO THE
DISCRIMINATION THAT'S HAPPENING
ON THEIR CAMPUSES AND HAPPENING
IN COMMUNITIES. AND THIS JUST
GUARANTEES THAT THEY RECOGNIZE
THAT THAT LIST CHANGES, THAT
THERE ARE GROUPS OUT THERE THAT
ARE EXPERIENCING SOMETIMES RAPID
INCREASES IN DISCRIMINATION, AND
THEY SHOULD BE TRAINING THEIR
PROFESSORS TO RECOGNIZE THAT
WHEN IT HAPPENS UNDER THEIR
NOSES ON COLLEGE. AND THAT'S
WHAT THIS IS SEEKING TO DO. IT'S
NOT CHANGING THE ANY OF THE
DEFINITIONS OF WHAT
DISCRIMINATION MEANS OR ANYTHING
LIKE THAT. WE'RE GOING BY THE
LIST THAT THE AG KEEPS OF HATE
CRIMES AND DISCRIMINATION. SURE.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS, COMMENTS?
DO WE HAVE A MOTION? SENATOR
WILK MAKES THE MOTION. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER, WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
THIS? I APPRECIATE THE ROBUST
DISCUSSION, AND I THINK THAT WE
ARE ALL DOING OUR BEST TO TRY TO
MAKE SURE THAT OUR COLLEGE
CAMPUSES ARE SAFE FOR OUR
STUDENTS AND THAT WE CELEBRATE
AND RECOGNIZE DIVERSITY FOR
EVERYBODY. THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
WITH THAT, MADAM CONSULTANT,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL CALL. ITEM
28 AB 2925 FRIEDMAN. MOTION IS
DUE PASSED THE SENATE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE. NEWMAN NEWMAN, IOTA
TOBAGI. CORTEZ. CORTEZ GLASER.
GLASER I. GONZALEZ. SMALLWOOD
CUEVAS. WILK I WILK I, THAT
MEASURE CURRENTLY HAS FIVE
VOTES. WE WILL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR
THE ABSENT MEMBER. THANK YOU. SO
THANK YOU, MR. CONNOLLY. A VERY
PATIENT MAN WITH YOUR DOUBLE
REFERRED BILL, GLAD TO HAVE YOU
HERE. SORRY ABOUT THE LONG WAIT.
WE WILL PROCEED WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY. THANK YOU. CHAIR AND
MEMBERS, I'D LIKE TO BEGIN BY
THANKING THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
THEIR WORK ON THIS BILL, AND I
WILL BE ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE'S AMENDMENTS. AB 2968
WILL REQUIRE ALL SCHOOLS WITHIN
A HIGH OR VERY HIGH RISK FIRE
HAZARD SEVERITY ZONE TO FOLLOW
DEFENSIBLE SPACE SAFETY
STANDARDS AND ESTABLISH A PLAN
FOR EVACUATING STUDENTS, STAFF
AND FACULTY IN THE EVENT OF A
WILDFIRE. DEFENSIBLE SPACE AND
EVACUATION PROTOCOLS SAFEGUARD
LIVES, REDUCE PROPERTY DAMAGE
AND ENSURE THE SAFETY OF
RESPONDING FIREFIGHTERS. MANY
SCHOOLS BELIEVE THEY WILL HAVE
ADEQUATE TIME TO NOTIFY PARENTS
AND HAVE THEM PICK UP THEIR
CHILDREN BEFORE A WILDFIRE MOVES
THROUGH A SCHOOL. HOWEVER, THE
CAMP FIRE IN 2018, AS AN
EXAMPLE, PROVED THAT A FIRE MAY
MOVE THROUGH A SCHOOL MORE
QUICKLY THAN PARENTS CAN PICK UP
THEIR CHILDREN, AND THE
CONGESTION OF PICKUP CAN POSE A
DISRUPTION TO RESPONDING.
EMERGENCY RESOURCES. THE CAMP
FIRE MOVED THROUGH THE TOWN OF
PARADISE SO QUICKLY THAT SOME
SCHOOLS NEVER EVEN RECEIVED AN
EVACUATION NOTICE. ADEQUATE,
DEFENSIBLE SPACE ACTS AS A
BARRIER TO SLOW OR HALT THE
PROGRESS OF A FIRE, ALLOWING
MORE TIME FOR EVACUATION AND
HELPING TO ENSURE THE SAFETY OF
RESPONDING. FIREFIGHTERS BY
IMPROVING OUR DEFENSIBLE SPACE
STANDARDS IN SCHOOLS AND
CREATING A COMPREHENSIVE
WILDFIRE EVACUATION PLAN, AB
2968 WILL ENSURE THAT OUR
SCHOOLS ARE ABLE TO EFFECTIVELY
FACILITATE AN EVACUATION IN THE
EVENT OF A WILDFIRE. THIS BILL
HAS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND NO
OPPOSITION ON FILE. I WILL NOW
PASS IT OFF TO TWO WITNESSES.
MARK BROWN, THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF MARIN WILDFIRE
PREVENTION AUTHORITY, AND KIM
JULIUS VÌ, DIVISION CHIEF AND
FIRE MARSHAL FOR WOODSIDE FIRE,
WELCOME TO BOTH OF YOU. PLEASE
PROCEED. GOOD AFTERNOON. CHAIR
NEWMAN, COMMITTEE MEMBERS. MY
NAME IS MARK BROWN, EXECUTIVE
OFFICER FOR MARIN WILDFIRE
PREVENTION AUTHORITY. PRIOR TO
BEING WITH MARIN WILDFIRE, I WAS
THE DEPUTY FIRE CHIEF FOR MARIN
COUNTY FIRE, SERVED THERE FOR 30
YEARS. AS PART OF MY ROLE THERE,
I WAS ALSO A MEMBER OF A CAL
FIRE INCIDENT MANAGEMENT TEAM
FOR 15 YEARS AS OPERATIONS
SECTION CHIEF, AND WAS IN A
COMMAND ROLE OF SOME OF THE
STATE'S MOST DISASTROUS FIRES,
INCLUDING THE CAMP FIRE THAT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CONNOLLY
MENTIONED. MARIN WILDFIRE
DEFINITELY SUPPORTS AB 2968. AND
I'D LIKE TO GIVE YOU A COUPLE OF
EXAMPLES. WHY I'M NOT GOING TO
TALK ABOUT THE CAMP FIRE.
ACTUALLY, I'M GOING TO TALK
ABOUT, IN 2014, A FIRE CALLED
THE BOWLES FIRE IN. WE'D FAST
MOVING FIRE HAPPENED RIGHT NEXT
TO A SCHOOL THAT WAS A K THROUGH
EIGHT SCHOOL. THEY HAD NEVER
THOUGHT ABOUT SHELTERING IN
PLACE AT THAT LOCATION, EVEN
THOUGH THAT LOCATION, IF YOU
LOOK AT IT IN THE AFTER EFFECT,
IS AN AWESOME SPOT TO SHELTER
CHILDREN IN PLACE. HOWEVER THEY
EVACUATED THE CHILDREN UNDER
HOSTILE FIRE CONDITIONS, HAD TO
KEEP THE CHILDREN SAFE WITH WITH
NUMEROUS FIRE ENGINES WHILE THEY
EVACUATED TO ANOTHER SCHOOL. A
PERSONAL EXPERIENCE IS THE GLASS
FIRE BURNED THROUGH MY
NEIGHBORHOOD AND MY SISTER LIVES
IN A NEIGHBORHOOD, AND SHE WAS
CALLING ME, WELL, WHAT SHOULD I
DO IF I CAN'T EVACUATE IN TIME?
I SAID, GO TO THE SCHOOL. AND
FORTUNATELY SHE WAS ABLE TO
EVACUATE IN TIME. HOWEVER, THE
SCHOOL WAS COMPLETELY SAFE. NOT
A SINGLE BIT OF SUPPRESSION
EFFORT FOR THAT SCHOOL. WHILE
THAT HAPPENED AT NIGHT, IF IT
WAS DURING THE DAY, IT WOULD
HAVE BEEN A TREMENDOUSLY SAFE
PLACE FOR CHILDREN TO SHELTER IN
PLACE. THE LAST EXAMPLE I WANT
TO GIVE IS THE EXTENSIVE
EVACUATION MODELING THAT WE'VE
DONE IN MARIN, AND WE'VE
ACTUALLY MODELED WHAT IT LOOKS
LIKE IF PARENTS ARE COMING BACK
TO GET THE STUDENTS COMPARED TO
IF WE SHELTER THE STUDENTS IN
PLACE AND WE HAVE THE MODELING
IS SHOWING UP TO AN HOUR
DECREASE IN EVACUATING THE
COMMUNITY. IF WE SHELTER THE
STUDENTS IN PLACE. SO THIS
ASSEMBLY BILL WILL ALLOW FOR THE
PLANNING, THE HARDENING OF THE
SCHOOLS, THE DEFENSIBLE SPACE
REQUIREMENTS, CREATING PLANS FOR
SHELTER IN PLACE, EDUCATING THE
PARENTS BECAUSE TRYING TO KEEP
THE PARENTS FROM GOING TO GET
THEIR CHILDREN IS GOING TO BE A
VERY STEEP EDUCATIONAL CURVE,
BUT ALSO ALLOWS US TO ESTABLISH
REUNIFICATION PLANS BECAUSE IN
REALITY WE'RE TALKING HOURS, NOT
DAYS. AND WITH THAT, WE SUPPORT
2968. THANK YOU AND WELCOME.
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON. I
THINK MY COLLEAGUE HERE PRETTY
MUCH SAID EVERYTHING THAT NEEDED
TO BE SAID, BUT AS A
JURISDICTION, ALSO IN A WILDLAND
URBAN INTERFACE JURISDICTION, WE
HAVE NOW ADOPTED A NEW ORDINANCE
THAT APPLIES TO OUR ENTIRE
DISTRICT. AND THAT ORDINANCE
REQUIRES A DEFENSIBLE SPACE THAT
GOES ACROSS ALL DIFFERENT ZONES,
WHETHER YOU'RE HIGH, VERY HIGH,
MODERATE. IT DOESN'T MATTER
BECAUSE FIRE DOESN'T HAVE ANY
BOUNDARIES. AND SO WITH THIS
BILL, WE WERE PLEASED TO SUPPORT
AND SEE IT MOVING FORWARD. THE
IMPORTANCE OF DEFENSIBLE SPACE
IS NOT JUST WITHIN THE HOMES.
IT'S NOT JUST PEOPLE'S HOUSES.
IT'S ALSO THE SCHOOLS WHERE THE
CHILDREN ARE, WHERE STUDENTS
ARE, AND IT'S PROTECTING THAT
STRUCTURE FOR THROUGH THE
DEFENSIBLE SPACE, WE'D BE ABLE
TO CREATE NOT JUST AN AREA THAT
WOULD INCREASE THE SURVIVABILITY
K¾T OF THE SCHOOLS, BUT IT ALSO
GIVES US A LOCATION FOR
FIREFIGHTERS TO OFFER STRUCTURE
PROTECTION IN INSTANCES WHERE
SHELTER IN PLACE IS RECOMMENDED,
SOMETIMES SHELTERING IN PLACE IS
THE BEST SOLUTION GIVEN THE
MOVEMENT AND HOW QUICKLY FIRES
MOVE. ESPECIALLY WE'RE IN A
HEAVY VEGETATIVE AREA AND EVEN
THOUGH IT'S HARD FOR PARENTS TO
COMPREHEND THAT THIS IS
SOMETIMES THE BEST SAFETY
MEASURE TO PUT IN PLACE TO
PROTECT OUR CHILDREN, WHICH IS
WHY THE DEFENSIBLE SPACE IS
CRUCIAL AS WELL AS THE HARDENING
OF THE STRUCTURE, WHICH WOULD BE
IN COMPLIANCE WITH THE CURRENT
BUILDING. CHAPTER A, CHAPTER
SEVEN A REQUIREMENTS. THE OTHER
REASON WHY WE'D LIKE TO SUPPORT
THIS BILL IS WE THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT THE SCHOOLS AND
THE FIRE DEPARTMENT CONTINUE TO
WORK TOGETHER IN AND WITH
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT TONIGHT TO
PREVENT ANY OF THESE
CATASTROPHIC EVENTS, BECAUSE
THEY'RE GOING TO HAPPEN. BUT WE
NEED TO BE PREPARED. SO WITH
THAT, I KNOW IT'S SAKE OF TIME.
I JUST WANT TO SAY WE SUPPORT
THIS BILL. THANK YOU, I
APPRECIATE THAT. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY. IS THERE ANYBODY
ELSE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THIS
MEASURE? SEEING NONE IS THERE
ANY OPPOSITION? OH, PLEASE GO
AHEAD. WELCOME, SIR. GOOD TO SEE
YOU, SIR, MR. CHAIRMAN, MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE, DAVID SHAPIRO,
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION, IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. THANK YOU. THANK YOU, GOT
A MOTION, GOT MULTIPLE MOTIONS
AND NO OPPOSITION. BRING IT BACK
TO THE DAIS. ANYBODY WANT TO WAX
ELOQUENT FOR HALF HOUR? SO IT'S
A GOOD THANK YOU, WE HAVE A
MOTION. WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE,
SIR? RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. APPRECIATE THAT, MADAM
CONSULTANT, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. WELL, ITEM 29, AB 2968
CONNOLLY. MOTION IS DUE PASSED
THE SENATE NATURAL RESOURCES AND
WATER COMMITTEE. NEWMAN NEWMAN.
I TOBAGI CORTEZ. CORTESE I.
GLASER. GLASER, I, GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS I. WILK WILK.
I, THAT MEASURE HAS SEVEN VOTES
AND IT IS OUT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU TO OUR
WITNESSES. THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE. ASSEMBLY MEMBER ALVAREZ,
WE'RE GOING TO DO THIS. ARE YOU
HERE FOR YOUR BILL FOR THIS?
WE'RE GOING TO DO THIS IN A IN A
SUPPORT. IT'S WELL POINT WELL
TAKEN. WE'RE GOING TO DO THIS IN
A SPRINT. WELCOME. THANK YOU.
PROCEED. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY, THE
ANALYSIS COVERS A HISTORY OF THE
BILL, THE FACTS OF THE BILL, I
JUST WANT TO REMIND YOU THAT
THIS IS ABOUT ALLOWING, CSUS TO
OFFER JOINT DEGREE PROGRAMS WITH
INTERNATIONAL PARTNERS,
PARTICULARLY FOLKS LIKE ME, WHO
REPRESENT BORDER REGIONS WHERE
PARTNERSHIPS WITH MEXICAN
INSTITUTIONS IN OUR CASE, HERE
IN CALIFORNIA, ARE CRITICAL.
THIS WOULD GIVE THE AUTHORITY
FOR CSUS TO OFFER THESE KIND OF
DEGREES, JOINT BACHELOR'S AND
ALSO JOINT, GRADUATE LEVEL
DEGREES. AND RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR. I VOTE ON
APPROPRIATE. WE HAVE A LITTLE
BIT OF TESTIMONY IF YOU CAN
INDULGE US AND THE SIGNIFICANCE
AND IMPORTANCE OF THIS. AND
PROFESSOR VASQUEZ RAMOS, WELCOME
AND APPRECIATE YOUR WEDDING. YOU
CAN APPRECIATE OUR THE CLOCK
TICKING HERE. SO PLEASE PROCEED.
OH, YEAH. NO, I WILL BE VERY
DIRECT AND BRIEF. I HAVE A
WRITTEN STATEMENT, AND THIS IS A
PLEASURE TO BE HERE WITH YOU,
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE SENATE
EDUCATION COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS
ARMANDO VASQUEZ RAMOS. I'M A
RETIRED PROFESSOR FROM CAL
STATE, LONG BEACH. I HAVE OVER
30 YEARS OF DOING STUDY ABROAD
PROGRAMS, I WANTED TO ALSO
MENTION THAT ON BEHALF OF OUR
CALIFORNIA MEXICO STUDY CENTER,
WHICH I HAVE DONE NOW,
INDEPENDENT UNIVERSITY FOR OVER
12 YEARS, I'M HONORED TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF AB 2633, WHICH
WOULD ALLOW THE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY SYSTEM TO AWARD JOINT
UNDERGRADUATE, GRADUATE, AND
DOCTORAL DEGREES WITH
INTERNATIONAL UNIVERSITIES.
COLLABORATIVE JOINT DEGREE
INITIATIVES OFFER STUDENTS AN
INVALUABLE OPPORTUNITY TO ACCESS
NEW INTELLECTUAL RESOURCES,
INNOVATIVE IDEAS, INNOVATIVE
IDEAS, AND NOVEL PERSPECTIVES,
THEREBY ENRICHING THE STUDENT'S
ACADEMIC AND SOCIAL EXPERIENCE
AND TO PREPARE THEM FOR SUCCESS
IN A GLOBALIZED ECONOMY.
BINATIONAL JOINT DEGREE PROGRAMS
ARE RAPIDLY GAINING PROMINENCE
AS COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES
WORLDWIDE RECOGNIZE THE PERSONAL
AND ACADEMIC BENEFITS OF
CROSS-BORDER COLLABORATION AND
LEARNING. THIS MODEL IS LONG
OVERDUE IN THE US, WHILE THE
EUROPEAN UNION FORGED FROM ITS
INCEPTION PARADIGMS TO
FACILITATE ACADEMIC
COLLABORATION AND INSTITUTIONAL
PARTNERSHIPS TO PROMOTE ACADEMIC
MOBILITY AND ENHANCE THE HIGHER
EDUCATION THÀNH SOCIALIZATION
PROCESS. THIS TYPE OF
COLLABORATION IS BEING LED IN
CALIFORNIA, PRIMARILY THROUGH
COLLABORATIONS WITH INSTITUTIONS
SUCH AS UNIVERSIDAD NACIONAL
AUTONOMA, THE NATIONAL
AUTONOMOUS UNIVERSITY OF MEXICO,
THE AUTONOMOUS UNIVERSITY
METROPOLITANA IN MEXICO CITY
ALSO, AND INSTITUTO TECNOLOGICO
AUTONOMO VÌ. THE CMC, THE
CALIFORNIA MEXICAN STUDIES
CENTER, SAN DIEGO STATE
UNIVERSITY, AND UC SAN DIEGO,
WHICH HAVE SUCCESSFUL PROMOTED
ACADEMIC MOBILITY AND IMPORTANCE
OF EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTIONS,
FACILITATING INTERNATIONAL
EXCHANGE. BUT THE CSU SYSTEM HAS
LAGGED FOR DECADES DUE TO A LACK
OF VISION AND RESOURCES.
ASSEMBLING AND DAVID ALVAREZ OF
AB 2633 REFLECTS THE VALUE OF
INTERNATIONAL PARTNERSHIPS AND
COULD EMPOWER CSU STUDENTS TO
PURSUE STUDY ABROAD
OPPORTUNITIES AND SCHOLARLY
EXCHANGE. AS A SPONSOR, WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE
TO APPROVE AB 2633 TO FACILITATE
A VARIETY FUTURE OF ACADEMIC
EXCELLENCE AND GLOBAL ENGAGEMENT
WITHIN THE CSU SYSTEM. IF YOU
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS, PLEASE DO
NOT HESITATE TO CONTACT ME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
SEEING NONE. ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION, SEEING NONE. I HAVE
A MOTION FROM SENATOR BORG,
ASSEMBLY MEMBER, TO BE CLEAR,
YOU'VE ACCEPTED. HAVE YOU
ACCEPTED THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS? I DO, THANK YOU, I
APPRECIATE THAT. I VOTE WITH
THAT. WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE?
THANK YOU. THAT'S YOUR CLOSE.
IT'S AN AWESOMELY SUCCINCT
CLOSE, WITH THAT, MADAM
CONSULTANT, CALL THE ROLL FILE.
ITEM 26 AB 2633. ALVAREZ. MOTION
IS TO PASS, AS AMENDED, TO
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
NEWMAN Ã NEWMAN, I OKOBOJI.
OKOBOJI. CORTEZ CORTEZ I.
GLASER. GLASER I. GONZALEZ
GONZALEZ I. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS I WILK I WILK
I. ALL RIGHT THEN. THAT MEASURES
OUT SEVEN VOTES TO ZERO. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU,
PROFESSOR, LET US NOW MOVE TO
THE CONSENT CALENDAR. MADAM
CONSULTANT, DO WE HAVE A MOTION
FOR THE CONSENT CALENDAR? SO
SENATOR WILK MOVES THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. MADAM CONSULTANT,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. NEWMAN A
NEWMAN. AYE, OKOBOJI. OKOBOJI.
CORTEZ. CORTEZ GLASER. GLASER.
AYE. GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. AYE. WILK. AYE WILK.
AYE. ALL RIGHT. MOVING NOW TO
OPEN ITEMS, STARTING WITH ITEM
NUMBER ONE, AB 1780 FROM
ASSEMBLYMEMBER TING. MOTION IS
DUE. PASS TO AS AMENDED TO
SENATE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
CORTEZ CORTEZ. AYE. GONZALEZ
GONZALEZ. AYE. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS AYE.
THAT MEASURE IS OUT. FOUR VOTES
TO ZERO. TO BE CLEAR, THE
CONSENT CALENDAR WAS OUT
UNANIMOUSLY, NEXT UP IS AB 1793,
ITEM NUMBER TWO FROM ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TOM WILK WILL MOVE A
MOTION FROM WILK, PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL MOTION IS DUE. PASSED A
SENATE, MILITARY AND VETERAN
AFFAIRS COMMITTEE. NEWMAN.
NEWMAN AYE. OKOBOJI. OKOBOJI.
CORTEZ. CORTEZ AYE. GLASER.
GLASER. AYE. GONZALEZ GONZALEZ.
AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE WILK.
AYE. WILK. AYE. IT MEASURES OUT
SEVEN VOTES TO ZERO. ITEM NUMBER
THREE AB 18 1818 FROM ASSEMBLY
MEMBER JACKSON. I DON'T KNOW
THAT WE HAD A QUORUM THEN. DO WE
HAVE A MOTION? YEA WE DID, WE
DID. SENATOR GLAZER, MOVE THE
BILL, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL,
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED, TO
SENATE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
NEWMAN NEWMAN. AYE. OKOBOJI.
CORTESE. CORTESE. AYE GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ. AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE. ALL
RIGHT. THAT MEASURES OUT FIVE
VOTES TO ZERO. NEXT ITEM NUMBER
FOUR AB 1858 FROM ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WARD. MOTION IS TO PASS,
AS AMENDED, TO SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. NEWMAN
NEWMAN. AYE. CORTESE. CORTESE.
AYE. GONZALEZ GONZALEZ. AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. SMALLWOOD
CUEVAS. AYE IS THAT SEVEN VOTES
TO ZERO? NEXT IS AB 1971. ITEM
NUMBER FIVE FROM ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ADDES. MOTION IS TO PASS TO
SENATE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
OCHOA BOGH CORTESE. CORTESE AYE.
GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ. AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. AYE. THAT MEASURES OUT
SIX VOTES TO ZERO. AN ITEM
NUMBER SEVEN AB 2047 FROM
ASSEMBLY. SORRY. YES. YES.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FUNKE. SIX IS ON
CONSENT, FOR AB 2047 MOTION IS
DUE. PASSED A SENATE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE. GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ.
AYE THAT MEASURES OUT SEVEN
VOTES TO ZERO, ITEM NUMBER NINE,
AB 2057 FROM ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BERMAN. MOTION IS DUE. PASSED A
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
GLAZER GLAZER. AYE. GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ. AYE THEN MEASURES OUT
SEVEN VOTES TO ZERO. ITEM NUMBER
14, AB 27 TO 24 FROM ASSEMBLY
MEMBER REYES. WE NEED A MOTION.
IT DID NOT HAVE A MOTION. I DID
NOT SO MOVED FROM SENATOR
GLAZER. OKAY, FILE ITEM 14 AB 24
2724 REYES MOTION IS TO PASS TO
SENATE ELECTIONS AND
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENTS
COMMITTEE. NEWMAN. NEWMAN. AYE.
OCHOA. BOGH CORTESE. CORTESE,
AYE. GLAZER GLAZER. AYE.
GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. AYE. WILK THAT MEASURES
OUT FIVE VOTES TO ZERO, NEXT
ITEM NUMBER 16. AB 2245 FROM
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JUAN CARRILLO.
MOTION IS Dð PASS TO SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS. GLAZER WHICH
BILL IS THIS? AB 2245 CARILLO NÓ
GLAZER. NØ GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ.
AYE. AND MEASURES OUT FIVE FOUR
VOTES TO TWO, ITEM NUMBER 17, AB
2357 FROM ASSEMBLY MEMBER BAINS.
MOTION IS TO PASS, AS AMENDED,
TO SENATE APPROPRIATIONS. GLAZER
GLAZER. AYE. GONZALEZ GONZALEZ.
AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
SMALLWOOD CUEVAS I. THAT
MEASURES OUT SEVEN VOTES TO
ZERO. ITEM NUMBER 18 AB 2398
FROM ASSEMBLY MEMBER KULIRA
MOTION IS Dð PASS TO SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS. CORTEZ CORTESE.
AYE. GLAZER. GONZALEZ GONZALEZ.
AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS AYE. WILK ALL
RIGHT. THAT MEASURE IS THAT FIVE
VOTES TO ZERO, NEXT UP, ITEM
NUMBER 19, AB 26 2640. ALSO FROM
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CARRA. MOTION IS
TO PASS, AS AMENDED, TO SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS. GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ. AYE. THE MEASURE IS
OUT SEVEN VOTES TO ZERO. ITEM
NUMBER 21, AB 27 TO 23 FROM
ASSEMBLY MEMBER IRWIN. MOTION IS
DUE PASSED A SENATE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE. GLASER. GLASER. AYE.
GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ AYE. AND
MEASURES HAD SIX VOTES TO ZERO,
NEXT IS ITEM NUMBER 22 AB 2565
FROM ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTHY,
MOTION IS TO PASS TO SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS. GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ. AYE THE MEASURE IS
OUT. SEVEN VOTES TO ZERO. NEXT
ITEM NUMBER 23 AB 2927 FROM
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY. MOTION
IS TO PASS, AS AMENDED, TO
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS, WHICH HÌ
GONZALEZ, GONZALEZ. AYE. THAT
MEASURES OUT SIX VOTES TO ZERO,
ITEM NUMBER 25 AB 2595. OH,
WE'VE DONE THAT. SORRY, ITEM
NUMBER 28 AB 2925 FROM ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FRIEDMAN. MOTION IS TO
PASS THE SENATE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE. GONZALEZ GONZALEZ
CUEVAS, THE MEASURE IS OUT SIX
VOTES TO ZERO, AND THAT
COMPLETES THE ROLL, SO THANK YOU
TO EVERYBODY, ESPECIALLY FOLKS
WATCHING ON TV THAT LET US
FINISH, VERY GRATEFUL. THANK YOU
TO STAFF, WITH THAT, THIS
COMMITTEE IS ADJOURNED.